Hello, hello!
I'm sorry I started late today... again.
I'm sorry.
I thought today would be the day I'm going to stream Marvel Rebels early.
And then I got eepy.
It was my bad.
I got tired.
So I took a nap.
And I made an alarm.
I was like, Alright, Doki, you're gonna wake up after an hour nap.
I was working all day in the morning.
When I woke up in the morning, I was doing work stuff.
Catching up to two months old messages and emails every day.
Ever since the new year, I've been slowly catching up on my backlog of messages and emails.
I can't do it all at once.
I have to slowly catch up to things.
So I don't get burnt out.
I'm slowly returning back to being a normal human being.
So I was doing that this morning.
And then all the way to 4 or 5 p.m.
And I was just like, I'm eepy.
Oh my gosh.
One hour.
One hour nap.
It'll be fine.
It'll be okay.
I slept through that alarm.
And I woke up at like 10 p.m.
And I was like, oh.
I was like, oh, that's not good.
And then the thing is, all right, so today I have adopted a new tank player.
We are going to be playing with Boger.
He is an European tank player.
He's known around in the scene.
And the thing is, I made an appointment with Boger yesterday.
Because I was like, all right, today I'm going to grind.
Do you want to play?
And then he was like, yeah, but I start stream at 10 p.m.
Is that okay?
And I was like, well, I do early.
I want to stream early today.
I want to stream an N8 hour.
So I'm going to be streaming at like 5 to 6, but you can hop on whenever.
And then he like messaged me at 10.
It was like, hey, are you ready?
Hey, hey.
And I'm like, I took a nap.
I was just like, oh, yeah, I took a nap.
So here we are at 10.30.
Hey, that's an hour early.
That's like 30 minutes earlier than my usual Marvel Rivals streams.
So like, that's an improvement, sort of.
That's sort of an improvement.
Also, give me a sec.
I just got a reply to this work email real quick, because I just got the translation.
And like, I know, knowing me, I'm going to be playing this for a while.
So let me just reply this real quick, because I know it's going to take me a while.
Anyway, here we are again.
Here we go again to more Marvel Rivals today.
I uploaded a new video about my first Marvel Rivals marathon grind.
So you do exclamation point, new video, you'll be linked to the new video.
To the new... Is that the command?
Oh, sorry, new vid.
Sorry, it's new vid, not new video.
Did I write the wrong command on my title?
I don't know.
I'm a little bit of a mess.
No, I did.
This is the right command.
New vid, yes.
Thank you for gifting a sub to Tempo.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
I swear to God, I will return back to normal in five days.
It could be sooner.
If Booger greased us with the rank roints luck, we could get 150 points today.
How hard could it be?
How hard could it be to win five games in a row?
Surely, it can't be that hard.
Shut up.
Surely.
Also, you know what I noticed?
I noticed that I haven't bumped into any fucking streamers.
Yet, everybody and their fucking mom is playing and streaming this.
Yet, for somehow...
I mean, earlier I've been bumping into them, but during my late night marathon sessions, like the last week, I feel like I haven't bumped into anybody.
Yet, everybody's streaming it.
Like, I bump into Mac one time.
Everyone is... I was talking to one of my friends.
I was like, I don't understand.
Like, they're all streaming it.
Like, I don't... Or I would just be on the enemy team.
Yet, but that was not... Yet, but bumping into xQc was not a week ago.
Like, I meant the last week of me streaming.
Of me streaming and, like, actually using voice comms.
I'm just so... Maybe they're all just in East Coast.
We have to reintegrate East Coast back in because Booger is European.
So, like, East Coast servers will have the best ping for him.
So, like, I have to reintegrate East Coast, sadly.
I have to acknowledge the Easties for today's session.
Oh my god.
Also, like, I had the fucking... I don't know why, but my dreams went out the window.
I dreamt about Rick and Morty, but, like, I was Rick and Morty.
I don't know.
I think I'm far too gone.
This grind has, like, fucked me up mentally.
I don't... I don't know why.
Like, I dreamt that I was Rick and Morty.
And we were playing out the fucking weirdest scenario of a Rick and Morty episode.
And, um, I need... I need to be freed.
Today, I... There is a chance that today will be the day that we'll all be freed.
We just need 5 games.
We just... We literally... We literally just need 5 games.
7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16... Yeah, 5 games.
5 or 6 games.
Just... 6 games of wins.
It can't be that hard.
Just 6 games of wins.
We either get 6... We either get the cutoff for top 500 or... Or we try and get Eternity back.
There's no in-between.
168.
It's 170 points now?
How... Okay.
How... It's, like, climbing, like, 10 points per day.
That's... Oh, my God.
I hate Endless Season.
Okay, maybe not 200 points.
Maybe it's gonna be 250.
I feel like... Oh, my God.
It could actually be 250.
I think it might be 250.
Like, I... There's no way.
We have... How many days left do we have?
We have... Oh, my God.
How do I check this again?
We have 4 days... Technically, 5 days.
Oh, my God.
It could be 250.
Maybe 250 is safer.
250 or 260.
Okay.
Maybe we'll try and get 200.
We'll try... We'll aim for 200.
I don't think we gotta aim high.
I can't.
I don't know.
250 seems a little bit too much.
Too many wins.
Maybe we're gonna aim for 200 or we get Eternity back.
Like...
Because I can't go either way.
250 or we get Eternity.
We get... We get back Eternity.
So... Oh, my God.
Mel, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Rodek, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
I wonder if he's ready yet.
I don't know.
Let me see if he's on here.
No, I don't think so.
Okay, I'm gonna do a quick play game to warm up.
I'm gonna play Psylocke.
I would say... It's gonna... Guys...
We will have a... Maybe I'll be Loki again.
I'm gonna copy Psylocke.
No Conquest.
No... Fuck that game mode.
NotSoDeadPool, thank you for the... Thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you.
Here you go.
Just for you.
Just... Oh, my God.
Just... Sorry.
Just for you.
I got you, bro.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Okay.
I don't think we're gonna be the top streamer of Marvel Rivals today.
There's a lot of big hitters streaming today.
Literally, Stride is on.
There's a lot of... I swear to fucking... Oh, my God.
Why is everybody into pink Psylocke?
Combat, thank you for the five gifted souls.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
A lot of the big hitters are on today.
So, like, they all want their rank roids.
MechaKitten, thank you for the 1,000 bitties.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
That's right.
Heal.
Heal, kittens.
I have to heal.
I have to be support in the next two, three plus hours.
It's your turn to heal.
Alright, I want to win this game fast, so I'm gonna play Hella.
I either get shit on by the enemy team or at fucking Papa.
We'll see.
We'll see what the...
I honestly don't even think, like, the higher rank players play quick play, honestly.
A lot of them tend to not play pubs because why play pubs when you can play rank?
So, like, it's... Oh, my God.
Maybe we'll be lucky.
Maybe we'll be lucky that it's just shitters on and quick play.
Alright, here we go.
Let's see if we can do it.
Alright.
I'm also, like... Oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh, wait.
It's not fine.
Oh, he's not... I'm not tank, so he's not gonna kidnap me.
Behind me?
Who's behind me?
Okay.
Did you guys all die from one guy?
Okay, guys.
Oh, please.
Why did you banish him?
There we go.
Where is he?
Where are you?
Get over here.
Let me send you some fucking arrows.
God, this Iron Man is dumb as fuck.
Like, you don't just stand in the open.
You're so fucking stupid.
Oh, my God.
Please, let me do something.
Push up.
Why are you hiding?
Oh, my God.
Where's my supports?
I swear to God.
Iron Man, swap off.
It's embarrassing.
Swap off.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Doki is quick.
It doesn't matter.
Gaming is gaming.
I might need to, like...
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm actually, like... I might need to grab some gamer stuff.
I...
Oh, my God.
I feel so lagarthic right now.
My aim.
I can't.
I'm done fucking too...
I just woke up, man.
I can't.
My aim is not ready for, like, wake...
Bro, why are you doing that tech and fucking quick play?
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
The fact that you're doing this tech and quick play and it's not even a good tech.
Like, a lot of people don't know that tech is...
That tech is, like, bugged out.
Kill me, please.
Oh, no.
He has his fucking buff.
No, it's okay.
I got the gamer subs ready.
Don't worry.
Alright.
We'll be fine.
Thank you.
I think, like, I've, like, pavloved myself into drinking gamer subs every... before a rank session.
Because of how many times I have to play rank at these hours.
And, like, it's not even intentional.
I just... It's either I don't find players until, like, 11 p.m.
Or, like... Or, like, I just got E.P.
I just get E.P.
It's not even intentional.
I literally only drink gamer subs from Marvel Rivals at this point.
Oh, my God.
Okay, here we go.
I actually have, like, a gamer sub jar.
Just in case I need the powder.
It's, like... Oh, my game...
Did you guys know, like...
People are, like, modifying game files to have more frames.
Where, like, it removes shadows and stuff.
And then the devs made a statement and said, like, Yeah, we don't like that.
So... So it might become a bad-able offense.
That's why I was, like, I'm not modding my game.
Like, I don't trust...
I'm, like, I don't trust them to be okay with it.
Like...
Yeah.
That's why I don't mod my game.
Because I literally... I don't trust them to be okay.
Like...
Oh, no.
He's gonna throw.
Oh, shit.
Goodbye.
Don't worry.
I'll be here.
Goodbye.
Oh, my God.
He's one.
Where is the Iron Man?
Jesus Christ, that's sad.
Oh, he's so low.
He's so low!
Get over here, Black Panther!
Oh, he's dead.
Okay.
That's fine.
It's apparently... No, it's just because, like, devs normally don't like when you, like, modify game files to enhance performance.
Like, they'd rather you do it, like, in the settings.
That's why I was, like, I ain't touching anything related to, like, mods.
Because even then, sometimes they think mods in general can be...
Because I don't trust Anti-Cheat.
I feel like Anti-Cheat's gonna think that, like, it's...
Especially, like, modding a multiplayer fucking game is so risky in general.
Because, um, I feel like they just think it's, like, a hack accidentally.
Because Anti-Cheat's stupid sometimes.
Alright.
I'm just gonna...
Oh, I'm backing out.
Bird!
Woo!
Alright, bird form!
Bird form!
How are they alive?
This is bullshit.
Like, how...
When they do hella ult, they get 20 kills.
When I do hella ult, it doesn't fucking matter.
Okay.
I feel like I get damage, but no kills.
Like...
That's fine.
I don't need to kill people.
I...
Alright, I made Luna ulted.
I did my job.
Where's Hulk?
Give me your ult charge.
Okay, that was dumb.
You could've waited.
That's...
There's still 20 seconds left of the Luna ult.
I'm not even gonna move my...
I'm not even gonna AD.
Fuck this.
I'm just...
I'm just gonna stand here.
Nobody's hurting me.
Nobody realized I exist anyway.
So, like, what's the point?
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm helping.
I'm help...
Oh!
I'm fucking...
I'll start helping.
He came right there.
Don't worry.
I'm helping.
Oh, I'm...
I'm helpful.
There, see?
Oh.
He did his...
She did his fucking passive.
See?
I told you guys.
I'm so helpful.
See?
I got him out of mech form.
I did it, guys.
Look at that.
Where is he?
Oh, my God.
I hate Black Panther players.
Where the fuck is he?
Please.
Oh, my God.
I...
Fuck.
Fine.
Fuck this.
What is this?
What do you mean?
What is this aim?
We won.
We fucking won.
I'm sorry.
We won.
Why are you...
What is this aim?
Oh, I'm sorry for winning.
This is a 20 bomb.
I have to fucking...
Do you not see the people doing jumping jacks around me?
Doing somersaults and flipping.
I'm fucking sorry.
Oh, my God.
Fucking criticize my ass in quick play.
I'm sorry.
I literally...
All I can do is just do damage.
Like my other...
My teammates fucking finish them off.
Like, oh, yeah.
The 12...
The 12k damage.
Helena was not doing her job.
All right.
Fuck you guys.
I'm playing Psylocke next.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Yeah, I did my job.
It doesn't matter.
Only 12k?
All right.
This person with the second most damage was 9k.
They're like 3k behind me.
Oh, my God.
Fucking ride my ass on quick play.
Why won't you?
Zach, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
This is...
This is exactly why I don't play DPS for you guys.
All right.
Back to Helena, I guess.
I guess.
It's back to Helena.
Why do I have to backfill?
I just want to play Psylocke so I can play ranked.
Oh, my God.
I swear to God.
If I...
If Jeff shows up...
Oh, thank God.
It's not me.
I was like, I swear to God.
We're waiting for the duo right now.
But also, like, I'm...
I wanted...
Of course, I have to backfill.
Of fucking course.
I...
Of course, I have to fucking backfill after I just...
I literally only queue up because I want to play Psylocke.
This is like the rare moments where I get to play DPS on my main.
A reason why I don't play DPS on ranked is because I don't...
I'm literally playing against, like, people who have been DPS players in Overwatch for, like...
For, like, seven years.
That's like...
Like...
Oh, please, group.
So, like, it's not worth it.
By the time I catch up to them, like, they're...
I'm just going to get shit on in general.
Like, literally, those are the DPS players I have to verse.
So, like, that's why I'm not even going to attempt.
Oh my god, he was 1 HP.
He was actually 1 HP.
I'm sad.
These...
These walls are, like, knotted.
I'm sorry.
Alright, there we go.
Yeah, like, that's why I'm, like, not...
Like, literally, I'm running into, like...
There's no way this car will save me.
Yeah, I was going to say, standing on this...
This car is literally the counter to Squirrel Girl.
I can literally stand there and we'll be okay.
Oh, fuck, I can't stand there anymore.
Yes, I'm not okay anymore.
It was...
It countered for, like, one second.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Oh my god, you're such a whore.
You have no friends.
You actually have no friends.
Fucking protect your shark, you idiot.
The waiting doll!
Oh my god, are you serious?
Wait, you didn't kill him?!
Okay.
That's fine.
He saw this in a video once and was like, this is it.
This is my time to use that shield.
Okay, come on.
Give me that bird.
I'm not even gonna do anything.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Oh, he's so dead.
Oh, I'm so dead.
Oh, no!
Oh my god, how did I live?!
That's okay, Riot.
Push me.
That's right.
He's gonna start Grooting.
There's no way.
There's no way the Elevation's gonna fucking kill me.
Oh my god, he's actually...
I just needed to hit one shot.
I literally just needed to hit one shot there.
I'm sad.
I'm so sad.
I should grab my ult soon though, at least.
They're like, letting me farm it.
They don't see me, right?
That's fine.
Let me farm you.
Oh, but like, don't push up.
Don't walk up to me.
That's... that's illegal.
Oh, support!
He's literally walking up to you!
Oh, there's that!
Gamer awareness right there!
I like how he just...
He just walked up!
What are you doing?
What?
You know what?
I know you don't have...
Okay, what am I...
Okay.
Alright, maybe I should've went a bit ahead though.
It's okay, this works still.
This works.
Thread the needle.
It still works, guys.
I threaded the needle.
What the fuck?
Okay.
That works too.
Thanks for the...
I guess...
Like...
I mean...
Okay.
That works too.
Alright.
That gave me...
Thanks for the free...
I don't know.
Thanks for the angle, I guess.
I mean, it literally backfilled.
I backfilled and I...
Oh my god, our group was fucking them.
Our group was actually fucking.
Okay, guys.
One more quick play.
I need...
I need like...
5 v...
What am I?
What do you mean 5 v 6 and still 1?
I...
What am I to them?
Excuse...
Hello?
Oh my god.
I guess I'm not a...
I was there for like...
2 parts of the map.
You just...
I was there for 2 sections.
What do you mean?
Okay, thank you.
Alright.
Now...
Silence.
They called you a bot.
I...
I got kills.
I actually contributed to society.
What am I?
Kar and Kazoo, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you.
Delta, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Sleepy, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Lingling, thank you.
Oh my god.
This is what happens when you try to contribute to society.
They don't appreciate you.
Alright.
Finally.
And we have no support.
Let's go.
That's fine.
You don't need support in...
In quick play.
Oh.
Oh, we have 2 people that left.
That's cool.
You can tell they...
They are willing to tank a 15 minute delay.
A 15 minute...
Delay just to not play support.
That's actually crazy.
Imagine fucking tanking a 15 minute ban.
Just cause you...
Just don't...
You're just like, oh fuck.
That's enough Marvel Rivals today.
That's actually enough Marvel Rivals today.
Alright.
Woah!
What you gonna do?
Try to kill me?
Haha.
But where am I?
Oh.
Goodbye.
Okay.
That's not fair.
They have 2 supports.
Haha.
That's fucking right.
This is my health pack.
Alright.
I can't believe it.
They got the privilege of having 2 support players.
That's fucking insane.
This is not fair.
Haha.
This is actually not fair.
Oh no.
No.
And I literally saw our 1 support player die.
I deserved that.
I went into the...
I went into the Thor thing.
I thought I wasn't even gonna touch it.
Doki's DPS.
What you see here.
This is...
Um...
Quick play.
Haha.
This is...
It's not looking very great though.
Um...
I got the short end of the stick when it comes to like...
When it comes to like...
You know...
Quick play teammates.
Haha.
You know the...
Uh...
The no support players.
Cause everybody's like...
Why support?
When I play...
When I wanna play DPS.
Like...
Haha.
Why support?
Alright.
So like...
This is the life we live in right now.
Uh...
Haha.
This is the...
We got the short end of the stick.
Alright.
Here we go.
I've come to bargain.
Oh no.
Is he gonna leave?
Haha.
Did I already lost my...
My tank player?
That'd be very awkward.
Where's that rocket raccoon?
Oh my god.
I'm getting healed?
I actually am getting healed.
That's insane.
Where are you going?
Ah!
Hahaha.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
I thought I could...
I didn't wanna die from that.
Guys.
It was either die from Psylocke or die from the clip.
I took my own way out.
I...
Haha.
You should...
I should've showed it here.
Alright guys.
I didn't wanna...
Guys, look.
I did not wanna die to Psylocke.
Although, okay.
It's...
I took my own way out of the game.
I...
It's not throwing!
I literally...
I wouldn't...
I didn't wanna die by her hands.
Alright.
It's not throwing cause like...
I chose my own exit.
Some would say I'm brave.
Some would say I'm a war hero.
Hahaha.
You know how like...
You know like...
Like...
Negotiations.
You got...
You're like a prisoner of war.
And you don't wanna...
You like...
You take that pill...
The pill in the...
In the...
In the mouth.
You know?
So you don't leak out the government secrets.
That's me.
That's me right now.
I took the pill.
So I can't leak the government secrets.
I'm so brave.
I should...
I deserve a medal for that.
The cyanide pill.
Oh man.
It's...
It's the bravest thing I could do.
Oh my god.
You're such a whore.
Supports fucking holding each other's hands.
Okay.
There you go.
That's right.
Respawn right now.
Respawn.
Thank you.
Thank you for your service.
Alright.
I'm almost done with my quick play warm up.
The mouth.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
That's fine.
I have not warmed up.
Alright, that's cool.
What?
You don't need it.
He doesn't need it.
Alright.
Ah, okay.
He doesn't need it.
I believe.
We just warm up straight.
We don't need to warm up.
We just hold right.
Damn.
What's your favorite DPS character?
Psylocke, currently.
She's really fun to play.
She doesn't require much aim.
Compared to the other characters.
I won't say she's like Scarlet Witch, but compared to the other characters, her aim is like...
Oh my god.
Fucking shit.
I don't even know what kill.
I got exploded.
I literally got exploded there.
Compared to the other characters, her aim is so easy.
The way you and your aim with her is like incredibly easy compared to like other characters.
You had a good aim.
Yeah, but like all I'm saying is that it's really easy to aim with her because her projectile speed is not that difficult to like figure out type deal.
Wait, where's our cloak?
Wait.
Where is she?
Oh, there she is.
I don't know.
It's just...
It feels very...
Because it's like a little bit like hitscan.
Okay, I have ult, so like...
Alright.
Are you serious?
Okay.
Oh my god, you fucking bitch!
You couldn't save your raccoon!
You couldn't save your raccoon, though!
Oh, you saved your raccoon.
Yeah, she is hitscan.
That's what I mean.
Sorry, my brain is like...
I'm fucking angry.
That's why she's so easy to aim because she's basically hitscan.
And like, I don't have to fucking worry about projectile speed.
I hate Mantis aim.
Oh my god.
Mantis's projectile speed is stupid as fuck.
Like, it's like...
It's delayed.
And it like fucks with my head.
Oh my god.
You can like actually get crushed, so I'm scared.
Oh, I missed my right click.
I...
Thank god.
Why every time I talk shit, I talk shit and that happens to me.
Alright, there we go.
There we go.
Now I can do it.
We're back.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh my god, she's one!
Oh my god!
Someone kill Syla!
That was my one and he won!
Oh my god.
The fucking Syla came out of nowhere.
I didn't want to get headshot.
I was like...
I tried...
I was scared of getting headshot by that fucker.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh shit, that's a Wolverine.
Bro, he's angry.
And he's fucking angry.
I was scared.
That was an angry man.
Is that everybody?
Are they all dead?
They're all dead.
There we go.
Oh!
Please, please, please, please.
I'm scared.
He's dead, Doki.
Alright.
I mean, he's not getting...
I'm not getting healed either.
I play as if I...
I don't know.
I play as if I'm getting healed, but I keep forgetting that I'm one support.
I was like, oh hey, he's not even getting healed.
That's cool.
That's pretty sweet.
But then I'm also not getting healed.
So that's not sweet anymore.
Okay, that's funny.
Oh my god.
I could've died.
They just backed out.
That should be illegal.
That...
They just...
They could just walk backwards.
They just walked backwards.
I don't know.
I thought that was a juicy ult.
I legitimately thought that was quite juicy there.
They just...
Actually...
Oh.
Oh, that was my only support.
Guys.
Are the health packs here?
Are they...
Guys, where are the health packs back here?
I don't...
I actually don't know.
Oh, he's gonna cocoon, isn't he?
Oh my god, I can't.
They're holding hands.
I...
How dare they walk away?
You can just do that?
Just walk away?
I...
You can...
Wow, I wish I could've done that.
Oh my god.
You can...
Why have I thought of that before when I get Psylocke ulted?
I don't understand.
How come when I get Psylocke ulted, I can't just walk away?
But when they Psylocke...
When I Psylocke ult, they can just walk away like that.
Like...
Is this a quick play buff?
Is this...
They have...
Honestly...
No, that's...
If anybody that should swap, it should be a Black Panther.
At least, like, even though I'm, like, playing like ass right now.
At least, like, I'm contributing a bit more than this guy.
He is definitely not Wakanda forever right now.
He's like...
No Wakanda today.
The S key count...
I know it's actually crazy.
I never expected that.
Oh, look at him.
He's, like, waiting.
He's like, ooh.
Oh, are you coming over, Thor?
I'm on, Thor.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
What the fuck is wrong with...
Where's your...
Yes, right.
Where's your support?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, there's your support, I guess.
Yup.
Just walk away.
That's what they did to me.
Just...
That's not fair.
That's actually not fair.
That's...
That's not fair.
He has an Adam and a Rocket, baby.
Fuck me, I guess.
Wakanda, not even briefly, forever.
That's actually not fair.
Not fair.
It should...
It should be banned...
from existing.
Oh my god, who?
Who's fucking shooting me?
I have to play on this just for any sense of healing.
You know what, fuck this.
Oh my god, you just walk away!
I still got him!
I don't...
I don't even...
I still got him!
I don't even know how!
Okay, that's fine.
I'm okay with that.
I still got it, baby.
I still got it.
I'm fine.
I'm okay with that.
That's fucking right.
Be gone!
Oh my god, they got so much.
Oh, I had to...
I guess I'll contest point, guys.
I...
I guess...
I guess I'll contest the point for us.
My little squishy body.
That's fine.
How does our panther still have zero...
He has gained zero kills!
In this one round!
How do you not have any kills in the one round?
In one full round!
That's actually crazy.
Is there anything I can do?
Walk back?
To cap the point?
That'd be a crazy thing to do.
I don't need it.
What?
Oh my god, I...
No, I couldn't.
I thought that was a wall.
I thought that was an entranceway.
And I was like, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
I can't go in.
Go through there.
Please back, black panther.
Do one kill.
Black panther, please!
Kill one person!
I mean, I knew it.
Oh my gosh.
I couldn't mute myself in time.
Please.
Oh my god.
Black panther, how did you not get one kill in one entire round?
I couldn't...
Bro did not get a single kill in one fucking round.
That's actually crazy.
That's alright.
He's having fun.
It's quick play.
Let him have fun.
Not sure why black panther was here.
At least, like, it's quick play.
You lose it.
Don't talk to me ever again.
What a great time, team.
Oh my god.
That's a marvel, baby.
Don't talk to me ever again.
By kindness and example.
Why are you so bad?
I don't know.
I don't know why they're so bad.
That was wild.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
I like how he's like, don't talk to me ever again.
He's been through things.
He's been through a lot.
Average quick play moment.
Wakanda never.
Guys, I don't think he's...
I don't think he's feeling Wakanda today.
I can't believe Doki said it's rivaling time and then marveled all over.
Guys, in five days, I'll return back to normal.
I swear to god, chat.
Five days, guys.
We're gonna be back to normal and then we'll move back to YouTube for regular content.
I'm planning on streaming on Twitch more.
But not, like, as much as I am right now.
Because, like I said, I'm putting all the Marvel rank grind on Twitch.
Because it's just easier.
I like to put scheduled content on YouTube.
Because, like I said, I don't know when I'm ever streaming rank.
It's always, like, so fucking random whenever I'm doing rank streams.
So that's why I don't put it on YouTube.
Because also I need to get a thumbnail made.
I need to get a thumbnail made.
I need to, like, put up the waiting room.
I need to, like...
It's just a little bit too much work.
And, like, it's just...
Yeah, that's why I just...
I'd rather just put it on Twitch.
And then later on, I put, like...
I'm gonna have an edited VOD.
Also, it's just really expensive.
Because, like, okay, so...
Okay, I shouldn't talk about expensive.
But, like...
Because I don't know when I'm gonna do Marvel...
Oh, we're doing quick play.
Okay, alright.
Oh, okay.
One quick play.
Alright, that's cool.
I'll be right back.
Actually, I'm gonna get...
I'm gonna get...
Cough drop real quick.
And I'm back.
It's just easier to, like...
Have it all on Twitch.
And then have an edited VOD of the grind.
Because I don't know how long it's gonna fucking take me.
Alright, let's warm up on Luna.
Let's fucking go on quick...
Is this quick play still?
Still quick play.
What?
What is XM?
Lou, I'm sorry.
Booger's also a tank player.
And I don't know if I wanna...
With probability's sake, I don't know if we can have two tanks on one squad.
But don't worry.
Don't worry.
The next spot...
The next spot is yours, Lou.
Don't worry, Lou.
The next spot is yours.
Alright, fuck this Ironman.
He doesn't deserve it.
Fuck this Ironman.
You're gonna learn how to play without a Luna.
Without a Luna crutch.
Guys, I'm waiting for my gamer subs to kick in right now.
If I'm not hitting anything, it's only because...
My gamer subs have yet to...
Oh my god, my gamer subs have yet to kick in.
My gamer...
Oh my god.
Okay.
My gamer subs have yet to...
I would have...
Oh my god.
Guys, it's just because my gamer subs have yet to kick in.
Okay.
Also, I have a...
Oh my god.
Why...
Why would you have fun playing Rocky Raccoon?
And fucking Whistler, of all things.
Like, alright, now it's on.
It's on.
It's okay.
It's kicked in now.
Guys, it's actually...
How?
How do you have fun playing Rocky Raccoon in quick play?
I don't understand.
How?
There we go.
That's the gamer subs keep talking.
But guys, speaking of gamer subs, if you use my code, you can get...
You can...
What reminder?
What is this reminder?
If you use my code, DokiBrewed, you get 10% off on any order you make on gamersubs.com.
Is that crazy?
Oh my god.
I got, like, hit up.
So...
Please.
He's just walking up to me.
Don't let him just walk up to me.
Please.
I can't.
I fucking can't with this team.
They just let him walk up to me.
Counter hit with S.
Please, at least kill Venom.
There we go.
Alright, we're fine.
We're just warming up.
Get fucking in.
Get fucking hit.
Get head.
Alright.
See?
It's so easy.
We're so warmed up now.
It's kicked in, guys.
It's kicked in for real.
We don't talk about that miss there, but it's kicked in, guys.
I swear to god.
Alright, who's just walking up to me?
Okay, there you are.
Please, do not let him just walk up to us.
Okay.
See?
He's so healthy.
Everything is so healthy.
Alright, I just get that nasty.
I only get that one good freeze and I know I'm ready.
Like right now.
Okay.
It would've hit, guys.
This would've hit, guys.
I swear to god.
You didn't see it because it faded out.
If it played a little bit longer, that freeze would've hit.
You could've seen it.
You should've been there.
You should've been there, guys.
It was crazy.
Guys, this is supposed to be like an echo chamber of praise.
If I wouldn't get flamed...
If I wouldn't get flamed right now, I'd be on Twitter.
No.
The tone of love.
Alright, let's go.
Alright, I need to know where my hate watchers are.
Where are my hate watchers in chat?
Me!
That's me!
She's talking about me!
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
She's actually talking about me.
She mentioned me.
Oh my god, streamer fucking mentioned me.
Oh my god, I don't know why I pressed that freeze there.
I just felt a little cocky today, I guess.
He's so healthy.
Look at him go.
He's so fucking healthy.
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine.
This strange was not.
I'm just here to make sure he has a good time.
Alright, strange.
Okay, what?
Okay!
Is he okay?
Oh my god.
Nice.
Where did he go?
There you go.
Is the gamer sub crew that makes you cocky?
True.
True, I'm getting my energy back now.
Thoughts on Moon Knight?
Only good on certain maps.
And even then, he's like...
He's only good on like, what?
Two maps, I feel like.
The other maps, he's like, not great in.
Not really like, something you should play.
Because there's, it's like, it's very map dependent.
Because if...
Oh my, what is that?
What the fuck is that movement?
It's a little like, gyrate.
It's a little circle.
He's like, gyrating in the sky.
Skill and shit.
I'm just like, bro, what the fuck?
And this is why you, people normally give the orb to Ironman.
Because he's fucking held it.
He's got the moves.
I was like, what the fuck?
What is this gyration?
It's like, he's like, fucking or some shit.
He's gotta keep practicing, that's for sure.
He's in.
He's like, hip thrusting in the air.
You see how I put an orb on the Ironman?
I've given up.
I've...
That's why they're like, guys gotta give...
Why me?
I'm fucking one person.
That little lower accurate.
Tony Stark.
Yay.
It was like, got him married.
Alright, nice.
Everything will be fine.
No, I'm gonna put it on the Ironman.
I can't, I can't deal with his movement right now.
I'm not, I'm not into it.
It ain't cool.
What's he gonna do?
Like, what are you trying to do?
Okay.
That's fine.
I have ult.
You don't have to heal me.
It's fine, Raccoon.
It's fine.
I know that healing me is not it.
It's okay.
GG.
Just ignore me.
Boar Nation.
Try to blame the healer.
Yeah, no spot for now.
For now playing with Ogre at the moment.
Two tanks is a bit too risky.
It's too risky because we might get queued into a team that also has tank players.
And like, I feel like I feel more comfortable having tank DPS than two tanks together.
We're min-maxing right now.
Guys, I can't.
I'm not.
I don't want to do a full five days, guys.
I don't know if I can do a full five days of just playing ranked.
Non-stop.
I don't know.
It's not.
I don't think it's.
That's why I'm min-maxing.
That is exactly why I have the min-max chat.
Everyone does it.
I ain't the first one that invented it.
Min-maxing stacks has been a thing since competitive.
Halo people.
It's been a thing since CSGO.
It's been a thing since Halo multiplayer.
It's been a thing since, I don't know, whatever came before Halo.
Everybody does it.
Since the dawn of humanity, exactly.
And it's my turn to min-max.
Oh, I'm against super.
Who's on my team?
I have no idea who's on my team.
I know I'm against super though.
Alright, here we go.
Bad mage in Subway is useless?
Who the fuck is Subway?
The chain?
Alright.
I guess we bad magic?
I don't know.
I guess we bad magic.
He's playing magic player.
Wait, but we have a magic player.
I eat fresh.
Wait, but like, we have a magic player though.
We just...
Wait, we have a...
Okay, I was gonna say.
I guess we're gonna have to have an Ironman play.
Oh, no, I have to play against a fucking...
If this guy, if the enemy Hulk just W-keys me.
And like, and my team just watches this happen.
I will...
I will not be okay.
Oh, we should have...
We should have banned Ironman then.
Do we even have an Ironman player?
Do we have a DPS player?
Okay.
That's not Ironman, but like, it's close enough.
I guess it's close enough.
He's red.
She's purple.
That's practically Ironman.
She's hitscan.
He's whatever the fuck he is.
Okay, we...
Okay.
Okay, well, they are...
Go heal, I'll go arm.
Okay.
Alright, that should be fine.
And then...
Oh, hey, look, he has a Hulk too.
There he goes.
Oh, he has a Wolverine as well.
Oh, thank god I'm not tank.
Oh, they're practicing baseball.
They're practicing.
Oh my god, they're practicing the tech right now.
That's funny.
They're trying out the tech.
Oh.
Yeah, Wolverine.
Well, there's the Wolverine.
Nice kill there.
I mean, there was the Wolverine.
I was right.
I'm walking.
Change is low.
Alright, nice.
Nice.
Oh, wait, Hulk is one.
Oh my god, oh my god, please.
Please, I had so much practice with the gyrating Wolverine.
I was like, hey, they have a Wolverine.
And then, like, my Hulk just disappeared.
My Hulk just fucking got deleted.
Alright, help, Mary.
Normally, I shouldn't do that, though.
That's, like, actually...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you fucking broke the map.
That's fine.
Wait, get the Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk.
So you just have to...
Come on, just dash.
Strange, strange, strange, strange, strange, strange, strange, strange, strange, strange.
You can mental assault first.
Okay, oh, that's awkward.
That's so awkward.
That's fine, everything will be okay.
Everything will be okay, guys.
We're so healthy.
Oh, I don't think they used... they didn't use any of their ults.
Oh, they have everything.
I have no mag.
That's fine.
What?
Oh, shit.
Hulk in the backline.
Watch out the wall.
Okay, I have Hulk 1, Hulk 1.
I'm ulting this after?
We're in the backline.
Oh, I'm ulting point.
If we could just play on point.
Just play on point.
I don't think we can... we don't need ult anymore.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
We got 99.
They used Mantis, Strange ult.
No more ult.
I think they used everything.
Did they use Logang?
Oh, they didn't use Berserker.
Oh yeah, they didn't use Berserker, yeah.
Why does this game look like it's a hero shooter?
Oh, there we go.
I'm scared of the Wolverine.
Oh, are you okay, Strange?
Oh, I fucking hate this.
Wait, Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna!
Luna's one, Luna's one!
Yeah, I'm on there, I'm on there.
Oh, I'm the only support left.
I might die.
It's fine.
We can win this.
Wait, no, Mantis is alive!
Wait, Wolverine's low too.
Wolverine no passive.
No passive, no passive.
Wolves is a game.
I'm chilling, I'm chilling.
Run, run, run, run for your life.
Get a Hulk.
Kill him, kill him, kill him.
Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk.
Hulk is one!
Hulk one!
Strange is portaling.
I'm stunning him.
Yeah, it's fine.
They're not on Strange, they're not on...
Oh.
Wolverine here.
Whoa!
Wolverine.
Logang, Logang, Logang.
Strange is half.
Strange is one, Strange is one.
Hello?
I'm a Hulk.
That's fine.
We're so healthy.
Wait, did I freeze?
Oh my gosh, things are like blurring together and I don't even know if I freeze.
To be fair, when he said Logang, I was like, Logan Paul?
Just like, I'm like, who's Logan Paul?
Just like...
I literally flaked out.
I was like, did they Logang all?
I'm like, who the fuck?
What did Logan Paul do?
I forgot that Logan...
Logang is...
is...
is Wolverine.
I know his name is Logan, but like, I don't know.
I just...
My mind instantly went to Logan Paul.
Great game's trash.
It only took a month for him to hate the game.
What a character arc.
The brain cell...
My brain rot has settled in.
I've actually rotted away all my brain cells from this game.
They definitely have Strange all here.
Yeah, it's got Strange diffs.
There's a Logang.
Logang left side, guys.
Look, this is literally the first time I've heard the comm of...
Oh, he's pitching.
He's doing baseball.
He missed.
I'm out.
I'm trying to run for it.
He fucking missed.
I can touch.
For a little bit.
Logang's on me.
Logang!
What?!
How did that kill me fully?!
I was at the edge!
Look at me!
I was...
What?!
I would've been shut down, not fully killed.
He's coming for me.
I'm terrified.
That's actually...
Wait, he ulted.
I was at the fucking edge!
That's actually bullshit.
That should not have hit me.
Legitimately, that should not have hit me.
We can Mantis in first if needed.
Logang, guys.
Logang.
Oh, how far...
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
I'm damage boosting this.
Oh, he's looking for a solo!
Oh no, I'm thinking Logan Paul now.
I meant Wolf.
Logan Paul!
I'm sorry, my brain rots!
I just did not intentionally mean Logan Paul.
I feel it in my ass, bro.
This guy's in me.
Portal behind, portal behind!
Logang in.
I'm on sports.
I have Hulk on me.
Hulk is on me.
I stunned him, I stunned him.
No!
Goodbye.
I'm dead.
What have I become?
Wait, did we not win this?
I thought we were up more.
No, we didn't win.
I'm coming back.
Can we not contest for it?
Okay.
Logang.
My brain rots.
It's not great.
I think it's not a great thing.
Oh my god, I didn't realize he was right beside me.
If I knew he was right beside me, I would have done...
Oh, we're up two.
We should push up.
There's a Hulk on me.
Hulk one, Hulk one.
Oh, I'm dead.
Please!
I'm getting juggled by Hulk.
Can I help you?
I don't know.
He's low, he's one, he's one.
Get him, get him.
Leave him, leave him.
Don't kill him.
Down, guys.
Good job, guys.
Oh my god.
This is why I hate playing against Hulk players.
Wolverine's to the right.
He's looking for...
He's half.
Shoot Logang.
He wants me, bro.
I stunned him.
I have Wolverine on me.
He's frozen.
Roadhog's frozen.
I'm with the Mantis.
I have to back out in two seconds.
I'm backing out.
Mantis dead.
Oh my god, please!
I tried to save you, Mantis!
Oh my god!
We have portal.
Bro, I can't move.
Oh my god.
You got portal now, Fabi.
Get on!
I see him, I see him.
Huge ult, huge ult.
Icebro's Hulk.
Jesus Christ.
Mantis on me, Mantis on me, Mantis on me.
I can't see you, Ironman.
I can't see you.
Psylocke?
Psylocke low.
Psylocke.
Oh.
That was an insane animal.
Oh my god.
Oh god, they sub one fight.
Maybe we can get a kill here and win the game.
I think they have a portal.
Maybe?
Yeah, they do, they do, they do, they do.
They're on point.
Our Strange needs help.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
I bowled him.
Kill the support, kill the support.
Strange is frozen.
How about Strange?
He's getting Rogan.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, that's bad.
I have a Psylocke on me.
I'm Strange.
Oh my god.
Yeah, they had portal.
That portal was clutch for them.
Oh my god, there was no...
I didn't have ult.
They had both support ults there.
Backwards!
Guys, you saw me walk backwards.
Why doesn't that work for me?
I don't understand.
Wait, I walked backwards.
I walked backwards.
What am I supposed to do?
Walking backwards is so hard.
Let's just walk backwards better.
Ow!
My legs don't work like that.
This is...
Who the fuck was your ma...
Oh, it's the subway surfer.
What is he...
What was he playing?
He was...
Oh, he was playing Psylocke.
Okay.
I feel like we should just ban Wolverine.
Instead of, like, magic.
I'd rather just freeze fucking...
Psylocke on me.
I have Hulk.
Hulk on me.
Hulk and Wolverine.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
A Hulk half!
Hulk one, Hulk one!
Any heals?
I'm like one.
He's up.
Can we kill him?
Kill the Hulk, maybe?
I can bubble this.
Okay.
Bubble the strength.
I want Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk.
I got...
Wait, what?!
What?!
My pick is...
I'm mad.
I actually...
Mad is low.
Wulgan, Wulgan, guys.
Wulgan's gonna kill everyone.
Wolverine half.
I'm so fucking mad.
Like...
Hulk one, Hulk one.
It actually went off my screen!
This is exactly why I banned the East Coast.
What?!
Actually...
Actually pinged him!
Like...
I have to predict the future 20 seconds in!
I got Wolverine ult here, too.
Yeah, they do.
Oh my god.
Wulgan half, Wulgan half, Wulgan, Wulgan.
He's solo.
Oh my god.
Like, what do you do in that situation?
I'm walking backwards!
I think we should fight on point.
Just get the...
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
We all walked out of point.
That sucks.
Wait, Wolverine one, Wolverine one.
Guess I'm here.
Oh my god.
Like, I don't understand why we didn't fight on point with the Mantis ult.
We literally just needed to walk to the point with the Mantis ult.
That's literally all we had to do.
Please.
Hulk on our Mantis.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
I'm like...
I have to heal so many people.
Oh, it's done.
This is last fight.
How far are you guys?
I'm just gonna ult this.
This is last fight.
Yeah, I'm going to backline.
Nice.
I'm on Mantis.
Wolverine, Wolverine on point.
Wolverine on point.
They're gonna have Strange ult too.
Oh my god.
Bro, what the fuck?
I saw that.
I was like, holy fuck.
You should have Strange ult and Psylocke ult here.
I think I'm gonna have low gank soon.
I'm scared.
Guys, I don't know.
I want to believe.
Oh, on me, on me, on me.
I froze somebody.
That's a huge ult.
That's huge, that's huge.
I'm just dead.
I bubble you, bro.
Peel this, peel this and win this.
How far Mantis is it possible?
Oh, I'm dead.
And our enemy is held too.
Guys, kill Hulk.
Leave, leave, leave.
Oh, I'm coming back.
I'm coming back.
I don't think they didn't use anything for that fight.
They used Hulk.
They didn't use Hulk?
Okay.
Low gank stun on me.
Oh, I'm scared.
Oh my god.
Oh, down point, down point.
Wolverine.
Oh, we won.
Wolverine won.
No, no passive.
Oh my god.
I have Wolverine on me.
Oh, you only have Mantis heals.
Only Mantis heals.
You don't have points, so you have to stay on point to fight.
Oh no.
Kill their Mantis, kill their Mantis.
Baby, you guys live.
I have support ult.
We can live this.
Just don't leave point, don't leave point.
We don't have point.
Alright.
Alright, I'm putting a show.
Psylocke here.
Alright.
Oh.
Wolverine, Wolverine.
Wolverine.
She's really slow.
Oh my god.
We did it.
Adam and I had the fucking worst time ever.
Oh my god.
We were not having a good time.
See, Adam and I are like...
I want to die.
Adam and I look at each other and we're just like, here comes the hulk.
Thank you for the Twitch prize.
Thank you.
Thank you for the tier one.
Thank you, thank you Clover.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate for those who are new here.
My name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube, but we're doing the fucking Marvel Rivals ranked time on Twitch.
Because I don't know how long this is gonna fucking take me.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, bro.
This is why I hate playing against Hulk.
Adam and I are just like, alright, what do we do?
We just look at each other and I'm just like, what do we do, Adam?
Do we just die?
I...
I guess we die.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is a fucking...
Oh my god, this lobby is...
Holy shit, this is a fucking...
Oh my god, this is an insane lobby.
We got Beast, Halo, and Dosu.
We got...
They're really good players.
We got Overwatch players.
Yeah, this lobby is freaking insane.
This is a dressed up lobby.
Alright, uh...
Hawkeye.
Oh, magic?
Okay.
Maybe they're smarter in their bans than I am.
I just... I do Hawkeye first because, like, fuck, I never want to play against a Hawkeye player.
Just pray they don't ban Hela.
They ban Hela, guys.
Getting a Lord Hela portrait is actually very impressive.
It's incredibly impressive to get a...
To get a Lord Hela on...
With, you know, with the society we're in.
Yeah, you can get... I guess you can get it below Diamond, but if you're a really good Hela player...
You would climb really fast out of Diamond.
Like, you would... You can just climb so fucking fast that you don't need a...
That it takes even longer.
I'm curious.
I heard they're planning on buffing Storm next season.
Which, I have no idea how they're gonna do it because she's fucking ass.
Like...
The Doki buy the Battle Pass?
No.
I will buy the Battle Pass if Marvel Rival sponsors me.
That's my only condition.
I don't ask for much.
I just want money for it.
What?
I just don't ask for much.
I just want the company to give me money.
That's all I want.
That's so real for that.
That's not too much to ask for, guys, right?
It's not too much.
Whoa.
Oh, someone says, I have a higher win rate on Mantis than I do on Luna.
Isn't that crazy?
But yeah, here I am playing Luna.
It's because I play too much Luna.
Where are we?
What the...
How did she die so fast?
I don't know if I want to be here.
I'm helping our Bucky down here.
Guys, it was okay.
Guys, I purposely went downstairs to help our Bucky.
I don't know why I always fall off in that area.
I don't know why I keep doing that.
Every time I TP there, every...
I don't know.
I don't know what's wrong with me.
That area is actually my kryptonite.
I cannot deal with that freaking area.
It doesn't happen to me to anywhere else.
It's literally that one section that makes me fall every fucking time.
And I don't know how to fix myself.
I don't know what to do.
I legitimately don't know what to do.
I just...
It's just every time.
Oh my god, they have a Captain America.
Wait.
Oh, Froze Strange!
Froze Strange!
Oh my god.
I might need to just pop off here.
I'm ulting here.
Sweet.
Alright.
I'm pushing back mine.
Do we have anything?
I'm backing out.
Nice.
Nice leap.
I'm getting run at by Strange.
And Captain America.
Oh, and everything else, I guess.
I'll get run at by everything, I guess.
Alright.
I was like, oh, there's Strange!
Oh, Captain America too!
Alright.
And then Bucky.
That's fine.
Again.
Where's our Syla?
Oh, there he is.
Alright.
There he is.
There he comes.
Alright.
This is fine.
I need to top off.
Nice.
Let's get the walkies.
I'm bottom of the ground now.
Strange on me.
Strange.
Where's... oh.
Oh my god, please.
I need care.
I'm pushing this.
Yeah, like, I need care.
I'm pushing.
Oh my god.
Please!
Top, top, top, top, top, top one.
They're portaling in, they're portaling in.
I got owl first, owl first.
Nice.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, alright.
They have their support ults here.
Strange is low, strange is low.
Oh, they got both supports.
I didn't have anything.
That sucked.
We were so close.
We were so close to capping that too.
Oh my god, I didn't have my freeze.
I didn't have my freeze there.
I hate the eye.
I hate it.
It's gonna be difficult, yeah.
It's gonna be difficult.
Some people are like, oh, when season one comes, I'm gonna be just as addicted.
Not in rank.
I only get addicted in rank for the first season.
And then after that, I just check it out casually.
I will play rank ever so often, but I won't be as obsessive as I am right now.
No, it's true!
It happened for me in Overwatch 2!
I got top 500 in Overwatch 2, and then I stopped caring as much.
I still play it ever so often, but I don't care as much.
But right now, it's also the hit new game right now.
And everybody's playing it, and I haven't been this competitive in a long fucking time.
So for me, I haven't been so this competitive, so I just wanna play.
I just wanna grind.
I haven't grinded video games like this in a long time.
That's for sure.
It's true!
I haven't!
I haven't grinded rank like this in a long time!
You guys are lucky though.
If you were in my Apex Grand Rank era, I literally disappeared for months.
I wouldn't even tell people I'd be gone.
I'd just disappear when I got my Pred.
I'm scared.
Oh!
Oh my god!
What the fuck happened?!
There's people here left too.
Ground point.
Oh my god!
I can't!
What happened?!
What the fuck?!
They just died!
Disappeared!
What the fuck happened?!
They literally just evaporated!
You don't wanna play inside though, no?
I think we wanna be...
You know what?
No enemies today.
That's crazy.
Just today...
Today...
Today there's...
Today we're not gonna...
We're not gonna say anything today.
Bro has no enemies.
That's crazy.
On the seventh day, there were no enemies.
He's just chill like that, guys.
I don't think there was anything...
I don't think I could've done anything to save those guys.
Dude, they were like...
They were like fucking dead.
They were so fucking dead there.
There was nothing I could do to save them.
Like, they literally got...
They hooked two...
Wait, how did they...
Oh, yeah.
This guy hooked two people into them.
And I was like, what do I do?
I could just...
I clap.
I just clap.
That's all I can do.
I clap and hope for the best.
I wanna be Luna.
We have to ban Mantis?
Oh, we have a Scarlet Witch one trick.
Oh, what the fuck is this?
I...
I'm just...
What am I...
What is my comp?
Why do...
Why do I have to get both the one tricks?
Why can't...
Why do I have both the one tricks on my team?
Why...
I...
I have both the Scarlet...
Like, I feel like it'd be more fair if one of them moves to the other team.
I don't know.
I just...
Is that...
Is that wrong for me to say?
It is not...
Oh, do I have compression?
It's cause the bitrate for Twitch...
I might need...
I think I just need to play around with my settings, but the maximum bitrate for...
Oh, okay.
Wow.
Okay.
Uh...
So, like...
Because of that, when a lot of activity is going on...
That's why it gets, like, pixelated.
Because the bitrate...
Maximum bitrate you can have on Twitch is, like, 6k.
So, like...
I don't know.
I need to, like, talk to Twitch people to figure out how to fix that.
Oh, absolutely not.
No, I...
I believe it.
This game just wants me to suffer.
I just need to min-max my stacks.
I need a DPS player in the stack, too.
That's it.
We got...
It's, like, support, tank, DPS, min-max.
But we...
Right now, we only adopted a tank player.
Wait, Rocket Raccoon?
Okay, but we banned Mantis, so it's fine.
It's fine.
We banned Mantis, so it's okay.
Oh my god, our one-tricks are not playing their one-tricks.
Oh my god, what a fucking...
What a time to be alive.
I remember when everyone thought Rocket Raccoon was good.
Especially with this map.
Oh my god, okay.
Oh my god.
I'm scared.
I have fly in four seconds.
Oh my god.
We were walled off, Strange.
Strange Nation is never walled off.
Oh, you're walled off again.
Fuck, I might be walled off.
Our Raccoon needs help.
Oh.
There's a Hawkeye in main.
Guys, I'm fucking dead.
Raccoon, please, you see?
Okay, okay.
Poor, poor little guy.
Poor little guy.
He deserves it.
Just call it when you want it.
I don't think he uses comms.
How do you call when the Raccoon and...
Can you top me off real quick?
I don't know if I should...
No, they have Strange over here.
I'm ulting this.
Alright, live!
Live!
I have my ult out for this.
Strange has ult as well.
Alright.
I froze Groot.
You know, I thought they would take, you know...
I legitimately thought they were going to take more damage, so I did the clap, but...
Oh, Groot is half.
Oh, nice.
I don't think we need any ults left.
We don't need ult anymore.
Wait, are they running?
Okay, no.
They still have Tripp.
They should have Hawkeye and Strange ult here.
Alright.
It's fine.
I have a 30% win rate on Cloak and Dagger.
It's not something to brag about, but you cannot put me on her.
For the sake of our team, I should never be allowed to touch Cloak and Dagger.
I don't even think it's me!
I just think I'm put in unwinnable situations.
When I'm playing Cloak and Dagger, it's just literally just unwinnable.
Like, we're even right now.
Oh, nevermind.
I can't see you.
Alright.
I mean, at least it isn't zero, right?
Yeah, right.
At least it is zero!
They have Stranger as well.
Strangers have.
Oh, get in my ult, get in my ult, Penny!
Oh my god.
Alright, I'm backing up.
Oh!
I keep forgetting this pull.
I keep forgetting that pull exists sometimes.
Oh, he's E'd.
I'm like, use your Z!
Woo!
I'm serious!
I was at the end!
Every time!
Every fucking time.
I got caught in the corner.
It was a really good whale ult though, to be fair.
I'm fucking leaving.
I leave.
Goodbye.
You can have my orb, Wolverine.
I leave.
Why did you just walk away?
God, I wish... man.
I wish I could just walk away.
I don't understand!
I was in the corner!
Like, I feel like when you're at the edge, you're supposed to take less damage.
I don't know, maybe I'm fucking crazy when I'm in that.
Maybe.
Maybe I'm just dumb for thinking that that's the...
I won.
Like, five people have one health left.
I walk.
I can't see you.
I see you, I see you for heals.
I'd reload.
I'm ulting this, I'm ulting this.
I don't wanna die to the... I don't wanna die to the fucking Hawkeye, so I'm fucking... I'm trying to...
Let's not die to the Hawkeye ult!
He has strange ult.
He's dead.
I won.
Jesus Christ.
I don't think I have it yet.
Should I use it?
I have to reload, you can heal.
Jesus Christ, you guys are all taking a million damage!
Is she ulting you?
Oh.
Strange.
Listen to the mic, mic, mic.
Jesus... Oh my god!
He fucking exploded!
And he's looking for the ult.
Oh, I got hit, I got hit!
It's fine.
I went strange.
Oh my god!
He's one, he's one.
No more slow to.
He's one, he's one, please.
He's one, please guys, turn around.
Strange!
Is he one?
Is he still one?
I'm pushing this, I'm pushing this.
Guys, I want to know, is he still one?
Guys?
Strange, strange, strange, strange.
Is he still one, guys?
Shut the hulk down.
There's uh, no more to our left.
Oh my god.
I got them all.
Oh my god, nice.
You're so healthy.
I swear to...
Get the turret!
I'm alive.
That's all that matters.
I did it, guys.
I dodged the fucking no more ult.
Guys, are you proud of me?
I fucking did it.
I...
I fucking...
I did it.
We're so proud, right here.
Did he do it?
Oh my god.
There's a hulk at main.
I'm ulting this.
Oh, they see nine.
Point out that your ult does a lot more damage if you're full range, bro.
Oh, really?
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
Guys, I did it.
I walked to the left, guys.
I fucking...
I did it.
I walked to the left.
That's called character development right there.
I'm gonna admit though, today's not like my best day.
I'm gonna admit, today's definitely not my best day.
My best gaming day.
I can feel it.
We did pretty good at kidnapping them, though.
Oh, we're doing good.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you for echo chambering me.
We?
No!
Okay, fat nojoki.
Find that guy out.
You're supposed to be like, no, doki.
You're doing great.
I didn't even notice.
You're supposed to gas me up.
I'm just gonna take him back to your portal.
Alright, we should defight.
That's right, it was a trap all along.
That's fucking right.
I was gonna trap you.
I'm gonna put down a tank, just because I don't trust...
Can you bubble me?
Nice.
I can feed right side.
Come right.
I'm walking, I'm walking, I'm walking, but I'm a little scared.
I'm a little scared about this position.
Oh my god!
What do I look at?
You're down a healer.
I feel so trapped.
Holy shit, I felt so trapped there.
I have no shield.
You're LOSing me right now.
Yeah, they're...
Tank, tank, tank, tank, tank.
Oh my god, I wish that were me though.
Who was that for?
That looked targeted.
That actually looked so targeted.
Not gonna lie.
That looked incredibly targeted.
That was so close to me.
Oh god, to the left.
He's half.
Oh, I didn't even notice that guy was there.
I literally...
I have ult so you can heal, Cloak.
You can go up, I have ult.
Alright, he ain't...
Okay, I didn't even think God it wasn't directed at me.
I was...
I was a little worried there.
I thought it was...
I was like, after everything I went through.
Yeah, I just want our Cloak to get support ult.
Cause I already have mine, so there's no use for me to push up.
That's Overwatch trap, baby.
What the fuck hit me?
Strange one, strange one.
You got this, bro.
Is this winnable?
Should I ult?
No, nevermind.
If they push up a bit, I'll ult it.
Oh, nevermind.
I'm back.
Okay, that's fine.
It's alright.
I need a little top off, please.
Please top me off, please top me off.
We're fucking worthy.
I'm ulting this in.
Just for us.
Alright.
We should have Strange ult, though.
Oh, my ult's over.
I'm a little scared.
Strange half, strange low, strange one, strange one.
Oh, he's doing it, he's doing it.
My god, you did it.
Thanks, bro.
Oh, my god.
He grew up.
Yeah, it might be.
No, nevermind, they swapped.
No strange.
What are they doing?
Oh, they're doing DPS.
Oh, my god.
He actually grew up.
We watched his character grow.
I learned how to walk left and he learned how to wolverine ult.
That's fucking crazy.
Push, push, push, push, push.
Push, push, push.
Alright.
There's no way he hits me there.
Yeah.
We can win this, we can win this.
I'm really low, though.
Oh, that's fine.
Magneto, one.
Or half.
I got him.
Oh, I can't, though.
I got stunned.
Nice kill, nice kill.
Can you live?
Live, live, live.
Back, back, back, back, back.
Give me heals.
Okay, I'm really ulting for you.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Alright.
Oh, sorry, I can't save you from a headshot.
Oh, goodbye.
He got headshot.
I was like, sorry, buddy.
My heals are great.
But, bro, I...
Guys, that's a headshot right there.
That's rough.
I'm not peeking.
Holy fuck.
This is why we ban Hawkeye, everybody.
This is exactly why we ban Hawkeye.
There's a Star Lord to your left.
Star Lord behind us.
Nice kill.
Oh my god.
Star Lord's still behind us.
Can't do anything about it.
No!
I'm dead.
You have no supports.
Remember when I said there's a Sturzy?
Just use it.
You're a Magneto.
Face a lot.
I need heals too.
I need heals as well.
That's awkward.
I need a top off.
Oh my god, I need a focus now.
Shoot the Star Lord.
He's not missing.
Help our Punisher, Reds.
I can't see you, Punisher.
He's one.
Nice, I'm pushing in.
Watch out.
This is his last fight.
How do you reload?
Got him.
I forced Squirtle.
If we live, we win this.
Watch out the Hawkeye one-shot.
Right side, right side, watch out.
I'm not peeking this.
You're welcome to Luna ult now.
Yeah, I can ult now.
Yeah, I'm going to do it.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go.
The backline.
Luna ult.
Nice.
Nice, nice.
There's a Squirtle girl to our left.
Squirtle girl to our left.
And Magneto to our behind us.
Magneto and Cloak behind.
Cloak, Cloak, Cloak, Cloak.
Cloak half.
Cloak one.
This guy.
I'm backing out from cart so I can heal.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
Thank god we beat a mutant.
That's right.
I didn't change my viewpoint.
Not again.
No, I'll never change it.
What do you mean?
What do you mean a non-mutant helped us?
I don't see no mutant being MVP.
Luna's my one exception.
She's my one.
Damn you Doki Striker.
She's one of the good mutants.
Eddboi, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Trusty Blue Nose, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
And Herbalist, thank you for the Tier 1 sub.
Thank you, thank you.
I need 60 points to be on the leaderboard.
But I think 250 is like the cutoff for it by the end of the season.
That's messed up.
What are you, a war criminal like Professor Xavier?
I bet you endorse a war criminal.
That's right, I'm anti-mutant.
Not this shit again.
It's true.
GamePig, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
I just think it's weird.
He's literally using children as soldiers.
Is that not fucking weird?
Is that...
We need to investigate Professor Xavier and shut down his school.
We need to...
That's true.
Wait, hold up.
Wait, she's cooking right now.
Hold on.
The children yearn for war.
Does Logan even have a degree?
Why is he teaching children?
Does he even have a fucking degree?
Does he even have a PhD?
He still needs a teaching degree to be of any sort of teaching.
Logan doesn't teach.
Also, is he even in American League?
All I'm saying is he's Canadian.
He's not even American.
He's Canadian.
How did he get to America?
No!
He escaped Canada.
Fucking fought multiple American wars.
Wait, does he actually teach?
Does he actually have a teaching license?
No, I know he's an art teacher, but does he actually?
I just like thinking he went to...
He's just going to school just so he can get a teaching license.
He's just going to fuck.
He has to go to university to get a teaching license.
Alright, we're fine.
We're so fine.
Wait, what?
Oh, okay.
Oh, I think he knows my 30% win rate on cloak and dagger.
I think...
I think he knows.
My Adam's not even that bad!
I swear to God.
My Adam's not even that bad.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
He's so... I didn't even fucking touch cloak!
Wait, where's the TP?
Bro, I can't... I hate the clutter on this specific area though.
This specific area?
Oh my God.
We can't... Oh, there's a strange sleeping...
Oh my God, I can't see!
I hate this area in general.
It's so hard to see.
I cannot see there.
Oh,
well, goodbye.
He'll be fine.
Here.
He'll be so healthy.
See?
He's so healthy.
Look at how healthy he is.
I... Okay, look at how healthy he is.
He's so healthy!
Look at him go!
It's so scary.
With this amount of heals, it's so scary.
It's like, you don't have that much heals in general.
Where's Hulk?
Oh!
Anyway, well...
I got him!
Hulk out!
Kael'thas?
Oh, strange one!
Strange one!
Alright, nice.
Nice!
We did it!
Yippee!
I hate playing... At least, like, I'm on Mantis so, like, I don't have to worry too much about, like, getting ran at by Hulk.
Because, like, at least I have...
God, I'm not... I need to, like, get used to Mantis Projectile.
At least I have Sleep.
I mean, to be fair, I have Freeze too, but Sleep has a... Feels like... Feels like people don't fucking wake people up.
Oh!
Oh, sorry, Bob!
Sorry.
I'm trying to help you.
I don't have leaves anymore.
Oh my god, I had no leaves!
I had no leaves and I was freaking out!
I'm gonna grab TP.
I'm gonna TP.
No, Mantis does not hit Scan.
She's Projectile.
That's why I hate, um... Her aim fucks me up sometimes.
Because of it.
Oh my god, where did he go?
Where did he go?
He's one.
I remember one health!
One health!
Oh my god.
I should've killed him.
He's one, I guess.
Train is half.
I have a... I have a Hulk on me.
I'm 97 on ult.
I'm 97.
I have it.
I'm on Hulk.
Hulk one.
Hulk is low.
Alright, nice.
Oh my god!
I got ult just in time.
That's a hateful aim.
That is huge.
You should have Starlord ult here.
There we go.
I'm on Mantis.
Mantis low.
Mantis one.
Ironman low.
Oh, Ironman one.
Oh my god, please!
I believe in you.
There's a Hulk that's like sleeping in the back.
Hulk one.
Oh, goodbye.
I have gamma.
Chill.
No, it's fine.
That poor Ironman.
Holy shit.
I just saw the Ironman and just...
Oh my god.
The poor guy.
He actually fucking went in.
What was that?
Who was that leader?
Of the anti-mutant person?
Something striker?
Yeah, no.
I'm taking it too far.
Striker.
It called me dookie striker.
I think she's called me dookie striker.
Okay, striker.
A new costume idea.
Wait, I'm striker.
Alright.
Oh, do your thing.
I wonder if jumping affects...
Because I normally don't jump because I got trained to not jump in Apex.
But I don't know if it's actually helpful to jump.
That's the thing.
I don't know.
Because I see so many people... I don't know.
I'm on strange.
Strange is half.
Strange is low.
Oh god.
I don't know.
I have no idea if jumping is bad or not.
Because in Apex, it's so bad.
Because it makes you super predictable.
I can't see you, Iron Man.
I might counter ult this.
I can't see you.
Oh, nevermind.
Iron Man just walked into me.
Yeah, that was my bad.
That's why I don't know.
I don't know if jumping is good for...
Because I used to jump in Overwatch.
So I don't know if it's actually good to jump.
Or not.
Yo, strange is right here.
He's looking for ult.
Strange, strange, strange, strange.
I slept the... Hulk.
I'm ulting.
Oh, he froze me.
Where are people?
I'm so confused.
It's so cluttered.
I meant as a support.
Because as a squishy, I can't tell if you're squishy if it's good or not.
I'm not gonna look at that yet.
I slept the Mantis.
Mantis is half.
Iron Man is half too.
Okay, I'm getting shot at by Hulk.
Hulk is on me.
Hulk is low.
Army Hulk is low.
Oh my god.
No, I don't have leap for you.
Hulk one.
I'm a little scared.
Are they portals?
They're all through it.
I'm ulting this.
Stay with me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm coming.
I have gamma.
I'm damage boosting you.
Strange one, strange one, strange one.
He's low.
I'm on lowkey.
Lowkey half.
Oh,
there's an Amora at the top.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, they swapped a cloak.
We have no supports.
We're both coming back now.
Strange one, strange one.
Boomer, I got you Boomer.
Thank you.
Amora at half.
No.
I got an Amora.
Wait, I can.
It's time.
I'm going as fast as I can.
This will be game changer.
This will be game...
I'm trying.
I'm on strange, strange half.
Strange one, strange one.
Strange actually one.
Get Jeffed.
It worked.
The Jeffswapped worked.
I had to start spitting.
I knew it.
I knew the Jeff would work.
I started spitting.
I figured it was the way to go.
Because, you know, I thought that Mantis doesn't give enough heals for the last fight.
Because all I can do is just throw leaves.
And I only have four leaves.
So I was like, it's time to start spitting.
Usually you got Jeffed at the last fight.
If you're the last support to die, you have to swap to Jeff so you can get back faster.
I mean, to be fair, Mantis gets back faster too.
But then Jeff gives more heal output for the last fight.
Also Archive, thank you for tier one!
And Omni, thank you for tier one!
So thank you!
We're like, we've been playing with the same people.
Is this the EastieQs?
Is this what it's like to be in the EastieQs?
You just play with like...
You just play with these same people over and over again.
Yeah, Luna was banned.
That's why I was on Mantis.
She was banned.
My 54% win rate with Luna.
It's because I play a lot of games on Luna.
That's really it.
I just have so many games played, guys.
Yikes.
Silo?
Okay.
I have a 64% win rate on Mantis.
Hey, I'm good with that, ban Silo.
Okay, whatever.
Everyone pick it.
I already picked Taka.
I don't fucking care.
I don't give a damn.
Doki Nation, we need your vote.
For what?
Silo?
Whatever your heart desires.
Alright.
Thank god.
Awesome!
My win rate?
No, I'm not.
I get into some crazy loss streaks.
I would get like really good win streaks and then some fucking crazy loss streaks.
Are we attack or defense first?
Like, we've been there.
We've all been there.
It's really...
It do be like that.
It's the GM era where I struggle the most.
I think GM was where I like actually was not great.
It was not like feeling it.
During the GM era, I was not... I was not feeling it.
I was back and forth for the longest time.
I would be like GM... I would jump from GM1 to GM2 to GM3 to GM2 to GM1 to GM2.
And then finally I got to Eternity and it's...
Every time I get to a new rank, I get to stay there for a little bit.
I will respect you.
GM was like my purgatory.
It was my fucking purgatory of hell.
Wait, we're solo tanking.
I just realized.
I just realized we're solo tanking.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, I need to clap.
I'm gonna start clapping.
There's a lot of damage being taken right now.
Oh, that's...
Oh my god.
I need to reload.
I can't help you.
No, nobody was taking damage.
Change one, change one.
There's a Punisher top left.
We need to get him.
It's a Bucky now.
Oh yeah, sorry Bucky.
Okay, these kids don't know how to play against Black Panther.
I'm telling you, every time I dodge them, they're...
Stay alive, stay alive.
We win, we win.
3, 2, 1.
You kidding that?
Magno, right side.
We have Punisher.
Change one.
Oh, Punisher's behind us, Punisher's behind us.
I don't have ult.
I will reinforce.
They're double ulting.
I have ult here.
I'm ulting this.
Kill the supports.
It ends in 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
It's gone.
They have Bucky on me.
They used Bucky off there.
Did they Luna ult that?
I got...
They used it.
I got Luna.
No, it was theirs too.
Oh my god.
There's a turret.
Oh, we're dead here.
Again.
Oh no, again.
Oh, he got it.
I saw him die.
We can't heal you there.
I'm gonna start...
I killed one.
That poor guy.
Oh, please top me off a little bit.
Jesus Christ.
I have to reload.
Oh my god.
Please.
Jesus Christ.
You're all taking so much damage.
I am ready to put on a show.
Why are we not killing the turrets?
I'm ulting here.
Okay, maybe we didn't...
Maybe we didn't need that.
They used again, right?
Yep, they used again.
I'm gonna go no more.
So they should have Magneto ult then.
And maybe Vantus ult.
I'm going backwards.
I'm scared.
Oh my god.
There it is.
They're hard pushing.
Alright.
Fear!
Frozen Magneto.
Fear.
Mag half.
I should go shield him.
Oh, you're...
I can heal you.
I got you.
Nice, my goat.
One fear.
I hear fear.
Fear.
Actual fear.
He's fucking going crazy.
I have ult here.
Look, he's going to farm ult.
Oh my god.
I have two seconds.
Two seconds.
I can't see.
I can't see!
Oh, I'm gonna ult this here.
It's fine.
Oh, I can't see you, Punisher.
No more ult.
Oh my god.
Not again!
How?!
Why were they all split up?
Our lowkey is 10% to ult.
Oh, nevermind.
He fucking did.
Why did our Punisher not drop down?
Oh my god!
Why did he not drop down?!
I literally was just ulting this for a strange...
If it was like...
God, Punisher, goddamn you!
Okay.
Oh my god, I'll fucking get rid of the turrets.
Guys, there's three of us.
One of us should be able to hit that turret, right?
Oh.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Don't worry, you're so healthy!
You're so healthy!
I'm like 10% left to ult.
Bucky no ult.
I got Bucky ult.
I'll get my Bucky ult here.
I'm 10% if you guys can...
I have 9%.
5%?
I have it, I have it, I have it.
I'm doing it!
Play around me again.
Okay, sorry.
Two seconds, two, one, zero, no more.
Oh, the Bucky's on me.
Bucky low, Bucky low!
Oh, he's getting healed, nevermind.
Nice, nice, we got Bucky, we got Bucky.
You guys, we're up one.
I need a third Punisher.
I'm helping, I'm helping, I'm helping now, I'm helping.
It's huge, it's huge.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
I have no more on me.
No more, no more, no more.
I have no more, no more, one.
Bucky no ult.
Oh my god, Magnio's one, Magnio's one.
Alright, nice.
If you keep bullying their Bucky, we'll win.
He's MVP'd every single one of his last 20 games.
He's obviously cheating.
He's distracting people through walls.
I think he was cheating a couple of times ago, but it's kind of...
I don't know.
Wait, is that right?
Is that right, is that guy?
Let's just match history after this.
I thought he was cheating a few games ago, but...
Repair won't hurt.
Yeah.
You know what they need to do in this game?
They need to make it so if you play as a cheater...
Whoa, whoa.
It's a simple mechanic.
At least no one's saying that one about me and Boger.
Oh, this guy.
This guy belongs here.
Wait, did it save?
Can we call triple support?
Triple support.
Who are you?
Answer the question.
Why would you think that?
Whoa.
No.
I'm woman too.
I'm also woman.
Alright, it's fine.
I need to break more turrets.
Oh, you're so low.
Jesus Christ, I clap, I clap, I clap, I clap, I clap, I clap, I clap, I clap.
It's alright, I still clap.
I keep clapping until stuff happens.
I do my job.
All I do is clap.
Oh my god.
There's a Bucky on high ground.
Jesus Christ.
This is my job.
I know my place.
I heal like this.
Hoping for something new to happen.
I just keep healing.
And then I start clapping.
It's like my own 9 to 5.
This is my 9 to 5.
It's called the clap to 5.
Alright, it's fine.
Holy fuck, I'm gonna be on the cart.
Why is one healed?
3 seconds, 2, 1.
I'm dead here to Bucky.
Bucky has it again.
Again.
Oh, he lost it again.
What support ults did they use there?
Oh, so they still have Mantis then.
They used Bucky ult too.
That's crazy though.
Alright.
He'll be okay, right?
You'll be okay, my little guy.
Alright.
I need to push with the Luna ult.
Oh my god.
I need to reload.
Oh, Wolverine, Wolverine.
No more, no more, no more.
It's on our Wolverine.
No more, one.
Come on, walk, walk, walk.
They die, they die, they die.
Alright.
I'm pushing up.
He has no abilities.
Max has no abilities.
He's cutting himself off.
He has no bubble, no shield.
We're coming up.
Don't worry.
Everything will be fine.
They have their Luna ult back.
I can't see you, Wolverine.
I'm ulting to you guys.
That's good, good, good.
I'm telling you, you can eat it.
Let me cut that.
Three seconds, three seconds, two, one.
I'm backing up.
He just pre-hooked me through a wall.
Oh, oh.
That's unfortunate.
They have strange ult here.
I can't, oh, I have to reload there.
Probably dead here.
Wait, can we talk?
What?
He got it again?
Wait, he has it again?
Yeah.
I'm telling you.
He's cheating.
I'm not gonna lie.
If he is cheating, there's no way to lose.
Wait, is he like, is he actually dealing with their Luna?
Probably.
But I think we still win this game if we luck it.
He plays with a lot of pro players, though.
Alright.
Like, I've seen that Jhin girl before, and she duos with, I know she stacks with a lot of pro players.
That's why I'm like, I'm like surprised if she's playing with a cheater.
We gotta push for that.
What?
Okay, let's watch this.
I'm down, I'm down, I got died to, Bucky.
Bucky's gonna get his ult in the next fight.
Oh, that's true.
But like, the guy is on a GM3 account, so it lowers the matchmaking for her.
That's why I'm like, are you sure she's cheating?
Cause I've seen that Jhin girl play with like, a lot of pro players in rank, so I'm like, I don't know.
Cause I've seen her play with like, Mace before.
I'm about to mag her.
Wait, I got mag her, I got mag her.
That's why I'm like, are you sure?
I'm gonna mag with you.
Mag his half, mag his half.
Oh, it's Tristana, Tristana's frozen.
I'm gonna ult to try and save you.
I'm pushing up with this.
4 seconds, 3, 2, 1.
I'm trying to keep you up.
We can't get to you.
Oh my god.
Tower is off the essence.
Okay, I'm just far.
Wait, this is our last fight.
6 seconds though.
Oh my god.
Oh, Berserker.
Again.
Look at his...
Like, he literally built his ult.
We capped first, he used it, and then we're second halfway and he's already using it again.
What the fuck.
I mean, we just look at the replay.
Rosa carrying from the back of the bus.
Holy shit.
That's why I'm like hesitant on the whole cheating allegations, because I know Din plays with pro players.
Like, stacks with pro players.
So like, I mean, I play with Boger.
That's why I'm like...
But I play with people who are like, who are known accounts.
Rosa is clearly an alt account, because it's a GM account.
So it's a pro player on a smurf account.
So like, that's why I'm like, I don't think he's hacking, just because I know who Din plays with.
Because I've seen her play with Mace.
I've seen her play with Mace, and I've seen her play with a lot of other pro players.
So I know, like, it's really weird if she fucking duos with a hacker all of a sudden.
Yeah.
I just think it's weird if she suddenly decides to duo with a hacker.
Yes, oh wait.
Oh wait, no, it's an Eternity account.
I thought it was a GM account.
Okay, it's just an Eternity account.
So it's somebody on an alt account.
It's an alt account.
Yeah, there's a tournament thing.
I thought it was a GM account.
But it's definitely an alt account, because it's level 22.
You're like, it's spectating time!
You're like, it's time!
I just think it's just a good player that's on an alt account.
That's really all I think.
Pull up the VOD.
I don't need to spectate, just because I know it's just a really good player.
I just thought it was funny.
Well, it wasn't funny, but like...
I'm just like, damn.
Damn.
Misogyny insults are so fucking low tier, though.
It's so low tier.
Insult where it actually hurts.
Like, that's what I'm saying.
If you use misogyny as an insult, it's such a low tier insult.
Just insult skills.
If you really want to hurt somebody, that's how high I feel.
I mean, no, Rose is fucking insane.
He's actually insane.
I don't know who he is, but he's good.
I shine in darkness.
You're bad at this game.
Yes, because I spent...
I have 120 plus hours on Marvel Rivals.
If you call me bad, I will cry.
It's like, all those hours for nothing?
It's literally all those hours I spent.
What do I do?
Was it all for nothing?
Yay, now I'm getting boosted by Rosa!
Let's go!
I swear to God, if you fucking...
If you lose this for me, Rosa, I'm fucking reporting you.
I swear to God.
Oh shit, my knuckles.
I'm surprised they're not banning Bucky.
I'm so surprised.
Yay!
Starlord.
Starlord is 8th tier.
Imagine if Rosa throws...
I swear to God, I'll fucking report him live on stream.
Woman boosted.
Oh my God.
If I'm getting boosted, we're all getting...
Alright, it can't be woman boosted.
Because there's men in this team too.
We're all on the same boat together.
We're all also getting boosted together.
So, men and women boosted?
I like how they called out Din for saying that she's getting boosted.
When she has an entire fucking team that's on the backs of Rosa.
Everybody on that team was getting hard carried by Rosa.
Equal opportunity boosting, let's go!
Oh my God, now two women are...
Oh my God.
Alright, Rosa, you get this.
Let's go.
Now it's my turn.
It's my turn.
Let's fucking go.
There's a Psylocke behind us.
I froze Iron Fist.
Oh my God, I got stuck on the fucking walls.
That was awkward.
We're up two, we should push up.
You're welled out for heals?
Groot, Groot, Groot, Groot on Mantis.
Alright, nice.
Everything is fine.
Oh, there he goes again!
Oh, he's dead.
No!
Iron Fist, Iron Fist.
He already got the ult, isn't that fucking crazy?
Go, Rosa, go!
Go, Rosa!
Do your thing, Rosa!
Wait, wait, stream, stream, stream!
Stream is half.
Mantis.
We can do Mantis ult first.
Alright.
For womankind!
Well, maybe I should...
I was gonna say, maybe I should add Rosa and poach him.
Oh shit.
Let me just, let me poach Rosa real quick.
I ain't, I'm shameless, that's a Q, right?
I'm ulting this.
They have, they basically have all their ults.
Oh nevermind, they're dead.
Iron Fist one, Iron Fist low.
Iron Fist half.
I'm gonna Strange.
They should have Strange ult here and Iron Fist ult.
Use both supports though.
Oh, there he goes!
Go, Rosa, go!
For womankind!
Let's go!
We get like two people at least down here.
Go have the time of your fucking life!
Oh, they can touch, they touch.
I can kill them, but it doesn't matter.
Assemble!
Go!
I'm alive!
Don't worry, Rosa's coming in!
Rosa, get in there!
Rosa, do your thing!
Rosa's here!
Captain, he's one, he's low, he's half.
There we go.
Go, Rosa, go!
Rosa's gonna...
He's gonna get in there and get his ult.
Let's fucking go!
Do that thing, Rosa!
What if I poach him?
What if I literally just steal him?
Tokido!
No, I'm gonna take him.
I'm a Rosa.
Oh my god, you're one of those women.
I'm gonna steal your...
Whoa, there's an Iron Fist behind me.
I'm gonna steal your red.
Steal your Bucky!
Okay, I got the Ashe.
No,
I don't wanna be a homewrecker!
Three, two, one.
No, I'm not a homewrecker!
It was just a joke!
For women, guys.
I would never do something that fucked up, guys.
Unless it's crazy.
Nope, nope.
I just get off now.
Oh, he's ready.
So as a joke...
It could save...
Oh, you're right!
It could save me five days!
Oh my god, you're so right.
Oh my god.
What do you mean?
Don't leave your Bucky around, Toekeeper!
That's different!
Don't leave your booster around, Toekeeper.
That is the truth.
Shaking my head.
Oh, I'm just saying.
It's right there.
Five days in and you're already free.
Don't leave your wife or husband.
I would never, guys.
I'm not a homewrecker, guys.
I'm not.
Guys, I'm not a homewrecker!
It was a joke!
It was a hee-haw!
Unless...
I'm gonna take your duel.
I don't believe you.
Guys, I would never.
That's so fucked up.
I would never.
For womankind, everybody.
For womankind!
Jesus Christ.
Clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap.
No more clapping, though.
No more clapping.
Oh, please top me off.
No!
And that's why I will add...
And that is why I will steal.
That was my line.
Alright, there you go.
It's fine.
It only takes one bad heal.
I froze strange.
I am ready to put on a show!
I'm like 20% off.
We kite this, and then we crash out, okay?
You can even get a little.
Oh my god.
We're up one.
In the corner.
Oh, here he goes!
He's coming in!
He's going in!
I have Black Panther on me.
Back here.
Here we go.
It's fine.
Why, why, why?
You're so healthy.
Why are you sleeping?
Why don't you sleep?
You're so healthy.
Black Panther's one.
Oh, he doesn't see me.
He doesn't see me.
Look at me go!
There we go.
Wait, did we kill Black Panther?
Yeah, I killed him.
Okay, okay.
We're one guy.
I could have had zero deaths, guys.
I'm poaching him.
I would never do something that fucked up.
It's all jokes, guys.
It's all a silly joke.
Oh, I didn't realize you got your ult.
Sorry.
It's fine.
We don't even need other ults.
Here we go.
Oh!
That's fine.
That's so fine.
All I'm saying...
I didn't know.
I didn't know she had her ult.
Please.
I didn't know!
I didn't know she got it!
I was like, she'll be fine.
I was not aware.
It's okay.
We just...
The more...
The longer we play, the more XP we get.
Guys.
We're XP farming.
Guys, we're XP farming.
We're hard XP farming.
He's half.
Oh.
Oh, again.
Oh, he's gonna...
He's gonna get again!
No!
Come on.
For women!
For womankind everywhere, Rosa!
We're...
Do something!
Let's stick out and do something.
Come on.
Do something.
Come on, Rosa.
Do it for women everywhere.
Come on.
I thought you had a reputation to uphold.
You got two women on this team.
Come on, Rosa!
There's a Black Panther.
There we go!
Go, Rosa, go!
Get another ult!
Wait, Mantis ult first.
Alright.
I will...
She'll get her.
Yeah, she has her ult.
I was like, should I heal?
It's fine.
You're so...
Oh my god.
He was not healthy.
I don't know what the fuck happened to him.
But he literally disappeared.
He...
He's looking for ult really hard here, by the way.
I got him.
He got nobody!
Fear, fear!
No more ult.
Oh my god!
Get me out of here!
Come on!
Rosa!
Go, Rosa, go!
Again, Rosa!
Women is everywhere!
Now that was fucking...
Do it for all the women!
That's looking right!
Women have been saved!
There's a Black Panther above.
Oh my god.
Yes, you can.
It's surprising that a lot of people don't know you can shoot this leap.
It's actually very surprising.
A lot of people do not know that and it's...
It's a little embarrassing.
You're walled off, Magnus.
Goodbye, Rosa.
No!
How could you disappoint the women in the chat?
Alright.
We're up one.
We should go.
We're half.
We're low.
We won.
Again!
God, I'm mad.
I love women.
Final score...
3...
2...
1...
Yeah, that archer seems so fast.
It's literally...
It's a Rosa diff.
Thank god for women.
He did it!
He did it for women everywhere!
Women are so cool.
I wish women were real.
Alright.
It's time.
You know what this means.
I'm not actually gonna potion, but...
Do you think he'll accept it?
No way!
I'm not ever...
I'm not a wallbreaker!
I just want to know if he'll accept it.
Okay.
Should you shoot your shot...
...or woman kind by stealing somebody else's DPS player?
Look, I didn't say all women.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'll be right back.
Back.
Are we Q-dodging?
Is that...
Oh, he's spectating!
Yeah, he's actually...
He's actually spectating.
Oh my god.
He's double-checking.
He's double-checking everything.
That's crazy.
He's like, alright, let's make sure.
I just added him as a friend.
Nothing more.
Guys, I wasn't poaching anybody.
I just added him as a friend.
You know?
That's it, guys.
That's it.
Cal, thank you for the Twitch Prime link.
Thank you.
Hat, thank you for the donation.
Thank you, thank you.
You keep singing a joke when you literally poached Mace from Wavy and you meanly crushed him in the match.
Oh yeah, by the way, here's a Wavy update.
Here's a...
He...
He's not having a good time today.
Oh wait, is Mack climbing?
Hey Mack, you doing okay?
Wait, Mack's climbing!
Let's fucking go!
I've always believed in him.
Good job.
Hun, Hun, thank you for the Twitch Prime link.
Thank you.
Ryko, the good tier 1 sub.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Is he Ashe?
I don't think he's hacking.
I just think he's just a really good player.
That's really it.
I don't think he's hacking.
Cause it'd be...
I don't know.
Just cause I know who they play with.
Cause it'd be like...
I don't know.
I just think it's...
Wait, he got off.
No.
I just think...
I think it'd be really weird.
Cause like...
It's a little weird.
To do that.
To play with a hacker.
For...
For like...
Rank points.
Especially when like...
She plays in super high elo.
With a lot of streamers.
And like there's not a lot of female players in super high elo.
That talks.
And she talks.
So like...
It's very...
I think it's very...
I don't think he's hacking.
Just cause like...
You lose more than you gain from that.
Like...
You lose so much more.
If you play with a hacker.
You're just...
You're like...
You're literally...
It's done.
It's literally done.
It happens.
Yeah.
But not if you're like a calmer.
If you actually like calm and try.
Especially in super high elo.
It's actually like...
It's...
I don't know.
Like most likely.
That's why I like trust them.
When they say he's not hacking.
Just cause like...
She literally plays with like mace.
And them.
So like...
I feel like that's really weird.
Like...
If you have like...
If you have the opportunity.
To play with one of the top players.
Legit top players.
Why the fuck would you play with a hacker?
Like...
That's really it.
If you can...
If you have like...
The opportunity.
To play with all these really really good players.
Like right now.
I'm playing with Boger.
Like...
I don't know.
But hey.
If she's gonna ruin her...
If they...
If she wants to ruin her reputation.
By dealing with a hacker.
We have VODs here.
So...
Like...
That's such a high risk.
Especially if you're in a streamer lot.
Like...
If you're in a streamer lobby.
And you're still...
If you're doing that.
It's just weird.
Yeah.
Like...
Why the fuck would you toggle on a streamer lobby?
At least...
Like...
Even if they don't know who I am.
You wouldn't toggle.
If like...
You see Boger.
Because Boger is literally like...
One of the representatives.
Of like...
Of...
Like...
He's like...
Really well known in the scene.
So like...
If you see Boger.
You wouldn't fucking toggle.
Your hacks against him.
Because...
If you're smart enough.
You'll fucking turn your hacks off.
In the streamer lobby.
Um...
AlphaLed.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Uh...
I appreciate it.
Maybe that's why you got off.
No way.
Oh shit!
Guys!
Oh my god!
We did it!
I'm not gonna...
Guys!
No!
That was in the...
I'm not gonna send...
Wait a minute!
Oh my god!
We did it!
It's your chat!
It's your...
Oh my god!
You know that the...
We did it everybody!
We fucking did it!
She's not beating the allegations.
No I'm not!
Guys!
I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna invite him.
Guys!
I'm not...
I'm not that fucked up everybody.
I...
I would never...
I can't!
He's in queue!
He's still there in the duo!
I can't!
I can't...
Guys!
Why are you encouraging this?
I'm trying to be a decent person here.
I'm trying to be a decent person.
I can't believe you...
What happened for womankind?
Guys!
What happened for women everywhere?
Because I want you to hit top 500.
Womankind will remember.
Guys!
Will Rosa ditch the duo for you though?
That's a good test.
I could be like, hey you wanna join my stack?
And then we'll see if he says yes or no.
And it'll be like a test.
You know?
It'll be all live on...
We'll be like, hey you wanna join our stack?
But we won't...
We just wanna test him.
To see if he'll actually say yes or no.
Okay?
Let's just...
It's like a little test.
No!
We won't actually invite him.
We're playing Whiffer against him again.
We are...
Oh no!
We got in a different lobby.
It's a different lobby.
Oh, it's Tony Florida.
It's him again.
I think he might have reformed though.
Tony Florida and Diamond was a different monster.
I don't know.
Maybe he's different.
I feel like he's reformed.
I saw him in Diamond.
And maybe Diamond did things to him.
Strange Psylocke player.
I mean everybody's a fucking strange Psylocke player if you think about it.
Fine, I'll ban Psylocke.
As a Luna player, I'll ban Psylocke.
What did Tony do?
He was really mad at our DPS.
And then he said a slur.
And then I was like, whoa!
That's how I remember Tony Florida.
But that was like Diamond.
That was like when I was Diamond and he was Diamond too.
So things could be different now.
You know?
I was like, whoa!
That's Florida.
No!
He...
I don't remember exactly what he said.
I just remember being like, whoa!
That's really it.
And then he swapped.
And then he swapped to DPS.
I mean, you can go strange.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Pretty sure he's better now.
I think it was his breaking point.
Legitimately.
I legitimately think it was like the line.
He like, he was at the line.
And like...
And like I said, it was Diamond.
He had a very bad day.
I will not be surprised.
Only Hela.
I love Hela.
And then he switched to DPS.
Maybe he's good at DPS.
I don't know.
I remember exactly the DPS he swapped to.
He swapped to Moon Knight.
I don't know what it is.
Whenever a tank gets really tilted, they swap to Moon Knight.
It's always like that.
He swapped to Dawn of Moon.
Wait, what?
Portland?
What?
Oh, okay.
Portland?
Alright, I'll stay here.
Are they okay over there?
I don't know if I like being here.
I never liked being up here in general.
Feels scary.
There's a strange on me.
Oh my god.
I saw it.
I don't know.
I'm looking at my cloak.
Cloak, please.
Cloak, what?
That's like...
What?
What the fuck?
I was right next to her.
Oh my god.
Oh no, man.
I have Starlord on me.
I'm gonna need help.
I need help.
Nice kill there.
Not today.
I'm gonna help our Luna get back.
Yeah.
I need bodyguard.
Oh, if you have to.
You win this, by the way.
Oh my god.
I'm not in a good position here.
I'm here.
Keep walking.
She's one.
Starlord.
Starlord half.
Kill the tanks.
Starlord left side.
He has elusive.
Starlord's on me.
Starlord's gonna kill me.
I got you, I got you.
Starlord, Starlord half.
Starlord half.
Kill the tanks.
Win me a fucking game.
I have Starlord on me.
This sucks.
I can't.
I can't get ult charge.
I can't get ult charge because I'm getting...
I'm getting died.
You gotta be trolling.
I killed two healers.
You couldn't win me a fucking game.
There he goes.
Fucking garbage.
Okay, maybe he's Starlord for him.
I don't think...
Welcome back, Tony Florida.
Welcome back.
I don't think he's Starlord for him.
I don't think he...
I'm sorry.
Three, two, one, no more ults.
They have strange on us.
We have strange on us.
He's one, he's one, strange one.
Starlord, Starlord.
Because I don't think he's reformed.
Guys, it's just...
Guys, it's just GM things.
No, I think he's Eternity.
Guys, no.
It's okay.
It's just...
Guys, it's just Eternity stuff.
Oh my god, that's hilarious.
It's not...
Okay, it's not that.
He's a bad person, but like...
You know, I thought he was reformed, but I guess not.
I guess he's not reformed, guys.
Strange can die.
Strange one.
Nice, push, push, push, push, push.
Heal Mike, heal Mike.
Oh my god.
The friendliest word.
I'm worried he's gonna get angry again, guys.
What if he gets angry again?
I told you.
Now you know.
Now you know how the slur dropped.
Now...
Now you know.
I love you.
Stay on cart.
My ult's on cart.
Okay.
Nice.
I'm pushing up with this.
One more dead.
Strange can die.
Yeah.
Now you know.
You're like, he seems alright.
He seems alright.
We all thought he seemed alright.
He's not.
Yeah, he's definitely not a chill guy.
It's okay.
Now he's fine.
Now that we're winning, he's fine now, guys.
He's reformed again.
Now that we're winning, truly...
Destroy bridge.
Guys, we're winning now.
He'll be okay, I believe.
He's gonna get a strange ult.
Oh, shit.
This guy.
Just run away.
I can't see you over there.
I think Wolverine's dead.
Nice kill.
Oh, no.
He's looking for ult.
The strange.
Yeah, go, go, go.
Strange is low.
I'm 55.
I don't have it for...
Oh, my god.
Jesus Christ.
Jesus.
I cannot heal all that.
Oh, my god.
That's a lot of damage.
I can't see you.
Alright, here we go.
I have ult for strange.
Oh, fuck me.
We have strange just walking up to us.
Bro, why is he just walking up to us like that?
We're free!
Oh, my god.
If he looks at me one time, I'm fucked.
I'm so fucked.
Wait, wait.
Get strange, get strange, get strange.
I have to stay on my ult.
Stay on my ult.
I grabbed him.
Get him, get him, get him.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, goodbye, Wolverine.
I'm damage boosting this.
One second.
I can't heal you from there.
Nice kill.
Oh, I cannot heal that.
The strange is walking up.
Oh, my god.
Okay, Wolverine, you can grab him.
He's looking for you.
Nice, nice, nice.
This is the last fight.
I have to reload.
You only have one support.
I have ult,
I have ult.
I'm ulting this, I'm ulting this.
I'm ulting cart.
I'm alive!
That's behind us, that's behind us, that's behind us.
Oh, no more is one.
Defense is gonna be much easier.
That was a good push, though.
Loki, please drop down.
Oh, my god.
This is the laggiest server I've ever played.
This is East Coast.
Welcome to East Coast.
Welcome to East...
This is why I removed East Coast.
This is why I cut the East Coast out of...
That time when...
That very first game...
When I got Luna ult...
And it popped off in my screen...
But it didn't, it didn't go off.
And I was like, excuse me?
That...
That made me mad.
Florida is in East Coast, right?
Nothing was lost then.
Yes, okay, yep, nothing.
We're gonna cut off the dick.
Because Florida is America's dick, right?
Oh, my god, Florida, man.
Oh, my god!
What the fuck?
Is it in?
Is that American Geography?
That's American Geography.
That's Tony.
Please, just a little bit.
Oh, we're Wolverine.
There's a Starlord on you.
Oh, my god, my frames are dropping, though.
Oh, my frames are dropping.
My frames are actually dropping.
This is bad.
This is bad, this is very hard to heal right now.
This is very hard to heal.
Oh, my god!
This is actually very hard to heal.
No!
Oh!
I can't heal the frames!
Oh, we don't.
Oh, no!
Not the frames!
Just because I wanted to cut off East Coast!
The server was like, no, no, no, we're not cutting East Coast out.
Because we had the Tony freak out, I'm too scared.
Because I don't want Tony to freak out, guys.
I don't want him to freak out.
I have a Xayah on me again.
I'm going to cart, I'm going to cart.
That's good for you, Rhett.
Behind, behind, behind!
Oh, no!
Magneto got both supports.
You have no supports.
Yeah, I'm chilling.
Okay.
I don't think they didn't use support ults, either.
Did someone also break fucking reasons to walk in?
Okay.
Don't worry, Strange!
Peek me, because I'm too scared!
Oh, my god.
I can't see.
I can't see you, Strange!
Yeah, yeah.
I'm angry.
Are they using both support ults, here?
Fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear!
Fear!
So much fear!
So much fear.
Can you guys ask our second DPS to...
What do you want our second DPS to do?
Look what he's doing.
What do you want him to do?
He's jumping around!
I don't have anything for that.
I have a Strange on me.
Yeah, yeah, I'm trying to help you.
I'll burn him more.
I can't, I couldn't see him for a few seconds.
Oh, my god, please.
Oh, there's a Strange behind us!
Oh, I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
I'm damage boosting this.
Star, more star, more star, more star, more star, more star.
Oh, you're fucking annoying.
Tell me Florida.
Hey, listen, I'm sheltering here.
It's important.
Oh, shit!
Oh, yeah, bro!
Guys, it's just a...
Oh, Florida.
Oh, Florida, man.
There's a Starlord on us.
I'm dead.
We still have Cloak.
Only Cloak heals.
I'm dead, we have two kills.
If we touch this, we win this.
Do anything we can.
Our Starlord is poking him.
Iron Fist, Iron Fist, you gotta fudge, bro.
I'm healing our Iron Fist right now.
We still have one more fight, so we should kill.
I'm gonna take damage, we need support.
Yeah, I have 86.
I'm opening a portal.
Hey, mate, TP on you, Punisher, I don't care.
There's definitely a Starlord ult.
Get out, get out, get out.
I got ult, I got ult, I got ult.
Stay alive, stay alive, stay alive.
Starlord one, Starlord one!
I can't get to you, Punisher.
I'm gonna ult point, I'm gonna ult over.
I'm going point.
They're gonna Starlord ult after this.
They don't, they don't.
Oh, they don't?
Okay.
I'm on point, I'm on point.
Ult's gone, ult's gone.
Good try.
Oh, no!
I don't think we're gonna... I'm leaving, goodbye!
I'm leaving, goodbye!
Goodbye.
Is he gonna live?
Alright, here we go.
Okay, no, we can't die.
Yeah, we take an early fight here.
Yeah, we... if we take an early fight, we can have like two fights here.
Guys, we take an early fight here, I think.
Yeah.
Yeah, guys, let's take an early fight.
Yeah, guys, let's take an early fight here, I think.
Starlord one, Starlord's low!
I see you, I see you.
Wait, that's good, I don't think we need to use anything.
Yeah, yeah.
We don't need to use anything, I think.
Unless we can get picks.
Okay, heal me now.
Three, two, one, let's go.
Alright.
Oh, I can't heal that.
You need to.
I don't know if I can heal a fucking rock!
I think it's like, you need to, and I'm like, how?!
That's a rock!
I have all your...
I'm playing, I'm playing, I'm playing.
Oh, I can't, sorry.
Luna's out of ult, Luna's out of ult too.
I'm dead to the Magneto.
Magneto's on me.
No more one.
Mine, mine, mine, mine, mine.
They're gonna stand it.
Oh my god.
I'm alive, I'm alive.
Magneto?
Hit this guy.
Fucking scale.
Dude, he's still mild?
Nice.
Oh my god, let's go!
GG.
He's like, well, you're gonna have to heal it.
I'm like, that's a rock!
How do I heal a rock?
How do I heal a fucking giant meteorite?
Like, I don't know what he wants from me.
Yay, we saved the stream.
We saved the stream, guys.
I didn't get yelled at.
Let's fucking go.
Oh my god.
No, I accidentally pressed escape.
Zeon, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you, loyally.
And Arm, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
VOD is saved.
How many more?
It's like...
171.
Oh my god, it went up three points.
It went up three points since I started the stream.
That's so fucked.
That's actually so fucked.
It's so fast.
Oh my god.
I'm like...
Yeah, I'm like two games away.
Yeah, I'm two games away.
But like...
I think like...
250 is the cutoff.
I want 200 points.
Yeah, I wanna...
I wanna like at least get 200 points.
And then...
Let's see how it goes.
I mean, it's been pretty good so far.
We've been playing...
Our record's alright.
I feel like I'm gonna jinx it.
We literally lost because we had to fight Rosa.
We literally...
We had to fight Rosa.
That's like the only reason we lost.
Honestly.
Any other time, it's been okay.
It's been alright.
Rosa solo right now?
Rosa good.
Oh my god, is it time?
Do we poach Rosa?
Is it?
I...
Wait.
I had it, Rosa.
Were you spectating, Rosa?
Is he...
Is he legit?
Just to be sure.
Before I poach him.
Oh, he's rank 16?
Apparently, he is a fursie.
I have no idea who he is.
I'm like...
I'm like the Flash meme.
I'm like the Flash meme where like...
What is it called?
Lex Luthor took his body.
Took Flash's body and he takes off his mask.
And then he's like, I don't know who he is.
You're just like, bro, he's a fursie.
And I'm like, who?
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
Alright, it's time.
We...
I could add him to the stack.
Like, I friended...
I friended him after he happened here.
Ruthless businesswoman.
Boog is like, no.
Instant no.
For women everywhere.
But...
But women.
But if he is cheating, then we lose aura.
The call of the rancorous.
Not the aura.
He's right, though.
That's why I asked Boog.
I was like, do you think he's cheating?
Alright, Boog was like, no.
Alright, we won't.
That's what I'm saying.
Like, because I was like, I don't know if he is cheating or not.
Because...
Because like...
The reputation of fucking playing with a cheater.
You lose more than you gain.
So I had to make sure.
Yeah.
He's not even playing with the other person anymore.
How am I home record when he's solo?
I waited.
Guys.
So he was alone.
That's so much worse.
Guys, sorry.
That's actually a lot worse.
I was like...
You are awful.
That's so fucked up.
Guys, I didn't add him to the stack, guys.
I didn't add him.
For womankind everywhere, I didn't do anything bad.
That's so bad, actually.
Oh my god.
Wait, what did he say?
How many points do you have?
I have...
I'm at...
Where am I at?
I don't even remember.
I'm at...
134.
Anyway.
It's just like my Japanese comments.
Who is that guy, anyway?
He's like, what?
His name is...
What's his name?
Alfred A.
Fersi?
He must be on the leaderboard, right?
He's 16th, right?
This guy.
This is him.
Holy shit.
409 points.
He's fucking insane.
Oh, he's a Starlord player.
He's a Starlord main.
What is his...
Chaos streak, critical strike hits, critical hit rate.
13%.
That's pretty good.
That's actually pretty good.
13% is actually insane.
80% best accuracy.
Because it's critical hit.
It's like headshots.
Yeah, the fact that like...
Yeah, that's actually...
That's insane.
Holy fuck.
13%?
If you see a Widowmaker with 13% critical hit, they're hacking.
But it's not Widowmaker.
It's not like...
Like, I know like...
Widow mains, if they have like critical hit accuracy that high, it's usually they're hacking.
But I...
I don't know.
I don't know about Marble Rivals.
I don't know the stat line for Marble Rivals, to be fair.
Marble Rivals is different.
It's a different stat line.
Like, Widow...
Yeah, it's like...
There's only a select few where like...
Like, you know, like there could be like Overwatch pros that are...
That have like...
That's how like people tell a Widowmaker that's hacking.
Which is basically like you just look at the stat line.
Of like their critical hit accuracy.
So 13% is like really good.
In general.
It's just good in general.
Oh my gosh.
There's so many.
One above all.
I'm just a little guy.
I'm just a little Eternity Girl.
I can play Mantis.
You can have Luna.
I'll play Hulk.
I'm just surprised Kefri didn't quit another...
Quit Overwatch again for a new game.
It's not shots fired.
It's like...
It's usually...
A lot of Overwatch players are like that.
They're like...
Wow, interesting.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna like quit Overwatch to play X game or something.
Do they have any one-trick?
So I'm surprised that he didn't do that again for Marvel Rivals.
No one recognizes Luna one-trick.
But that's about it.
I think we just ban like Hawkeye or one of the healers.
They're banning Hawkeye.
Jonami, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Dragonfood, thank you for the tier three subs.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
They ban Iron Man though.
Thank God.
They still have Hulk though.
So like...
That's not the best for me.
I mean...
Widowmakers?
What's it called?
Black Widow is so bad.
Like her...
She's only good if you have a Mantis that fucking pockets you all the time.
That's the only reason to go...
Widow.
Black Widow.
But like...
A Mantis sometimes doesn't do that.
So like...
Yeah.
I fucking hate this map.
I wish they'd take this map out of rotation.
I hope we get new maps though.
I know we're getting four new heroes.
But like...
I hope...
I'm so tired of this map.
I need more maps so I get to see less of this one.
That's really it.
I just want less of this fucking map.
She's bad.
Cause then like when you have a...
You have to fucking...
Peel for this...
The Widow.
And everything.
Cause she has...
Like at least Widowmaker she has her grapples to get out of situation.
Black Widow...
She doesn't have a grapple.
All she has is her fucking...
Thing that...
Beats people...
Off.
That like...
You know...
Throw them away.
Her kick.
Yeah.
Like she just...
She can just kick and that's it.
She gotta jump.
Yeah.
Like where the fuck am I jumping?
What?
Where did she go?
Where did...
What?
Where did our stream go?
I slept him.
Where did...
Where did my stream go?
Where did he go?
Oh yeah!
Where the fuck did he go?
That was strange.
I don't know where the bubble was.
Yeah.
Oh!
I'm so unlucky.
I dropped there.
Wolverine's one.
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm dead.
I slept him.
He's one.
Wolverine's coming in though.
Oh my god.
He's grappling!
I think we might have to die no more.
I'm leaving you by the way.
Bye no more.
Alright.
He went...
He went home.
That was such a crazy strange port.
They're not gonna lie.
They're strange.
That was so smart from their stream.
That's actually crazy.
Holy shit.
I got it, I got it.
Oh.
I got the ult though, I got the ult though.
I might be dead.
No, I'm okay.
Strange one, strange one, strange one, strange one.
Strange trap, strange trap, strange trap, strange trap.
I'm going in.
Oh, I'm stunned.
Oh.
There's a hulk behind us.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Ember Stranger already won the mental game.
Bro, that shit was crazy.
That was a fucking crazy...
Yeah, they still have their lowkey ult though.
They have their lowkey ult.
Yeah, they do, they do.
Oh, you just exploded.
Oh, we have hulk in the backline.
He's asleep.
Um, I'm with the hulk right now.
Hulk one, hulk one.
I'm still being harassed by hulk.
Hulk is low, hulk is low.
They have no line of battle.
Yeah.
They're gonna have strange ult again soon.
Hulk is...
Oh, I couldn't do anything.
They're gonna have strange ult here.
And Wolverine ult.
Oh.
Oh, I don't have any heals left.
That's huge, that's huge.
Hulk, hulk, hulk, hulk's one.
I have all our hulks.
Strange one, strange one.
Come on, no more.
No more is low.
No more is one.
Nice.
Oh my god.
That was... do they have portal?
Oh, they can't portal anymore.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Wolverine at the top, top right.
Hulk is low.
Oh my god.
Oh, there he goes.
There he goes.
Nice.
That's a good trade.
We're even right now.
I'm on the walkie.
I can't save your ass!
Oh my god, no!
Hulk on backline, hulk on backline.
I got
it.
Wolverine top right, top right, top right.
Jesus Christ.
I got some.
Oh.
Yeah, no lamp, no lamp.
Hulk has ult too.
He's asleep.
I have hulk on me in the back.
I can't do anything, hulk is on me.
I should have walked to the chat.
I should have walked to the team.
Hulk ulted.
Yeah, that's my bad.
I should have walked to the team there.
So I wouldn't get separated.
That's my bad for...
They have strange ult here.
Hulk top right.
He's so low.
I'm gonna push.
Can you ult with me, Mantis?
I got my ult off.
Hulk, hulk, hulk, hulk!
That's insane.
They have no more ult here and low heal.
I'm damage boosting you guys.
In the front.
I'm on cart, I'm on cart.
Yeah, I'm on cart.
I'm gonna ult soon.
I'm damage boosting you.
Oh, I don't have leaves, sorry.
Got it.
Oh, shit!
I'm trying to keep you up.
I couldn't.
Wolverine's low, Wolverine's low.
Wolverine one, Wolverine one.
Only I'm healing, but...
Oh, there's a...
There's a Hulk behind me, there's a Hulk behind me.
Strange one.
Hulk, hulk, hulk, hulk one, hulk one.
I'm just standing away from cart.
I'm on cart now.
You're well off, Adolph.
Yeah, well off, we can't heal you guys.
Help is here.
I don't think they make it.
Nice.
Oh my god.
This is so...
Bro, I hate...
This is why I'm one of...
Oh, that's important though.
Oh, me, oh me, oh me.
Oh my god.
Oh, nice, nice pick.
Hulk, hulk half, hulk half.
Hulk one.
I think he's getting healed though, yeah.
He is getting healed.
Jesus Christ.
Only 16 seconds left.
Hulk, hulk, hulk, hulk, hulk.
I'm ulting this.
Hulk asleep.
Yeah, we got shrooms, we got shrooms.
Get hulk, get hulk.
Hulk, hulk, hulk, hulk, hulk.
Half, half, half, half.
One.
Oh, we don't...
I don't know if we can get support all in time.
Neymar, Neymar, Neymar, Neymar.
I'm on cart, I'm on cart.
I am ready to put on a show.
No lamp, no lamp.
I'm trying to ult.
I'm backing up a little bit.
Can I get focus you?
I'm going to ult him.
I got Neymar'd.
Oh my god.
I'm about to have ult, I'm about to have ult.
We have TP.
Wow, what a quad.
I'm going to ult to the TP.
Can you make like an angle?
10 seconds.
Yeah, 5 seconds, 4 seconds.
2, 1.
That was a crazy will.
Damn.
Yeah, portal was way too far away.
That's why I was like...
When he was like, I'm going to portal.
I'm like...
I don't know if we're going to make it.
You should have just put the portal.
You shouldn't have like...
You shouldn't have like thought about it.
You should have just made it instantly.
He was thinking about angles and stuff.
You shouldn't have tried to position.
You know what's crazy?
I've been bumped into another streamer.
That's what I'm saying.
Every time I do these grinds, I'm bumped into nobody.
Like, I don't...
Everybody and their mom is fucking queuing.
Why am I...
Don't understand.
Never get to interact with people.
Look at that.
4k guy was a streamer.
He wasn't even fucking live and you know it.
You're not queue sniping.
I want to just naturally bump into them.
Is that too much to ask for?
Behind us.
Oh my god.
I'm backing him, I'm backing him, I'm backing him.
Oh my god, that was scary.
Wait, there's a Warwick behind us.
He's asleep, he's asleep.
1v1.
Got you.
Oh my god, there's a Hulk behind us.
There's a Hulk on us.
I'm trying to help you, Luna.
I need help here.
Thank you.
I don't have leaves.
Sorry.
Farming leaves off of him.
I was trying to say surefour.
Strange is low.
Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk.
I can't see you, Punisher.
They're so low.
They're all so low.
Surefour is low.
I was going to say strange and then I went...
I just called him surefour and I was trying to say strange.
Oh my god.
Rent-free.
Standard buff starts with S.
Do you really blame me?
I can't even break this fucking wall.
I'm not strong enough.
I'm just a weak little girl.
I can't even break this fucking wall.
I'm melting.
It's fine, it's fine, you're fine, you're fine.
I'm damage boosting you.
Oh.
There's a Wolverine behind us.
And a Hulk too.
One back, one back, one back.
I stunned him.
There's a Hulk behind again.
We have two tanks on us.
Oh my god.
We couldn't do anything.
They used both tank ults.
They used every ult, actually.
They used everything.
Yeah, they did.
And Hulk ult soon.
Oh my god.
I wish I was strong enough for this.
I'm just gonna damage boost everything and hope something happens.
Hulk half.
Oh.
Oh, actually I dropped off.
Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna.
Oh, the Hulk was so low.
Monkey one, monkey one.
Monkey dead.
Strange one, strange one.
You have no supports, you have no supports.
We're coming back now.
We're up a lot if we can make it back in time.
Um...
I can't damage.
Oh, oh my god.
Crazy, Luna.
Number one again.
Live, live, live, live, live.
They should have strange ult soon.
Oh my god, I'm lagging.
Hulk is sleeping.
Woo!
I'm ulting this.
They're gonna have strange ult though.
Please strange ult it.
Strange one, strange one.
I have Hulk on us.
Hulk is asleep, Hulk is asleep.
I'm frozen too.
I need help.
Jesus Christ.
I think they're just better.
I think it's just the team though.
I think their tank line is just really good.
I think.
Like, both their tanks are working together really well.
Oh my god.
Strange no shield.
I'm trying my best to damage boost everybody.
Hulk asleep, Hulk asleep.
Hulk one.
Oh, I'm sorry Punisher.
Nope.
I have Hulk like on my spawn.
Wolverine?
Wolverine half?
Oh my god.
Neymar half?
Oh, I don't have leaves, sorry.
I'm ulting this.
We lost their Luna.
Got their heals.
I don't think...
Oh my god.
Wolverine, Wolverine one.
No more, no more.
Yeah, they're on me, they're on me.
We're even though right now, so we gotta be careful.
Change, change, change, change, change.
Change his ult, change his one.
They have, they have their Strange ult.
3,
2, 1.
Nice.
Bliss, bliss.
Oh my god.
We have to do three fights.
Oh my god, our fucking Luna went in front of me, so I couldn't...
I need to like, make sure I don't waste my leaves.
Am I ulting early?
Yeah, I think I'm gonna ult early.
Oh wait, that's my turn.
Yes, he's looking for Strange ult, he's looking for it.
I grabbed him, I grabbed him, I grabbed him, I grabbed him.
He's still looking for it though.
Wolverine has ult too.
Luna, Luna, Luna on the left.
I'm trying to keep you guys up.
I got you.
Hog is sleeping, hog is sleeping.
Luna on the back, we need to get the Luna.
I got, I got Wolverine.
Oh my god, I got Wolverine.
This is bad.
Oh, it's over.
It's over.
No!
I got Wolverine!
I got him.
Their tank line was, their tanks really good.
I mean, their tanks played really well together.
That was a Wolverine.
Yeah, because our tanks kept getting, our tanks had to fight against the Wolverine.
So like, so like, we were always missing one.
Yeah, and then our Luna was not having a good time.
Our Luna was not having a good fucking time there.
She was, she was getting fucked up.
Yeah.
She got, she got fucked up there.
Wait, what the fuck?
How did the GMs get into our lobby?
Holy shit.
Oh, that's cool.
Rest in peace.
Rest in peace to our Luna.
Our Luna was not having it.
She kept getting harassed and I tried my best to keep her up.
Yeah, they can.
They can.
They can also play with uh...
I know a lot of like Eternity players play with GM players to get easier games to climb.
And that's like something people frown upon.
Yeah.
Yeah, they exploit to get lower rank queues.
Apparently that's like a really uh...
That's like a really uh...
Uh... taboo thing.
Oh yeah, fuck Hawkeye in general.
Yeah.
I'll listen to my duo.
Sounds kind of lame.
I mean...
People would do anything for rank points.
I almost...
I almost poached somebody.
The only thing stopping me was Boger.
If Boger wasn't there to be the angel on my shoulder, I would have done it.
I would have done it.
See, look.
I'm not a bad person.
Alright.
Let's go.
Can you go Mantis though, Kayn?
Oh, yeah, yeah, I can.
Yeah, I can.
I mean, yeah, I think so.
I think so.
I think, yeah.
It's a little bit rough without Nadal.
We just gotta play safe.
I only said he was...
I didn't say he was legit.
I said it's really weird that Dune would risk her reputation playing with a hacker.
That's why I was like...
I didn't think he was hacking because of it.
I think it's weird because I see her play with other pro players before, so I thought it'd be really weird.
I also sense great sarcasm.
I didn't watch the replay just because of that.
Wait, what is the passive?
I'm so confused.
Oh, the rez?
The rez would not be so working.
Alright.
There's a match behind us.
Lunar or not, man.
I'll eat.
Oh!
Bro, what the fuck?
I missed my wave while playing this.
Oh, nice.
I slept somebody?
Babe, I knew we were gonna...
Might just have to.
Shouldn't just have to.
Woah!
I'm gonna grab this.
Oh my god, I'm really low.
Jesus Christ, I'm taking so much damage.
I really need heals.
Magic.
Magic no half?
Magic no sleep.
Magic one.
I'm gonna ult this.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Luna, Luna, Luna.
Superpush up.
Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna.
Magno one, Magno one, Magno one!
Mag, Mag, Mag.
Behind us, somebody.
Magic.
Magic, Magic, Magic.
Where was she?
I'm gonna hit that turret.
There's an Amour in the hallway.
She's one, she's one.
I'm getting three on cart.
Uh, an Amour and Mantis are in push, yeah.
I'm backing out, I'm backing out a little bit.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
Magic, Magic.
They have strange ult after this though.
And Mantis ult.
Not Mantis, uh, Magic.
We got hit.
I see, oh, I see Strange.
I can't see you, Starlord.
I can damage boost you if you want to ult.
Oh, you're already ulted.
He's looking for ult, Strange.
He's still asleep.
Strange is looking for ult.
I can't see you.
Magic on me in the back, Magic on me in the back.
I got damage boosted, you take an Amour.
Magic, go on Magic.
Actually, pick someone here.
I can't keep you up.
Oh, fuck.
My bad, my bad.
Oh my god.
Please.
Please do something, DPS.
Magneto half.
My half, my half.
He's still having Strange ulted.
He has Strange ult.
Damage boosting you, Starlord?
Oh.
More right side, one.
I can ult this in.
I'm ulting this in.
I'm going.
They triggered Luna ult.
They have Luna ult too.
No, they just Luna ulted you again.
Oh my god.
There's a Magic behind us.
Oh my god, please.
Dude.
Do something.
This is last place.
Oh my god.
That's just what's up.
Do something.
Oh my god, I don't know.
That was just...
I don't know.
I feel like we got nothing out of it.
I damage boosted...
I damage boosted everybody.
And I got zero kills out of it.
That was like...
Yeah, I was just like...
Nobody got anything out of my damage boost.
I was like, you're all damage boosted.
Kill something.
Do something.
When we're using ults, it's not as defensive.
Like the Luna ult.
Usually the Mantis is the aggressor.
I was like, here's my Mantis ult.
Do something.
And then I triggered Luna ult though, so that's fine.
They also went double tank, so it's like...
It just is what it is.
Alright,
I have no idea.
I don't know.
This game seems a little rough.
This one.
This one seems just a little rough.
I think we also have like...
We have like Adam player.
We don't have Mantis, Luna.
And it's like...
We're gonna have a...
If Mantis isn't...
Magic's 2, right?
He's coming over.
I can help.
I healed you too.
Alright, it's fine.
Oh my god.
Everybody's taking so much damage.
What?!
What is our DPS?!
What is our DPS doing?!
Oh my god!
No, this is 100% a DPS diff.
I refuse to think of anything else.
No, this is definitely a DPS diff.
Oh my god!
Whatever.
Magic behind.
What a shit show.
There's a Magic behind us?
On our Adam?
A stranger, maybe?
I need heals here.
We have...
A reload.
Reload.
Okay,
I might die to this.
But I'm okay.
I should've been on Luna.
I don't think our Luna knew how to play Luna.
We have no support ults too.
I don't hear the Luna.
I'm fucking blind.
Did they Mantis ult?
I know they have Magical.
No, a long time ago.
A long time ago.
So they might have it again.
Yeah, they definitely have Magical here.
He's behind us, I think.
That's really good.
Nice.
I wonder if...
They won't hide?
I wonder why not.
Stranger than man, yeah.
I'm coming.
Oh my god, I need to focus on heals.
I'm focusing so hard right now.
The Stranger is out of position.
Stranger one, Stranger one.
Stranger, Stranger one, Stranger one, Stranger one.
I think I can kill them both here.
One more minute, guys.
One more minute.
I'm going in the backline, I'm going in the backline.
We gotta push up that...
Oh, we don't have Luna left.
Push him, push him.
We get the kill.
Back, back, back, back, back.
I have the name of the blue.
I have ult soon.
I have ult in five.
Can we get the magic?
Where is she?
She has ult.
I don't know.
She's behind us somewhere.
She's gonna wait.
Yeah, I might be able to grab ult before she ults.
I have four percent.
You will have your ult.
You will have it.
They might be keeping eyeshield on soon.
And they won't hide?
No, they won't, they won't, they won't, they won't.
I have it.
I have my ult.
They have magic on me.
I'm shielding.
I'm ulting this, I'm ulting this.
Oh, they're all behind us and they have strange ult.
Magic ulted.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Strange, strange, strange.
Strange one.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, we did it!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Oh, I knew I should have, I should have fucking played Luna in the, at first.
I, I knew it.
I was like, I was like, oh, this item does not know how to play Luna.
Oh, I actually locked in so hard there.
Booger carried me too.
Let's go!
This is why you gotta adopt a tank player.
You gotta adopt a tank player, guys.
Tony Florida!
I got Tony Florida fucking friended me.
I'm gonna use somebody's bathroom.
I'm sorry, Tony, I'm sorry, man.
I can't.
You get mad too easily.
Tony just gotta get to rehab and then...
Who's this?
Oh.
I'll never know!
Who's this, though?
I'll never know.
I mean, EU, obviously, cause of the ping.
Chibi Doki fan.
It's Healist?
Wait, who's Healist?
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry, I don't know people.
Healist.
I'm sorry, I legitimately don't know anybody.
I'm so sorry.
Where is he?
He's not even on the leaderboard.
I told you, it's like the Flash meme.
I'm like...
You gotta be more specific.
Alright, educate me on Healist.
Who he is.
Bro, I didn't even know who the fuck Mace was until you guys told me who he was.
Oh.
With this treasure, I summon...
I don't...
No, I'm just ignorant.
I'm just ignorant.
I didn't even know who Mace was until you guys yelled at me.
He's rank...
What's his rank?
He's rank 21.
Oh, him.
It's TTV.
What does he play?
Oh, he's a magic player?
Oh my god, he's a Wolverine magic player?
Let's fucking go.
It's a DPS player.
That's all we needed.
I'm just ignorant.
I haven't been in the Overwatch scene for fucking years.
I didn't even know who Boger was until like...
Like a month or two ago.
I literally learned who he was a month or two ago.
I'm just ignorant.
How are you an Eternity pro?
I just played the game.
I'm just a grinder.
I'm literally just a grinder.
I don't fucking do anything else.
I just play the game.
I just play the game and be like, whoa.
I just remember people who say slurs.
I just remember people who yell at me.
That's really it.
Who yell at me and say slurs.
Because it's very memorable.
It's incredibly memorable.
It's true.
Oh, it's Helis.
Oh, it's him.
I still don't know who...
Is he a...
Is he like a...
Is he a Overwatch player?
Overwatch.
Helis.
Can't Google you.
Let's see.
Okay, wait.
Leaderboard.
We're learning, guys.
We're educating ourselves.
Helis.
Rank 21.
Did I spell it correctly?
Helis.
Overwatch.
Oh, he has a Twitch?
Oh, wait.
His name is TTV.
His name is literally TTV.
I'm sorry.
I'm so stupid.
Oh, my God.
He's French.
I'm not doxing him.
It's his profile.
He's French.
I'm literally just reading his Twitch profile, guys.
What do you mean by that?
Wait.
What do you mean?
Oh, my God.
Guys, my chat doesn't...
Guys.
Guys, my chat doesn't represent me.
I won't get better.
Because I have taken the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
I've been aware of the curse of France.
Thank you for the resub for 12 months in a row.
Thank you.
All right.
I wonder how long the queues will be.
I'm fine with queuing EU.
Oh, yeah.
I'm fine with adding EU to the queues.
If needed.
I mean, if it's just me with shit ping, it should be fine.
Are you sure?
We can try one game.
I'm used to 200 ping in Apex.
How different can it be?
Oh, my God.
It's one bar.
Guys, I'll be fine.
Guys, it'll be fine.
What's wrong with one bar?
The way it went to red.
Guys, it's just one game.
Maybe.
It's just one game.
Guys, it'll be fine.
No, we don't know yet.
We don't...
Even though it says I have one bar, it could mean anything, guys.
It could mean any...
Guys, look at...
Guys, it could mean anything.
Guys.
Guys, it just means I have to predict 10 seconds of the future with my Luna ult.
I mean...
How game-changing can it really be?
How game-changing is my Luna ult, which is 12 seconds of actual game-changing...
Of actual gameplay.
It can't be that bad.
Just play...
Okay, Mantis is worse.
Mantis, you actually have to aim.
Like...
Mantis is projectile, which is even worse with high ping.
And I send Healist to hell.
It can't be that bad.
I believe.
Rainbow, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate that.
How could you do that to ChibiDokiFan?
It's because you're not...
You're not DokiFan69.
LOL
Wow.
That's right.
I need 20 blue essence for a real rename.
Raging, thank you for tier 1 sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Not even gonna spend money for the privilege.
LOL Shake.
I think I spelled privilege wrong, but I can't be bothered.
LOL So cheap.
I don't have a fucking spellchecker.
You can tell what I wrote.
English is my...
English is my first language.
Spend some money for real, for real.
I can't believe it, guys.
Shake my head.
Not even gonna spend money.
LOL No, I'm EFL.
English first language.
LOL Hmm.
LOL This is...
If you wanna piss somebody off, just write hmm.
LOL
Shake my head, fake DokiFan.
That actually pisses people off so much in conversations.
So mean.
LOL Hmm.
LOL LOL
Because you don't even give them...
You want me to go to practice range?
Oh yeah, we should.
We should see.
You'll say, oh I can say...
I've never done that before.
I've never been in a queue that long.
I've never been in a queue so long that I have to...
Wait, why is he here?
LOL Why is he here?
Alright, let's see.
I'm just saying I'm pink.
It can't be bad.
Look at that.
It's hitscan.
Guys, ignore what you just saw there.
Ignore...
See everything...
Oh my, I see everything is fine.
See?
Look at that.
Look, I can heal him.
That was just a minor bug.
It was not related to pink.
It was perfectly normal, guys.
Look at that.
Perfectly normal.
See?
We're fine.
We're not TPing at all.
No, no, you saw nothing.
I don't...
There's no...
No TPing in Ba Sing Se.
Sorry, my...
My frame...
I...
I dropped frames there.
That was not TPing.
Just a minor drop of frames right there.
Which is...
LOL See?
Everything is fine.
Look at that.
What do you mean there's no delay?
Everything looks great on my end.
Look, see?
Everything looks A-OK.
Look at that.
No TPing.
Everything looks fine.
Where the fuck is my EU game?
Right here.
No, we're not at 182 pink.
I don't know where you guys get that number from.
Guys, I don't...
Guys, I have no idea...
Where you get that number from.
I don't know where it could be.
Look at that.
Oh my god, it's like crazy.
My one ping.
LOL
Oh my god, I live right next to the server, guys.
You can't kick me.
Oh, true.
I mean...
He's right.
LOL He's right.
Why is the G red?
What are you talking about?
There was no G.
What are you...
LOL What are you trying to say?
There's no G anywhere.
There we go.
Oh my god, guys.
I literally live next to the server.
LOL
There we go.
This is that easy.
I just wanted people to play with.
You're just too good.
You should de-rank.
LOL
Oh shit, we got in!
If he de-ranked, we had faster queues.
That's all I'm saying.
That's all I'm fucking...
Oh my god, he's back.
Rosa is back.
Oh wait, you're right.
They have Rosa.
We should just ban them.
You're right.
With this treasure, I summon the psychic.
Guys!
Okay, we're in NA servers though.
Should have poached him.
Yeah, but I'm Doki Bridgefan69.
Now I have a real, a true bro.
If Rosa wants to join this stack, he should be Doki Bridgefan68.
LOL Is it NA or...
If he truly wants to...
Hell yeah, brother.
Alright.
Are we banning?
Okay, hello.
Is he not?
That is true.
He is a Starlord main on his other account.
Damn.
Stream sniping.
There's no way.
Like...
How would you know?
There's no way.
How would you fucking...
Who would you think is playing the Wolverine?
Like, you see Doki Bridgefan69, you automatically assume he's a Wolverine player.
There's no way.
He pulled up...
Somebody pulled up the stream.
There's somebody pulled up the stream.
It's okay, I have a guy with no hands on record.
Like, it's literally just name change.
How would you know?
He just...
This is his first game as Doki Bridgefan69.
How would you know?
His first fucking game.
But what if we don't kill him?
It's a 50-50.
Where do we begin to lose?
What if he gets his ult after that?
Listen, it's 50-50.
I've made the calculations.
I'm gonna TP, I'm gonna TP, I'm gonna TP.
Not in front of me, I'm gonna TP on the side.
I'm scared.
The Starlord's looking.
The Starlord is Rosa.
Okay guys, get ready.
3, 2, 1.
I'm in.
Oh my god, we got picked, we got picked.
I can't see over there.
We have Resvee.
I have Psylocke on me.
Oh my god.
Listen, we lost the 50-50.
Oh no.
I think he might have ult now.
Oh, he definitely has ult.
Oh my god!
Guys, we need to go.
We got it, we got it, we got Starlord.
Yep.
Nice.
We need to go on the backline, guys.
Support.
I think their Luna has ult.
If you focus her really hard.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm coming back.
I'm almost there, I'm almost there.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Go, go, go.
Oh my god, I'm a little scared because I used my clap prematurely.
Their Starlord is back, I think.
I have a Psylocke on me and he's frozen.
Psylocke one.
I can do this.
Psylocke low, Psylocke low.
Starlord's low.
Nice.
I got her, I got her, I got her, I got her.
I have bubble soon, I have bubble soon.
I have bubble B.
He has ult, he has ult, he has ult.
I don't have ult here.
Throw this one, throw this one.
There's not enough healing, there's not enough healing to sustain him.
It's so hard to farm ult with one tank.
They have Luna ult too.
Guys, I might be cooked here.
Oh, goodbye.
I'm good.
I'm still good.
Yeah, they have Luna.
I have mine too.
Oh, actually they swapped.
Wait, they swapped the Luna.
Oh, they swapped Luna, yeah?
Yeah.
I froze somebody.
They have...
They have my needle.
We're meeting Kai.
Oh, nice ult.
I'm ult after my needle.
I'm ulting.
I'm going to be on my needle for my ult.
3, 2, 1, no more.
They have Starlight ult here.
Oh, I couldn't.
They're killing everyone.
Yeah.
They have no support though.
Here we go.
That's Rosa.
Yeah, at least there's no again, you know?
It's the little things, guys.
I don't know, but we have a free silo.
Yeah, we shouldn't use it.
Jesus Christ.
Jesus Christ, everybody is taking so much damage.
Oh, I'm dead here.
I got...
I got Psylocke ulted.
Psylocke's low.
Magnus one, Magnus one.
Mag one, Mag one, Mag one.
I need support, I need support, I need support.
I just got one, by the way.
Zylo also one.
Zylo one HP on the left.
One HP, Kali one.
Psylocke one, Psylocke one.
Trying to keep you up, but I have to reload soon.
I'm 90.
I can't.
Oh, I was so close.
I was so close to being alive.
I couldn't be alive.
I think we can full ult them.
I think these guys are good players.
I told you guys.
Guys, I just think...
I respect her.
There is purpose.
Play Raccoon, bro.
Play your character.
I'm not bullying you.
I'm really the player.
I'm very normal, by the way.
Defense is very...
Artificial.
You have to pick Black Widow and stuff.
The Black Widow will work.
He wake up every day.
No, no, but he's right.
I am here.
I'm a fucking Raccoon auntie.
I'm gonna fucking call the animal control.
I'm gonna call...
Apparently, Rose has a smurf account for a rank 16 player.
I mean, if he's hacking, then like...
He must have paid a lot of money for it.
Or he's testing a...
Or he's testing a hack.
But he's in a tournament.
That's what I'm thinking.
How would he fucking get through that in a tournament setting?
How do you get through that far in a tournament without being caught?
Don't mind me.
Is he in the semi-finals?
Okay, they're looking back, right?
Oh...
Yeah, well...
That's unlucky.
We got the res though.
Someone behind flanking.
Yeah, I might be dead.
I might be dead.
He's low, he's low though.
I'm gonna speed up.
I'm pushing this.
There's a Psylocke in spawn.
I need help, guys.
I need help.
I'm looking, I'm looking.
I'm healing, I'm healing you.
Someone's to my left.
Psylocke's to my left.
I bubbled.
I exposed her.
But I have to back out.
We have res.
I have to reload.
I might have.
I'm only 78 of off.
This is awkward.
97.
I'm ulting the moment I get it.
They're gonna Starlord ult after this though.
I have my ult for it.
I'll be saving it.
I need to get a Mantis.
I have two, one, zero.
Oh, there it is.
Aww.
I need to do a Q already.
That sucks.
Our Raccoon.
We need a double support ult.
We have a Raccoon ult.
Yeah.
The Raccoon is not it.
Just a moment.
Let me avoid real quick.
Yeah, the res had no value.
Damn.
Right in front of our Raccoon player.
That's rough, buddy.
That's fucking rough.
No, Raccoon.
I didn't mean to rank on my team, guys.
I didn't mean that, guys.
I didn't mean to rank on my team.
We good.
Doki.
That's me.
Why did you say Doki?
Alright, what is Mantis like with one ping?
You wanna hear a joke about ghosts?
Sure.
See?
Look at my one ping.
Sure, that's the spirit.
Is he a dad?
Look at that.
Oh my god.
This is truly one ping.
One ping.
Right there.
One ping gameplay right there.
Look at that.
Oh my god.
That was fast.
Oh, hey.
It's NA.
Oh my god.
It's Mack.
Oh, it's Deathcoder.
Oh, wait.
Shasta Cola?
I mean...
We have Deathcoke on Luna, guys.
I think we win this game.
And we have Shasta and Death.
Who the fuck do a support kill?
Like, how do you do it?
We have Mack.
Oh, yeah.
I don't.
I was gonna say...
Is there like Slash Whisper?
If he was a homie, he'd throw it.
Poker, what do you play?
I don't even know.
Mack, play Backpather.
I don't know about that.
Play Backpather.
I know you want to.
What are we gonna do if Deathcode is not on Luna?
Pull out the storm, Mack.
Pull out the storm!
Adam Moloch, maybe?
Also, Arrow!
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
I appreciate it.
If you guys are new here, my name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube, but I'm here on Twitch for the ranked grind.
I think like...
I think I'm making...
Am I like up two games, I think?
I think I'm up two games right now.
It's been four hours and I'm up two games.
We can't lose.
How much am I up?
I don't even know.
Technically, it's possible.
Am I up two or three games?
Sounds like an absolute dub.
Every time I lose, I had Rosa on the enemy team.
This time, we won't lose because we have the Logang.
Logang is going to go in.
Yeah, yeah, I believe.
Guys, I might be up two or three games.
I don't know.
It was just a Rosa debuff for women everywhere.
I'm placing it on the right.
I'm scouting.
I don't think Moon Knight is good for this map.
Oh, we have Groot.
Groot, Moon Knight.
Okay, three, two, one.
It's right behind them.
I'm looking.
Alright.
It's fine.
I have...
Oh my god.
He's asleep, he's asleep.
What the fuck?
I got hooked.
You're down too.
I don't know if he lives.
I am Groot.
We're coming back from main.
We need heals.
Guys, go main.
Okay,
we got some space though.
Oh, Magno, Magno one.
Cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak.
He's so low.
Cloak is one, he'll be up here.
Adam, Adam.
One, one, one, Adam, Adam.
Cloak one, cloak one, cloak one.
Adam is respawning.
Cocooning, cocooning.
Asleep.
One, one, one.
He's so low.
He's really low.
I can't believe that that worked.
Me and Cloak just went in there.
They...
They Starlord ulted though.
Yeah.
Enemy in front of us.
Yeah, no rest Starlord, no heal.
Yeah, they might be close to Bucky ult.
Oh my god.
Watch out though.
I will.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna look for an ult soon.
I have ult here.
We have Moon Knight, a brutal combo.
We got Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
I have my ult just...
What the fuck is going on?
I don't know what's going on.
Cloak is asleep.
Cloak is asleep behind me.
I know, I know.
I can't heal you guys.
Oh, that's a big ult.
Right side cloak, right side cloak.
Behind us.
We need, we need.
I'm gonna get my Mid Knight.
Magneo one, Magneo one, Magneo one.
Push him, push him.
Before he heals.
Jesus Christ.
They have Starlord ult here, but I don't have ult.
We can activate this wall when they come.
Alright, they're gonna go left side.
Yeah, they have Starlord ult.
I'm backing a little bit.
Nice.
Focus on the battle.
Can we win this fight quick?
I believe in you, bro.
That's it, that's it.
That's it, that's it, that's it.
No, nothing else.
Thank you for your sacrifice, Guru.
I'm gonna look for a kidnap again.
I'm 80, so I might be able to get it.
I think I did.
I didn't.
Yeah, they're definitely gonna Starlord ult here.
90%, I'm 90%.
99, I have it, I have it, I have it.
I slept Bucky, I slept Bucky.
They have Bored again.
Starlord behind, Starlord behind, Starlord behind us.
Okay, just push point.
Yeah, we can have three on cart.
I can't believe we...
If you're GM1, can you play with D1?
Yeah, you can.
It's basically like one whole tier.
I'm sorry, Mac.
I'm sorry.
I need this more.
Mac, I can't function.
To be fair, he might need this more because he actually has to scrim.
He has to like scrim next, I think like this week, next week.
Starting, starting like tomorrow.
I heard like a lot of Apex players are getting yelled at right now.
For not playing, for not practicing Apex and playing, never been playing rival rivals.
I heard in the Apex pro community, a lot of Apex players are getting fucking yelled at right now for just playing rivals.
They're like, you have to, we have to practice, that is in the early end of the month.
I can't,
so Mac really needs this because he has to go back to the Apex waiting hours.
Rival rivals sabotaging LCS.
Not their fault.
That was strange.
Alright.
I'm scouting with my DPS, actually.
We have to TP, just put it on them and we just beam them with Moonknight, no?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I believe.
I believe in the strange word of...
They're pushing up.
I believe in you, Moonknight.
Oh, strange, huh?
You're fine.
Oh, Magnio, Magnio one, Magnio!
We're damage boosted.
I'm damage boosting you.
Oh, nice.
You're fine, you're so safe.
Someone help her through it.
I'm fine now, we can look for a blocker a little bit.
Mantis, Mantis one, Mantis one.
I slept her, I slept her, I slept her.
He's like 1 HP.
Nice, Urpin.
I'm going first.
He has no Cocoon.
We have Grut and Moonknight, which is probably a combo.
Yeah, they have Strangel here.
It's a crazy combo, actually.
I mean, they don't have Strangel though, because I'm going to block it.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
Alright, then I won't ult, right?
When they Strangel.
Yeah.
Okay, I've saved it.
Alright.
Magnio, Magnio, Magnio, Magnio!
Magnio, Magnio, Magnio!
Okay, I have to ult this.
That's a huge ult!
Starlord, Starlord, Starlord!
Wait, he's floating.
He's Cocooning.
Starlord is Cocooning.
He still has Strangel.
He should have Magneto too.
I'm not dead, but I'm running.
Oh, he's so done.
He jumped.
No ult, Starlord.
They might have the rest though.
I think they have the rest except Magneto.
How dare you?
He jumped!
That's illegal!
How dare you fucking jump!
They should have a Gen here.
Oh my god.
Go!
Booster, go!
There's a guy right here to my left.
Or again.
He's so low, but the item is low.
I'm so low, I'm so low though.
Behind, behind Starlord.
He's on my way, he's on my way.
I think he's low.
I think we gotta regroup though.
Yeah, I'm fighting.
I believe in you DokiBirdFan69.
DokiBirdFan69, my ghost.
Oh, they saw you, they saw you!
Goodbye.
I guess I didn't believe hard enough.
Oh, we're locked out, we're locked out.
We're locked out.
I'm locked in, I know about you.
They're on silo.
I'm so close.
Any second now.
Guys, scan, scan, scan, scan, scan, scan, scan, scan, scan.
I'm not looking, scan, scan, scan, go.
Nice, nice, nice.
There's a Starlord top right?
Nice peek.
I'm looking, I'm looking.
I'm down on this key, by the way.
He's floating, he's cocooning above us.
He's right here, he's spawning and cocooning.
Guys, look at this, look at this.
I'm looking, I'm looking.
Got him.
Nice, nice, push, push, push, push, push, push, push, push.
Woah!
Nice, nice, nice, no brawls, no brawls.
I'm on the other one, I'm on the other one, I'm on the other one.
He's so low, you can stag him.
Mantis to your right, Mantis to your right.
Yeah, we gotta walk back, they're pushing out, they're pushing out now.
Aura, Aura, Aura, Aura.
Good luck, bro.
Aura, Aura, I'm telling you.
They're chasing me, it's fine.
Okay.
Are you sure?
He's getting time, he's getting time.
She's still chasing me.
I ulted it.
But they're gonna start their ult after this.
They're starting their ult.
I'm TPing to you guys, don't worry about it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, give me a second guys, I'm coming back.
Okay, okay.
I need some heals, I need some heals.
I'm trying, I'm trying!
No, I'm on you all!
No!
Look at me, look at me, look at me.
Oh, we're down.
We're down one.
Don't worry.
They're chasing me, they're chasing me.
I'm coming back as Jeff.
Oh, okay, I'll stay Jeff.
We have root and moonite again.
Oh, wait, wait, I got picked, I got picked!
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm getting, alright, I'm getting on you, Groot.
We're living!
Okay, we're not living.
It's alright, we tried Groot, we tried.
I'm coming back, I'm coming back.
I damage boosted you.
Goodbye, Cloak, I'm sorry.
Yeah, I think we got regrouped here.
I'm backing up slowly.
I don't have more leaves, I'm sorry.
You might get staggered.
I mean, they're...
Bordination, Bordination is dead.
I have ult here, I have ult.
Leave, leave, leave.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
I have ult, I'm coming in, I'm coming in.
I'm ulting this for Groot.
Lucas, train, train, train, train, train, train, train.
I'm on stream, I'm on stream.
Oh, he ulted too, he ulted too.
Our Groot's like, low though.
I take the point, I take the point.
We actually almost have...
We have cloak up, but I don't know if we can make it.
We can, I think Venom can maybe.
Nah.
Okay, that's fine.
Legendary.
No, we trolled a little bit.
Groot fucking explodes.
I don't know what to do with our Groot.
I have to...
Our Groot is like...
He takes so much damage.
He fucking...
I use all my Lee's on the Groot because he explodes so fucking hard.
Those darn fucking trees.
I hate trees.
In game, in game.
He eats up everything.
I'm trying to save his life, but he's just like...
What if I just fucking get chopped down?
We can do the same thing.
Yeah, we'll do it.
If I wasn't Jep, our Groot would have died even faster, y'all.
That's all I'm saying.
My heals is regen heals.
It's not insane.
Guys, can you all shoot through the TP?
I'm gonna place it like...
Above them.
Make them a little bit unsuspecting.
I'm scouting their spawn.
Okay, get ready guys.
Give me a second.
We need a moment.
Yeah, if I was Loki, but we need magic.
Oh, they're going the other way.
Inside.
They're here now.
More power for you.
I'm here to kill them.
They have no shield.
I think if we just focus, we'll get to support and stuff.
And they're kinda in a bad position.
Try to get Penta.
Shine, shine, shine.
Spin one, spin one, spin one.
No weapon mag.
Oh, my shield is low, shield is low!
My god.
Look at me, look at me.
I have damage boost to you.
Mag me.
Mag one, mag one.
Starlord, head over.
Starlord's low.
Turn around, turn around, turn around.
Psylocke, Psylocke.
He's rezzing, he's rezzing.
Psylocke half, Psylocke's low.
They TP'd, they TP'd.
I don't have enough heals for this.
Look at my, look at my, look at my one.
I have Starlord on me, he's half.
It's fine, we play for next, I think.
There was just too many people.
They have no TP.
It's time to shine.
So much going on.
You had to heal, and then I had to shoot, and then I had to heal.
Psylocke to my right.
They're gonna get Psylocke ult soon.
There's a, there's a Starlord on her.
I'm dead.
I got, I got Starlord, I got Starlord, I got Starlord.
Starlord one, Starlord two.
You only have cloak heals.
We traded, but we have only cloak heals.
If you have your ult, maybe.
Oh, nevermind.
Yeah, we should reset, maybe.
I'm looking, I'm looking, I'm looking.
I'm coming back soon, I'm coming back soon.
I take ult, I take ult.
I have ult, I have ult here.
Careful, they have Starlord ult here.
I'm trying to save.
I hit him.
Starlord, Starlord, Starlord, Starlord, Starlord.
I'm looking, I'm looking, I'm looking.
I'm back, I'm ulting, I'm ulting this.
I got both.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice.
Point.
Yeah, I don't know why, but...
We got this.
4 minutes.
Yeah, okay.
Look, I have my 50 kills.
Maybe we get 60 kills.
Yeah, if I lock in here.
I believe.
60 kills, 60 kills, right?
You're thinking in your head.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Why stop at 60?
What if we do 100 kills?
Yeah.
I didn't...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're right.
Like, when we cap it, we should just all leave the point and have...
Just push up.
What if we tell him to go AFK so I can farm kills?
Sounds like the game plan.
And then we lose.
Oh, hell nah.
Okay, listen.
Would you be willing to lose if I get 100?
No.
What?
No, no, no.
No.
That's crazy.
I would be ready to lose for you to get 100 kills.
Yeah, but I'm not aiming for 100 kills.
I'm aiming for top 500.
Why not?
Why not, Doki?
You can get 100 kills whenever you want.
This is why I am the LeBron James of this game, Doki.
Okay, chill out, chill out.
Okay, chill out.
DokiBirdFan is higher-ranked than you.
Yeah, that's right.
DokiBirdFan is abusing Wolverine.
DokiBirdFan is a LeBron of them, alright?
DokiBirdFan abusing Wolverine, alright, buddy?
Don't you abuse Dr. Strange?
Wolverine abusing.
Don't forget, securing the victory.
He pulled a Rek'sai.
They're placing TP.
They're placing TP in front of me.
Get ready.
Okay.
Go right side.
Fast, fast, fast, fast, fast, fast, fast, fast, fast.
I'm only 125.
Yeah, I don't... I can't even see anything.
I'm like... I'm just holding right click as much as I can.
Okay.
I'm trying to.
I don't have leaves anymore.
There's a... Oh, there's a Starlord behind us.
Strange one, Strange one, Strange one!
Um, I slept the Strange.
I slept Strange.
Oh, I saw Lux on me.
Deathcloak, help me!
I'm getting Mag, I'm getting Mag, I'm getting Mag.
I think we got regrouped.
Yeah.
I can... I don't know if I should save it for a Starlord.
We need something for Starlord.
Yeah.
We need something.
I'll save mine for Starlord and we can use Cloak.
Starlord's here, right?
You're so low.
I'm sleeping right now.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
I'm going for it.
Okay, I'm going to ult.
You guys see him?
I'm on Mag, I'm on Mag, I'm on Mag.
I'm ulting too.
I am...
There is a Psylocke!
Psylocke's asleep!
Starlord one, Starlord one!
Psylocke, Psylocke, Psylocke!
Oh no, this Starlord.
58 kills, 58 kills!
They will TP, they will TP, they will TP.
They won't TP.
It's really hard to TP here.
No, it's fine, it's fine, because he's already alright.
Okay, nice.
Okay, we got this.
And the ult charge.
I think they used Mag and he died instantly.
They used Starlord, they have Psylocke.
Yeah, they used Psylocke.
Oh, they already used Psylocke.
I killed her out of Psylocke ult.
Okay, nice, okay, nice.
They still have Strangels, right?
Yeah, they have Strangels.
Careful, crew, I don't have a lot of these.
Nice, guys, that's big, that's big!
Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag!
Wait, what?
How did she get it again?
We got Psylocke now.
I thought I killed her out of ult.
Ah, it's fine, it's fine.
Starlord's one.
It's fine.
They used C, we have two minutes to push, that's very good.
Okay, that's weird.
I legitimately saw her ulting.
Oh, she got 50% back.
I thought...
I didn't realize.
I didn't realize it was 50%.
She built it so fast.
I don't have anything for it.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
Adios, adios, adios, nice.
I'm asleep, I'm asleep.
Go, push, push, push, push.
I am pushing.
There's a Slardar behind me.
Get Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag.
Starlord, Starlord, Starlord got his ult.
Got it all, nice.
Now we got this.
Push, push, push.
He's rezzing, he's rezzing, he's rezzing.
That's huge, that's huge.
Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag.
They can't, they can't keep them up.
I'm coming back with ult, if you guys can live.
Yeah, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
Nice.
Keep Psy.
Oh my god, 69 assists, let's go.
Bro, Mag was trying so hard.
I'm sorry, Mag.
Why was I fighting for it?
There was nothing more I could do.
He was doing so good too.
Oh my god.
Like it's not, like I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, buddy.
I'm so fucking sorry.
I needed it more.
Bro, he was actually playing out of his fucking mind there.
It was actually crazy.
He was playing out of his fucking mind.
Poor guy.
Am I getting stream sniped?
I think I might be.
Probably.
Did you see that?
In team and then they got in queue and I got in queue.
Missed it.
That's pretty sus.
Yeah, that's pretty sus.
Oh my god, thank god.
We are back in the land.
Wait, new names.
Wait, is this EU?
Oh my god, my one ping.
Guys,
my one ping, guys.
Good thing I had that one ping, right?
Good fucking...
Do we just ban Storm, Hella?
Yeah, go Hella.
Orange guy detected.
Bro, he's literally in my stack.
That's so fucking bad.
Also, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
One ping is real.
I get one ping no matter what region I'm in.
Thank you for gifting five stars.
Thank you.
I can't lose, you're right.
Ban Storm?
We could let it open and just kill it.
Okay, well, let's just ban whole guy.
The one ping to rule them all.
Man, my fiber internet is so fucking good, guys.
That's crazy.
Okay, you go play Luna, I go play Mantiska.
My fiber internet is fucking crazy.
Wait, I play Luna?
Can I not play this map?
What do I play?
Actually, we are trapped here.
Three times in a row.
We fucking hate that map.
Guys, no.
Guys, trust me.
We're doing one match on EU and see how it goes.
If it goes poorly, that's my bad.
I even encouraged it.
I was like, it'll be fine.
Okay, guys, let's go.
It'll be fine.
One ping.
Luna, we need passive health, so Panthers.
What did he say?
Yes.
Did you get that?
Wait, what did he say?
We need passive heal.
Nah, nah.
Guys, I need translation.
Guys, I haven't played with EU players in so long.
Guys, translation now.
We?
Guys, I need translation, please.
Place above them.
If they decide to face me.
Yes, yeah.
Guys, translations, please.
There are no ping.
Okay, I'm just going to place it above them.
Just shoot them.
Who's going to shoot them?
You?
I'll shoot it, bro.
I'll shoot it.
Our Panther got this, bro.
I called it.
Nobody followed.
I was there.
I was with you.
Thanks, Doki bro.
I know you got my back.
Behind, behind, behind.
There's a Psylocke.
There's a Psylocke behind.
Jesus, you're taking so much damage.
There's a Psylocke.
On our Mantis.
I can't get to you, Mantis.
Psylocke's on me now.
Psylocke's on me.
I have a Psylocke on me.
Still.
Do you know how to play Namor?
No, I don't play Namor.
I'm sorry.
Bro, that's the most American European I've ever met.
Oh no, you're the legend.
It sounded so American.
Oh, Mantis, I can't...
Hey, fuck it, I'm down.
Bro, where are you from?
Make a skinsh.
Heal me, heal me, heal me.
I'm one.
I'm trying to heal you from below.
I have no ammo.
Oh my god.
Push this, push this, push this.
W, W, W.
Punisher, Punisher.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Punisher's by himself?
We got locked out, we got locked out.
He's behind us.
I froze him.
Nevermind.
I have my TP.
I'm at TPS.
Where is this Black Panther from?
No, I don't have TP.
I'm sorry for a second.
Oh yeah, I can't be CC and all.
Yeah, I just noticed that.
I forgot that he was in ult form.
My mind blanked out there.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, you're...
Oh my...
Oh my god.
We're locked out.
Yeah, it's not now but...
Yeah, I can't do anything here.
I'm gonna slow.
I froze stream.
Oh, that Psylocke wants to kill you.
They're one, they're one, they're one.
I have to reload.
But he's still contesting if we can...
Are we getting suicide?
Nah.
We're not gonna go all far.
Help our Penny.
I'm trying my best.
Don't clap.
We can Mass Assault first.
Get out!
Just walk backwards!
Oh my god, that's right!
Walk backwards!
That's the plan!
I have a Psylocke behind me though.
I don't want to ult here.
I need help, I need help!
Heal's here.
Did you kill one?
I have ult so you can build ult off of our...
Play here, play here, play here, play here.
I'm with you.
I have to reload.
Strange one.
Strange one, strange one.
Psylocke's just poking us.
Molting us.
Woah.
Watch out.
Oh my god.
3, 2, 1.
Oh my god, I'm dead.
Jesus Christ, the triple support is going crazy over there.
I am not wasting my potential on support because the DPS players I'm playing against have been playing DPS on Overwatch for fucking years.
Bro, I cannot compete against that.
Yeah, I play Apex, but like I play...
Oh my god.
I've been playing Overwatch support for years still.
I'm literally playing against Overwatch League fucking DPS players.
Like what the fuck am I going to do?
I'm leaving, I'm leaving, I left.
He fucked up TP, he fucked up TP.
Can we touch, can we touch?
I'm on it, I'm on it.
Which is why you should learn tech.
I don't hate myself that much.
I don't...
Guys, I don't hate myself that much to play tank.
I feel attacked.
Needless.
Thor is fun as hell.
Thor is in meta.
In high elo, it's Magneto, Strange.
And then...
I guess nothing.
Magneto, Strange.
How many people play other than that?
That's really... I guess like Root with the Strange.
Hulk, yeah.
Magneto, Strange, Hulk.
I'm sure.
Do I even TP?
Every time we TP, we lose.
Yeah, I think it's pretty good actually.
That's so true.
Root is fine, but like...
It depends, it really depends.
It's very situational.
Whoa, one ping?
That's crazy, I know.
Whoa.
I don't see their Strange.
He's TPing, he's TPing.
I'm TPing on him.
Right side, go fast, go fast, go fast.
On him, on him, on him.
I'm frozen, I'm frozen, I'm frozen.
Okay, okay, okay.
We got one.
Jesus Christ.
The Rocket is by himself.
Wait, there's a Psylocke in our TP.
I'm trying to help you.
Get the supports fast.
There's a Raccoon to our right.
We got one.
Ah, she's out.
It's fine though.
Get point, get point.
Don't die, don't die.
Oh.
Just keep getting points.
Psylocke behind, Psylocke behind.
Psylocke's on me.
Psylocke's one, Psylocke's one.
I got Psylocke.
I'm on Strange, Strange one, Strange one.
There we go.
That's right, heal this!
Alright.
Yeah, Mathis, you can push up for ult charge.
I already have my ult.
Alright, here we go.
Yeah, Jeff is quick play meta.
Unless you're a fucking one trick.
Then you're scary as hell.
Then like, I don't know, do whatever the fuck you want.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
There's Strange one, Strange one.
Psylocke's one.
Oh, we lost our Mantis.
I think we should just back off a little.
I froze the Strange.
Morenation is dying, guys.
Goodbye.
Yeah, it's fine.
Oh, I might get staggered.
No!
It's fine.
Rocket Raccoon is meta too.
Oh my god, we've lost him.
We lost him too.
He cut off his hands.
We fucking lost him.
I'm gonna look for finish off to E5, okay?
Yeah, there's no shield.
Strange no shield.
Jesus Christ.
E damage on finisher?
Thanks for the shield.
Psylocke's half.
He's looped, he's looped.
Okay, he's out.
The king in black shall not see the light again.
I am ready to put on the show.
There's a Psylocke behind us.
Yeah.
I'm ulting.
They have Strange ult though.
That's fine, that's fine.
He's looking for it, he's looking for it.
Strange, Strange, Strange.
Yeah, it's fine.
Again.
Strange one, Strange one.
Psylocke half.
Oh, he's getting healed.
Watch out, Psylocke's half, Psylocke's half.
Oh, no, no, no.
I did.
I healed you.
I healed you, I swear.
Watch out, watch out, watch out.
Feed him, bro.
He did every headshot possible.
Oh my god.
Why?
You saw my fucking thing on him.
He was headshotting.
What do I do?
It was so strong.
Nothing could...
I mean, if our Luna also...
I'm not Luna.
If our Mantis...
If our Mantis also healed him, it would have been possible.
I literally did everything I could to keep him up.
Psylocke's behind.
Bro, is our Mantis okay?
Oh my god.
If only our Mantis was not having a good time.
Our Mantis is dead.
No more nation.
Our Mantis is not having a good time.
I just realized that.
He's dead.
They're all there.
Watch out, strangers.
Strangers, strangers.
Okay, we never land well.
Jesus Christ.
There's a Psylocke above high ground.
I'm trying to make sure.
Bro.
Bro, they're all...
Oh my god.
There's so much damage being taken.
No!
We have one fight left.
I'm going to have to give this to Psylocke.
Psylocke one.
Bro.
Oh my god, we're going Squirrel.
That's fine.
This is it.
The Squirrel is the pick.
It's game changing.
I believe.
I still believe.
I still...
I'm so low.
Bye.
Two seconds.
Oh my god.
We gotta touch.
They're going to Psylocke after this.
I'm a little scared.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I have to reload.
Just run backwards.
That's what they say, right?
Oh, I have Psylocke on me.
Guys, I don't think this is it.
This Psylocke fucked us up.
Oh my god.
No, this Psylocke farmed this hard.
Yeah, it's understandable.
Their Psylocke was just better.
Raccoon was only viable because there were two other supports, guys.
They ran triple support.
You can't fucking say Raccoon carried.
He was like in plus one.
Just hit your freeze.
I have a Mantis with me.
Why don't you tell her to hit her fucking sleep tail?
Why is it just me?
The Raccoon was near the third wheel.
What about her Mantis?
She was also struggling.
He was near the third wheeling fucking Peter Hal.
Why is it with noise?
Oh, it's you, is it?
Yes, absolutely.
I'm glad people noticed.
I'm glad people noticed, guys.
Thank you.
We get that map a fourth time.
I'm going to...
That's true.
That was like the fourth time.
We played that map for four times.
Oh, finally.
We're in Shibuya.
We're in Shibuya now.
We're not fucking playing the Raccoon.
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
Oh, we're still in EU.
With my one ping.
But I want to play Halo, bro.
I want to play Halo.
Yo, that's too bad, I guess.
Guys!
How long have I been streaming for you?
I've been five hours.
Right click, left click.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
We're better Hawkeye?
Yeah, we're better Hawkeye.
No, you do not.
It'll be fine, guys.
It's how nobody says they're not a fan of Doki.
How they are a fan.
Wait, we didn't even ban Mantis.
I'm bored!
I'll drop follow on Doki, you guys!
It's working!
It's fucking working!
He's a paid actor.
Weakest Doki breed.
Plus one.
The grind never... It's just that easy.
It's literally just that easy.
Marketing goes insane.
Why don't we have a Mantis?
That doesn't matter, bro.
That doesn't matter.
Gain plus one.
Now will they throw for you?
Doki, that's true.
That's true.
He dropped the follow.
It's time.
Free me from this cage.
The moment I get 200 points, I'm fucking ending it for today.
I can't keep going.
I'm not strong enough.
I'm sorry.
Wait, can you play Luna?
I can play Mantis.
Okay, they have Luna.
Okay, okay.
If we die, we'll swap.
Wait, Black Panther!
Black Panther!
Okay, now we swap.
We did it.
It was planned.
Okay, they have to keep on diving.
Alright, nice.
What if I go panic?
We did it.
Rio, Rio, Rio.
I believe anybody can do it.
It's you.
Thank you.
Thank you, though.
Oh shit, nice, nice, nice!
Magic, magic!
Careful for Black Panther, though.
Wait, the supports are low.
Black Panther on me.
I'm looking for one.
We're down.
We're down support.
They're still...
They only have Luna heals.
Yeah, we have Luna heals.
I think we should play.
There's a Magic.
Magic, sleep.
Right, right, right.
Woah.
I'm just gonna stay here.
I'm a little scared about that Black Panther.
Black Panther on me.
He's on me.
I need heals.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
I'm ulting.
Oh wait, nevermind.
I'll ult after.
I'm ulting.
Magic's asleep.
Oh wait, nevermind.
Oh.
There was the strange ult.
I'm ulting.
Strange ult.
Black Panther low.
No, no, no.
No support.
They're coming over.
It's safe.
We got this.
Yeah.
Luna's coming in now.
Luna's coming in.
Nice.
Panther's still low.
Oh, slept Black Panther.
Slept Black Panther.
Right here.
He's low.
I stunned her.
Oh, magic one.
Oh my god, I hate this Black Panther.
I'm gonna fuck you.
Wakanda no more.
Oh.
Oh, I might be dead to this.
Oh, Psylocke's half.
Psylocke low.
You only have one support right now.
There's someone to our far right.
I don't know who it is.
Psylocke on the way.
You only have Psylocke.
Psylocke.
Oh, Black Panther low.
I'm dead.
You still have.
Luna's back.
Our Luna's back.
I'm coming over.
Wait, what?
Oh, that's unlucky.
I think we should just reset and not use anything.
Yeah, reset.
I told you so.
I have TP.
I can go in with Mantis ult, too.
I'm back at the point.
C9?
Whoa.
In my one above all lobby.
There's a guy behind us, guys.
Yeah, I'm dead.
There's one.
I just won.
We have five ultimate.
Yeah.
I can engage with Mantis.
I'll engage with Mantis.
Oh, Mantis one.
I'm going to go in.
Three, two, one.
Strange is low.
I'm on cart.
I'm on Strange.
There's somebody behind.
Magic's on me.
He TP'd somewhere.
I don't know where.
Behind.
I'm trying to get to you.
Magic and Panther are behind us, I think.
Magic is main.
Oh, Magic's main?
Okay.
Panther's behind, though.
He's one.
I have Panther on me.
I can Magic.
This stupid Panther.
Somebody go back and destroy Wakanda.
Wakanda!
Oh, I can't help you, sir.
Jesus Christ, I can't do anything.
Wakanda is no more.
Okay, I'm being harassed by this Black Panther.
Wakanda's not real!
Wakanda's not even real.
What do you mean?
Wakanda never lasts this long.
Someone from Wakanda, I feel offended.
It's not even...
None of this is real!
This is my emotion.
None of this is fucking real!
Are you a Black Panther player?
Yes.
Ah.
I mean, you can.
It's real to me.
Wakanda forever.
Might be too late at that point, but...
I believe in you.
Oh my god, this is gonna be rough.
Okay.
I'm literally watching...
I'm like the top 500.
It hasn't changed me at all.
Can't change me if I'm not top 500.
Yeah, it's so true.
So true, bestie.
I'm gonna think...
Oh my god!
I'm cocooning now.
I have a Luna on me.
Luna's behind.
Mantis one.
I got Mantis.
Magics one too.
I have a Psylocke on me.
She's behind.
I can't get to you.
There's Psylocke to our right.
I need top off.
I got you.
There's a Psylocke.
Oh, hi girl.
Psylocke's behind in Black Panther.
He's asleep.
I'm trying to keep you up.
I sliver.
I have no leaves right now.
Okay, I damage boosted you.
I'll do Mantis ult first.
Since I have...
It's fine.
That's unfortunate.
Good one, maybe?
It's fine.
Magic.
Magic's the lead.
I got it.
I'm ulting in.
Stay together.
Oh, that hit me.
I can't.
I got support.
We have...
Oh, our Luna died.
That's unfortunate.
That was unfortunate for our Luna.
It's fine.
We got magic.
She's low.
Oh my god.
I don't have any leaves right now.
Nice.
I'm pushing up.
There's a Black Panther.
There's magic behind us.
I'm ulting.
Black Panther on the right.
He's still on the back.
I didn't help.
You're leaving me behind.
I'm trying to help you right now.
Behind me.
Black Panther's low.
Mid shift.
I'm fine.
Oh my god.
Oh, magic one.
Nice, nice, nice.
We're up two.
Nice, that's a huge sleep.
Huge sleep.
I did that.
That was me.
I did that sleep, guys.
Nice sleep.
I'm mine.
I'll Mantis ult first.
Yeah, I'll kite this for now.
Yeah, I'm coming.
They're near me.
I was very clear that I was gonna ult first.
I was very clear about it.
I'm going over right now.
I'm on it.
Oh, I died though.
I'm okay.
I don't have leaves.
I'm asleep.
I can cocoon on it.
I said Mantis ult first.
I was like, Mantis ult first.
I don't know.
I made it very clear.
I mean, we all heard it.
We all...
I don't know how she would have it low.
I made it very clear what my plan was.
I made it very clear.
I thought we all knew what was gonna happen.
This is why you don't talk about Wakanda.
I mean...
I was getting...
What do you want me to do?
He was diving me.
Who was it?
This was our other Luna, right?
What did you want me to do?
I'm sorry.
I have to avoid you.
Your voice chat was too low.
So you get avoided.
How else am I gonna talk to you?
How?
This is not a me issue.
I said...
Mantis ult first.
It's not real!
They don't even have a Disneyland park.
They don't even have a Wakanda Disneyland.
That's right.
I said it.
It's only real.
They get a world in Disneyland.
Wow.
It's real to me.
They wouldn't if you accepted them.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Francis?
God, I hope it's real.
We have a guy that says he's from France.
They're trying to say...
JokeyBirdFan69 is not real?
You're right.
I don't have...
That's too many fans.
You're right.
69 is way too many dragons.
Me and my 68...
bots in my chat.
That's right.
The 9 was just...
What the...
That seems like a weird number.
I'm JokeyBirdFan1.
I think we kind of have to ban...
Hela and Hawkeye.
Hela...
and Hawkeye.
Hi Mono and Booger.
I saw you in...
Overwatch once.
Just one time?
Just once?
I believe in them to do all the bans for me.
Wakanda forever!
Thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you.
Kaz, thank you for the 500 bitties.
Psylocke?
Psylocke is fine.
I think we ban Psylocke.
Team, I understand why you're scared.
But we can win this.
Okay?
I understand why you're scared.
Are we scared?
Am I supposed to be scared?
What am I supposed to be scared about?
I didn't...
I didn't go in here thinking I'd be scared about something.
I didn't know.
What am I supposed to be scared about?
Be scared of Wakanda.
Do not be afraid.
Does she know?
I don't know.
What am I supposed to know?
What am I supposed to do?
Don't be afraid.
What am I supposed to be afraid about?
Wakanda doesn't even have a Disneyland resort!
Doesn't even have a LAN in Disneyland!
Stop!
The moment Wakanda gets a...
gets a LAN in Disneyland, I'll acknowledge Wakanda.
Oh, my bad.
I opened the portal, guys.
I'm a little scared here, guys.
Just a little bit.
How about Black Panther on me?
Kenny on me.
I need heals.
Guys,
okay.
I acknowledge Wakanda.
If I acknowledge Wakanda, can I survive?
Can I...
Every time!
You're right.
Wakanda is real.
Wakanda... Oh, wait.
There's a Namor behind us.
There's a Wakanda... No, there's a Namor right behind us still.
Black Panther.
Okay.
Oh, there's a Wakanda cat.
Hey, cat.
I fucking got brain rot right now.
I have fucking Wakanda.
There's a Black Panther on me still.
He's half.
He's low.
Black Panther's one.
Oh, Namor behind me.
I need heals.
Yeah.
I know, right?
Okay.
Black Panther's still behind me.
Black Panther half.
Berserker!
I'm coming, Namor.
Oh, my fear!
I have Black Panther on me again.
Oh, my God!
Holy shit.
Fear.
Guys, if I acknowledge Wakanda cannot survive, cannot live, cannot just, you know, live for one second.
And Namor's always, like, in our backline.
Can you get top to off Mantis?
Oh,
my God.
Oh, yeah.
Black Panther to our left.
We got it.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, Black Panther behind me.
Black Panther behind me again.
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna ulti this in.
I'm capping through now.
Alright, I'm coming over.
I'm coming over.
Right side.
Penny, Penny, Penny, Penny.
Penny frozen.
Penny one.
Namor, Namor, Namor.
Namor half.
Magina, Magina.
Oh, my God.
The reload.
Black Panther, Panther.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my...
In the fictional country, Marvel Rivals.
See, you guys know it's not real.
You guys even admit it's not fucking real.
Acknowledge Wakanda.
It's real.
You can't report a Wakanda.
It's good.
Yes, please do it.
That's it, Wakanda.
Curse back.
No, I acknowledge Wakanda.
It's a beautiful country.
It's a beautiful country and I love it.
I love Wakanda.
Wakanda sometimes.
Munich high and Wakanda.
Wakanda.
I can't see you, Magia.
I'm capping.
We can't see you, Magic.
Okay.
Okay, I need to get top up if you can.
Get him.
Grab him again.
I'm peering.
I got killed.
I'm looking.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Penny just walked up to us.
Sorry, guys.
I was killing them.
She did the thing again.
I can probably go in one minute, so I can just stick on Magic.
I will go in and kill her.
Give me an A.
You can get Mantis out first.
I'm ulting.
I'm ulting S.
Kill Penny.
Penny.
I'm sleeping.
Hold on.
Try my best.
Three, two, one.
I'm backing up.
I have a Bucky on me.
Bucky.
Oh my god.
He went full French.
He went fucking full French there.
They don't even have Black Panther.
What do you mean Wakanda?
They don't even have fucking Black Panther.
Who is he Wakanda?
Who are you guys Wakandering for?
I got stunned.
I'm one.
I'm dead.
Jesus Christ.
I can't see.
Oh my god.
Okay, I don't have a deal.
Someone's frozen.
I have no idea who.
We can win this.
I'm dead.
I can't see you.
I'm gonna go.
They don't have E though.
Look at Penny.
Penny.
Penny's low.
Penny won.
Penny still won.
Oh no.
I can't kill you.
I got you.
Iron Man is low.
Okay, he's getting me.
Oh my god.
I'm ulting.
Look at Penny.
Penny.
I'm gonna look at the Iron Man.
I'm gonna try my best.
3, 2, 1.
I've got this.
Nice.
Very nice.
Did he Penny ulted?
One HP Bucky.
Oh my god.
Guys, maybe Iron Man close to the ult, okay?
Do they have Penny ult?
Maybe.
They definitely have Bucky ult for this.
Iron Man right here.
Iron Man to my left.
I'm gonna ult this.
Penny won.
Penny's won.
Strange one.
Strange low.
I got you.
We still have like one more fight here.
I hope our Mantis get ult.
Our Mantis has ult.
Let's get Luna ult as well maybe.
I'm gonna feed you.
I take damage.
Watch out hook.
No hook.
Iron Man behind me.
I froze him.
Turn around.
Get him.
Nice.
I'm trying.
Oh, I got hit.
I got hit.
Please.
I'm so close.
I gotta look out.
Just play on me again.
Three, two, one.
I should've saved it.
Bro, I'm going on that point.
I don't care.
I'm going there.
I believe.
One by one.
I'm coming now.
I'm touching, bro.
I'm getting the minefield.
Minefield is down.
Nice.
Maybe we can get ult.
Try to still leave that game, Papaya.
Bro, I had such a good freeze.
Still!
Bro, my freeze was fucking insane there.
It was actually such a good freeze.
That was a game changer.
For Wakanda.
He's not even in the game anymore.
He's not.
He's not even in the game.
Okay, we got this.
Travis, make Doki believe in Wakanda.
You repaid my freeze.
That's true.
Don't be scared.
But I'm scared.
What a fucking statement.
Don't be scared.
Actually.
I need to be top of Mantis.
Penny, penny, penny.
Try to Q, I'm trying to Q.
Train, train, train.
That's huge.
That's good ult.
Fuck you ult.
I can ult after this.
I'm near reload.
I'm ulting.
I'm ulting this.
I'm okay.
That's huge.
That's a huge ult.
Did they use both support ults?
Or just one?
Yeah, they did.
Okay, because I only saw Mantis.
I wasn't sure.
Might have Viki.
Okay, look behind.
Okay, they have Wolverine now.
Wolverine low.
Wolverine, no Passive, no Porn.
Viki's one behind.
Penny, Penny, Penny one.
Yep, we can.
I can't see you, Ironman.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
I'm dying, I'm dying, I'm dying.
I got you, I got you, I got you, I got you.
You're not dying on our...
That's right, you're alive!
How can lose?
Do not be afraid.
You can touch, you can touch.
Mantis on me.
Oh, no freeze, no freeze.
Penny top up, top me up, top me up.
Nice.
Yippee!
Do not...
Enemy team...
I told you!
Wakanda's not real.
Wakanda has fallen!
Am I a bad guy?
Am I the villain?
Thank you for the 500 bitties.
Am I a villain?
No.
Wakanda sometimes...
Nah, I couldn't be it.
I always have been.
Wakanda made me.
We're definitely on...
We're EUing.
I'm EU now, let's go!
I can't believe I didn't bump into a fucking single...
I literally haven't bumped into any streamers, it's actually crazy.
The only streamers are literally in my stash, like all my team.
I bumped into Mac, but he was on the enemy team, it's actually crazy.
I had ShroudQE, I had Sinatraa, Dafran, TenZ, like...
And I never saw any of them!
I never saw any of them!
I bumped into Super, but they're always on the enemy team!
They're always on...
Yeah, I bumped into Super, but he was on the enemy team!
They know the truth of poke.
Wakanda.
Nice target banner.
No, don't ban Bruce banner, please, I beg.
Please ban Hawkeye or I'll end my life on VC.
Big mistake.
Big mistake, big mistake, big mistake.
You and me, baby.
Can't lose, can't lose, can't lose, can't lose.
But what if they go Hulk?
How can we lose?
My Hulk dives their Hulk.
Our Ironman dives their Ironman.
Our Ironman dives their entire team.
Jarvis clip this.
I'm judging everything you do, Ironman, by the way.
I'm gonna watch the replay of our Ironman after this.
Okay, okay.
I'll be on it.
I'm gonna make a video of it.
I never lose a game.
I will let you know that me and Doki were rolling them.
That's so true.
We were winning all our games.
Oh no, I'm so vegan.
I'm so vegan.
Alright, DokiBerryFans69.
You gotta pick it up.
I'm picking it up as we speak.
I love how French you are, man.
It makes me happy.
Jarvis deleting the replay.
DokiBerryFans69 needs to pass his audition.
Triple support.
Play forward.
They have no damage.
Their damage is just death.
Just get point.
Can you top me off real quick?
Oh, I have to reload.
Okay,
we need to look now.
One, two, three.
Oh my god.
Get the support.
I have to reload.
I have my ult.
I'll ult this.
We'll keep Mantis second.
No!
I'm so sad.
We can just stall point if we can.
That's really nice.
You're so healthy.
I'm not, though.
I'm dead.
You like me, Doki.
You said I'm healthy.
Alright.
I wasn't talking about you.
I was talking about the guy in front of me.
My bad, gang.
Okay, I'm reloading.
Let's look for one now.
Three, two, one.
I need to reload.
I see a Jett.
We're up one.
We got this, gang.
What if I hunt down their Ironman and just grab him?
Do it.
Put that in the video.
Jarvis, clip that.
He's on the left.
They're pushing now.
I'm frozen.
I don't think I can heal you.
I got you.
They have Hulk, alright.
I'm looking.
We lost one.
I have Hulk chasing me.
Jarvis, give me Jett.
We should just die on point.
That's fine.
My bad.
We don't have ult.
Jeff ulted.
Don't let me get D.Mech.
I'm trying my best.
Okay, you need to get value on your ult.
I'm going to look for our flank, okay?
They should have Hulk ult as well.
Nice.
I got Ironman.
That's fine.
We have no support.
We're fine.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
I can ult right in with Luno.
I'll ult.
I'll ult first.
I'll go in 3, 2, 1.
3, 2, 1.
I don't have anymore.
Kill the supports.
I have a Magneto on me.
I have a Hulk on me now.
Hulk is on supports.
Jeff is low.
No,
I had...
Yeah.
Jarvis, this is real.
They're focusing support.
They're like...
I think we just need to play...
The Hulk and the Magneto is just pushing the supports freely.
Yeah, that's...
That's bad.
They have like... Yeah, but Hulk and...
They had one DPS.
And it was three supports.
With Ironman, Hulk, Magneto.
But their Hulk literally just walks up to me.
And I'm like, what do I...
What?
What do I do?
Hulk smash?
I guess I die?
I think our Psylocke is struggling.
Nice.
Hulk on our supports again.
Run, run, run, run.
Oh my god.
This is so funny.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
That was pretty good.
I'm trying to keep you up.
I'm moving back.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
I'm on Hulk.
Jesus Christ, dude.
Your Hulk is good.
I'm gonna ult this.
I don't think that's what you guys want.
Oh my god.
We're up one.
I got you.
Nice, nice, nice.
Get the Hulk, get the Hulk.
Hulk one.
I stunned him, I stunned him.
3, 2, 1.
I need to get topped off, Mantis.
Or not.
I can go in with my ult.
I got you, I got you.
We got the Mantis out.
I have a Hulk on us.
I'm trying to keep you up.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm on Jeff, Jeff, Jeff.
I'm on Hulk right now.
Luna, luna, luna.
I got you, I got you.
I'm on Hulk, I'm on Hulk, I'm on Hulk.
We staggered him?
Oh fuck, he booped me.
Oh no, he's gonna live.
They have Hulk ult here.
I'm looking top right, by the way.
God, you're fucking serious.
I'm mad.
I froze him, I froze him.
Oh,
I couldn't, I couldn't, sorry.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
I'm on point, I'm on point, if you need heals, I'm on point.
I'm going first.
Oh, that's fucked up.
I'm on point, I'm on point.
Hulk one, Hulk one.
Stay on point, Kat, stay on point, Kat.
I'm looking at Luna, I'm looking at Luna.
I'm beaming Luna, I'm beaming Luna.
Magneo's just looking at me.
We never lose, we never lose.
That's fine, we have point, by the way.
Magneo, Magneo, he's just...
He's free shooting me.
Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna.
Oh my god.
Machiko, thank you for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
For those who are new here, my name is JokeyBit.
I usually stream on YouTube, but I'm here on Twitch because I'm...
I hate myself, but I'm doing the Marvel Rivals re-engrine.
Yeah, I think we just keep the defensive line.
I just...
I'm just here.
That's fine, we're trying.
We're trying to get 200 points and then calling it.
I don't even know how long Boger's gonna be streaming for though.
I don't even know how long he usually streams for.
We're at the...
We're at the six hour mark now.
The goal is...
The goal is 200 points and then we'll try again tomorrow.
Can you stop having sex in my lobby, please?
Okay, bro.
Excuse me?
I don't like dual streaming.
I don't like splitting the audience and I don't like having to deal with two different chats.
Because it's like...
I feel like I have to balance out two chats and I can't.
I can't focus enough for that.
It's going to be me, I'm fine though.
I'm gonna go, I'm gonna go.
Oh my god.
Oh, I tried to hook you up too.
We're down one.
We're down a support.
I'm on point right now.
I have to reload.
Reload.
Yeah, you're down three.
We're coming back.
Oh, I can't see you.
I can't see you for heals.
Okay, I got you.
I got you.
Guys, we're up.
I'm gonna have to save my ult for...
I have to save my ult for Starlord.
We're even, we're even right now.
I couldn't help you there.
Okay, I'll ult now.
They're gonna Starlord after this though.
Three, two, one.
I'm trying to help you.
I have a Hulk behind me.
Hulk is frozen, Hulk is frozen.
I'm a cloak, I'm a cloak.
I need heals, I need heals here.
Nice.
No support, no support.
He's one, he's one.
We have no support.
Oh my god.
Last fight.
Jesus Christ, this Ironman is crazy though.
Cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak.
Starlord, Starlord, Starlord.
Italy, where's anyone?
Oh, I couldn't see you.
I can't see you, Psylocke.
There's an Ironman just shooting me.
Ironman half.
I froze Hulk behind me.
Push this, push this.
He's gonna, Hulk is gonna be on me.
Hulk is gonna be on me.
Let me survive for one second.
Kill them, no more.
No more ults, no more ults.
Mantis is like on the area of low HP by the way.
Yep.
We only have one fight here.
I need to back out a little.
We have no support ults by the way.
Yeah, I can't build in time too.
I'm asleep, I'm chilling.
Can you reload?
I have a Starlord on me.
We have no supports.
That's unlucky.
Mantis is coming back right now.
No!
Oh, yeah.
I did everything I could.
Oh my god, I freezed every time I could dive.
I tried to freeze.
Those two ults.
That's so cruel.
Holy fuck.
Guys.
Guys, I think this Ironman dipped us.
You're right, it wasn't our Ironman.
It was our Psylocke, you're right.
You're right.
It was our Ironman.
It was our Psylocke.
No, Psylocke was definitely not doing well.
Because our Psylocke wasn't doing well, their team got more space than us.
I saw our Psylocke solo ult a fucking Hulk.
That was...
That was pretty bad.
Oh my god.
Our Psylocke solo ulted Hulk.
It was pretty cool.
That's why I waited.
I hope he...
having a good Sunday.
Is today Sunday?
Or is today Saturday?
I lost track.
Oh, it is.
Thank you.
So positive.
And I hope someone loves him.
Because he's not getting that on the internet.
Alright.
Anyway.
It's Monday in Wakanda.
Casual Rivals Gaming.
That's so mean.
In Marvel Rev.
In game.
There you go.
It makes it a lot better if you put in game.
In game.
No, we're ending it at 200.
Or 150.
I'm just gonna...
You know what?
Or 150.
I'll settle.
I'm willing to settle.
I'm willing to settle at 150.
No, guys.
Guys, don't say that.
Guys.
Guys, we can settle for 150.
Guys, no, no.
It's fine.
We can do... I believe.
Where did I start at?
I started at 66, so like we're up technically.
We're up.
If we do 150 and then maybe we can get 250 next time.
I believe.
It's alright.
I took a nap before.
I took a nap before I started my stream.
I mean, I was gonna start my stream early and then I fucking took a nap early.
So, it'll be fine.
I believe.
What could go wrong?
Absolutely nothing.
As long as we keep believing.
Guys, I need you to believe in me more, guys.
This is the reason.
We just need more people to believe.
Then we'll be fine.
No, I do not drop.
We're in a state of mind where we don't drop.
I wish there was like custom lobbies to pass the time.
Or like um...
um...
I wish there was like just...
Let's see.
I wish I had a better item.
I was watching like a pro Adam player and like literally all he solo carries as Adam is actually crazy.
I don't remember his name.
But like, he would literally get like...
He would get like four kills by himself and then just carry the game.
Damn it.
He said I play like super... You gotta be like super restrained.
Wait, are we back in NA?
Did we gave up on EU?
I don't know if we gave up on EU.
Do I watch any of the top 500 low-key players?
No.
I know they're really good.
I've seen like a lot of like the low-key players are low-key one tricks.
What?
Did he just say he's a squirrel girl player?
What's wrong?
What?
I've seen like really good low-key players and they're like it's actually like, it's really interesting watching them play because people are figuring out how to play low-key now.
People are figuring out how to play low-key now and it's like, it's all like mind games.
Go Adam and make your dreams reality and become the Adam goat.
Nothing wrong with squirrel girl, Doki.
Don't be sexy.
Like I said, don't be sexiest.
Don't be sexiest.
I'm literally playing Luna.
What the fuck?
Not all women.
Jesus
Christ, how do you have Lord?
Lord, which end?
Squirrel girl?
How?
What do you mean she's pretty mid?
What the fuck do you mean?
Look at her!
What?
Look at that!
All cake is good cake.
Doesn't matter.
Okay.
I'm fine, I'm fine, I'm fine.
Wait, there's an Iron Fist behind us.
No parries, no parries.
There's no parries, there's no parries.
Yeah, yeah.
I have two.
Mag, mag, mag, mag.
I need a reload.
No parries, no parries.
We can die, baby.
I need a reload.
Oh, I'm gonna die.
There's an Iron Fist!
Frozen Iron Fist!
I tried, I tried.
I have Iron Fist on me still.
Everybody ignored Iron Fist.
Alright.
Oh my god.
That's fine, that's fine.
Oh, Iron Fist is behind us.
Iron Fist behind us.
I have Dull, I have Dull.
Iron Fist has their ult though.
No more is behind us, no more is behind us.
I might be dead, I'm dead here.
We have...
No more, no more, no more.
Alright.
Punisher's low, Punisher's low.
They still have Iron Fist ult, they haven't used it yet.
Did they punish ult yet?
Or no?
I froze Penny, I froze Penny.
Iron Fist one, Iron Fist one!
I got him, I got him, I got him.
I have to reload, I have to reload.
She does, but she's not doing anything.
Watch this, watch this, watch this.
They're gonna have...
They have both DPS ult here.
Oh, they're more behind us, they're more behind.
I'm really low.
No more.
No bubble, no shield, no shield, no shield.
He's still behind.
Sorry, I had to heal so many people.
Is this winnable?
I can ult.
I'm gonna ult this, I'm gonna ult this.
I'm ulting for her, I'm ulting for her.
I damage boost you.
Penny to the left, Penny and Iron Fist to the left.
Penny is half, Penny is low, Penny is half.
Namor is behind us again, Namor is behind.
They double, they support ult.
There's a Namor behind, there's a Namor behind.
I'm low, I'm low.
I'm trying to save our Mantis right now.
I got you.
Oh, I don't.
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm gonna say it.
I don't think Scarlet Witch was it.
Iron Fist is zoning the supports out.
Iron Fist, Namor is behind us.
Namor is on our Mantis.
I'm gonna test Namor.
Try.
Wait, Iron Fist is one.
I got you, I got you, I got you booger.
We're up, we're up too.
We're literally up too.
We should push up.
Penny, Penny frozen, Penny frozen half.
One.
Mantis low first, so we have to.
Iron Fist.
Iron Fist one still.
Iron Fist still one.
Namor behind us again.
Namor one.
Alright.
We Mantis ult first.
Oh, that's rough buddy.
That's rough.
Oh, he's fucking bugged out.
Namor to our left, Namor to our left.
Again, on me, he's frozen, he's frozen.
I need help, I need help.
Can you put a TP in front of them?
No.
I'm sorry.
I can stun left door in a second.
I'm watching right door.
I'm pushing right.
Iron Fist behind us.
Iron Fist on cart.
I'm frozen, I'm frozen, I can't do anything about it though.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting on point.
I'm on point.
If you need heals, I'm on cart.
No parries, no parries.
I need to get out of here.
Oh my god.
You're the walled off, booger.
No wall can contain me.
You just died though?
I've been spawned.
I'm alive, I'm well and alive.
Oh, so true, so true.
Yeah, I'm taking an off angle.
He's on me, he's on me by the way.
I can't help you there.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
I'm reloading.
I'm on grid, grid, grid's up.
Grid one, grid one.
Grid one.
I might be dead to this.
I have ult, I'm gonna use it.
We can mantis ult after.
Luna, Luna on me.
Luna on cart, Luna on cart.
Huge no crew ult.
Oh my god.
I got Luna ult so fast there.
Nice, they burned all.
Guys, also travel over and push.
I'm like at a baseball game.
I just watched you hit a fucking...
Is that supposed to be a compliment?
I'm proud of that.
Was he ulting?
Did he ulted in the middle of my freeze?
I couldn't tell, it was reflex.
I'm kidding.
It was literally reflex for that freeze.
Proud nonetheless.
Oh shit, I didn't realize.
That was so intentional guys.
JK, of course I knew.
I'm fucking gamer.
Of fucking course I knew guys.
You keep saying we can't lose, yet we lose.
Yeah, didn't you say...
Yeah, you said we were gonna dip that R man.
What happened?
What happened bro?
We were getting that video ready.
My editor was ready to edit that video.
This was a flipping design, a lie.
90% of Ironman players int just before they make it into a YouTube video.
It is.
It's not okay.
Don't be sending your assassins.
Be ready for the ult.
I'm looking.
I'm on them.
I froze the group.
There's an Amour behind us again.
He's still in there.
I see him, yeah.
Oh, I'm getting healed by the turrets.
Okay, I'm looking.
I'm healing your tanks then.
I'm stunned.
I'm stunned and quiet.
I'm blinked.
This Amour plays so fucking weird.
I have to reload, I have to reload.
You're good, you're good.
Let's kill the one.
This is real firepower.
Kill him in, kill him in.
I'm gonna hit a big one, I'm gonna hit a big one.
I believe.
There's an Amour turret.
Nice peek, nice peek.
I'm back, I'm back.
Yeah, I'm not using ult yet.
Amour turret, right?
He's by himself, he's out of position.
They have Moon Knight group combo, careful.
Moon Knight dead.
I'm pushing, I'm pushing.
Alright, that's okay, I guess.
That's a bad problem, that's a bad problem.
We don't have any combo anymore.
They still have Moon Knight ult here.
Okay, so when they Moon Knight ult, guys, we move away from them.
W palms.
I'm safe.
Making sure you guys know.
Oh, I hit the...
There's an Amour turret, right?
I got it.
Yeah, yeah, you're also the only one left.
Yeah, you're right, nobody died.
I don't think so, I don't think so.
That's five.
We're so healthy.
They still have the Amour ult.
They have the Amour and Raccoon ult.
Oh, we're down a healer, it's just me.
I'm like really low, I need a health pack.
You're walled off, you're walled off.
I'm gonna look, okay?
You're still walled off, okay, gotcha, gotcha.
Nice, that's two, that's two.
I'm on the Amour, Amour half, Amour half.
Punisher behind you guys, Punisher behind.
Alright, you can farm...
Spoiled here, I already have mine.
I'm gonna just heal the squishies.
They're gonna have Moon Groot ult again.
Nice,
I'll let you farm the ults here.
Nah, nah, nah, that guy's not killable, no, no, no.
Yeah, kite back, kite back, kite back, we're a bit too open right now.
He's gonna beam us.
And we need to combo...
Oh my god.
I have to do this.
We have Men's ult again.
I'll do my Men's, it's hard to pull off to be honest.
Yeah, I know, I know.
Oh my god, not the fuck, no.
Stupid ult.
Oh, oh, oh, you are alive!
Holy shit.
Okay, we have to use both support ults there to stabilize.
They use like all their DPS ults though.
Other than Punisher, they still have Punisher ult.
Yeah, bro, me, yeah.
I'm kiting out, I'm kiting out.
They still have Punisher ult, they still have Punisher ult.
I believe,
I believe Doki bro fans.
I have Wolverine on me upstairs.
There's three people, I froze Groot to my right.
Groot's on me, Groot's on me.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
Okay, okay, we're good, we're good.
If we kill them now, this could be last fight.
I have to reload, I have to reload.
There's a turret, there's a turret.
Don't die, don't die, don't die, don't die.
Yeah, we had two support ults here for last fight.
Nice, he's dead.
I'm being caught.
We're getting them all, we're getting them all.
No more, no more, no more.
Oh my god.
I'm okay.
Yo, yo, yo.
I love you.
I love you too.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
GG.
I'm sorry about that.
Oh my god.
The Wolverine saved me.
Holy shit.
The Wolverine saved me from the fucking No More Hells insane.
I was like, thank you.
Doki, we're number one.
You saved me from the well.
What a, what a guy.
What a guy.
I always believed in him.
Bro, I was absolutely a bigger fan of you.
The ult saved Doki.
Oh, thank you Wolverine.
Thank you for kidnapping me.
Shout out to that guy.
Where the fuck is Jimbo?
Jimbo Limbo.
Well, I'll never know.
Down this president.
The Wolverine was like, no.
Save her.
Groot.
Guys, what do you think Groot God plays?
I think the Groot God 69.
Damn, same.
For real, for real.
Sadly, Boger is the only player that I think can play Strange better than me, so I won't ego the pick.
The goat.
I need a Strange God 69.
Okay.
Okay, Groot God was taken.
I had to throw something in there.
It was going to be 69 420, but I thought that was a little bit too much.
But they banned Hulk for us.
He's weak.
Nice people.
Weak.
The 69 guys are with us today.
What if they think we're...
Nah, well, guys, the etiquette is that if they're supposed to ban Hawkeye, we're supposed to ban something else.
Like, so...
No.
I refuse to ban anything else.
Ah, nope, they're assholes.
Their assholes, their assholes, their assholes.
Or the 69 squads.
I would add 69 after Doki Bird, but I'm worried somebody's going to take Doki Bird right after.
I'm worried people are going to squat Doki Bird.
Right?
Bro, did I tell you guys?
The moment...
The day...
I did, I did.
The day I came back to streaming, literally the day it was announced I was back, someone instantly took Doki Bird.com and is squatting it.
And is actually holding it hostage.
Like...
That's why I claim Doki Bird and as many things as I can.
No, it's true.
They literally...
I looked it up.
They made the website the day I came back.
They didn't make it before.
They made it the day I came back.
It could work.
Listen, Doki, you're going to be fighting there.
Like, it's going to...
What?
Nah, nah, nah.
Wait, what?
It's going to be...
You're going to be on the front lines over there.
No, I didn't fucking try and buy it.
They're going to ask for a million dollars or something.
Let them waste money on that domain.
I don't fucking care.
Let them waste their money just holding it hostage.
Wait, what do you think he's going to do?
Dinky dinky.
Captain America.
Behind us, behind us.
Captain...
I think I have Iron Fist too.
I'm a little scared.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I have Captain America on me.
I have Iron Fist on me now.
What do we do?
There's a cap on us.
He's blocked my freeze.
I need help.
There's a Magneto on us.
And a Captain America too.
Bro,
I'm scared.
I don't think you're fine.
He blocked my freeze.
Iron Fist on me, Iron Fist on me, Iron Fist.
Oh my god.
Guys, this is the worst game for a support player.
This is fucking terrible.
I killed both of you.
Oh shit.
I don't know what's going on.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
Stay on me.
Thank you, good ult, good ult.
Very good ult, very good ult.
Support's in the air, back.
Cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap.
No, no, we have...
Bro's cap, bro's cap.
Mag, mag, mag, mag, mag, mag, mag.
Huffer, wolf, huffer, wolf, huffer, wolf.
Mag, mag, mag.
What the fuck happened?
I can't even tell what happened.
What,
what happened?
This guy's trying to win.
Found trouble.
Kept up, right?
I'm aiming cap, I'm aiming cap.
Ironfist?
The Ironfist is looking to push supports.
Cap dead, cap dead, cap dead.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
He ult, he ult.
Berserker.
Oh my god.
Ironfist's behind.
Yeah, yeah, he's looking to flank us.
He's right here.
He's like...
He's still up there.
I'm a little scared of the Ironfist.
Ironfist behind me, Ironfist.
Ironfist, nice.
Oh my god.
Do you want Cloak or Luna ult first?
Okay, okay, Luna ult, Luna ult.
I'll Luna the Wolverine ult.
Oh, that scared me.
He's on me.
I've frozen, I've frozen, I've frozen.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
Yeah, that's good.
We just need to kill the Luna after.
Kill Luna after this, kill Luna.
Oh, the Ironfist is here too.
I'm dead to this.
I'm dead, I'm dead to it.
I'm alive.
Trench, Trench, Trench.
Trench one.
I have to reload, I have to reload.
Thank you.
Nice, nice.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
MagnetoGod69, seriously.
Oh my god.
The Ironfist.
I just healed.
I just, I just healed.
Oh my god, that was so scary.
Is that your American accent?
Hell yeah.
I think it's like, and women.
I said like, what you don't...
I was just gonna say, Europeans don't love women?
Why is women so specific?
Not the in and out.
The southern friend.
I would love to have a DC rivals.
Cause it would be like, Batman doesn't kill.
USA, healing my warrior.
I thought I was gonna fuck it up.
Oh, they're to the left, they're to the left.
There's four under, there's four under.
There's four under here.
Yeah, the cap's there.
There's an Ironfist right behind you guys.
There's an Ironfist coming to us.
Coming to support.
I have a captain on me.
That was good.
Far most guys, far most.
I froze cloak.
Oh wait, is this winnable?
I can...
Yes, yes.
Okay, okay, I'm ulting this in.
Let's go kill the Captain America.
God, I saw you miss that.
Wait, did you see what I just hit?
I might be fucking dead.
Oh, I'm definitely dead.
Luna's one, Luna's one.
Nah, I got it.
You owe me a cloak heals.
Okay, okay, okay.
I was like, woah.
Goodbye.
Captain America's coming back now.
Unchested, no you.
Oh, goodbye to map change, map change, booger.
Guys, guys.
Map change.
Don't worry about it.
I'm gonna give you a little tip, but map change is exactly 50%.
Oh, really?
It's 50% changes, yes, but even if it's combined.
Yeah, Ducky is a noob.
Yeah, I am.
Fair enough, fair enough.
Wait, are you boosting right now?
He's hot as meat, what do you mean?
Because I don't pay attention.
There you go.
I have a cloak on the backline.
I have an Iron Fist on the backline.
I'm on it.
No,
if I had Rosa on it, then I'm getting boosted.
Hi.
For women everywhere.
Oh my god.
Guys, why is he here?
Why is he here?
I need to get topped off.
Guys, hey, there's an Iron Fist right here again.
I'm just going to ult this in.
Nice, nice, nice.
We wasted low kill.
Nice.
Oh, there he comes.
Most useful Iron Fist ult.
To be fair, he did the burst.
That's crazy.
Bro, he kidnapped him.
That shit was crazy.
The Iron Fist will burn with it.
Where the fuck was the Iron Fist?
I was like, why is he here?
Get down this person.
Look at that.
That's the Doki Birdfan69 right there, guys.
That's him right there.
Do you lose?
You lose less.
ESVP, you lose less.
That's how it usually goes.
That's crazy though.
The fucking...
The kidnap we saw there.
I'm going to use the bathroom, guys.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Guys, do you think we can get 200?
Or do we settle?
Do we settle?
Are we senators?
Oh my gosh, my cable is like catching on the...
Are we settlers?
Or...
Guys, we're at the 7 hour mark.
Oh my god.
Guys, don't say that.
What if we just win 3 games in a row, guys?
What if...
What if we do that?
Could be...
Guys...
We could just win 5 games in a row.
Just...
Could be possible.
I think he actually...
I think he actually took away Europe.
I think he...
I think they took away EU.
Wait, he's been trying to get Eternity.
Wait, what the fuck is this...
What the fuck?
Did you guys see the...
The matchup?
We're against Timmy.
I mean, he's been trying to get Eternity, right?
Or like, one above all.
I think he's GM1 right now, right?
Yeah, but I'm always playing against them.
I want them to be on my team.
I don't ask for much.
Just to be on my team.
I ask for so little.
Also, Gerard, thank you for the tier 1 sub.
Game, thank you for the tier 1.
Marshy, thank you for the prime.
And I also ask for a sponsor.
I ask for so little.
I ask for money.
From the game devs.
I ask for...
So little.
Can't even have one, the bare minimum.
Exactly.
I just want the bare minimum.
It's not even that much.
It took out our boy, DokiRudeFan69.
I just have to play 7 more hours of Marble Rivals.
Let's go!
Alright, sounds good.
Whee!
I wish I had the stamina to stream this long on YouTube.
If I'm playing Marble Rivals, I do.
Not gonna lie, if I'm playing Marble Rivals, I do.
But like, you know what I mean?
Oh shit, nice.
Like, if I'm just playing competitive all the time...
I can just...
I'm pushing cart right now.
I'm pushing cart, I'm pushing cart.
Okay, okay, yeah, I'll push up then.
I don't know, I don't know what it is about competitive...
that makes me like, stream...
that I can stream ranked.
Like, it doesn't even matter.
It can be any ranked game.
I can nearly...
There's a Gritch at right.
Yeah, I got crossed.
I don't know, it's just something about competitive...
that makes me like, want to stream for so long.
Like, it feels like hours pass by, like, so fast.
Alright, I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
You guys ready?
3, 2, 1.
There's a... more on high ground.
Oh wait, it's just turret.
They broke Mantis ult for it.
We Mantis ult first then.
They have Grille too.
Oh my god, okay, I'm locking in guys, I'm locking in.
I can... I'll... Luna ult the Grille.
There's more to our left.
They have Strange ult too, careful.
We have blue.
They have no Spardos, they have no Spardos.
Nice.
I'm ulting this, I'm ulting this.
They're on my point.
Kill Strange and Groot, they have ult.
I'm damage boosting.
Psylocke, Psylocke.
Psylocke behind.
They still have Strange, they might have TP.
3, 3, 3, 3, 3, 3 before they get here.
3 on cart.
Nice, we got it.
Yeah, they TP'd, they TP'd, they TP'd.
Groot is behind us.
Groot is behind.
Guys, I can kill the Groot behind us, get him.
You're walled off, but he's one, he's solo, he's half, he's half, he's half.
It's a bug stone.
Amour is top right.
Amour is right here.
Kill her, kill her, kill her, kill the Psylocke.
Psylocke one.
Oh my god, I'm locked in.
I'm getting E-speed, I'm getting E-speed, run away.
Got you, got you.
I don't have support ult for their tank ults.
I'm halfway too.
Psylocke going to the right, I think.
They're gonna have Groot here.
I, I, I throw a spring.
That's it, that's it, that's it.
Nice, nice, we got it, we got it, we got it.
They're all low, they're all low, they're all low.
I got you, I got you.
I'm on cart.
They have a Loki now.
Wait, Timmy's on Luna?
Who put Timmy on Luna?
Luna!
Why is there a Strange?
I'll, I'll, I'll Luna off the Strange ult.
I can't see you, I'm sorry.
You got walled off, you got walled off.
I didn't get you.
Oh, you're walled off, you're walled off, you're walled off.
Oh, we can Manta's ult first then.
Oh my god.
Manta's ult first if needed.
Alright, let's go.
Alright, I popped the, I popped the hibernate.
I'm backing off.
Oh, oh, what?
Oh, I was waiting for Manta's ult, sorry.
No!
I was like, Manta's ult?
Manta's ult?
Okay, I'm ulting in, I'm ulting in.
There's a lot.
I got a lot.
I'm frozen, I'm frozen, I'm frozen, I'm frozen.
I'm alive.
You're alive, you're alive, you're alive.
Shit, shit, shit.
You're walled off.
I can't see you.
They have no support ults.
I have mine in 20.
Holy shit, I'm fucking trying so hard.
Oh,
I killed through my ult.
I hit them all.
That's huge, that's huge.
You have no supports, you have no supports.
No supports, no supports.
No.
If they do, like, Groot well again, I can support ult that.
I don't think they'll have time for a Groot ult again, but...
You're walled a bit.
Reload.
They have low heal here.
I'm just trying my best to keep you alive.
You're walled off, you're walled off.
I forced them.
I got walled off here.
I got walled.
Oh, I got Groot walled.
That was so unlucky.
I don't know if you can play Moon Knight, but I can play something else.
That's so unlucky.
Well, I don't play Moon Knight.
What do you play?
Let's have a discussion here.
I mean, I play Sylak, I play Hela, I play Punisher, Star Lord.
Punisher.
I think Punisher works here great.
Punisher is going to pop off here.
Alright, let's do it, let's do it.
That's just unlucky.
They coordinated their ults a lot better.
And, like, I think...
We need the Mantis ult.
Our Mantis ulted late sometimes, which was a little tilting.
I was like, hello, Mantis ult first.
And then Star Lord was like, legendary.
And then he said the whole legendary.
And then I...
And I didn't get the...
He was like, Mantis ult where?
He said legendary, I died, and then I got the Mantis ult.
And I was like, okay.
Fuck me, I guess.
So it was like, I don't know what to do.
And he was like, Mantis ult first, Mantis ult first.
I said it like 20 times.
Mantis ult first.
I had to pre-heal that because I knew he was going to take so much fucking damage.
He walled off.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, same combo.
I'm going to go follow them.
Oh my god.
Your tanks are walled off.
Namor's behind us.
Namor's still behind us.
Bro, what do you mean, oh fuck!
I'm dead here, yeah?
Mantis, what do you mean, oh fuck!
We caught the point three times!
Mantis, what's going on?
I'm with you, I'm with you.
Change, change, change, change.
I have a Groot on me.
We walled off, walled off.
Sorry, I got walled off.
Help me, help me, heal me, heal me.
I'm healing, healing, healing.
I'm down, I'm down, I'm down.
I got Namor ulted.
That was unlucky.
I had to touch point two there.
I'm putting on bogey, I trust him more.
And we got our up one.
No, their Groot is good.
Their Groot is so good.
Namor's behind, Namor's behind us again.
I hit Frozen, I froze him.
Please, oh.
Wait, Mantis, heal me!
Mantis!
I'm actually mad at our Mantis.
Our Mantis' game awareness is so bad.
I've never, I've never talked shit about...
Oh my god, don't hurt their game awareness.
Their Mantis' game awareness is actually tilting me so hard.
Like, why would you not heal me?
They have Groot all here.
Yeah, I'm backing up, I'm backing up.
I can bubble you.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
They're all off here though.
Look at, look at them.
I'm with the Punisher, one heals.
Three, two, one, backing up now.
Groot one, Groot one.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
I have to reload.
I'll get, I'll get.
I got Groot.
I'm coming back.
I have to reload, I have to reload.
Jesus Christ, I'm just healing.
I know, oh my god.
I'm dead here to... I'm dead.
We have Mantis ult here.
We can push from my ult, if anything.
Alright.
Okay, can you do an angle again?
I'm gonna do my turns.
They're, they're pushing up.
Behind me.
I'm on the level.
Oh.
I'm jumping in now.
I'm walled off, I'm walled off.
I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay now.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting, I'm ulting point.
I'm ulting on point.
They need heals.
I'm damage boosting, I'm damage boosting, I'm damage boosting this.
No more, no more, no more.
Oh.
We used both support ults for that fight.
They still have strange ult, right?
They have a strange groove.
No, no, they have a strange groove.
Oh, you said, okay, okay.
They have no more Psylocke.
We need a defensive ult too.
Hey, there's Loki's ult too.
Dude, the Psylocke might just solo ult me.
Psylocke ulted not too long ago, I think.
Yeah, last time they ulted was two fights ago, where he solo ulted me though.
Watch out for walls.
Alright, I'm gonna ult soon, I'm gonna ult soon.
Get ready, get ready.
I'm gonna ult in three, two, one, ulting, I think.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go.
I'm in, I'm in, I'm in.
You're walled off here.
You're walled off.
I have Psylocke too on me.
Can't kill, bro.
Groove and Strange were just one-tabbing.
They just kept on getting healed.
Yeah, that's true.
We gotta run before no Stagger is here.
Oh my god.
It's not reliable, it's just the Luna tech is not reliable at all.
It does less healing than you think it does, and it can bug out to where...
Psylocke has ult, by the way.
I'm dead here.
Why?!
Why don't you ult?!
What?!
Our Mantis?!
Our Mantis was there to gank.
What?!
They TP'd.
We can't get out.
Oh wait, what?
I'm here.
There's a Psylocke behind.
If you guys live, I can...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Our Mantis threw so many times!
Oh my god.
Our Mantis...
Oh my god, our Mantis was so bad!
I didn't Q yet.
Oh my god, I was...
I don't understand!
I got solo ulted and then she let me die!
Twice!
She did it twice!
I can't...
Oh my god.
Wow, she has a 20% accuracy!
Alright, I'm looking this guy up.
I can't, I'm gonna look at your profile.
I can't.
Holy shit, that was...
Oh my god.
That actually tilted me so hard.
How do you have a 20% accuracy on fucking Mantis?
Oh my...
That's like you're intentionally not hitting anything.
I can't.
There's no way.
You're...
Wait, what?
You have a...
What?
Is your win rate so high?
I don't understand!
What the fuck was that Mantis game?
What was that Mantis game?
How is your win rate so high on Mantis?
I don't understand.
Oh my god.
How did he get it?
How did he get so high on that?
Probably bad game.
Bro, that was such a bad game from him.
He literally watched me get...
He...
Oh my god.
He could have saved me from the side.
I don't understand why he didn't save me.
The fact that he did that twice.
Oh my god.
It made me so sad.
I actually...
I've never been tilted at another support before.
It's because I had to see it happen too.
I'm trying to avoid double support.
But the fact that to see that happen.
Oh my god.
Like, in front of me.
And then the fact that she didn't heal me.
When the Nemor was behind.
Like, when I froze the Nemor.
She just...
She let me die.
I was like, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
I did communicate.
I was like, Mantis ult first.
Mantis ult first.
And then she like, waited.
She...
She waited.
I communicated several times.
And then someone was like, Oh, Timmy has more kills on Luna.
He has the opportunity to shoot at the team.
Did you know that?
People were like, Why don't you DPS more on Luna?
I wish I could.
If I had the time.
If I didn't have to save my fucking team from dying.
Oh my god.
I was literally...
Like, my team was always like, 1 HP.
Even with like, Snowflake on our other tank.
I was basically...
I was like, with my heals.
For that game.
It's...
Oh my god.
Like...
I had to pick up the heals.
That's crazy.
20% on Mantis is actually...
That's like...
I've never seen 20% on Mantis before.
That's actually like...
An accomplishment.
I've never seen somebody heal...
Have a 20% accuracy on her.
That's actually my first time.
Like, everybody would have like...
Like, it would be like...
30% average.
I've seen like, the average accuracy is like, 30 to 40%.
40% of your...
Of your...
Oh, here we go.
See, at least I have 25.
We lost that though.
I think that was an EU game too.
Wait, what's that?
Oh my god.
Is this EU?
This was...
Yeah, this was EU.
This was EU.
Holy shit!
Wait!
Wait a minute!
Oh, now I know why I lost this.
Wait a minute.
This was also EU too.
Yeah, we removed EU.
We removed EU.
They were...
They've had enough of EU games.
17% is actually wild.
That's fucking wild.
I'm checking the receipts now.
I've never been like...
Holy shit.
That's actually crazy.
We were in E.
I never played EUQs before.
That was my first time playing EUQs.
I need to like...
How far off fucking is...
We're at 113, I think.
Right?
Are we at 113?
Is that where we're at?
Yeah, we deleted Europe for now.
I think I'm like stuck at like 100 points.
At the moment.
It's been like on and off.
But like...
It's not like our stack issue.
We both like play...
Like everybody in the stack is playing well.
It's literally like one or two players that's like not doing their best.
Oh yeah!
I remember I asked about the jumping thing.
Is jumping good in Marvel Rivals or should you avoid jumping?
When you're...
Because in Apex, jumping is like more predictable.
And like...
So is like...
I don't know.
I don't remember in Overwatch.
I played Lucio in Overwatch.
So like I jumped a lot.
Same with like...
I know like as Ana, I try to avoid jumping.
I don't know.
Because I see so many players jumping.
But I feel like that's such a bad habit.
Yeah, jumping is like so bad.
So I don't understand.
I only jump if I have to like shoot somebody that requires you to jump.
That's the only reason to jump.
I don't know any other reason why you would jump at all.
I see so many...
I see like people try to jump a lot like that.
But like it's so bad.
It makes you so predictable.
You should just like...
I understand like crouch spamming, but you can't crouch spam at all.
Jumping always causes...
Yeah, like jumping makes you so predictable.
That's why I try to avoid jumping.
It's like a little...
I need to practice like aiming projectile on Mantis.
Mantis is so hard.
I do 1v1s here.
I know you can.
I do 1v1s.
I wanna 1v1.
No!
I was doing a crouch.
That's fucked up.
Oh, he's not gonna make it.
He's not gonna make it.
I fucking knew it.
Okay, that's fucked up.
That's so...
I can't even do anything!
Wait, what?
I was like, what?
It's like, how is that possible?
Wait, how do I practice settings?
There we go.
Friendly fire enabled.
Oh, you pussy.
Oh, you're such a pussy!
Fuck this.
Man, it's all the time.
It's all the time.
No, shit, no, no.
That's illegal.
You're in spawn.
Oh my god.
That's so...
Bro, you're taking advantage of spawn.
You're a bitch.
You're an actual little bitch.
You're a little bitch.
No.
No cooldowns.
No ability cooldowns.
We're...
Alright, we're...
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
Oh, that's so...
That's actually bullshit.
He actually bull...
That was bullshit there.
That was actually bullshit.
That was such a sick...
Oh my god.
Come on.
Don't be a little bitch.
Oh shit, I keep forgetting.
He fucking just shows up.
I keep forgetting.
What the fuck?
He just...
He's abusing...
He has zero cooldowns.
He turned off cooldowns.
That's cheating.
There's no way you can do that without cooldowns.
That's no way.
He's actually abusing the no cooldown shit.
Can't believe it.
He fucking zero...
He's zero cooldowning me!
You're so...
You're so bad.
That's looking right.
Oh my god.
You're such a little bitch.
That's looking right.
Don't mess...
Where is he?
You think I don't know about the zero cooldown shit you did?
Oh, you're hiding in spawn?
Pussy.
Oh!
Oh, fuck.
Jack at me and...
Oh, oh, oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh my god.
Hide behind.
Hide behind him.
In the spot.
Oh, you're such a little bitch.
So yeah, oh I'm gonna go in there too!
Get me in there!
It's okay!
I'm back up the old!
Get back up the old!
No!
That's okay.
There we go.
I got the old again!
I got my old again!
I'm fine!
I'm so healthy!
The world came back to my old!
It's okay!
I'm still so healthy!
There we go!
I got it!
Get me out of here!
No!
I get it all the time!
Don't make me do this!
That's a great!
Now you can't!
Now you can't leave!
You can't leave!
It's just like Ana all over again!
That's a great!
It's a cool guy now!
That's right!
No more ults!
No more ults smash!
No more!
That's right!
You know what would be petty?
Boom!
That's a great!
Oh shit!
No!
I fucked up!
I got too cocky!
I got way too cocky there!
Okay, it's one or the other.
I'm first!
I'm first, bitch!
That's a great!
That's a jack shit now!
I'm first!
Easy!
So fucking easy!
Oh, you don't like that!
Don't do you!
You don't like that!
Oh shit!
What are you gonna do?
You're just gonna dance!
Octavia, thank you for the red!
Thank you!
Are you enjoying Marvel Rivals 2?
He's just dancing non-stop!
Hello everybody!
My name is Doki Bird.
I am trying to grind top 5.
I usually stream on YouTube, but like, we're here.
You know what?
What if I wanna dance too?
I'm ready to put on a show!
Let's go!
Woo!
We're ready to put on a show!
Is this Marvel Rivals?
We're ready to put on a show, everybody!
The girls are grilling right now!
Let's go!
Yippee!
Slay!
This is Marvel Rivals.
We're all ready to put on a show.
Woah!
I'm ready to put on a show!
Please give us a fucking game!
I don't understand!
Where is our game?
Where is our fucking game?
Because I've been in queue for 15 minutes.
I am ready to put on a show!
Where is our game?
I'm not even at 200!
I need EU.
Are we in EU queues yet?
Queues?
This is what you deserve.
That's right.
No gameplay for you now.
You don't get to play.
You don't fucking get to play.
You don't get to play video games after that!
That's right.
That's fucking right.
Nothing can save you.
Oh shit.
Oh he's gone.
He's gone forever.
Oh shit we got a game!
That was so fast!
That was so fast.
Are we in EU or NA?
I think this is EU right?
Oh yeah it's EU with my one ping guys.
It's EU with my one ping everybody.
Are we banning Hawkeye?
Alright.
Yeah and then they're gonna ban Hulk.
I believe it.
It's gonna get banned yeah.
100%.
Yeah I loved it so much.
Let's get it.
Oh let's get it.
What is this team comp?
I don't get this vibe.
Because it's funnier.
Stop.
I just wanna...
800k on YouTube.
Mamma mia.
Wait Dokibroid are you famous or something?
No no I'm just a fan of her.
I took the name before she could take it.
Wait if somebody stole my name before they stole your name does that mean my fans are more dedicated?
No no I'm her fan that's why I took the name.
You took my name?
Yeah you can have it back for $30.
$30?
I have Iron Fist on me, Iron Fist on me.
Yeah we lost.
You lost both supports, you lost both supports there.
I'm a really good impersonator.
We need to play for Iron man.
Yeah.
Wanna loot?
What is... like I don't... these bans are crazy though not gonna lie.
Hulk is low, Hulk is one.
I woke you up.
Play for Tiger, play for Tiger.
I can go in screen, I can go in screen.
Watch out.
Hulk is...
I got him, I got him, I got him.
I froze him, I froze him, I froze him.
He's low, he's so low.
That's fine, that's fine.
I have a... I have an Iron Fist on me.
I grabbed him, I grabbed him, I grabbed him.
Oh double supported.
I'm on damage, I'm on damage, I'm on damage.
I bubble you.
Iron man right side, Iron man right side.
I pushed.
There is banner, there is banner.
I'm asleep, I'm asleep, I'm asleep.
Oh my god.
This is a little difficult.
I didn't realize the Mantis gonna ult there.
Cause I had Iron Fist on me.
Oh I'm gonna try, I'm gonna try so hard now.
I got me, I got me, I got me.
There's a Hulk on me.
I need heals here.
I need heals.
Oh my god.
I'm not ulting this.
I'm dying.
Holy shit.
I've never played the bar.
Oh no, yeah this is rough.
It's rough because like, uh...
We need, we need like, heal.
I'm trying, uh, I wanna orb the Iron man, but like, it doesn't matter.
He gets, he gets deleted so fast.
Yeah, alright.
Uh, we can do Mantis ult first so I don't overlap with yours.
Yeah, that's why you press Q first.
She pressed Q too.
I'm gonna try to grab the Iron man.
Alright.
We just need like, we just need heal.
That's really it.
We're TPing?
You guys are TPing by the way.
I'm just gonna stay here for now.
What the?
I have Iron Fist on me.
Oh, I just have...
I saw her, yeah.
That's unlucky.
I need some peel.
Peel.
There's an Iron Fist on our Lute Mantis.
Iron Fist again.
Iron Fist one.
Are we right side?
Can we go right side?
No sleep, no sleep.
Mantis is here, Mantis is here.
Fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear.
Mantis, Mantis, Mantis.
I have Hulk on me, I have Hulk on me.
I'm ulting this now.
Nice, nice.
I'm on damage, I'm on damage.
Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk low.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Just kill him, just kill him.
I'm coming.
I don't have Heal Spore, I don't have Heal Spore.
I have Hulk on me.
Heal Hulk, Hulk, Heal Hulk.
Hulk one, Hulk one.
You got that, you got that.
Yeah, we got it, we got it.
Help over, help him.
I got him.
I'm on his head.
I'm trying to help you, Mantis.
Got him.
Nice, nice.
Thank you, thank you.
Mantis, I have Iron Fist looking for you guys now.
Watch out.
I'm trying to sleep him after he shoots.
Maybe you can kill him.
I need a little bit of Heal, Mantis.
Thank you.
He's up, he's up.
Left side, left side.
I see him, yeah.
He's gonna most likely push me.
I can't heal you.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
I grabbed him.
Nice.
Man, you don't have?
I'm face, I'm face, I'm face.
Can you kill Mantis off the hook maybe?
I broke... oh no, they woke me.
I'm on you, I'm on you.
I'm trying to help you, Mantis.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
Mantis, Iron Fist on me, Iron Fist on me.
Iron Fist still on me.
I'm on you, I'm on you, I'm on you.
I'm only healing you.
Thank you.
I got you.
Oh, I'm asleep now.
You can sleep with Heals.
You're fine, you're fine.
Look at Iron Man, look at Iron Man.
I have ult in 10, I have ult in 10.
I hear an Iron Fist behind.
Iron Fist 1, Iron Fist 1.
I have to reload.
Oh, that's unlucky.
I have to reload, I have to reload.
I froze Hulk, nice.
I have ult for you.
3,
2, 1.
I froze Iron Fist, I froze Iron Fist.
Iron Fist is low, Iron Fist is 1.
I'm dead, I'm dead though.
Look at Hulk, Hulk 1.
I'm dead though.
I'm going back now.
Oh my god.
They used, I don't know if they used Luna.
I don't remember.
They did, they did.
They did, okay.
I was in the back line.
I waited for her to leave, grabbed her, killed her.
Hold me baby.
Damn, all you.
I won't say, 0 deaths.
I feel like I was matting this match, they're just going on back line all game.
Yeah, listen, Wolver, you're my goat, you're fighting demons there.
You're fighting demons.
I'm getting a fucking headache, I need to flick like back and forth all day.
Listen guys, listen, keep flicking, keep getting a headache, just let me pop off, let me eat you.
Yeah, you cook, you cook I guess.
I cook, I cook.
Oh my god, my mantis peeled for me.
She held my hand, I'm so happy.
I'm so happy.
I'm so happy, what the fuck, I love it.
It's baseball time.
Okay, now, now, now, now.
That's crazy.
Oh my god, that...
Oh my god, she like died through her ult, that's crazy.
I don't know how she died through her ult.
Okay, you can do it.
Iron Fist behind us.
I frozen my Frozen Veil.
Oh my god, I got, I got, there's a Hulk behind us.
Where did he come from, what?
I didn't even see that.
You're down, Luna.
I'm coming back, I'm coming back, I'm coming back.
Nice, nice, cap point, cap point.
It's fine, it's fine, they have no supports.
Don't die, don't die, don't die.
I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming.
Iron can die.
I don't see Iron Man for heals.
I got you, I got you now.
Oh my god.
I'm just gonna mirror their Luna.
He's looking on the right wall.
I have Frozen, I have Frozen, I have Frozen.
I have Hulk right behind me.
I'll ult after this, I'm gonna ult after this.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting, I'm ulting on point, I'm ulting on point.
I'm going to their Strange, I'm going to their Strange.
Iron Fist, Iron Fist, Iron Fist.
Okay, I'm backing up, I'm backing up.
Hulk behind you, Hulk behind you.
They also have Iron Fist, Iron Fist to the right, Iron Fist to the right.
I'm reloading.
I slept, I slept, I froze.
I couldn't do anything for you.
I'm on point, I'm on point.
Oh my god.
I tried my best to heal him.
He just beats me up in the back.
All he does is beat me up in the back.
That's all he does.
I'm like in the air.
Hike maybe?
Hulk low.
Hulk out, he's low, he's low.
Iron Fist, Iron Fist.
Dead, dead, dead.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
I got, I got froze off.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Iron Man's half.
I'm so low, I'm really low.
Magneto's alcohol is not coming to me.
Luna's low, Luna's low.
Support's coming in.
I'm coming back now, I'm coming back.
I can get all here.
They might TP, they might TP.
They're TPing, they're TPing, they're TPing.
Keep me up, keep me up.
I'm 98, 98, 98.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
I'm on point, I'm on point, I'm on point.
5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
I have Iron Fist on me.
Oh, there's Iron Man.
No.
Oh my god.
Me, Iron Fist is just, I had nobody.
Clearly, Iron Fist and Hulk were just on me 24-7.
No, it wasn't too early.
I had to ult there.
They were, all of them were like running at me.
I had to ult because I had Iron Fist and Hulk literally running at me.
And if I didn't ult there, I would have died.
Because Iron Fist and Hulk were both, were both...
Yeah.
The team needed to kill Iron Fist.
Our Iron Man got grabbed by Hulk on the high ground.
So like, I couldn't heal that.
Yeah, we, the Mantis and I had to peel for each other the entire time.
But like, we can't peel for each other if Iron Fist and Hulk were on each other.
If our Iron Man didn't get grabbed there, we would have been fine.
I think our Iron Man was the weakest link there.
Our Iron Man was the...
Because like, he kept getting, he was like, he got out Iron Man.
I even, I had Orb on him on everything too.
He had caught, like, he had 24-7 Snowflake.
And, but like, the enemy, the other Iron Man, uh, Craggy just like out-beamed him.
Yeah.
There's nothing we could do there.
I even tried to have, like, my deaths weren't even that bad too.
I think the only issue was that it was hard for, it was hard for us to heal because we were, we didn't have a lot of peel.
We didn't have, like, uh, a lot of peel at all.
I tried my best to heal Iron Man as much as I can, but it was just too, it was too much.
If someone did less Overwatch, I don't know.
I feel like, I like this game because I like Overwatch.
I don't know.
Oh, wait.
Okay, we got a game.
I legitimately don't know if you like this game and you don't like Overwatch because this is, like, Overwatch coded.
It's Overwatch coded, so I don't know.
I love this game, but only because I love Overwatch.
Hello.
Hello, guys.
Hello, two gamers.
Hello, hello.
Yeah, we ban Druid against that guy.
Get this guy out of here.
Yeah, get him out of my fucking video game.
Get him out!
I think the Marvel Rivals skins are better than the Overwatch skins.
Only because it's, like, the reason why is just because, like, Marvel Rivals has, like, I get that.
It's, like, they have the reference.
You know, they're, like, I understand that reference.
I like the skin more.
That's really it.
They're just, like, I know that skin.
Come.
Thank you for the biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm not top 500.
I need four wins.
Four to five wins.
Two, four, six, eight.
Yeah, I need, like, four wins.
They have a Hulk player, though.
Life energy is a powerful weapon against evil.
Am I not tired?
Pure fucking adrenaline.
Not gonna lie, it's legitimately... legitimately just pure fucking adrenaline.
And my need to be top 500.
Guys, I don't want to take five days to get... Guys, if I get there early, I can stream other things.
I can go back to my YouTube channel.
I'm on one.
I just drink... Every time I fucking play my rival, stream my rivals, I just drink one cup.
One cup of Gamersubs.
Oh my god.
We've been, like, at least we're... Games have been fun, though.
I enjoyed the games we had.
Except for that fucking Mantis game.
No, fuck that Mantis player.
Honestly.
I liked every game except for that goddamn Mantis player that we had.
We need a Grinding to keep it.
No, Decay... I think Decay is, like, once... I think Decay happens within a week.
Because I didn't play for three days, and I still had... I didn't drop any.
I didn't drop any.
So I legitimately think it's just... I think it's, like, a week or something like other games.
Other games are a week, so I think that's really it.
Woop.
Oh, they have Hawkeye.
Wait, we didn't ban Hawkeye?
Oh my god, I didn't pay attention.
I didn't realize we...
I did not... Oh, you guys are very low.
I'm fine.
Yeah, they...
You only have... Careful, I don't have...
I'm on Strange.
What happened?
I don't even know what happened.
TP, TP behind them, guys!
I have my Mantis ult, but I don't think I should use it yet.
Hide, hide, hide.
I'm freezing down.
Strange is to our left.
I'm ulting you for this.
Yeah.
We should be able to go up.
Oh, he...
I can heal you guys from up there.
I'm back, I'm back, I'm back.
I'm damage boosting you.
Bro, I'm going in then.
I don't see you guys up there.
I have no leaves, I have no leaves, I have no leaves.
Get this guy, get this guy.
Point, point.
Yeah, we got it, we got it.
I'm looking, I'm looking.
I'm gonna look on the right.
I'm trying to get to you.
I got you, I got you.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting, I'm ulting them all.
I got them all.
That's it, that's it.
Strange, Strange, Strange.
I have to reload.
I slept Strange.
Wait, I have all here.
Is it winnable?
No, no, no, no.
No?
Okay, I'll keep it then.
One ping.
That's right, I have one ping.
I still have Hawkeye up.
I can't see you.
One ping.
I'm not ulting yet.
I can give you damage boost.
He's one, he's one.
I got him, I got him, I got him.
I'm ulting.
I got my ult up, I got my ult up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're even right now.
I got damage boost on you.
I'm not peeking this.
I am not peeking that either.
Oh, our Punisher.
He's one though.
He's pushing up for it.
I'm going against Strange.
Strange, Strange, one, Strange, one.
They have ult too.
Our enemy is on here.
I'm damage boosting you, Punisher.
Hawkeye is on high ground.
I am one, I am one, I am one.
He's trying to...
There's a, there's a...
There's a Adam turret.
Our Magneto got hooked.
I slept Strange.
I can't kill this guy.
I got you.
Strange is half, Strange is low, Strange is low.
Try now.
I'm ulting you for this.
He's low, he's low.
Nice.
There's a Mantis cocooning.
Maybe?
I should've just looked out.
Go, go for some reason.
Nice Mantis ult, by the way.
Really clutch.
Oh, behind us, behind us, behind us, behind us.
I'm gonna die to this.
I'm dead.
I'm cocooning now.
Someone has to touch him.
I'm trying to save you.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
I can hook you up, sir.
I'm on it, I'm on it.
But...
I'm dead.
I have some scores to settle.
Shake it up.
I will crush them all.
Strange is half.
Mantis one.
Mantis still mid-life, by the way.
I appreciate you.
Turret's close.
Oh my god.
Stop them!
She's looking.
I'm trying to keep you up.
I keep trying to kill him, but...
Oh, you're all so low.
I got one.
We should push up, we should push up.
We're up two.
I have ult here.
I got hook.
I'm trying my best.
We can't shield yet.
Oh, I should have ulted, sorry.
I got hooked.
They might have to...
They have strange ult, too.
I'm damage boosting you.
I'm one.
I'm ulting this.
I'm coming up.
But they're gonna have strange ult here.
I'm ready.
Trina's looking for ult.
On the back, on the back.
I'm on point, I'm on point.
I slept the...
Oh, I didn't sleep.
Mantis is low, Mantis is low.
Trina's one, Trina's low, Trina's low.
I got him, I got him, I got him.
Get the Mantis.
Oh my god.
Again.
Oh, shit.
I gotta start focusing more.
I gotta focus up.
Oh my god.
These games have been, like, so difficult.
I have to lock in.
Oh my god.
These games have actually been, like...
They've been really good games.
They've actually been, like, insane quality games.
Like, I don't...
The only bad game I could remember...
Was the Mantis one.
That was a fucking terrible game.
But other than that, all these games have been, like, really fun to play.
I just need to focus up more.
I've been...
I can't help it.
I like fucking around.
I don't think we've ever won a TP fight.
We've been...
We've been live for seven hours.
Seven hours and only one TP worked.
Enjoy...
Listen, listen, listen, listen.
99% of strange players quit just before they hit a perfect TP play, okay?
Never give up.
Alright, this is it.
It's gonna work.
This is the one, baby.
This is the one.
This is it.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Awesome, guys.
We did it.
Did it work?
Yeah.
Atom is low.
Try our best.
This might be the 99%.
I got him, I got him.
I'm gonna cocoon, I'm gonna cocoon.
I'm cocooning.
Alright, Atom needs help, though.
Um, I'm fucked over here.
I slept him, but...
Yeah.
I'm trying to save you, I'm trying to save you.
Oh, I didn't have any leaves left.
That was the 99%, guys.
Nevermind.
I didn't have any leaves.
I might need donations.
I have ult here, but they have their aggressive ult still.
There's like an Atom turret left.
Atom loves me.
Oh, my god.
We're not 6 yet.
I'm not gonna use anything.
There's a sleep, though.
Alright, let's... I guess.
What the fuck?
You're okay, you're so healthy.
Atom turret left, Atom turret left.
I'm breaking the lamp.
I'm asleep, I'm asleep, I'm asleep, I'm asleep.
Focus point, focus point.
I'm trying to keep her mag me up.
Oh, you're so low.
I'm trying to...
I have no leaves, I have no leaves.
They're left, they're left, there's a Hawkeye.
There's a Mantis turret main, too.
He also has, he also has a Hawkeye.
Got him, I got him.
Make some noise, make some noise, make some noise.
I'm on, I'm on strange, I'm on strange, strange, strange, strange, strange, strange.
I have Atom on me.
Oh my god, there's an Atom behind.
I got them both.
I got two strange kills.
I got...
I got Mantis.
Look, there's just Mantis following us.
Oh my god.
He's Atom.
I don't think I saw a strange though.
Yeah, yeah.
Nice pick on Hawkeye.
I'm on the cart now.
I'm on the cart, I'm on the cart.
So, alright.
I can't heal you guys back there.
Nice, nice pick.
I'm using this.
The strange is pushing us.
Strange is up, strange is one.
He's still low, he's still one, he's still low.
I got him, I got him, I got him.
We have Adamult.
I don't think... No, no, no, no, no.
We don't need it, we don't need it.
I'm on the Mantis is heading high ground, the Mantis is heading high ground.
Turn around, turn around, turn around.
They're staggering.
Careful, it's a mortar boat.
I slept Loki, I slept Loki.
Blam, blam, blam.
I see one.
Strange is half.
They have Born again, they have used Born again.
I can't get to you.
Okay.
I'm pushing them.
Hawkeye low, Hawkeye low.
I'm trying to help you.
Adam one, Adam...
I'm trying my best.
You are doing your best.
Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam one, Adam one.
Oh.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Jesus Christ.
I saw that solo on the Hawkeye.
That poor guy.
I soloed that Adam and Hawkeye.
I'm close to my ult.
I'm on stream.
Strange is...
Oh, never mind, he's getting healed.
Nice, let's get this.
Oh, I couldn't start.
Strange, Strange, Strange, Strange, Strange.
I'm going to push up.
Second chance, don't worry.
Nice pick, nice pick.
Yeah, I'm waiting for my ult.
I'm using it, I have to use it.
I'm pushing, I'm pushing.
I got...
Strange, Strange, Strange.
I'm trying to keep you up.
Mantis, Mantis, Mantis on point, Mantis on point.
Mantis low.
Oh my god.
No, what?
Yeah, they didn't push it.
GG's.
What a fucking comeback.
The voices.
I was like, what do you mean?
He forgot we fucking held that.
He like, he forgot.
Oh my god.
Oh, thank god we have fast games.
I can't feel...
Thank god.
Thank fucking god we have fast games.
Okay.
We win these, right?
Yeah, I don't...
We are still in the...
I think we just ban the classic, no?
I think we ban Luna, we ban Mantis.
Just so Doki can't play anything.
I can play any...
I can flex.
I can literally play all the other healers except for Loki.
I have a positive win rate on Adam.
We don't talk about Cloak though.
We don't...
We don't talk about Cloak.
Cloak is a 30% win rate.
I do it.
No, I'm gonna do it.
You're so lucky.
You guys are so lucky.
Fucking cowards.
Cowards.
They don't believe in me!
They don't...
I don't understand.
Why don't they believe in me?
I literally have a positive win rate.
On Adam.
But not Cloak.
But on Adam.
I have a positive win rate on all the other supports.
Wait a minute, I can't play Loki.
Loki, you have to...
Loki...
There's too much thinking involved when it comes to Loki.
It's actually crazy how much thinking is involved for Loki.
I don't play this role good.
There's like a lot of like things you gotta know how...
What to do for Loki.
Like his...
Especially like the copy ability.
It's like you have to decide what to copy to.
In the moment.
It's such a...
Like you gotta think a lot.
Wait, what?
Why?
Wait, why is it my fault?
I'm teleporting.
Please focus here.
I might have slightly miscalculated my positioning on the portal, but it's okay.
Okay, that's Ken.
Ken's Loki.
Oh, he does it.
Oh my god.
Trin Trin Trin Trin!
Trin's up!
There, they used Linkage.
Look at him.
I'm half, I'm half.
I'm at you.
You guys can?
I'm looking at him.
I'm playing, I'm playing.
Set one, set one, set one, set one.
We can't see you, we can't see you over there.
I have to reload, I have to reload.
Oh my god, you're taking too much damage.
Yeah.
I can ult this.
I'm ulting this, I'm ulting this.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
If I don't point, you heal.
I'm onto Namor.
Three, two, one, I'm backing out.
Trin Trin Trin Trin!
She can't heal!
I'm keeping you up, Namor.
I am on point now, I'm on point.
Okay, okay, I'm keeping you up, Namor.
I'm dying here.
Oh, I'm fighting, I'm gonna die.
Somebody on point, we need to touch on point.
I'm on point, I'm on point.
I'm trying to keep you up, I'm trying to keep you up on point.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm leaving.
Goodbye.
That's a strange ult.
Okay, I have it.
You know, I've seen all Wolverine players, like, ult when they strange ult and just cancel his ult.
Or if he can't also stun you.
It's so weird that I can't see the... I'm like so focused now.
I froze him too, I froze him too!
Reborn again.
Why is this strange, bro?
I'm so confused.
I don't know where he'd go.
Stay close, stay close.
I need to reload, I need to reload.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm on one.
I'm taking point, I'm taking point.
TP, TP!
Oh!
Dead game, dead game, dead game, dead game!
That was insane!
Holy!
I hear someone to my right.
They don't have TP, so we should be fine.
I still hear someone walking nearby.
Let's move, let's go.
I don't know where the strange is.
I'm ulting, I'm on the, I'm on the strange.
Can you grab him?
If you grab him, I ult.
3, 2, 1, back down.
I have no more on me, no more on one!
Your powers are mine!
Alright, I'm ready to put on a show!
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
Oh, be ready, be ready, be ready!
I'm blinking, I'm blinking.
I got hit by the strange.
I don't, is it winnable?
I have point, I have point.
Let's hit.
No, no, no, no.
Stranger ult.
Are they still, did they ult it or no?
They used stranger, they used it.
They used Loki.
Yeah, they did, I saw it.
Either way, the plan is...
BERSERKER!
Yeah, I have a snowflake on you.
For the berserker.
Yep.
I'm looking point, I'm looking point.
They know I'm on the left, I'm fine.
I'm gonna look again.
I'm looking now, I'm looking now.
You guys can...
Oh, you fucking exploded.
We're even, we're even.
This is last fight.
Yeah, yeah, no, yeah, no, the server is...
The server is getting doxxed.
Oh, he fell off!
I'm ulting on point!
I don't think anybody gets...
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice!
Strange, strange, strange, strange!
Focus strange, please!
Please focus strange, please focus strange!
Starlord, starlord, starlord!
Starlord half, starlord half!
He's ulting, he's ulting, he's ulting.
He's gonna touch though, isn't he?
Oh no.
Must be the work of an enemy stat.
Holy shit!
You guys, wait, they think we DDoSed!
I thought it was bad for us!
Zawardo!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why did they think we...
I should learn Japanese and Indian dialect.
Y'all are some cowards!
And then when they get unstuck, like, time has started moving again.
That's crazy!
Oh, it looked...
I felt like it was harder for us!
It felt like we were at a disadvantage!
Why?
Bro, like, we had to get the point!
How was, like, our team that was supposed to DDoS this?
We were literally fucking fighting for our lives!
Starlord where?
We went left.
I might be...
Fuck you.
I got it, I'm okay.
GG!
I don't have healing for this.
I'm so low!
Can we just die on point?
Yeah.
Ooh, nerds!
Woah!
Alright, Adam's not with us.
Okay,
Adam's here now.
I have ult now.
Train is half!
Train's low!
You have no lamp.
I don't see you.
He used it already.
He used it or you used it.
I'm ulting here.
But we won't have defense alone.
They TP'd.
I'm backing out for you.
I froze Starlord!
No, no, no.
I see him.
They're born again!
No more slow!
Our Adam... No.
Our Adam DC'd.
Actually,
I don't know.
He stood still.
Oh no, he's back.
I can touch.
I can TP, actually.
If you can touch, I TP.
Um, they're looking at me right now.
You have a TP back.
Adam, you can ult.
I'm gonna die here.
We really need it.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
But we just can touch next.
Just touching next.
I go, I go, I go, I go.
They used Strangereal.
Yeah, they did.
They did.
They used Strangereal.
He assumed he died to Legendary, didn't notice Doki.
I literally looked at him.
I was like, I don't...
He just stood there.
He like accepted his fate.
He accepted his fate and just fucking died.
I just like watched him stare at the Adam.
I was staring at Starler.
I was like, what are you doing?
Yeah, the fucking slow turn.
He's like...
I like killed him and everything.
I was like, what are you doing?
I'm just doing sub guys.
Moon Knight for what, Kim?
Yeah, Moon Knight players.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
I just walked up the stairs twice.
I don't feel so good.
I don't think they took the bait.
They are main.
Oh,
he fell down the stairs.
Oh, no, no.
Yeah, it's fine.
Change left side.
Oh, nice assist.
I have this guy.
They reload.
Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam.
He has born again.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm on point.
They have Starlord all of a sudden.
They reload.
I froze, I froze Strange.
I'm ulting on point.
We gotta push the backline.
Yeah.
We got the point.
Starlord, Strange, Strange, Strange.
Starlord.
Alright.
They Adam ulted that, but they still have Luna.
They used low-key with an Adam ult.
They have Adam ult.
Oh, it was low-key Adam?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They might TP, they might TP.
They used Ling, though.
They used Ling.
I'm on the left, by the way.
I'm on, I'm on Starlord on the left.
I'm on point.
We got Luna.
Kill Abel, kill Abel, kill Abel.
Oh my god, this Psylocke.
I'm gonna fucking break a table.
I have no shield.
Just keep poking them without dying.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm flying up.
I'm ulting on Luna.
I have to reload.
I got you, I got you.
I'm dying, I'm gonna die to this.
Yeah.
I mean, you can fight on point.
Just fight on point.
Oh my god.
That Nemoro was so good.
I have TP, I think.
Okay.
Let me check.
Alright.
Yeah, I do.
They Nemoro'd Strange ult back.
Yes.
I'm keeping my Luna for Starlord.
They also have Luna.
They're high ground.
I see their Luna, I see their Luna.
I am TPing.
He's here, he's here, he's here.
I'm killing Loki.
Nice.
I'm pushing out.
Starlord.
Oh my god.
Look at Luna on the point.
I'm pushing up, I'm pushing up onto point with my ult.
I'm back up, I'm back up, I'm back up.
I think we have a risk.
I have my ult out for this, by the way.
3, 2, 1, backing out now.
I have my ult.
On him, on him, on him, on him, on him.
Look it up, look it up, look it up.
I'm dead here.
I'm on him, I'm on him.
We have to regroup for one last fight.
Yeah, I'm dead.
We have one fight left.
We have no TP.
Oh my god, that's little.
Oh!
I can touch last second.
You guys wanna wait a bit and group up?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, that Venom pick.
Venom!
They have strangers.
Yeah, they do.
They're still behind me.
I'm dead.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
I have to reload.
They have strangers.
I'm burning in two.
I got one.
I need to reload.
Oh!
We got our point.
No more...
Okay, yeah.
They're no more was insane.
No.
We had three DPS and like...
They can't...
They're no more literally carry that game.
It was crazy.
I can't believe I tripled his support for this.
I'm stuck in...
I'm stuck in Purgatory right now.
I'm literally stuck in...
I'm stuck in the 90 to 100 Purgatory.
I'm fucking...
Oh!
Get me out of here.
The elo hell.
The 90 to 100 elo hell.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I love Marvel Rivals.
I fucking...
Love this game!
That's true.
It's called Eternity for a reason.
And I'm in it.
I'm fucking in Eternity.
I love...
I love Marvel Rivals.
She is true.
I am losing it.
I've been playing for like...
Eight hours.
Fucking hell.
I'm so...
I'm so strong!
Guys, 150 is my cutoff today.
If we hit 150, I'm logging out.
And then we're going again tomorrow.
We're going again tomorrow.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
We'll get 150 today.
God, I hope we get 150 today.
God, I hope so.
Wait, wait.
Don't say that!
You gotta believe!
We hit 150 today.
And then we clock out.
And we'll try again tomorrow.
We'll try again tomorrow.
I believe.
You just gotta believe.
I know I was very...
I was very overconfident with 200 there.
I was way too fucking overconfident for it.
Jesus Christ.
One second delay.
I believe.
It can't be that bad.
Guys, I believe.
It cannot be that bad.
It can't be that bad.
We can do it.
What if we just ban Storm then?
Alright.
We can do it.
What can we play if we can't play Storm?
Man.
Can you play Loki?
No.
It's not like I don't want to.
I actually can.
And I don't...
I don't have the brain capacity at the moment.
Well, I've never had one.
But I definitely don't have the brain capacity to play Loki at my current state.
In my current state, Loki is not it for me.
Why does everybody think I'm a Luna one trick?
Okay, guys.
I'm not a Luna one trick.
She's just the best healer at the moment.
She's the best healer.
Guys, I can literally play all the other supports except for Loki.
That's really it.
I have like a good win rate on Adam.
Okay.
JK.
I can play every support but like Loki.
And like every time I play Cloak, I lose.
Because I have a 30% win rate on her.
But I don't think I'm bad at Cloak.
I just don't know how to...
It's just not winnable.
I can play Rocket.
It's just anybody can play Rocket.
People with no fucking hands can play Rocket.
Oh my god.
I played Rocket before.
I played Rocket before people realized he was dog shit.
Because everyone was like, no, he's so good.
He's so good because of Punisher.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
This is...
This is EU.
But that's okay.
Oh, he's so low.
Oh, Thorlo!
Thorlo has...
Grab.
Oh my god.
Thor has...
Guys.
I know it says one ping.
Thorlo!
Thor's so low!
1v1!
Oh my god.
I need to reload.
I need to...
Oh, I had to reload.
Sorry.
I have ult here too.
I'm not going to ult you.
I'm ulting.
Oh no!
I didn't think...
That was my bad.
I have to reload.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
I need an ult faster there.
I need to remember.
Magneto!
Magneto one!
We can push up with that.
To the right!
Wolverine!
I'm ulting.
Oh,
there's a Thor right behind us.
Thor!
Hold it.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Oh, my one ping.
My one ping is working as intended.
Watch out, Thor.
The one ping right there.
Both tanks are up right by you.
It's dead.
Okay.
It feels like I have ping-ish.
Like, no, it can't be.
It feels like the game is being played by 10 frames left.
Wolverines have.
Thor's have too.
We need to be on point.
I'm on point.
I'm okay.
There's a Thor right behind me.
I'm on wolf.
Wolf is low.
Jesus Christ.
Magneto top left.
He's half.
Guys, no.
It's just one ping.
Magneto's so low.
You're so fine.
You're so healthy.
No, guys.
I'm one ping.
It's working as fucking intended.
Guys, is it noticeable?
Where's Thor?
Oh, he's healed.
He's healed.
Guys, is it obvious?
Nah, right?
What happened?
Guys,
do you think it's noticeable?
That's not a one ping there.
No, right?
No.
Chill.
I had to use it.
He hooked me in.
Oh, you're using it?
Yeah.
No, he hooked me in.
He hooked me in.
He's pushing.
Thor!
Thor's still on point.
Thor's one.
Fetch.
Wait, Psylocke!
Psylocke!
Psylocke, how about money with Psylocke?
What?
Guys, I think it's like one and a half ping.
Guys, you're right.
Guys, it's not one ping.
It was actually...
Two.
Guys, you're right.
This feels like two ping.
This doesn't feel like a one.
Oh, man.
That two ping's hitting fucking hard right now.
It's hitting so hard.
I knew it.
That hundred ping.
That hundred percent increase.
That was double the ping in there.
What?
Oh, okay.
Oh, my God.
That two ping is crazy.
You're right, guys.
I feel the two ping right there.
I see the landing in like five days.
I think like four and a half now.
Technically.
Oh, my God.
There was nothing I could do.
There's still a change in front of us.
I'm asleep.
We have no heals.
Oh, there's no more pushing me.
Oh, it looks like three to me.
I'm back in the fight.
You're complaining about two ping.
Yeah, I am.
Yeah.
Goddamn.
Of course I am.
God, two ping is so unplayable.
It's so unplayable.
Oh.
You guys are so healthy.
Oh, you guys are...
Can you reload?
I'm fine.
I can't see you over there.
Oh, I didn't got reset.
Oh, my God.
Are you guys okay over there?
Why the fuck are we fighting?
Oh.
I was gonna say, why are we here?
Okay.
I won't ask questions.
Oh, I'm ulting for you.
Alright, we got scared.
Alright, two, one.
I'm dead here.
There's a Magneto on me.
Okay, maybe we can get them.
Oh,
I had two people walk up to me.
Nah, they used way too much.
They used more on there.
Oh, my God, please.
Waluigi.
Waluigi, what are you doing?
Listen, listen, listen.
I'm gonna press Q.
Okay.
You disagree with me?
Oh, what are you thinking?
What are you thinking?
Should I?
No, no, no, no.
Chat, type one.
Chat, type one if I press Q.
Oh, my God.
I need to win this game because it's the final.
Wait, Ryo, log in.
Oh, Ryo, log in.
Guys, my brain is not working anymore.
I'm like, my brain is only Marvel Rivals.
It's just I close my eyes and it's Marvel Rivals.
I open my eyes, I'm in Marvel Rivals right now.
150.
We can get back to- We can- 150 is the cap.
We get to 150.
People top left, watch out.
Please, just look at me.
Look at me.
Change is low, change is one.
There's somebody behind us.
There's a Bucky behind us.
We lost our low key.
You're only solo healing.
I'm solo healing.
I froze him too.
Is this winnable?
I can ult this if we need it.
No, no, we don't need it.
We don't need it.
I'll put it on you.
I need heals here.
Oh my god.
I'm so locked.
I'm locked in right now.
He's low, he's low.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
I got it all, I got it all.
Who's going to scan?
I'm going to follow our... I'm following our...
I froze Mantis, I froze Mantis.
I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead.
Our low key is close ult.
We need to keep alive.
Our low key is ult, our low key is ult.
I don't need, I don't need.
Just come back, come back.
Oh my god.
I froze somebody.
They are at the top left.
I froze him, I froze him, I froze him, I froze him.
I don't have ult here.
We're even, we're even, we're even.
I'm going to ult in here.
Support, support is back.
Luna low, Luna low.
Oh that's ours.
Whoops.
I'm on the...
Let's change.
I'm in the back.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I'm reloading.
No more one, no more one.
I can never tell if it's our Namoor or the enemy Namoor.
Like I can't, I can't, I always like, I always freak out.
They're pulling, they're pulling.
They're behind, they're behind.
They might take the high ground.
Flip the map, flip the map, be careful.
I can't tell.
It like freaks me out.
We have to get on point here.
I have ult here, we can...
I'm ulting here, I'm ulting here.
I live, I live, I live, I live.
I live, I live, I live.
3, 2, 1, I have to back up.
Mag is frozen.
But she's looking for me, she's looking for me.
We have to stay on point.
I'm out, I'm out, I'm out, I'm out.
I cannot do anything.
I might be dead then, yeah.
We have to follow up for the next fight, by the way.
It's really good, they have no spoilers.
Keep the orb on her, Starlord.
No more stagger, though.
We have low health soon.
I'm dead.
I froze it, but that's all I could do.
Oh, no!
The voices, the voices are speaking to me, the voices are speaking to me, the voices, the voices, the voices.
No!
You just lost the finals, Heelys.
I hope you realize this.
It's that two ping.
It's the two ping.
I blame the two ping, guys.
I blame the two ping.
Oh, my God.
Guys, we can do it.
I believe.
It's 11, oh my God.
The fact that our record's 11-11.
I'm gonna freak out.
No, I'm not back.
I started at 66.
Our target is 150.
That's actually really good.
Can we ban Punisher?
We can ban Punisher.
Oh, no.
No way.
August is gone.
It's time for September.
Oh, sorry, I'm muted.
Sorry, as I was saying.
I closed my eyes.
It's Marvel Rivals.
I opened my eyes.
I love Marvel Rivals.
I'll leave my assets to Marvel Rivals.
It's in my will.
God, I fucking love Marvel Rivals.
Someone teased me.
Thank you for the 10 gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Alright, 150 is our target.
If we get 150, we fucking clock out.
We clock out.
We clock out at 150.
Surely not.
I don't believe it.
I'm praying for his return.
I belong to Marvel Rivals now.
They own me.
They own my entire existence.
I love Marvel Rivals.
It's 7am.
I have to, like, walk my dog after this.
At this point, I'm gonna play so much that I gotta walk the dog.
Is he coming back?
I would be so sad.
You fucking tryhards.
There's only...
There's nearly only...
You fucking tryhard.
You nerd.
You're such a nerd.
You're so bad.
I'm coming for you.
Oh my god.
How are you losing?
How are you losing a 5v6?
How?
Come back.
Oh my god.
He never came back.
Bro.
Why didn't he come back?
I'm sorry, Tony Florida.
Like, I can't have you in my life.
Oh, who is this guy?
Who is Jimbo Limbo?
Who the fuck is Jimbo Limbo?
I have no idea who they are.
You're right.
Cause I'm at 2 ping.
It's all because me being at 2 ping.
Who's Jimbo Limbo?
My mental check.
It's not been okay for a while.
Since I started playing Marvel Rivals.
I'm not dead inside.
I'm just...
I'm just Marvel Rivaling.
It's just my existence.
Please, walk dad.
The fresh air will give me the strength to hit top 500.
My god.
I believe.
Do we just ban?
Hello, Loki.
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
No, it's not his walkie's time.
I might feed him in an hour though.
It's not his walkie's time yet.
I'll let them figure out the bans.
I've stopped...
thinking.
I can literally play Luna on autopilot now.
This is your smurf, you can chill.
This is not his smurf.
This is his actual account.
Like, what do you mean?
That's literally his actual account.
I can't believe we're back where we started.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it actually.
Oh my god.
Have we won an Ironman Hulk matchup yet?
We have him.
We have a man with no hands.
Have we ever won...
Have we...
My chat said we haven't won an Ironman Hulk game yet.
That is because...
Because...
We have Felix inting.
But your chat...
Your chat will be wrong now.
Because this is the game where we win.
The Ironman Hulk.
I keep popping off on the Hulk.
My team keeps getting diffed, okay?
This time, my team isn't getting diffed.
I'm gonna pull the weight of everyone.
I've finally warmed up.
After 8 hours of gaming, I'm warm.
I'm ready.
Put your trust on me.
Also, your chat has probably never won a game ever.
Isn't Helios in my chat?
Wait, Helios is in my chat.
But Helios is in my chat.
That affects me.
Wait, they have a Hawkeye.
Hulk is behind us.
Oh, we lost.
Punish you.
I have to back up.
This portal is not my creation.
There's a Strange on the supports.
And a Hulk on supports too.
Hulk is half.
Luna by herself to the left.
I got you.
This is the win, guys.
Is this it?
Is this the win?
Haven't lost today.
We're on an 11 game win streak, right?
We're 11-11.
Yeah, I know.
To be fair, our win rate drastically dropped after adding one player.
Who added him?
I froze Hulk too.
Please, I need help.
I'm 1 HP.
I can't.
Oh, they double support.
I'm trying to keep our Strange up.
There's an Iron Man.
Iron Man on me.
I can't.
This is fine.
I can't do this on YouTube.
I can't do it on YouTube.
There's a Hulk right in front of us.
Guys, there's a Hulk on point.
That two ping is way too much.
That two ping.
No!
Rocket heals.
I'm gonna kill them all.
Guys, I can't.
If I had one ping, it would've been so different.
It would've been so different.
If I was on one ping, guys.
Oh, Grimad.
He lost him!
I can ult on point.
I'm ulting on point.
Oh, it's okay.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
I got off.
Oh my god, little guy!
Oh my god!
Little bruise!
Bruise is one!
You guys thought I was throwing, but I was setting us up.
Nice show!
We haven't won yet.
That's true, that's true.
The fake throw.
We baited them into thinking we're throwing.
So they went in overconfident.
And then we did it.
Jankos doesn't lose.
Kat loses.
Also, Ham, thank you for tier 1 sub.
Thank you, Kat.
Also, thank you for the 200 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, thank you again for the 100 bitties.
When you walk down, you will see me.
Marvel Rivalry.
My head is like so mush.
It's so hard to figure out what the fuck I'm comming about anymore.
Oh my god, we're on a hype train!
I didn't even notice!
That's how mushy it is.
It's like actual pasta right now.
Thank you for the 5 gifted subs!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, we're at 2k subscribers now.
That's crazy.
As someone that doesn't stream on Twitch.
To be fair, I've been living on Twitch.
Because of this.
I need to get top 2!
Please, 150 points at least today.
Also, Camilla, thank you for the 5 gifted subs!
Thank you, thank you.
It's like overcooked pasta.
Everything will be fine.
Don't forget, securing the mission area is your top priority.
I've been here for a fucking week.
I'm sorry, I'm like...
What?
No!
You got cooked, bro.
Bro, you just did this.
Oh, he got eeved.
Good doggy.
Keep talking to me guys, I'm fighting here.
Are you winning?
It's not about winning or losing.
It's about fighting.
Yes, it is about winning or losing.
What do you mean?
It's about winning, not losing.
It's about giving it your best.
No, listen, I'm fighting here.
Oh, I'm getting shot at by Strange.
Where's my Strange?
I'm right there, I'm right there.
Doggy, we have Doggy.
Let's get him, let's get him, let's get him.
I'm using it, I'm doing it, I'm doing it.
Yeah, baby.
Keep brawling if you need to.
I'm on point.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, our first Hulk Iron Man win.
It's the first of many.
The first of many.
Baby.
Three supports in the team.
There's probably triple support, what's wrong with that?
We did it.
We fucking did it, guys.
Oh my god.
I don't even get to be a hundred, that's...
Oh my god, that's... makes me sad.
I don't even get to break three digits.
You're right, this is where the win streak starts, guys.
This is...
I streamed for so long.
I'm literally at decent hours now.
I'm at decent streaming hours.
That's how long I haven't streamed.
Thank you for the 10 gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, you wanted decent hours.
Here we go.
I'm technically on a decent schedule now.
We're so back.
Guys, we need like...
You're right, the winds don't kick in until...
9 hours deep.
You're so right.
That's...
That's where...
You're so fucking right.
Technically, in East Coast, it's 9 AM.
So it's decent hours.
Technically.
I believe in us.
This is where the win streak kicks in.
Oh shit, it's...
Oh no, that's central.
I'm thinking about central.
Sorry.
You guys haven't existed for me for so long.
I already forgot the time zones.
No, I am locked in.
I am so locked in right now.
I messed up.
What is this?
Who the fuck are this?
Is this also EU?
My two ping?
Yeah.
Okay, hear me out, hear me out.
5 on 5, okay?
We have an Itzkan player.
And they have a Groot OTP.
He's good on the other character, but we should probably ban him.
Okay, what if we ban Groot?
Then they ban Strange.
Then they ban Hulk.
And we ban Magneto.
And then we replace Sain.
Bogrenation.
Let's go.
I'm locked in.
I'm so ready.
And if I'm not...
I should know.
My EU translation...
isn't working right now.
I literally had no idea what he just said.
I'm so sorry.
My brain cannot translate anymore.
What did he say?
All I heard was Itzkan.
You will go support, buddy.
Yeah, okay.
Because they are about to ban Hulk.
It's Hulk Nation time.
Oh, again, Niki.
There's one character.
Here you go, girl.
This is the second win.
This is the second Hulk Ironman win.
Hulk Nation in shambles.
We're all on the same team!
What team?
Listen, I clicked on your chat and people are telling you to go to sleep.
Yeah, exactly.
Never go to sleep, loser.
We get 200 points today.
We built true strength.
I'm so locked in.
I'm fucking locked in, bro.
Also, a lot of people keep asking me if I'm playing with Valeria, the voice actor of Venture.
Because you have very similar voices.
Venture from Overwatch?
Valeria Rodriguez.
My ghost, personal ghost.
Do I sound like her?
That's the first time I heard that.
I hear so many other comparisons.
Anyways, guys, lock in.
She does?
Yeah, right?
I'm just like, what?
I do not think I sound good.
Oh my god, we did it.
Bad Hella.
There's an Ironman above us.
We're up one.
I can't see you, I can't heal you.
Ironman one, Ironman one, I got Ironman.
It's mine, it's mine.
I'm locked in, guys.
Magnus one too.
Hella to right, Hella to right.
Oh, Ironman too.
We win this, bro.
They can't touch.
Oh, you're nice.
Guys, I blame my two ping.
Okay,
don't worry.
Things are blurring together, but don't worry, I'm so locked in.
I'm pushing cart so you don't have heals.
You have Mantis heals.
Oh, we can Mantis ult first.
Literally, I know right, two ping, literally unplayable.
I can't believe it.
What's the point of living next to the servers if I get two ping?
Clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap.
Oh, he's baby.
He's baby now.
I have to reload, I have to reload.
Oh, it's Hella, Hella.
I'm on Hella, you know.
There's a, Ironman to right, Ironman half.
He's solo, he's one, he's one, he's one.
I froze all, fuck one.
Hulk low, Hulk low, Hulk low, Hulk low.
I'm fighting.
I'm on Mantis, oh wait, they support us.
We're okay, oh we are not okay.
I reload.
Magnio, Magnio Magnio on point, Magnio on point.
That's fine, that's fine, we win this point.
I still have my lune all up.
Don't worry.
Oh my god, you're so healthy!
You think they know you're up there?
Oh my god, what's going on?
What's going on?
I'm just shooting bodies!
Get healed, get healed, get healed.
I haven't stopped healing!
Magnio to the right, Magnio to the right.
Magnio solo to the right.
He's over there.
Bye bye.
What's going on?
He's out, he's out.
Okay, we need to get this face.
Ironman, Ironman, Ironman, watch out, watch out.
Nice pick, nice pick.
Nice.
I woke you up.
Oh, I got you!
I got you!
You're so healthy!
I can't hold after this.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting on the cart.
Ironman, Ironman, Ironman.
Fear, fear, fear, fear, fear!
No!
Oh my god.
No, I feared, I feared.
He told you.
He warned you.
Oh my god.
He warned you, Toki.
Nice.
Maximum!
Oh, that's behind us!
That's fine.
He warned you, Toki.
How did you not know?
Oh my god, my thing is not...
I can't get to you.
Oh my god.
Oh, I need heals, I need heals if you can.
Matis.
Oh, I can't see you, Booger.
Ironman, Ironman, Ironman.
Oh my god.
You were not chilling.
I need five, five, five.
I have all in 20.
I froze somebody.
Our Matis has two people, two tanks on her.
I'm ulting this, I'm ulting this.
I'm damage boosting.
Oh!
He's smashing!
Two, one, I'm backing out.
I froze Hulk.
Ela's looking at me, I can't heal.
Oh, I can't heal, I can't heal.
It's just you, Booger.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, I might be dead.
Oh, you're dead.
I'm so dead.
We have Hela going in.
And maybe we can get Matis up.
Guys, you gotta watch out for the Jarvis clip that guy.
Yeah, he has Ironman ult.
I'm kind of stuck here.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
Please go, please go, please go.
Ironman ult!
We lost two.
We should back up.
I'm healing our tanks.
I'm on our tanks, I don't see Hela.
Oh my god.
Nice, nice.
Matis two left, Matis.
We got this, we got this, we got this.
Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk.
Hulk half.
Heal him, heal him, heal him.
Back up, back up, back up.
Oh my god.
That was crazy.
What a fucking- That was a crazy push.
Oh my god.
Could this be it?
Our second Ironman Hulk win?
After nine hours?
How many fingers am I holding up?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this could be it.
We just gotta believe.
Guys, but like, if I can hit 200 points today, we're so close to finishing this off.
We're so close.
I legit think I need 250 for the cut.
Oh my god.
I need 250 for the fucking cut.
I just gotta- Stop climbing!
Stop climbing!
Why don't you come here right now?
Don't be a pussy, don't be a pussy, don't be a pussy.
Come here, come here.
Jarvis, Jarvis, Jarvis.
Jarvis, come here.
I'll bubble you, I'll bubble you.
I'll bubble you.
I need people to stop climbing.
So I can just leave it at 200.
2, 1.
You have to stop them from securing the missionary.
Jarvis, Jarvis, Jarvis.
2%, 2%.
2%, I have 4%.
This is about min-maxing, really.
What if I jump into them and die?
No, no, no.
Do it, it'll be so funny.
Please?
Do it.
It'll be so funny.
Hulk up top, Hulk up top.
Hulk left half, Hulk half.
I'm beaming them, beaming them.
I'm punching them, by the way, I'm punching them.
I'm punching them.
Oh, Hela, no!
Hela, I got you, I got you.
The Hulk here, we're having a 1v1.
Yeah, I'm chasing.
Where is he right now?
I have no idea.
Oh, he's here, he's here.
Watch out.
I'm gonna look at him.
I'm trying.
Did he just clip this?
Hulk half, Hulk half.
Hulk is low.
He's not low, I lied.
I just thought they would look at him.
Travis clipped that.
Look at the one guy that's not streaming.
He's like, Travis clipped that.
Don't worry, you're so healthy, little guy.
You're so healthy.
Watch this.
Where's my nice freeze, chat?
Where's my nice freeze?
Here.
Oh my god.
Oh man.
Hulk is definitely mad now.
Oh, I'm gonna ult here.
I'm ulting.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
You're so healthy.
I'm in such a zen state now.
Bro, every time I hear
fear...
Fear and pulse charge, I fear.
I literally wake up.
I fear.
I actually fear.
There's a Thor.
Thor is frozen, Thor is frozen.
I fear myself.
Look at Hella, look at Hella.
I'm going first.
Drop down.
I couldn't, sorry.
I have two people on me and I'm scared.
Starlord is one.
She's Hella dead, yeah.
I'm ulting.
Oh, I saw that, Hella.
Is Mantis alive?
Why did it take so long?
Why did it take so long to kill Mantis?
Oh, fear.
Oh.
Magneel's half.
What happened?
What happened to him?
What's going on?
I need help, I need help.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
I leave you.
I'm sorry Mantis, you're gonna die.
Two out of two.
Yeah, I get it.
I was like, I'm sorry Mantis.
It was worth it.
Oh my god.
You're safe.
Goodbye.
He did so much to save me and then I just left him to die.
I was like, I'm sorry buddy.
I'm fucking out.
Two more for 150.
Two more.
10,000 damage?
Who?
Oh, our Starlord.
Oh my god, poor guy.
Fucking 19 deaths?
What the fuck was he doing?
Look, I know I could have saved him because I literally had the best ult when it comes to like, you know, saving him.
But I don't know if Mac is doing okay.
He's climbing.
Why is Gamora?
No one asked how is Gamora.
How is Gamora?
Oh my god, my dream.
We have cross, cross, cross with us again.
Can't lose.
Can't lose, can't win.
Why is Gamora?
We don't ask how is Gamora.
When is Gamora?
Guys, can you do the bans?
I'm gonna go piss.
Good luck.
Is there a Black Panther play on the enemy team?
Okay, let me think.
Whom is Gamora?
You guys see that new James Gunn show?
The DC one?
And like...
I...
There's so much...
I tried to watch the new...
the new James Gunn animated show and I was not ready for all the fucking...
The Creature Commandos.
Yeah.
I was just like...
What the fuck?
They also like...
They added the newest...
I haven't watched the full show but I've seen like clips of it on... I saw clips of it on Twitter and then he introduced... Did you guys know there's a superhero Hooters bar in the DC universe?
I didn't know that.
I didn't realize in the DC universe they have...
They have superhero Hooters.
Yeah!
Where like instead of like they wear like the Hooters thing, they wear like superhero costumes.
And then they had...
Nope.
We had a 100% win rate.
It's all about the...
It's all about the multiverse.
Shut the fuck up.
I'm mad.
Alright.
Hell yeah.
I'm so cooked.
I am.
Okay, we don't.
Yeah.
Okay.
There's a magic to the left.
Magic, magic, magic.
Oh my god.
There's a Captain America, right?
Magic on us?
Oh my god, please.
Shoot, shoot, shoot.
I bow in.
Magic, magic.
Oh my god, please let there be no...
There's a magic on us?
Magic, magic, magic.
Magic one, magic one.
Cap, cap, cap, cap.
Please, please.
Oh my god.
I have to reload.
I have all here too.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
I see.
Magic half.
I have no mag, by the way.
Oh, that's awkward.
I see him, I see him, I see him.
I have to reload.
Magic one.
Cap again.
Jesus Christ.
I have to ult this.
We're all too low.
Go, go, go, go, go.
I'm going backline.
Oh my god.
Mantis one, mantis one, mantis one.
Okay, four, three, two, one.
I have magic on me.
Our mantis is gonna die here.
Oh my god.
No supports, no supports.
Stay inside, stay inside, stay inside.
I'm coming.
Yeah, we're coming back now.
Mantis one, dead.
Look at the side, side, side, side.
If you can peek me, I can heal you.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
Just touch point, touch point again.
I'm king number two.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
Luna half.
Captain America half.
Come back, come back, come back.
Did they captain America ult yet?
Magic.
I'm trying, I'm trying, I'm trying.
Got the reload.
I stunned him.
Three, two, one.
Nice, nice, nice.
Mantis, mantis, mantis.
I have captain America on me.
We can live for...
I have ult, I have ult.
I'm on it, I'm on it.
Four, three, two, one.
I'm backing out now.
I have to get on point, I have to get on point.
Do we have TP?
We have TP.
No!
I fucked up there.
You only have mantis heals, you only have mantis heals.
Oh, I fucked up there.
I got shot at.
I don't know how we are losing this.
Another map, another map.
Helios, is that you?
Oh my god.
I fucked up there.
I didn't want to jump in because I knew I was going to get exploded.
I would have fucking exploded there if I jumped in.
So if I checked stream right now.
Whose stream?
Nadala, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you.
We can't lose a game on Hulk.
Jesus Christ.
I feel like I healed so much during that too.
I never stopped healing.
I was just...
It's literally...
There's so many people that need heals.
I'm scared.
This Captain America is scary.
He's not doing much.
But he's just scary.
He's just there.
He's doing it for America.
And I'm scared.
I'm trying to help you, Mantis.
We're getting pushed by this magic.
Bro, this fucking Mantis.
Like, what are we supposed to do?
This Luna actually saved their Mantis' life.
That was crazy.
That Luna babysat the fucking shit out of their Mantis.
I'm out.
There's a Magitier left.
There's a Psylocke behind me.
I need help.
That's a huge ult.
I'm ulting.
Nice, nice, nice.
We got Cap now.
I'm on Mantis.
Mantis one.
Give me life.
Oh my god.
I bubble.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Oh, he's coming over.
He's coming over.
Cap half.
Stay together.
Oh, we couldn't get to you.
Cap's still low.
Magic's behind you.
Mantis, I can't see you.
How about Captain America on me?
Oh no.
I know.
Our Mantis and I split up.
No.
Oh my god.
You fucking died so fast.
Yeah.
Sorry, I didn't see.
There's so many things going on.
There's so many.
I'm getting shot by like 10 angles.
Yeah.
I think they're on me.
I touched.
I'm dead though.
Oh my.
They're coming over.
No way, man.
There's too much pressure from every angle.
Yeah, yeah, it's the first one.
The first boss.
Don't die, Man Hulk.
It truly is the first one.
My god, we're so close.
We're so close to perf We're so close.
Oh, I just need...
I just need 150.
Please get me out of here.
Get me out of here.
Toki, please.
We need this lead.
Weak!
You're all weak!
I've like...
Honestly, I've just accepted.
I'm fucking...
I'm settling with 150.
And tomorrow we go again.
Tomorrow we go again.
To 250.
Maybe...
No, I should just aim 200.
I will aim for 200 tomorrow.
Today we aim for 150.
And then tomorrow...
We aim for 250.
And then...
We should be secured.
And then after that...
We can come back to YouTube.
And then we'll be back on YouTube.
Sorry.
Tomorrow as in today.
So later today...
I don't know.
I don't want to promise you guys anything.
I don't know what my life is going to be like later today.
I don't know what my life is...
I could be a whole different person later today.
Toki, imagine...
That's what I'm trying to do!
I'm trying to be...
What a bubble!
What happened?
Oh my god.
I've been trying.
I swear, I've been trying.
Oh my god.
It's okay, it's not us.
I don't think it was a me issue.
Can't be me.
It's never me.
No.
It's society's fault.
Can't be, it's never me.
This has been like...
Oh my god, this hurts actually.
This actually hurts a lot.
What a fucking shitty record.
What a shitty record.
Exactly, I'm never the problem.
My pain.
Oh my god.
That's also...
That's my record.
You're right, it's...
It's a 2 ping issue.
Can we see your win rate?
You think I'm fucking ashamed of my win rate?
I have a 53% win rate on Luna.
Because I play way too much.
Okay guys, is this what you wanted me to say?
I have a 64% win rate on Mantis.
I have a 30% win rate on Cloak.
I have a 55% win rate on Adam.
And then everything else, I don't care.
I just...
It's because I play way too much.
I played so much.
And I was hard stuck GM.
For the longest time.
I was like...
I was stuck in GM for like a week.
I think.
Yeah, I was stuck in GM for a fucking week.
And it was the roughest time of my life.
My lobbies are so cursed.
I've had some of the most fucked up lobbies doing this grind.
My lobbies are actually so fucked up.
One thing can only...
Only one thing can make me happy.
Who do you hate on your team the most?
God, there's so much hating.
There's so much hating.
Sorry, I need to get a list.
I need a list.
There's so much hating me.
Who do I not hate?
That's so true.
Who do I not fucking hate?
Do we have a Storm one trick?
I think we ban...
I think we ban Storm.
Let's just ban Storm.
I mean, we ban Hella.
I mean, Krogi can play whatever the fuck he wants.
I mean, he can play Punisher.
Yeah, but I think he played Ironman his entire way...
...up...
...GM...
...by Emberwell.
It's a bit his main.
Yeah, they would ban the same shit.
They would play...
They also have...
We're banning Ironman.
Yeah, but Defran got off.
So I don't have to fucking worry about Ironfist anymore.
That fucker.
Me too.
I hope I get to 150.
I've settled.
Storm?
Jesus Christ.
I mean, what does this guy play?
Yeah, you see, he plays Mike.
Krogi is amazing.
Who said that?
Do you have hat?
I'm sorry.
My hate is coming out right now.
My hate is coming out.
Don't keep chill.
Sorry, I'm like this close to starting something.
Oh, it's fucking...
No, Rocket is fucking terrible in high elo.
Oh, I can't wait to win another game.
It's actually a troll.
Yeah, we can't end on a win, right?
We can't end on a win.
She's going full elo.
Are you gonna donate them?
Where did I even put this orb on?
I think she's gone.
Oh my god.
I think she might be asleep.
Who am I?
Oh shit, is he talking to me?
Oh my god, I'm so...
I am...
I didn't even realize he was talking to me.
I couldn't even register.
Wait, there's a Black Panther.
There's Hulk on us.
Oh my god, I'm sorry, Mantis.
I'm sorry.
I think I need to go back there.
No, not Wakanda.
We're coming back.
Storm, stop.
Storm, please.
I've been streaming for nine hours, Storm.
There's a Black Panther on me.
I need heals.
I have ult here.
I can ult in and then we'll keep Mantis ult for defensive.
Can we do it?
Oh, yeah, it's fine.
I'm with my Magneto.
How are you fighting?
No ult, no ult, no ult.
I have...
I'm scared.
There's a Black Panther behind us.
I froze Hulk.
Use Punisher.
Yeah, then use both DPS ults.
Hanzo, Hanzo.
They have Hulk ult here.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
I don't have flash.
I'm baiting.
I froze Hulk, I froze Hulk.
He has ult, he has ult.
Black Panther is back, back to the ramp.
He's on support.
He's still on me.
I might be dead.
We have something, we have something.
I couldn't do anything.
Black Panther.
Support's coming over now.
Peek our Mantis if needed.
My Hulk.
There's a Punisher top right.
Oh my god, I'm pushing up.
I'm fucking subbed.
I'm so locked in.
Stop saying I'm Groot.
I'm Groot.
I am Groot.
I am Groot, I am Groot, I am Groot.
We can Mantis ult first if needed.
I am Groot.
Oh my god, Hulk is on you.
Black Panther is on us too.
Black Panther is half, Black Panther is one.
I am Groot.
Kill him.
Oh my god, that 2-ping is hitting hard right now.
That was bad.
I hope I don't need that freeze.
I hope I don't need that freeze, lady.
Oh man, that would be so awkward.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
I don't know.
We don't need ult here.
Rocket, Rocket?
Oh, you need ult, never mind.
I got you, I got you.
3, 2, 1, backing up.
Black Panther on me.
Black Panther is still... he's half.
Bucky low, Bucky low.
Hulk, Hulk.
Oh my god.
Lunch break, it's 8 in the morning.
I am Groot.
I am Groot, this is why I hate trees.
In game, in game, guys, in game.
I would never...
If I had a choice to burn a tree down right now, in game...
Hulk is low.
Oh, stay where our man is, he can't...
It's not time for his walkies.
I'm not fucking walking him early.
He's gonna be a little bitch if I walk him early.
Then he's gonna fucking think he gets walks early every time.
He has a schedule.
This is real firepower.
Jesus Christ, how did I keep him up Alaska this long?
Oh, I'm so dead.
We need to rotate, we need to rotate, we need to rotate.
Oh, we got Hulk, we got Hulk.
Nice, nice.
Okay, you're just down two.
Oh, that's a huge ult.
You are Groot, bro.
You're Grooting it.
I love it when he Groots.
And he Groots all over?
Yeah, he Groots all over them, bro.
Okay, I still have my ult.
I don't see you.
There's an Immortar left.
I have ult this.
Oh, we lost two, that's unfortunate.
Oh, I'm backing out now, Groot.
We still have their support ults.
It's in your Mantis.
Jesus Christ!
I froze the Hulk.
Why?
Let's fight.
Again, again.
Okay.
I think we can go.
I don't think we can touch that.
It's a little bit hard.
Again,
and again.
I think against Dark Horde, we need to play...
We need to play Mag...
Mag Strange.
I don't think she's Mag Strange.
I think Groot is fine.
I think he's doing good.
Stay Groot, bro.
He is doing the best he can.
Yes, we're gonna lose our brain cells together.
We don't need them, right?
We don't need them.
We're just here to play Marvel Rivals.
What do you need your Marv...
What do you need Marv...
Oh my god, I can't even force sentences.
Sorry, what do you need brain cells for if you have Marvel Rivals?
It took me three times.
It only took me three tries to make the correct sentence.
Oh my god, why the fuck are...
Mattis, I'm already having a rough time.
Where's our other DP?
Okay, you don't need...
Actually, I'm just gonna put on fucking Groot.
Our Groot is like actually gonna die if I don't...
No brain, just Marvel.
Marvel my rivals.
I miss...
I miss winning.
What was that like?
What was that like, guys?
I'm on him, I'm on him.
He's coming from behind.
Yeah, he's on me.
He's behind us.
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die.
Hulk is on me, please, any help?
I'm here.
You only have Mantis heals.
Oh my god, I'm so sad.
I woke him up too because I was so scared.
I accidentally woke him up.
Another one?
I'm back spot, I'm back spot.
We need to regroup.
Jesus Christ.
This storm is not it.
He's Grooting.
Oh my god, I am Groot.
I am Groot.
Another one?
Don't worry, they're in a line.
I'm worrying, I'm worrying, I'm worrying right now.
One more.
How do you have fun playing one of the...
How do you... How do you have fun playing one of the worst characters in this lobby?
How?
How do you have fun?
What makes you happy?
Nice, nice, nice.
How do you... What makes you happy in life?
Oh my god, you guys take so much damage.
You guys take so much damage.
How do you feel joy in life?
Why would you make this harder for yourself?
I don't know about happy.
I'm just thinking like, why would you ever make this game harder for yourself?
Like...
How do you wake up at night knowing you're playing one of the shittiest characters in Marvel Rivals?
How?
Where does it come from?
Oh, that was the wrong prediction.
I predicted that fucking wrong.
I am 80... 92%.
I'll call a 1v1.
I have it.
I have ult.
I'm on the point.
Guys, I... Oh my god, I'm so excited to fight this for four more minutes.
If we're lucky, it'd be two.
If we're lucky.
We just have to do this for two minutes.
She's not... Hulk is frozen.
He's actually so low.
I'm trying so hard to keep... Oh my god.
I have Hulk on me and he has 1 HP.
I'm solo healing.
It was nice knowing you, booger.
It's nice.
Guys, I knew it.
Two minutes.
One, two, two, three.
Oh my god.
Wow, you can't expect to win them all.
I had a feeling when we had that storm on our team...
That it might be rough.
That it might have been rough.
And it doesn't.
I felt that...
I could feel it.
I was like...
Is this doom queuing?
I wouldn't say doom queuing.
I would say...
I would say that I am here.
I think they have the storm player.
They do have the storm player.
But the question is, do we want to ban storm or let them play storm?
I would say that I am here.
10 hours?
I have 10 hours and I made...
Guys, at least I'm not down, you know?
At least I'm not...
It's the little things, guys.
It's the small things.
At least we're not under.
Only positive here.
No more.
I can punish her.
I don't wanna have her.
Yo,
2 ping is insane.
I know, right?
I got my 2 ping right here.
Yup.
I want my liquid.
How the fuck am I getting...
How the fuck...
I'm getting target banned.
I don't get it.
I've been so nice to people.
Maybe it's time to not be nice anymore.
And be like, you've been nice?
No.
I've been so nice to everybody.
It's over.
It's time to hate.
It's fucking over.
What if I just like... Wait, but then they can just watch my teammates.
I was like, what if I just cover my screen so they can't even figure out what they...
But I'm like, I've been streaming for 10 hours so they know exactly what my teammates are playing.
Guys, listen.
Why do we fall down?
Gravity.
We're so close to 150.
I believe.
It's so possible.
Guys, it's because you guys stopped believing.
They can grab Storm.
I'm solo.
I can set up this.
Oh, good.
I'm looking.
I'm looking now.
Thor's low.
Thor.
Oh my god.
Kill him.
It's fine.
Don't want.
Everybody is so healthy.
Oh my god.
Look how healthy everybody is.
Helios, I need us.
I need big energy here.
Yeah, I'm getting the big energy right now.
Helios, just turn on your monitor.
I'm turning on your monitor.
Turn on your monitor.
Honestly, you sound like you're going to fall asleep any second now.
No, I'm so locked in.
Our Mantis was not... I didn't die.
Can you guys peek me so I can not die?
Hello, here.
I can't see you.
Are you sure?
I'm definitely not the one that's tired.
What happened?
I'm going to... I have the ult in.
I'm ulting in.
I'm on the point.
Please,
I need the TP too.
We got to regroup then.
There's someone to our left right here.
I froze Magneto.
That was...
That was very unfortunate.
I'm moving.
Reloading.
We have Mantis ult for it.
Nice.
I'm on Thor.
Thor half.
No fear.
No more fear.
Our Mantis and I are not doing so well right now.
We have Thor on us.
Nice play.
Play.
Coming back now.
We're coming back.
They lost all their ultimates, I think.
I'm all here.
I'm locking in, guys.
I'm trying so fucking hard right now.
Psylocke.
I'm reloading.
Psylocke one, babe.
Top.
I need top buff.
One top.
I got him.
Pugis.
Mag.
Jesus Christ!
I get my ult!
No!
I'm fucking getting...
Oh...
There's a Psylocke up top.
I have a Psylocke on me.
He's over here.
He's one.
Bye-bye.
Okay, I didn't want him to force it.
Like, I'm playing insane!
I'm fucking insane!
Shit.
I swore.
Here.
I'm here.
Help her.
Strange.
It's fine.
Oh my god.
It's alright.
They have Psylocke ult here.
Jesus Christ.
I will fucking punch you down!
I'm sorry.
I'm gonna be.
Someone high ground.
Someone.
Someone if you want to be.
No.
I am ready to put on a show!
Akira?
Ah, fuck.
End game.
That's fine.
What is that?
Where is it?
Oh my god.
There it is.
Like, where is it?
He's ulting.
Oh, no.
You have only Mantis heals.
I got Dilvo there.
I'm on.
We got two kills.
And Tori's on my ass.
In spawn.
We're coming back now.
We're coming back.
He's chasing me, guys.
He's chasing me.
I think he's coming back now.
I'm back now.
I'm here.
Look at Tor.
Tor one.
Tor solo.
Tor has no passive.
I'm coming back.
I froze him.
I'm almost there.
There's a Psylocke on us in the backline.
Psylocke one.
Oh, man.
Daluna is dead.
I'm on Storm.
The Storm is...
The Psylocke is still behind us.
I'm going to get Psylocke.
Psylocke.
Oh, that's a good ult.
Nice.
Tor, Tor, Tor, Tor, Tor.
We have a four on us.
I'm low.
I'm fading.
You going fight?
I have to reload.
Oh, my god.
I played out of my fucking...
I meant this.
I can't leave!
Wait a minute, wait a minute...
I need to go pump you back, just leave me alone.
Jesus Christ, you're fucking welcome!
You're actual fucking welcome!
I got him, I got him, I got him.
I frozen two, I frozen two!
His lip is too pink.
Guys, it feels like 3 ping.
Not gonna lie, but it feels like 3 ping.
I know, it's actually crazy.
What's the point of paying for 5 if I'm getting 3 ping?
I can ult this.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
I'm damage boosting, I'm damage boosting this.
Change?
Nice.
Luna, Luna, Luna!
Alright.
It's fine.
Woo!
No!
It's fine!
He doesn't know!
That felt like 3 ping right there.
I'm on Storm.
Storm 1, Storm 1!
Nice.
Gamers, I think this is a genuine.
Guys, I feel like that felt like 3 ping.
I felt like it spiked to 3 ping there, I think.
Guys, oh my god.
I need to call my provider.
How could I be having 3 ping right now?
How could I be experiencing 3 ping after all the money I spent?
Insane.
Literally unplayable.
Literally fucking unplayable.
Guys, it's red.
Do you think it's bad that it's red?
Guys, why is it colored red?
This is my bad day.
Like, if I don't see it, like...
Guys, red equals good, right?
It's like, you know when you get band-aid and you put it over?
Like, it's like, you know, at your car.
And then your car is like, like you're saying it's dangerous.
And then you put a band-aid over the meter.
That's what I'm doing.
Red equals faster, right?
Red equals it goes faster.
Beaming tower, beaming tower, beaming tower.
Red for SR.
Next one, next one.
I'm pushing this tower.
Look at tower, look at tower.
Forza!
Keep pushing, keep pushing.
Okay, I'mma push up.
Psylocke in B.
Watch out behind.
Wait, I froze Psylocke.
Oh my god.
Yeah, with my three ping, guys.
With my three ping.
I'mma go with my three ping.
Oh my god.
It's fine, we're so healthy.
We're so healthy.
The ping did it.
Alright, we mentos all first if needed.
To be fair, it looks smooth.
You guys forgot what it was like to play with NA ping, guys.
You actually forgot.
I think you guys actually Stockholm Syndrome'd you.
You guys legitimately forgot what it was like to be on NA.
We have not been on NA ping in a while.
You're so healthy.
We have a Sora on us.
Where's Sora on point?
Where is he?
Another one, another one.
You're so healthy.
Change, change, change.
Huh?
I'm just like...
What are you doing?
I'm just looking at him and then we look at each other.
Bro, just keep up.
Bro, just watch.
They're gonna touch, they're gonna touch.
Change half.
Sorlo, Sorlo.
Nice, we got it.
Goodbye, everybody.
Goodbye.
Die for it.
Die for the team.
Die for your Raycrofts.
Good sacrifice.
Goodbye.
You see, you see?
Okay, we might have lied about the top 500.
Wait, really?
What the fuck?
See, guys?
Red means good.
I knew it.
I knew it, guys.
Red means super fast.
I told you.
Okay, I feed the dodge.
I'll be right back, guys.
Okay.
They have two Wolverine players, by the way.
We banned their Warrior and I think we leave Hela open.
Yeah, I'm down.
I can play Hela, though.
Can you play Hela?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, good.
I'm back.
I fed the doge.
I fed Doki Amur Doge.
He's like, he's just like, feed me!
Feed me!
And I'm like, okay.
I feed you.
He is sustained for another... Paging Doki Burn.
Feed me, human.
He's like a little pager.
He reminds me if he needs... He actually reminds me if his water bowl is empty, too.
It would be like... Oh my god, is it?
Oh god, no, it's still... It's still three ping, guys.
He actually reminds me if he needs water as well, which is nice.
He's my little pager.
Like, mother.
My water.
I'm not judging.
Dude, Hela and Hawkeye are a powerful weapon against evil.
Okay, I was gonna say.
I'm perfect on both of them, to be honest.
Go Hela, go Hela.
He literally... He like, barks at me and is like... Water!
Water!
Hawkeye and Hela in one team.
Let's fucking go.
Alright, I'm so locked in.
Locked in round... Fuck, I'm slurring.
I am locked in round two.
What is... What did we ban?
What the fuck is our ban?
We have Hawkeye and Hela?
What the fuck?
I never read this.
What did we... Why do we have Hawkeye and Hela?
That's crazy.
I can't believe we have both Hawkeye and Hela unbanned.
I hope to God we have the better Hawkeye-Hela player.
I hope to fucking God.
I hope to God that...
Jesus Christ.
I hope to God.
Oh my God, we might actually have the better... Oh my God.
We... We have the better Hawkeye player.
Let's fucking go!
We actually have... Oh my God, and he has a thorn blade.
Oh, the map changed.
Oh, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Woah, I don't feel so good being over there.
Woah.
I'm doing so much damage.
Peek me, peek me, peek me, peek me.
Look at point, look at point, look at point.
I slept... I slept Thor.
Look at Thor, look at Thor.
Thor is so low, Thor is so low.
That's right, go do your thing!
Oh my God, this is it!
Hawkeye, dip him!
Do your thing!
What?
Oh, I can't... We can't help you there.
We got you.
He's low.
I have ult soon.
I will heal you.
I'm fine.
I slept him.
Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom.
Oh my God.
Look at Thor, look at Thor, look at Thor.
I'm on Thor, I'm ulting him.
Oh, okay, cool.
I'm on Venom, I'm on Venom.
I'm on Thor, Thor, Thor, Thor half.
Thor one.
There's a Hela behind us, there's a Hela behind us.
We need help.
I'll restore three times.
I'm dead.
What happened?
That's fine.
Node Hela, node Mantis.
Thor, they've Thor ulted too.
Bro, I have life, do I have health?
Let me help.
Alright, it's my bad.
I need assistance.
Hela's one.
Oh, fuck, she's one.
Yes, she is.
There's a Venom behind me.
Venom.
I'm on Venom.
Venom's so low.
He's one, he's one, he's one.
Thor, Thor, Thor, Thor.
Don't die to Hela, do not die to this character.
I'm gonna do it, I'm gonna die to her.
Don't fucking die to Hela.
I'm gonna do it.
Please don't.
Please kill her, she's one.
She was literally one.
This might be our fifth game in a row that we win.
Oh wait, I did not smite him, he's one.
Thor, Thor, Thor has.
Are you guys, like, stuck?
No, bro, I wouldn't play with these losers.
Yeah, no.
I agree with you.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I just meant that.
I don't know, we just keep it in each other.
You don't disrespect the Dragoon, man.
Dragoonation.
Okay, so...
Who is up for due after this?
Nobody, bro, get out.
Wait, wait, what's your rank?
What do you mean, what's my rank?
What's your rank?
Peak check, peak check, peak check.
Peak check, peak check, what's your peak?
Bro, fucking 6,000 points, bro, easily.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You remember how you got 7,000 points?
The only reason I'm doing well is because I have a job to do.
Didn't even tell us his peak.
Wait, there's someone to my left.
There's so many things going on.
Let's peak together.
What am I getting hit by?
Oh my god!
Good luck.
Good luck, everybody.
Is this winnable or no?
Because I can ult.
Yeah, okay, I'll ult this.
Let's do this.
Oh, they ulted too.
Click one, click one!
Oh, I got you, I got you.
I don't have heals, I don't have heals for Loki.
Strange, strange, strange, we can't focus on him.
So funny, bro.
I just made one joke, bro.
I made one joke.
What the hell?
Oh, sorry.
Jesus, oh, you are so fucking low.
Okay, okay.
I got you, I boosted and healed you.
Goodbye.
Just chill, chill, chill.
Yeah, yeah, we're dead.
I think I might get a random ass kill.
I believe in him.
I damage boosted him.
That scared me.
I damage boosted you again.
Okay,
they have double tank now.
I got you, bro.
That was such a good time, bro.
You should have Psylocke on here.
Fear, fear, fear, fear, fear.
Nice block.
Fear.
Nice, Psylocke.
Look at me, look at me, look at me.
I'm looking at Magneto.
Magneto's half.
The strange is pushing our Pella.
I can't.
He's half, by the way.
There's a... close to sleep, close to sleep.
We're up too, we're up.
Magneto, Magneto.
Focus Magneto.
I have...
They have strange ult, right?
And Psylocke too.
Oh my god, she had a lot.
That would be so silly.
Really?
I'll ult first.
I'm looking, I'm looking, I'm looking.
Oh, I can't see you.
I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
I got you, I got you.
Pella's low, Pella's one.
Nice.
Whoa, Pella to your left.
They only used hella ult for that.
I'm pushing up, bro.
They might TP.
I might cancel it.
I'm going to spawn.
Alright.
He's opening portal.
I canceled it.
Oh, nice.
I'm so fucking good at this game.
You're so good at this game.
They're coming in, though, they're coming in.
Nice.
Oh!
We even got the use of portals.
Yay!
Yippee!
Let me restart.
Winning stream.
Winning the stream.
This is...
This is it.
You know what?
Maybe...
No, I shouldn't test it.
Oh, I got an achievement?
Because I fucking read?
I'm going to make...
I'm going to make Doki bridge fed.
Leader, because I don't like responsibility.
How's Mac doing?
Hey, he's winning back his games, too!
Nice.
Me, too.
How's Rosa doing?
Fuck you, Rosa.
What the fuck?
Jesus Christ, Rosa.
I can't poach him!
He's actually hacking!
Oh my god.
Booger was like, don't invite him.
We don't know for sure.
We can't tell.
Nobody knows if he's legit or not.
We don't want to risk it.
Don't say anything.
Oh my god.
He was so...
For those who have never seen Rosa...
He basically got Bucky-aled every fucking fight.
That was how scary he was.
And I was going to poach...
I wasn't going to poach him.
He was doing it with somebody else.
And I was like, what if I just steal him right now and add him to my stack?
And then...
But then...
Booger was like, he doesn't know.
We don't know if he's legit or not.
Because he's like somebody's smurf account.
But we're like, we're not that sure.
We know he's that smurf account.
He's that guy's smurf account.
But we aren't sure if he's legit or not.
I don't know.
Either way, I don't know the community that legitimately.
I don't really know people in this Marvel Rivals community.
So like, I can't tell.
But he has a 13% crit accuracy on Bucky.
Which is pretty sus.
Like, 13% on Bucky alone is really fucking good.
What rank am I?
Don't worry about it.
Let me get to a good ELO first before I tell you my rank.
Let me get there first.
The same ban?
They've all blurred together.
What does he mean by that?
I can't tell anymore.
I cannot tell.
It all feels the same.
Oh no.
Who are you?
We just banned Volv again?
Nice.
Okay, let's go.
Do you know how to play Mantis?
I don't remember.
I don't think he knows how to play Mantis, guys.
I don't think he knows.
Come on, little guy.
Meow, meow.
Come on!
Just do one little thing.
Come on.
You know you want to.
Yay!
Oh my god, he did it.
Good boy.
He fucking grew hands.
I'm so proud of you.
Oh my god, he fucking grew hands.
I'm so proud of him.
I'm so fucking proud of him.
He fucking found some hands to use.
She gave up.
Don't screw this.
Guys, I'm not a Luna 1 trick.
I have a higher win rate on Mantis, guys.
I'm not a Luna 1 trick.
It's just Luna's a better character because she's the strongest healer.
And I trust myself on the strongest healer.
It's different.
I hope he has the orb.
Bro, I can't keep healing you.
I can't.
Oh my god, kill him!
What am I doing?
Look at you!
Nice.
He fucking did it.
Focus one.
Here we go.
Nice.
Wait, there's a Hulk.
I remember him.
It pleases me to be helpful.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
I froze him.
Nice, nice.
Who's my DPS players?
I can't heal you up there.
You don't need to heal me.
Alright, I'll stop healing.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
You need to move me.
You want to move me?
I...
I don't have ult yet, so you can Luna ult first if you need to.
I'm gonna heal up there.
I can't get to you, booger.
I just damage boost.
I just... I'm a damage booster.
I just...
All I do is press E.
Okay, I don't have Mantis ult.
Nice.
All I do is press E.
I don't even shoot my hands.
All I do is E.
Like, they just die before I can shoot my hands.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
Stay near me.
Holy shit.
I am damage boosting you.
I got this, bro.
Oh, I don't got this.
You are so yo.
I got this.
Oh, there's a Hawkeye on the left.
Watch out.
I'm on Magneto.
Magneto's on point, Chris.
Can we help on Magneto?
Oh, fear.
Oh my god.
We're down one.
Okay, we're down two.
Rest in peace.
Nice.
I'm healing you.
Oh my god.
I grab him.
Did you get him?
There's a Starlord to our left.
He's behind us.
I'm on Starlord.
Starlord one.
Pushing up.
Pushing up with this.
Push up.
Push up with this.
Get the Magneto.
He's half.
I got you.
I'm close to ult.
I'm ulting.
I'm ulting this.
I cannot see.
I'm backing up.
Nice.
Oh, legend time.
There is...
Cloak.
Cloak and Magneto.
I slept Magneto.
Luna is on her ult.
I think we got to regroup.
We got to regroup.
They Luna ulted.
I don't know you live this bug.
Oh, you do.
You're so alive.
You're so healthy.
I'm damage boosting you.
One spit away from dying here.
I'm going to chase him.
We got to pick.
I got you.
I don't have heals.
I slept...
Oh, I picked nevermind.
I see you.
Push.
I'm on my heal.
I'm on Magneto.
Magneto.
Please.
I damage boost you.
Psylocke.
Oh my god.
That was an insane heal.
We haven't lost once with Ironman health.
Yeah.
Yeah, we haven't lost once.
I haven't seen the screen in so long.
I actually forget how it looks like.
Sure.
Not bad for a Luna main.
No, I swear.
I haven't... I swear.
They die so fast.
I don't get to shoot my hands.
I literally just E everybody.
And please let me shoot my hands.
It won't let me.
It won't let me shoot.
I just go E.
That's all I did.
Everybody was so far away.
Let me shoot my hands.
Guys, my accuracy is low because I literally can't fucking shoot anybody.
I just let... I just go E.
Guys, I can't have such a low accuracy.
Guys, please.
Please.
I'm supposed to be one of the players.
Look.
E.
This is my whole job.
Nice.
E.
This is all I do.
Oh.
That's unlucky.
That's very unlucky.
I... I did everything I could.
I can't get to you.
Oh.
E.
Fuckers have...
Oh, fuck.
Oh.
Coordination is dead.
Nice kill, though.
Nice kill.
We can play for support.
Maybe we can get him.
Oh, my God.
I might be fucking dead.
No, don't keep...
You're not dead.
You click.
I'm so dead.
I can... I... I try to...
I'm, like, not okay here.
Go.
Get him.
I'm okay now.
I'll... I'll mess this up first if needed.
Booger, are you okay?
Oh.
Listen, no heal, no DPS, no tanks, no nothing.
Backing out.
I'm backing out.
Oh, fuck.
I can mag this shit.
Oh.
Oh, fucker.
We gotta... we gotta regroup here.
I'll dial...
Oh, just stay near me for the extra heals.
Oh, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear!
How did he fucking walk through all of us?!
What the fuck?!
Oh, I'm trying to get to you right now.
I got you, I got you.
He's one, he's one.
I'm one, I'm one.
Can we even contest this?
I think we should be able to contest this.
Okay, okay.
Oh my god.
It's fine, it's fine.
I see you, I see you.
Nice pick, nice pick.
We should be able to...
I'm fucking blocked, I'm fucking blocked!
Oh my god.
I believe, I believe.
He's so low, the Magneto's so low!
The Magneto's low.
I don't have heals.
No!
I'm okay!
I'm damage boosting you.
You're damage boosting, you're damage boosting.
I need, I'm so close to an ult.
Nice, nice, nice.
There's a Hawkeye to our left.
Who did he copy, who did he copy?
I'm ulting, I'm ulting this.
I slept somebody.
Yeah, he's dead, he's dead.
He's coming now though.
Oh my god.
If I don't die.
Oh, I live.
Run!
Jesus Christ, I hate, I hate my three ping.
Three minutes?
We have to defend this for three minutes?
That Magneto's so low.
Nice.
Massive, massive.
He never missed, guys.
Oh my, you were so... yeah.
I'm backing up.
They have Starlord ult here.
We have Luna ult.
I'm gonna damage boost you.
I'll do it again.
Oh, Magneto, we got Magneto.
Jesus Christ.
We got Luna, Luna, yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm coming for you.
Oh, I'm coming on.
Alright, let's go!
Starlord no ult.
We can, we can, just listen.
Is Starlord to the top left?
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Magneto half.
Nice.
I need to re...
Psylocke half.
That's fine, that's fine.
I'm backing up a little bit.
They're on leaves.
Magneto half.
Magneto's so low.
Oh shit!
Again!
Again.
If we can kill Luna, we can have a good stagger here.
I'm damage boosting you guys for it.
Oh nice, yeah.
I have ult here for this fight too.
We might have Luna ult too here.
I'll let you farm the ult, Luna.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
Stay near me if you can.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
That's behind us, that's behind us, that's behind us!
I got him, I got him, I got him, I got him.
Starlord!
Starlord one, Starlord one, Starlord one.
Oh my god!
We did it!
We fucking did it!
I don't know why he, I don't know why he did it.
He fell like that.
He just let's me slap him.
I was like, alright, slap.
I fucking, I just slapped him.
I was like, okay, I'll take it.
I'll take the slap.
Oh, the one more win and then we'll be free for today.
We'll be free for today.
What a fucking...
It's okay.
The cutoff's gonna be 250, but like, I can't, I can't, guys.
It's gonna be fucking rough, guys.
I can't.
250's gonna be the cutoff for the end of the...
End of the season, I can tell.
As somebody that, as somebody that has like, calculated cutoff for Overwatch seasons for, for so long.
I can tell it's gonna be 250.
It's either 250 or 270, 260.
Because it's climbing at least like, 10 points a day.
And we have, I feel like maybe the last day it could climb even faster.
So if it does go over 250, if I feel like it's gonna go over 250, I might have to climb to 270.
I might just need one more win.
I'll just min-max it.
I will min-max it.
That's right, I'm not shameless.
I'm sh- No, I am shameless.
That's right, I am shameless.
Is that the, oh...
Oh, that's the...
Insta guy.
Does he have like a...
Oh my god.
Kind of trauma.
Oh, the usual.
The usual that justifies my hate.
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
And Black Panther.
Hello.
Do we?
I think we might have.
Who am I gonna ban from this match?
We'll be fine.
Mister, what is the NSA doing?
I'm just drinking.
I have like, a lot of water with me.
Yeah, me too.
Yeah, yeah.
I always have water on me.
We'll probably have to ban.
Probably have to ban.
Well, I'm limiting actually.
We need to ban Panther.
Yeah, he is.
Am I gonna ban Black Panther?
Alright.
MVP probably.
I'm kinda scared of letting Ulti free, but...
I think we have to.
Hit my second win.
I've done it.
He plays a lot of things also, but...
Guys, I fucking hit my second win.
It's over.
It's so over for the enemy team.
And they banned Wolverine.
Okay, he's free.
How am I still up?
I love Marvel Rivals.
We'll have to play really aggressive against Okai.
My sheer force of will.
I am used to the grind.
I'm just so used to the grind.
I told you guys.
I used to, when I grinded for Apex Legends and Overwatch.
I would play 15 plus hours everyday.
And that was everyday.
This is like...
Not even that bad.
Guys, at least now I stream it.
In the past, I wouldn't even stream.
I said it before.
But the Bark Knights have went through several hiatuses.
Because I would literally disappear just for the grind.
I would cease to exist.
And they'll be like...
I wonder where Doki Bird is.
I'd just be like...
Hey guys, I'm back.
I got Pred.
I'm back guys.
There's someone behind us.
Yeah, up top.
Clap, clap, clap, clap.
I got Hawkeye.
That was intentional.
Gotta reload.
Gotta reload my hands.
Intended kill!
Okay,
but what if we actually aim for 200?
What if...
What if this is where everything changes?
Guys, what if...
What if this is it?
This is where everything changes, guys.
What if...
What if it just never ends?
I hear Sylak behind us.
Oh, I thought...
I legitimately predicted the seconds wrong.
I got you, I got you.
We need to get kills here, we win this.
Yeah, you gotta push up, push up.
We can Mantis ult first if we need to.
Woah!
There's Thrall to our left.
That's fine, just don't use anything.
Okay.
No!
They used...
Magneto...
And what else?
And Mantis.
Mantis?
Okay.
Oh yeah, I'll Luna for Sylak.
Yeah, I'll Luna for Sylak.
Kill him, kill him.
Focus him.
I have a Sylak right behind me.
I need help.
I have Sylak right behind me.
You have no Luna heals.
Oh my god.
Nobody protected me.
Where was my health?
Literally, I just needed a second.
Woah.
I'm dodging.
Jesus Christ.
We no like this.
We no like...
We have to get him.
Okay, get back.
I haven't been able to use my fucking freeze.
Oh my god!
It's really hard for us to contest.
There's a Hawkeye to the right.
I froze him, I froze him.
He's frozen.
That was a fucking sick freeze.
Come on.
My shield is down.
Oh.
Guys, why did we not ban Hawkeye?
Guys, why did we?
Why did we?
Guys!
Sylak one, Sylak one, Sylak one.
Here.
I hear someone behind us.
I hear Sylak, Sylak, Sylak.
Sylak one.
We need to deal with Hawkeye.
I'm moving towards him.
Hawkeye main, Hawkeye main.
I have to reload.
Jesus!
Oh my god, I healed you through all that.
Oh my god.
Careful, careful, careful.
He's one.
We just need to kill the Hawkeye!
Why did we ban Hawkeye?
Oh my god, I got Hawkeye'd.
Please!
Sylak and I are playing like chicken right now.
We're like, we're like, I won't ult if you don't ult, Sylak.
Legitimately.
I'm right side, right side.
There's a Sylak on me, there's a Sylak.
Jesus Christ.
There's an Immortar, right?
I don't know.
I froze the Magnia.
She's one, she's one.
I hear Sylak next to me.
There's a Sylak.
I couldn't.
Yeah, it's close against a Hawkeye.
Yeah, Sylak kept saving her ult for mine.
I mean, if we ban Hawkeye, then they're gonna go something else.
There's always gonna be something over.
Yeah, but Hawkeye is like the worst character in the game right now.
Yes, but then they will play Banner.
Honestly, honestly playing against a Black Panther, I can put my squids there.
What can I do against Hawkeye?
Nothing.
This sucks.
I couldn't even ult.
Maybe we go...
I go Mag.
I go Adam.
And we go triple support.
Go Adam and Loki.
Adam and Loki?
Yeah, that's a lot of support.
I mean, I don't think we go all support.
I think you stay, I think.
Swap the Luna for Loki and then go Adam.
Do you play Loki?
Maybe she plays slow Mantis and you go Loki.
I can play Loki, but it might be good.
I can do Adam.
I don't trust myself on...
We can't play like when I can tank against...
We need... No, no, no.
We can.
Why can't we go one tank?
What are we gonna do with two tanks?
We can try this.
I'm just sad.
I couldn't even Luna.
That Psylocke literally saved her ult for mine the entire time.
And then she only ults when I die.
But then I die from fucking...
I die from fucking Hawkeye.
It's like the worst part.
This is gonna be a little fucking scary.
It's just a Hawkeye diff.
Jesus Christ, I hope he lives.
Hawkeye top left.
No, he's still up there.
He's just standing in front of us.
Oh my gosh.
I have Psylocke on me now.
It's actually a Hawkeye diff.
What do we do?
I still bonded.
I'm on Psylocke.
There's a Psylocke on me, there's a Psylocke on me.
Come on, let me live.
Please.
Goodbye,
everybody.
Goodbye.
I can't live.
But they won't let me live.
Oh my God, he did it.
I'm so proud of you.
No more slow.
There's a Psylocke to our left.
Oh my God, they rushed me.
That's huge, that's huge.
Mantis is low, Mantis half.
I heard a Psylocke behind us.
Oh, now he's in front of us.
I'm scared.
Left side.
Hawkeye left side.
I'm going to go with them.
Give me a sec.
I heard Psylocke behind us.
I hit everyone, everyone, everyone.
I got you.
Loki needs help.
He's one, he's one, Loki.
There's no more, there's one.
I can't heal you from there.
I'm out, I'm out, I'm out.
I got you, I got you.
I have ult.
Watch out, watch out, watch out.
I got ult soon, I got ult soon again.
We just got to temporize.
Yeah, I was going to swap.
There's an Ironman.
He's one, he's one.
I'm a little scared.
He's too far.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
That'll be fun, right?
I hate him, I hate him.
Left side, left side.
I'm bling, I'm bling, I'm bling.
Ironman.
I'm ulting this, I'm ulting this.
Behind you.
We're fine, we're fine.
Jesus Christ.
Left side, left side.
Blink, maybe.
No, there's one.
No, I'm dead 100%.
I have TP if we can kill.
Okay.
Goodbye.
I'm going for you.
I give you heals there.
I'm concluding all.
Oh my god.
There was nothing we could do.
Their Hawkeye was so good that it shut us down there.
Oh my god, this is why.
This is exactly why I ban Hawkeye.
I never trust anybody.
I never trust anyone that says they can diff that Hawkeye.
I'll never trust them again.
This is a never-ending nightmare.
I never trust anybody.
Every time they're like, don't worry, I'm a better Hawkeye.
I'll never trust you.
There's no such thing as a better Hawkeye.
It's always their Hawkeye, not my Hawkeye.
The fuck is that bullshit?
Is this what hell is like?
No, this is purgatory.
They always bait me.
They bait me with the like...
With the appeal of maybe you'll get it.
And then they...
It's always a fucking bait.
They give a Twitch prime, then you're like, thank you.
They're like, maybe this is it.
Maybe this is the game where...
You might get it.
I'm in actual purgatory.
I just suffer for the enjoyment of it.
I believe.
It's okay.
This is where the win streak starts, right?
This is where it starts.
What in...
Alright.
Oh my god, we're finally in...
Wait, wait, we're in...
Oh my god.
Guys.
I haven't seen a yellow ping in so long.
Holy fuck.
I have...
Oh my god.
I haven't seen it in color yet.
You know what that means?
I'm back in one ping territory.
I'm back.
We did it.
Oh my god.
NA ping?
What is this?
I would be fucked up if I banned Wolverine.
I'm so back.
I'm so back, guys.
Here we go.
Alright.
Oh my god, it's actual normal hours now.
God.
Why is my panther player an ultimate panther?
The morning people are up.
The morning people are actually up.
Oh my god.
I've never streamed in morning hours before.
This is fucking crazy.
This is new territory.
This is actual new territory for me.
I streamed for so long.
It's 9.30 in the morning.
Isn't it wonderful?
We're so back.
Guys, the sun is out.
I wake up and then it's back to Marvel Rivals.
I'm sorry.
Stay strong, dragoons.
Four more days.
Guys.
Four more days, dragoons.
Oh no.
What?
I have a widow.
I got the bitch.
Oh, you're low.
I'm okay.
You're low.
Yeah.
I'm fine.
They're to the right.
I'm very high ground.
Watch out.
Lowkey's half.
Lowkey's low.
Lowkey won.
He's dead.
I slept the mantis.
I'm getting bullied by this widow.
Where's widow?
Oh.
Hooked me five times.
Woah.
He's the sniper master.
I'm a little scared to peek this sniper.
I have shields in the fight.
Oh shit.
Well, mantis all first here.
I'm so slow, bro.
I can't move.
I'm mantis.
Oh.
Okay.
I thought we were mantis.
We double support ult.
You gotta get some heals.
I'm good.
I can hit him.
Wait.
Okay.
No more to the right.
I see him.
Oh, there's one way.
Fucking god, bro.
Okay.
The strange is blocking me.
I don't know why I fucking jumped there.
There's a widow to our far right.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, I'm asleep too.
Oh, you can actually.
What the fuck are you doing here?
That sucks.
Oh, we have Luna ult first.
Okay, so...
We can Luna ult first.
Are you triple support?
Oh, the triple support.
I just realized that.
We can Luna ult first for the next fight since you have it.
I'm a little scared.
Yeah, I can use it first.
Oh.
That's strange to do still.
I'm a little scared here.
He's backing up.
I found one.
I'm with you.
Loki's still alive.
Loki's low.
They're all in the back.
Careful.
You guys are way deep in.
I'm backing out.
Choo-choo.
Whoa.
Where's the sniper?
So, I need to stop with it.
Oh.
That's a little awkward.
I'm ulting this.
I'm just pinging.
I slept him.
Oh my god.
I'm dead.
We have no support.
Like it?
How do they have triple support?
That's so fucked.
Like, what do I do?
Oh my god.
They have no shield.
I broke it.
Oh, keep our Punisher alive.
Damage boosted you.
Oh my god.
Oh, well.
Oh.
We're down two.
He has no shield.
I'm trying to keep you up.
Our damage boosted you.
I'm ulting.
I'm ulting now.
I got you.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Go, go, go.
I'm so slow.
No one, no one.
The supports are really slow.
They're one.
I'm one.
I got you.
They're low.
I'm fine.
I have ult for last fight.
There's a Widow up top.
Thanks.
I'm gonna look.
10 seconds.
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm fucking so focused right now.
They have strangers.
We are undefeatable!
I have ult.
This is for us.
We are undefeatable!
I have ult too.
I am ready to throw a fit.
No more behind us.
He's asleep, he's asleep!
Oh no!
I'm on him, I'm on him, I'm on him.
I'm dead.
No!
He was asleep!
We should win this, maybe.
I don't know who can touch.
You can do it, Luna.
You cannot do it, Luna.
Go back, go back, go back, go back.
You can do it!
Nevermind.
Let me go back now.
Oh god, I don't fucking wanna...
Wait, we're so low!
Oh no.
Jesus Christ.
Oh!
I'm scared.
We'll help our Black Panther if we can.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
Oh yeah, okay, nice.
Oh!
String is so low!
Oh...
Basket, what?
There's a Mantis behind us.
I'm asleep.
I'm going to get it because I'm so slow, I can't move around.
I need it.
String, String, String!
We almost have Mantis, we almost have Mantis.
93, 93.
Give me the Mantis, give me the Mantis now.
I have it, I have it, I have it.
We got Mantis, we got Mantis.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm melting now.
Let's leave, there's Stranger.
Stranger's one, Stranger's one!
Stranger's one, Stranger's one.
I see him, I see him, I see him.
I got him.
Mantis, Mantis half, Mantis half.
Mantis low, Mantis low, Mantis half.
I got her, I got her, I got her.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Just chucking it.
God, this is such a stupid comp to play against.
It's such a stupid...
I hate this comp that we're playing against.
And I hate...
I hate...
Oh my god.
I have to lock in.
Scott, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Manny, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Hazru, thank you for the tier 1 subs.
Thank you.
I have to lock in for this.
I'm so...
Oh my god, I have to be so fucking focused here.
There's just too many supports.
There's too many supports.
Just because...
They were like...
I hear like three...
I hear like three Luna ults.
And I'm like, what?
No.
Why you need...
Why you need those skins when we're getting rival games?
Yeah, I thought you said we haven't lost.
Bro,
even our stack doesn't even believe that.
Even the Doki Bird fan account doesn't even believe that.
I walked against the wall, that's not good.
Alright, my shield's broke.
I'm going to contest top, I'm going to contest top.
Oh my god.
I took so much damage.
We're taking so much damage.
This is going to be really hard.
I'm just waiting.
I can't peek from main.
We need to.
We need to surround a little bit.
We need to force them into a position.
We need to kill the clones.
Jesus Christ.
I have to do that just to...
I damage boosted you.
There's one, there's one.
Nice, nice, nice.
String tap, string tap.
I can heal you guys from there.
I slept him, I slept him.
You can kill him.
I'm dead.
I got whaled.
I have ult in 20.
Sniper on the right, watch out.
There's squids.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
No more sleep, no more sleep.
Where's one, where's one?
Backline, I'm backline.
String, string, string, string, guys.
String, string, string.
String's one.
I'm on point, I'm on point.
We can't help you, we can't heal you dude.
We're so healthy.
I can damage boost you.
Oh, you're doing that thing.
Okay, I'm gonna damage boost your stupid thing.
Ding.
I can't even.
They're just hiding.
They're terrified of my next step.
Sniper mid-life.
Okay, get ready guys.
I'm about to lean into them.
The mantis is by herself right there.
Go!
How do I?
Do you just keep shot?
I don't know.
Dude, double support ulted.
There's a mantis right behind us.
Live, live, live, live, live, live, live.
I'm ulting this.
Oh, I should live this, yeah?
Yeah.
Change one, change one, change.
Change the ult.
What the fuck?
Get out of here.
I'm trying to get you up.
I'm not gonna use it though.
I'm helping.
Not the will.
Wow!
What?
Oh, that's my bad.
I didn't see it.
I didn't see sniper master.
My bad.
I was definitely...
I don't wanna peek.
I'm scared of sniper master.
Sniper master might come over.
Okay, let's go.
Let's do it.
On point, on point, on point.
At the cap point.
Four seconds, three seconds.
I'm gonna ult this, I'm gonna ult this, I'm gonna ult this.
No one's getting me though.
Oh my god.
I don't know what to do for you.
I got...
Got whaled.
Got fucking whaled.
I was so slow.
Do I run away?
We can play next.
We're playing two flankers in two anymore.
What do I do?
A little peeking, a little peeking, a little peeking.
I'm doing one, two, three, go.
Damage boost to you two.
No one, no one, no one, no one.
Oh my god, I'm so scared of this fucking sniper.
Help our Pantheon, help our Pantheon.
We can play, we can play.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm ulting this.
I got the ult, but...
Okay, I'm staying.
Look at Mantis, look at Mantis.
I'm asleep, I'm asleep.
I'm pushing right now, baby.
I do, I do, I do.
Oh no.
I'm looking at the strange.
I'm looking, I'm looking, I'm looking.
I'm asleep, I'm asleep.
Not the fucking way.
Oh my god, it's the fucking way.
Guys, I'm in, I'm in purgatory.
I'm in, I'm in fucking purgatory.
I'm in, I'm in purgatory.
Where do I run?
What do you mean?
Run!
It's like one second.
See you on my main account one day.
What?
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
I'm just like, where?
How do I get away?
I cannot respond that fast.
I'm going to use the bath to be right back.
Hello.
Goodbye.
I come back and I see a rocket raccoon.
Have I like fallen?
An OTP no more?
Oh shit.
Whoops, I literally heard Black Panther.
Oh man.
Wouldn't it be funny if it, oh thank god, I was going to say.
I'll never escape the rocket raccoon.
Is me hydrating, it's a cycle.
Just like how I keep losing and gaining, it's a fucking cycle.
It's a cycle of abuse.
I fuck with that heavily.
True.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, let Doki play support.
Yaren go tank or something.
Yaren just go tank or some shit.
Wait, am I 12 hours deep?
Oh my god, I'm too far gone.
I'm actually too far gone.
I'm a Twitch, oh my god, I'm fucking embodying Twitch streaming.
I'm too far gone.
I didn't even notice I was at 12, this is actually, no this isn't the longest stream I've ever done.
What's crazy is that I've hit my second win so I'm not tired at all.
I'm losing it guys, I'm losing it.
I'm just fucking it.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go sleep right aw... no I shouldn't sleep.
I need to walk, I need to walk my dog and then...
and then we do it all over again.
Where's my Ironman?
There it is.
Surely...
Oh my god, surely he lives those, right?
No, he does.
He fucking does.
He fucking lives those.
I knew he lives those.
Fucking know it.
I know he fucking lives those.
He's a gamer!
Oh, he wasn't though.
He's not gaming.
Oh my god,
please.
Jesus Christ.
Please.
Holy shit!
We both won.
I lowkey agree.
I'm not okay.
I'm... I'm not okay right now.
I don't know how I lived that long.
I'm not okay.
We got strength, we got strength.
Oh, he angry.
I'm pushing up, I'm pushing up with this.
I'm backing out in 3, 2, 1...
Oh shit!
Hulk is half.
I can...
Bruce, Bruce, Bruce!
Oh shit, nice!
That was the one thing he said.
Damn, bro!
I need a build.
I'll try.
Break what?
What?
There's no way.
What's his ring?
That Hulk has his ult.
I frozen.
Hulk is on the Raccoon and I.
He's still on us.
We need help.
No!
You have no hands!
I hate Raccoon players.
I hate them so much.
I fucking hate Raccoon players.
Behind us, behind us, behind us!
I'm trying, I'm trying so I can ult this.
Hulk is low, Hulk is low.
Starla's gonna have ult for next fight.
All I'm saying is that...
He can't peel!
He doesn't peel!
He just dashes away!
Strange one, strange one, strange one!
I'll push up, I'll push up.
You push cart, Raccoon.
Hulk, Hulk, Hulk!
Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk!
Hulk is half still.
Get back, get back now, get back, get back, get back.
We need to rein this one.
He's one, he's one.
Oh my god.
Okay, get back.
I'm so fucking focused right now.
I can't see!
Hulk, Hulk, Hulk!
Starlord,
Starlord!
Wait, wait, I'm running.
Nice, I'm not seeing shit.
Oh, goodbye!
Oh my god.
If I ever see a Raccoon calling out, I'm gonna troll.
I'm calling.
I don't care what happens to that Raccoon.
I could've said something really fucked up about Rocky Raccoon.
And I'm gonna say it.
He should've died like his friend.
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
Jesus.
Woah, Doki.
What did I say?
I didn't even finish my sentence.
Woah!
What did I say?
I didn't even finish my sentence.
He's not even real!
Who am I offending anybody?
Who am I offending?
He's not even real!
He is real to me.
Oh, 10 Raccoon views.
He's not even a real fucking Raccoon.
He might as well be like...
He's like 10% Raccoon at this point.
You know he's less Raccoon now.
Oh wait, what the fuck?
He's probably behind us.
I'm with you, I'm with you.
He's on me.
I froze him, I froze him.
3, 2, 1.
Look at that, look at that, look at that.
Half.
Nice.
I believe in Doki Raccoon.
Yeah, you're a B2R who's real now.
Found one.
At least I streamed.
Raccoon doesn't even stream.
Oh, I froze somebody.
Oh my god, you died.
You died.
There's a Starlord behind us again.
Yeah, I'll use it now.
Okay, 3, 2, 1.
Oh my god, my experience with Doki.
He's French.
I saw you yelling.
He's a criminal.
You're supporting a fucking criminal.
Oh my god, I gotta focus now.
I gotta ignore my hatred of Raccoons and start focusing.
There's someone.
I froze Hulk.
I'll find her.
Oh my god.
There's a Hulk on us.
I froze him.
Oh goodbye, we might die here.
Raccoon and I are definitely dead here.
I got another one.
All I'm saying is if we had literally anybody else.
Anybody else.
Other than a fucking rodent.
I would have lived.
If we had anybody else.
Other than this god damn rodent.
This fucking criminal.
I am ready to put on a show.
Oh nice, nice, nice.
My god.
This is so mean.
I can't believe.
Rodent.
Rodent slad.
God.
But he even has rabies.
This is fine.
How do we know he doesn't have rabies?
Huh?
How do we know?
There's me.
Oh shit.
Oh fuck.
Of course it's me.
Fuck you, Raccoon.
Fucking lunatic here on my ass, bro.
I can't kill her.
I hate this.
I'm ulting it.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm pushing up with this.
Whoa.
There's a Hulk behind us.
This might be where I die.
We have a Hulk on us.
You KDA player, you fucker.
Fucker.
What do you mean Seraph does?
You're a fucking KDA player.
Watch out, watch out.
My bad, my bad.
I am not in my green mecha.
Yes, it was a lie.
I hate him.
I froze him.
I have the Hulk.
He's on me.
It's alright, he'll be fine.
What's he doing?
He's not gonna die.
The banner, the banner ban.
Goodbye.
He's so low, let's change.
I swear to God, I swear to God, if you touch me, I swear to God.
I'm sorry.
I'm going through some stuff right now.
2 -2-2.
We're okay.
The fucking Rocket got zeroed in.
Rocket KDA'd.
I'm gonna kick something.
Are you okay?
No, I literally had the Rocket Raccoon play KDA this entire time.
I had him fucking play KDA.
He let me die so many times.
Fuck this Raccoon.
Raccoon's right.
What a fucking bitch.
He just let the Hulk slap me around.
He literally...
Yeah, I wonder why he has more heals.
After I die.
I wonder how.
The other support dies because Raccoon doesn't fucking peel for me.
Just skate away.
Oh my God.
Oh.
You know what?
Raccoon.
Can you eat Raccoons?
Despite what you might think, Raccoon tastes pretty good when cleaned and cooked properly.
Like dark meat chicken or turkey, though it is greasier and more tender.
Where can you find a Raccoon to cook?
Oh shit, can I like eat Raccoons where I live?
Raccoon restaurants.
What is it?
What are the pros and cons of eating Raccoon meat?
Well, it depends on how old the Raccoon is.
Older, larger, have a lot of fat, which makes the meat taste funky.
Oh shit, funky Raccoon meat.
Yeah, rabies.
That's what they want you to think.
That's what they want you to think so you don't eat Raccoon.
It's fucking false news spread by Raccoon propaganda.
Since when grew up booger, I can try Hella.
You stay Wolverine, bro.
You stay in your lane.
It's fine, it's fine.
What do we ban now?
I mean, I guess if no one is playing Hella, we ban like...
What about Hawkeye?
What if they don't ban Hawkeye?
What if they don't do it?
Doki, are you talking about eating Raccoons?
What?
No way.
Doki, why would you eat a Raccoon?
How much protein in a Raccoon, actually?
I need to check.
What the fuck?
Who fucking snitched?
Now they think I'm crazy.
Now they think you're crazy, Doki.
My goat.
Listen, what if you go Venom and we just dive that hook?
Only now?
I never tried that.
It works, but I don't know.
If in Europe, it works.
How do we play?
Where is this comp?
Alright.
Restaurants...
Restaurants, Raccoon.
Bro.
How do I... Do any restaurants serve Raccoon near me?
Raccoons with a view.
Guys, I just want to know.
I just want to know if I can eat Raccoon.
I just want to know if any restaurants near me serve Raccoon.
Is that really so much to ask for?
Like, is that really...
Like...
Oh my god.
I can slam again, but I have no E.
I throw a storm.
I can slam.
Slamming 3, 2, 1 now.
I'm on... We can cap point now.
I'm on cap.
I'm capping.
Okay, but if they're like baby Raccoons, it's fine because they're not like...
The older they are, the more funky they are.
So if I eat baby Raccoons...
Sorry.
I should stop.
Alright.
Guys, I swear I'm... Alright.
Guys, it's just all... It's hypothetical.
It's all hypothetical.
It's not like I'm actually gonna eat baby Raccoons.
I'm about this.
Oh.
That's awkward.
They're on point.
Thor's on point.
I think they're down point.
Yeah.
What if he doesn't die?
What if he locks it?
What if he's the goat?
He's already dead.
Guys, it's just a lack of sleep.
Guys, it's just a little...
Too much rival rivals.
I swear to god, I'm not gonna eat a baby Raccoon yet.
I froze.
I froze Penny.
Mine, mine, mine.
Nice.
Penny half?
Oh.
Oh, we gotta reset.
We gotta reset.
We hit him.
He's the goat.
He's my goat.
On my body.
We got the kills.
I'm pushing.
I'm going point.
Straight point.
You have orb.
I'm moving really fast here, bro.
You made me angry.
Put orb on me if you can.
They have Hawkeye out here.
Look at them.
Keep an eye.
I'm killing the mine.
Jesus Christ.
I'm killing that one.
You are all so low.
You can't see me.
Play it cool.
Coronation is dead.
I'll kite one.
I have no tanks.
Okay, I think we go top fight honestly.
We have one.
Last fight.
Who touches?
Good question.
I think we as a team can touch together.
We got pick.
We got two picks.
We got touch.
We got top.
Top.
Penny.
Nice.
Hawkeye.
Push Hawkeye if you can.
Hawkeye is low.
So low.
We only have one fight here.
They have Sorrel here.
And Penny.
Not Penny.
Hawkeye.
Careful Hawkeye.
Oh my god.
We are undefeated.
Akira.
Sorrel is behind.
I'm ulting.
I am ready to put on a show.
I'm on point if you need heals.
Yeah, I do.
I'm not going no more.
Three.
Two.
One.
I might die from...
I froze Sorrel.
Penny one.
We got Luna.
I have to reload.
I don't know how.
I might be dead though.
Why?
Why did you wake him up?
Don't.
Don't use.
Yeah, don't use.
It's fine.
You used a lot.
It's good.
Lock in for next round.
Next round.
Okay.
Lock in time.
It's another day of locking in.
I need no more players.
I get you're mad at Raccoons but do not eat the babies.
But maybe I am the more player we need.
You're like, you're right.
We eat the mothers.
What if I blip out the mothers?
Fuck man.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Listen.
You don't believe but maybe this is the play.
Asgard is not our concern.
What's the play?
We should be fighting on Earth.
Every battle against doom matters.
You'll find that out when Krakoa gets to this timeline.
What's the play?
We just need to go home to back.
They can't shoot no damage.
They just have to die.
Oh, this is a good day for Asgard.
They know we die at some point.
3, 2, 1.
All you need to do is capture this area.
I have 100 ping hope?
100 ping?
100 ping is nothing, buddy.
Wow.
That's so much.
Door's high.
Door's so low.
Oh, I'm down.
And the moor got me.
Oh, that's awkward.
That's so awkward.
I'll use ultimates, I think.
Why didn't we ban Haka?
I'd rather fight.
Why did we not learn?
Why didn't we learn?
I thought we learned!
After this, I'm always banning Haka.
I can't.
I'm gonna fucking... I can't, I've had it.
Is that big?
I can't even tell.
No, I'm not ulting.
Oh, you're so fucking dead.
I said it last time, but I thought we were gonna ban Hawkeye, but we never did.
I...
Oh my god, I said it last time, but I didn't think we would make the same mistake again.
God.
I can't believe we made the same mistake on the same day.
Oh my god, he's ready to put on a show.
You might just ult first if you have it.
Oh, never mind.
Nice pick.
I'll ult this.
I am ready to put on a show!
Support, support, support, support, support.
Oh my god.
No one, no one, no one, no one, no one.
Five seconds.
Two, whoa.
I have a Thor on me.
Guys.
Guys, I can't.
I love Purgatory.
Curse you, Hawkeye.
Yeah.
Curse you.
I mean, he doesn't even have that many kills.
The more is 31 and 2.
Yeah, well.
Oh my god, they're in the moor.
Never mind, it's in the moor.
He has so much damage on me.
They're in the moor.
Hard carry that.
Evil lurk is looking for a sub.
Can't scrim against one.
Are we looking for scrim partners?
This is why I ban Hawkeye.
I'm banning Hawkeye first no matter what.
I don't fucking care what my teammate says.
I don't.
I don't care.
I'm gonna fucking ban Hawkeye.
He's not even a person.
I mean, he is.
He's just a person.
How could he do all of this?
He's partially.
He's like not even like any mutant or anything.
He just has a bow.
He's got.
He should eventually run out of arrows.
This is not accurate.
He's just.
He's just a human.
He's a man.
How does he not run out of arrows?
He literally works 9 to 5 at the Avengers headquarters.
He has tech for 29.9.
Oh, I'm lobby leader?
Here you go.
I didn't even realize.
Oh, he's out?
GG's.
I didn't even realize.
This is our winning streak.
I didn't even realize he left.
Hang on.
I'm just saying.
He just.
There has to be limited ammo.
Oh, good luck.
Good luck on your tournament.
I hope you're super warmed up now.
I hope now you're like mega ultra warmed up.
Oh, GG's man.
GG's.
Guys, no.
Cut off 150, guys.
We can make it to 150.
And then we'll do it all over again today.
I was going to say tomorrow and I was like, oh no, it's later today.
How much it increased?
Under 74, it increased like 3 points.
I don't even think 250 is going to be the cut off.
Guys.
I don't think 250 is it.
Guys, it's going so fast.
It's actually going so fast.
Oh, and Max.
I wonder who he's playing with.
At least he's stuck in purgatory with me.
That makes me happy.
Knowing that he's also fucking going through it with me.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I don't know how I'm...
Guys, I just need 2 wins.
Just 2 wins.
No, it's 3.
Oh my god, why am I always stuck in 2 to 3?
Why am I always...
Why am I stuck in this...
Oh my god, this is purgatory.
I'm always 2 to 3 wins away.
I'm just always 2 to 3 wins away.
This is actual purgatory.
It never changes.
I had such high hopes because we were winning so much in the beginning.
I was like, look at us go.
Thank you for the 5 gifts.
I was like, this looks so easy.
Surely we can...
Surely it won't be that bad.
Yeah, let's check on...
Let's check on our boy.
What's his name?
I don't remember his name.
What was it?
The raccoon guy?
What was his name?
Oh, Power of Love.
How?
Oh shit, we have the widow.
Join us.
You know you want to be a raccoon man.
Bro, okay.
I don't understand raccoon one tricks.
I don't understand you guys.
It's like you're willing to take all the abuse.
Oh, we have...
Alright, it's time.
It's fucking time.
Oh man.
I don't care.
I don't care what all of you say.
I fucking... I've had enough.
I've had enough with Hawkeye.
I can't...
I...
Nobody ever listens to me.
Thank you.
I'm not going raccoon.
I still have some integrity left in this fucking...
Alright, call it.
I still have...
I still have some integrity in me.
I still...
I have not fallen that deep yet.
Come on.
150.
Give me 150.
It can't be that difficult.
150?
Surely not.
Surely it can't be that difficult.
Right?
Surely it'll be okay.
We rest when we're at... Guys, I'm already settled, guys.
I can't go any lower.
I've already...
I've fucking settled, guys.
I can't...
Ogre, we're TPing.
Listen, bro.
I'm two steps ahead.
I don't think he would.
That's not who I wanted to damage boost.
Black Panther on us?
Sure.
Oh my god.
I'm a little scared.
I don't have enough fucking heals for this.
I don't have enough heals!
Oh my god.
Please.
Wait up!
Do something!
Jesus Christ.
Oh, I can't help you.
I'm just... I have to just right click.
I have ult here.
I'm ulting.
I'm on Strange.
Oh, Magneto's on me though.
Ugh.
Black Panther's low.
Black Panther's asleep.
I got him.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking walking in the walls right now.
Magneto!
I sleeped him.
I slept him.
Oh my god.
Please!
I have Strange on me.
Strange is still on me.
Strange is one!
Oh my god.
Please!
Why is nobody killing the healers?!
Guys, I don't...
Me and you, Strange.
Me and you.
I'm going for Adam.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Wait up, please!
I will fucking...
I have a Black Panther on me.
I had to save the stupid Widow!
It wasn't worth it!
I'm gonna let the Widow die.
I'm just gonna let this Widow die.
I can't.
This Widow...
I'm just gonna let her fucking die.
It was not worth it.
100%.
I'm gonna fucking leave her to die.
Yo.
Bucky.
Maybe we go to the support?
I don't think this Bucky plays DPS.
I don't...
Or if you play Wolverine.
That's also a really good thing.
Have you ever played Wolverine, Bucky?
I don't think he cares.
He's gonna remember you forever.
I'm gonna...
6,000 people will now know you're...
6,000 people will now know who you are.
XD We all know now.
We all...
XD
We all know now.
Oh my god.
That's weird.
Give me one more chance.
No, it's over.
XD Why did he just...
What?
What are you doing?
Did he go back?
Oh my god.
That's fucking right.
Know your place.
Oh my god.
Thank fucking god.
Thank god.
Things will be okay.
Things will be okay, guys.
Things...
Things will be okay.
I can feel it.
I slept him.
He's won.
Alright.
I'm asleep.
How did we... Why did we let him do that?
Why did... Okay.
Okay.
I slept Mangito.
Luna half.
I'm on Mangito.
Oh, Man is one.
Man is one.
Black panther on me.
Black panther one.
Good job.
You're fighting for your life here.
I can feel it.
I just want to get this over.
I can hear your voice.
You're like a breakdown client.
I hate this black panther.
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
Bro, I'm fucking gonna die.
I'm okay.
Oh my god.
We have a lot of...
We used a lot of ults there.
Change one.
Yeah.
I have a black panther on me.
He's asleep.
You're so good.
Oh my god.
Get him out of here.
You can win this, Donkey.
Don't give up.
I'm not giving up.
We're the only ones that are talking.
It's okay.
That's all we need.
I have to ult for you.
I am ready to put on a show.
Yeah.
Chill.
Strange, bro.
Bro, where are we going?
Luna's so low.
I'm dead.
We can TP, maybe?
I don't...
Oh.
I'm cocooning.
Oh my god.
I don't...
I don't know.
That's a huge ult, but...
He's by himself.
Oh my god.
We need to touch.
If we can.
I'm running.
Why did he...
Why did he push up?
What the fuck?
No, our Strange threw.
Our Strange was like...
Okay, also...
Also, fucking Bucky was like...
Believe.
Give me one more chance.
And I was like...
Bucky, please.
Holy shit.
I'm just like...
What do you want from me?
Oh my god.
My entire life is just...
Marble Rivals.
I cannot...
Guys, I will not settle.
I already settled at 150.
We can't settle more.
Settle again.
We promised 150.
We will get 150.
Unless Booger fucking leaves me.
I don't know.
Then maybe we settle.
Hahaha.
If he leaves, then I guess we settle.
I guess.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
Who are these people?
I have no idea who they are.
Oh my god, he fell.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Just keep a bunch of Eternity Players on standby here.
Like, I don't know who you are.
I'm just gonna...
You're just here.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
I have no idea who some of these...
I have no idea.
I don't know who they are.
I'm just putting them there for standby.
Been through a lot, guys.
This has been a wild ride so far.
This has been like a wild fucking 12...
How long have I been up?
12 hours.
What's my record for the longest stream I've done?
Wait, he is a teammate?
Alright.
Who is he?
He's a teammate.
Alright, he's in.
I have no idea.
What does he play?
14?
It's my one ping, right?
My one ping.
You're right.
Ever since I put one ping...
It's all been downhill.
Ever since.
One ping with one bar.
Oh no.
Wait, what's my...
What's the battery on my mouse?
39%.
We still got it.
It's still fine.
What are we waiting for?
Is he dodging?
Is he dodging right now?
What the fuck are we waiting for?
Oh, he's snacking.
You don't need...
You eat rank.
Rank points is our food now.
Our rank points is what sustained us.
I am not gonna embrace...
Guys...
I'll cut off my hand.
Haha.
End game.
Of course.
I shouldn't be that hungry.
I made pasta last night.
I made pasta, but like...
I really wanted... I used buldak sauce.
With my pasta.
I was like... I was tired.
I just wanted to try it out.
Because I always have it with the ramen.
It comes in.
And I was like, you know what?
I'm gonna mix spaghetti...
Spaghetti with buldak sauce.
Kelvin.
Yeah.
I'm not.
I'm so locked in.
Haha.
Wait, how long are you planning on streaming for?
I'm streaming until we get to our goal, Doki.
Guys...
Guys, do you think we're cooked?
We shall achieve greatness.
Oh my god.
Are you a quitter, DokiBird?
No, I'm not a quitter, but...
I'm a little worried.
What are you worried about?
We didn't ban Hawkeye.
I'm listening.
What is the worst thing that can happen here?
I don't know.
The Hawkeye dip like the last three times.
We didn't ban Hawkeye.
Maybe it's time for me to play Hawkeye.
These other players just listening to our conversation.
Haha.
These players are listening to my fucking descent into madness.
They're like, is she okay?
And I'm like...
I'm like...
Haha.
Did you guys lose your last game?
No, I'm on a 10 win streak right now.
I'm on a 20 game winning streak, baby.
It ends now.
Everybody's against me.
I'm gonna fucking freak out.
God,
if I could, I would fucking kick you.
It was strange.
I'm pushing up.
Right side no more.
My shield is broken.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Nice kill.
There's a Psylocke to the top right.
Or behind us.
She's one, she's one, she's one.
I think she got healed.
She got healed, it's fine.
Yeah, it's me.
She's on me.
She's high ground, I'm flying to her.
She's out.
Strange on me, shoot Strange.
Strange is...
Strange low, Strange one, Strange one.
Focus...
Focus Strange if you can.
Oh, I think...
He's still low, he's still low.
He's high, I got him.
There's still a Psylocke behind us.
She's walking around.
Nice kill.
That Octopus was so scary.
We have unlimited.
At him, at him, at him.
Strange.
We win.
Where's Rosa when we need her?
That guy...
That guy went on a fucking 10 win streak.
It's actually crazy.
That guy...
I'm probably going to miss everyone, but...
Maybe I'm going to go.
Are you ready guys?
3, 2, 1, hit them all.
Mantis all first if we need to.
Yeah, I'm on Mantis.
Nice.
There's an Amorn behind us.
There's an Amorn right behind us guys.
He's still behind us.
We report our Strange.
Woah!
We deserve this.
Yeah, they say that.
It's actually funny.
He is the ace.
What the fuck has he been doing?
I don't understand.
What is he doing?
He's playing the game.
I got it.
I'm fearing...
3, 2, 1.
I'm...
I froze him.
He's playing the game.
I don't know.
Are you okay?
Oh, you're not okay.
Yeah, I'm fine actually.
Are you okay?
I'm so okay.
How was your baby raccoon conversation?
It's because I want to eat a raccoon.
I'm the bad guy.
I don't understand.
Why would you want to eat a raccoon though?
I don't know Kelvin.
Why do we have Kelvin here?
Who is Kelvin?
I don't know.
Kelvin, bruh.
I knew I would.
I'm gonna hit a big one by the way.
We have a strange in front of us.
I'm dead.
I'm rezzing.
I have a magneto and strange just fucking WT me.
I'm coming.
I have to...
I got you.
Hawkeye right side.
No shield for strange.
I'm Hawkeye.
The red boss.
My shield is broke.
They have no mantis.
I couldn't get that off.
Oh my god.
I got headshot.
Oh my god, Hawkeye nation.
Guys, we need a plan against the Hawkeye nation.
Can we rotate right side?
Go right side.
My shield is breaking.
Almost broken.
I have no shield.
Strange.
Oh my god, I'm so locked in right now.
We have unlimited.
I'm dead.
My shield is breaking.
I'm crashing.
I froze magneto.
Hawkeye is dead.
I need to reload.
Strange is just walking up.
This is last fight.
Wait.
My shield is broken.
Hawkeye right side.
I have ult here.
I'm ulting now.
3, 2, 1.
I have a...
I'm trying to keep you alive.
I'm trying my best.
Strange, strange, strange.
Look at me, look at me.
Sleeping, sleeping.
I'm backing out if someone else stays on cart.
I'm going to back out so I can heal.
Can we just cap it?
Can we hold close?
Stay on point then.
We got it, we got it.
We have to cap.
There's a strange that's just walking up.
I can maybe touch this guy.
I'm about to do it right now.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
I'm walking, I'm walking.
I got slept.
Punisher's one, Punisher's solo.
He's solo.
Yeah, I got Hawkeye'd.
We still have two other healers.
Oh, nevermind.
I'm 71.
I don't know if I can get in time though.
You can.
I have strange out.
Punisher left side, Hawkeye left side.
Go right side, go right side.
Just take the right side angle.
They're one.
He top me off.
We almost have a...
Oh, I'm 96.
I was 96.
I couldn't get my ult in time.
This is why we always bad Hawkeye.
This is...
I'd rather play against Hela than a Hawkeye.
I feel like you can counter Hela more easily than Hawkeye.
I don't understand.
Why is that?
Why do we not bad Hawkeye?
I couldn't farm it.
I told him like, I can't.
I need...
Because we had two other supports.
They fucking...
They took up all the heals.
I was just...
This is why I hate you, Calvin.
This is why...
The Raccoon just takes all the heals.
I can't do it.
Because all he does is left click.
And it just absorbs the heals.
I fucking hate you, Calvin.
I hope you...
I hope you're a roadkill.
I legitimately hope you're...
I hope Rocky Raccoon continues to get nerfed so that every time these people pick Rocky Raccoon, they will get fucking...
They will drop 500 points.
Dude, I hope...
I hope they never get back to this elo the moment fucking Rocky Raccoon gets nerfed.
Left click is so slick.
Don't give Hawkeye too much space.
Stay here.
They have a better frontline.
Oh my god.
There's a... I froze him.
Hawkeye peeking.
Nice kill.
My god, I'm fucking helping you.
Don't worry, my queen.
I'm here to assist you.
Oh, I have to reload.
Oh, you got Hawkeye'd.
We have portals way slower than them, by the way.
Like, we have triple support.
We have Mantis ult.
Hawkeye half.
Hawkeye one.
He's so low.
I'm 97.
I have my ult.
But they have strange ult.
He died so fast.
They have strange ult here.
She's waiting for it.
Goodbye, me.
Goodbye,
me.
I say goodbye.
Never again.
Never again will I let them not ban Hawkeye.
I lose because we literally don't have the better Hawkeye.
That's actually so fucked up.
Like, I...
That's so... Every time.
Every time.
I literally lose because my team has the shittier Hawkeye.
I don't understand how this is possible.
I...
I need that strange player to start throwing again.
I got one.
Nice, nice.
Strange, strange, strange, strange.
Change one, change one, yeah.
Nice, winnable, winnable, winnable.
They're rezzing.
Right here.
Strange, change one, change one.
Strange, we got him, we got him, we got him.
Watch out for Hawkeye left side.
I'm trying my best to pick you up.
Woo!
Never miss!
Careful of this guy.
Kill him above.
I'm safe here.
I need 10% for all...
Coming back, coming back.
I have ult, I have ult.
I'm ulting here, I'm ulting here, I'm ulting here.
We're even right now.
I'm just...
We almost have Strange ult, we almost have Strange ult.
I got him.
He's huge, he's huge, he's huge.
Serenite cart, Serenite cart.
Yeah, I'm fine, I'm fine.
Get him, get him.
Oh my god.
Hawkeye is main.
I'm a little worried.
I don't even know if this is a good angle to play.
They have mech.
Strange has ult, he's gonna fly up and try to ult you guys there.
Be careful.
Goodbye everybody.
Goodbye.
Guess who I'm avoiding after this game?
Yeah, I tried to heal you.
Nice.
I froze Magneto.
I froze Strange.
Strange has won.
Leave Raccoon alone.
I'm fucking kidding.
I'm not gonna say it.
I hope you guys had a nice day.
We need to play aggro on their tanks.
With Wolverine.
I'm gonna ult in this.
They might have Strange ult here.
And Hawkeye, yep.
Nice, there's no more ults, no more ults.
We're winning this.
Oh my gosh, he's solo.
I can't get to you.
Nice, oh we lost.
Yep.
I'm asleep, I mean frozen.
I'm gonna reload.
Oh my gosh.
Here, here.
Oh, you got it.
Last fight, this last fight, this last fight.
Strange, Strange, Strange if we can, Strange if we can.
Hawkeye on me, Hawkeye.
What the fuck.
Stay with me, stay with me.
I'm trying, I couldn't, I had you healed.
We gotta keep investing.
I'll be there.
Keep stalling, please.
Stay put, stay put.
Come on.
I'm trying to keep our...
9%, 9%.
I got it, I got it, I just got it.
I see him, I see him, I see him, I see him.
Oh, don't get Hawkeye, don't get Hawkeye.
3, 2, 1.
I froze Magneto.
Where, where's behind?
Strange has ult, Strange has ult, we have to...
I got him, I got him.
Oh my god.
Oh.
I almost threw that entire fucking game with my shitty Wolverine ult.
Oh my god, I'm gonna fucking...
End game, end game, end game.
I'm pecking.
Oh my god.
Get out, get out of my life.
I'm gonna fucking unblock you.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god.
This one right here.
Did she get him?
Oh, I'm okay.
I'm a good person.
Good vibes, good vibes.
Yippee.
Woo.
We're good vibes here, good vibes all around.
I love my rivals.
Raccoon hater in 2025.
I'm a hater of many things.
I've actually started hating more.
I've started hating more because of Marble Rivals.
I'm having a great time.
Thumbs up if you're having a good time.
And you also wanna eat a raccoon.
It could be either.
We don't know which thumbs up it's gonna be.
Thumbs up.
We don't know.
It could be I'm having a great time and you wanna fucking eat a raccoon.
Let's go.
Thumbs up everybody, thumbs up.
Thumbs fucking up.
I don't know who any of these people are.
Oh, it's a power of love.
It's a power of fucking...
Oh my god.
You're that KDA raccoon.
You're that KDA fucking raccoon.
I remember you.
I'm losing it.
I am.
I'm settling with 150.
I'm settling.
I know I said 200, but like I...
Today's been rough.
Today has to be one of the roughest sessions.
Because I'm literally stuck in purgatory.
I don't have enough.
Oh thank god.
I was gonna say I don't have enough fucking voice slots for these.
Where did they come from?
It's like they just showed up.
It's like they literally showed up out of nowhere.
Where did they come from?
A bad raccoon.
It's not meta.
Why do you hear that they're meta?
It's fine.
I'm okay.
It's time.
Guys, it's time.
I can... It's time.
Oh my god.
It's time.
They have a raccoon.
It's fine.
Yeah.
I mean, did it say he was throwing?
I feel like we have to try so hard to win these games.
Oh my god.
I miss Rosa.
I'm gonna cry.
I'm so locked.
I'm so locked in.
I'm locked in as hell.
That was real.
Oh my god.
Logang.
Magic too.
Magic.
Logang.
Oh, you gotta see this over.
Otherwise, I get Logang.
Oh my god.
I don't think we have enough heals for Adam.
I stole it.
No, I think you stay stole it, man.
Jesus Christ.
I'll be just...
Wait, he's one.
Magic's one.
Oh, I got one.
I got one.
Nice.
Push.
I got another.
We're up to...
Madness.
Madness is so low.
Oh, goodbye, everybody.
Oh, wait.
Hey, is this...
I'm cocooning.
Sleeping.
Behind you.
He's one.
Wait.
Change.
Change on cart.
Guys, change on cart.
I'm coming.
Turn around.
He's one.
Okay, I have ult here.
Low gank, no passive.
And I think you need to set up for your ult on Starlord because they have no defensive.
I think their Mantis ult is still not out.
It should be pretty free.
I don't care.
You should set up for res.
Yeah.
I'm just pushing the cart a little bit and I'll go set up for res.
I'm pushing.
I'm setting up for res now.
He's one.
Okay, I'm not going to set up.
Change.
I'm pushing cart.
Oh my god.
See you guys.
I can add him.
I see as we might lose this game anyway.
Who knows.
I'm just going to push cart.
I'm pushing cart.
Goodbye.
You only have Mantis heals.
I'm just pushing cart.
They're so healthy.
I'm setting it up.
Oh, actually we can just die here.
Honestly.
I don't think it's worth resing.
I don't have heals for you.
He's strangled.
Oh, I got hit.
Thank you.
I got you.
Change.
Change one.
Oh, it's my warriors.
Oh, magic's one.
I'm pushing cart.
There's someone behind us.
I heard something.
We're both pushing cart.
Mantis and I are pushing cart so you need heals.
Yeah, I need to set up for res.
I'm just going to push a little bit more.
You should heal our teammates.
He's inside the house.
I'm pushing.
Magic.
Logang.
Logang missed.
Come on.
Mag-heal.
I got him.
No second chance left.
What is he doing?
I'm pushing cart.
There's a...
Oh, I solo-linked us.
Break.
This is real firepower!
I have magic on me.
Magic one.
Nice.
I'm asleep.
No more heals.
Logang on me.
Hello?
I'm pushing up.
Logang right side.
Logang one point.
Logang.
One.
He has no passive.
Logang dead.
Magic.
I got ulted by...
I am cocooning.
Cocooning.
Okay, still have no heals.
I got... I got Wolverine.
Logang dead.
Groot.
He is Groot.
I'm on cart.
Groot is dead.
I'm asleep.
Can you shoot too?
Yeah, I'm shooting.
I'm shooting.
I have ult in 10.
I can get ult soon.
Watch me.
Push.
Push with her.
Behind us.
Magic.
Turn around and help.
Magic solo.
I'm gonna set up for rez.
If you guys can push the cart.
I have ult.
I'm pushing up.
I'm getting ready for rez.
I have ult.
Cap.
Clap.
Yeah, they're manning stone.
I have U salt.
I have C salt.
Go for the Eng aglore.
Use your passive.
Oh my god, goodbye.
I used Toba.
Cap, cap, cap him, cap him!
Nice.
Magic, magic, magic, magic!
Oh, he's low.
Oh, that's so good.
Oh my god, I told you I could play Adam!
I...
I told you I don't know what trick!
I told you I don't have to play other heroes.
I told you, I told you I could do Adam Warlock.
I just wish he has... his ass is so flat though.
That's my only...
What is it?
He's supposed to be like the perfect being.
Why the fuck is his ass...
True.
I thought he was supposed to be one of the most perfect human...
Like, not being, sorry.
One of the most perfect specimens out there.
And yet his ass is so flat.
But yeah, that ass is tragic, it is.
Nice thighs though.
See, this is why Raccoons need to be put out.
Out the shed.
Venom literally stole all his ass.
Oh yeah.
Guys, what did he say?
Guys, I just said okay, but I don't know what he said.
Headbutt.
Oh no.
Okay, I need to be like super careful with my heals.
Alright.
Keep up.
Wait, there's chains!
Chains pushed up!
Oh, you're so...
Reg, reg, reg, reg, reg, reg.
You're walled off, you're walled off.
I have TP though.
Oh, this is bad.
I think I can TP in time.
Yeah.
We can TP, we can TP, it's fine.
Nah, I can TP, I can TP.
I TP, mine, mine, mine, mine, mine.
I linked us.
Is this... I'm cocooning.
Nice job.
Rook in, rook in.
I couldn't, there's a... point, point, point, point!
That's unlucky.
I...
I'll swap to Loki after I feel like we might need more heals.
Oh my god.
Boop!
Alright, it's time to learn Loki again.
I don't remember how to play Loki.
But I feel like we definitely need the heals.
I have Rez here.
They should have Bucky ult, they have Bucky ult.
There you go.
You're alive.
I have Bucky on me.
I'm trying to... I can't get to you guys.
I'm almost got it, I got it!
Trench is low.
I don't know how the fuck that worked.
It worked out, thank god.
What did he say?
I'm sorry, he's like mumbling.
He's...
He's like mumbling what...
Oh, he's playing close.
Yeah, we're playing... Oh, there's a group behind you.
I'm asleep.
Groot's half, Groot's half.
There's another Mortar left.
I got you, I got you, Mag.
We're just gonna have ult here.
There's a Groot.
He's one, he's one.
Okay guys, I know where I'm using my Strangeload.
He's opening a port though.
He doesn't have Strangeload, does he?
Wait, byes!
I don't have any heals now, you know?
Oh, this is bad.
I still bonded.
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
You still have... That died fast, that died fast.
I'm not gonna use my cocoon.
I have ult here.
Not yet, not yet, yeah.
Yeah, that's good.
You can use your first solo, I don't think they have Mantis yet.
Yeah, you need to go solo, yeah.
Yeah, Strangeload, Strangeload on me.
They're holding really close, I need that.
He ulted me.
But I can cocoon, I can cocoon.
I'm ulting this.
I can't, I can't.
I'm trying to touch base, I'm gonna die.
I can't, I'm dead.
No!
Wait, wait, wait, we're touching, we're touching, we're touching!
I'm gonna go, I'm gonna go.
I'm backing out, backing out now, I'm backing out.
No more second chance, no more second chance.
Nice, nice, nice!
I'm on Groot, I'm on Groot.
Groot one, Groot one, Groot one!
Change one.
I got him.
Nice.
Oh my god.
We can just wait for our ultimate charge.
Let's go.
We did, I think we did.
We did?
Okay, cool.
Did they have Groot ult then?
No, they didn't.
No, no, no.
That's fine.
We can play without one of my grenades on.
I might.
Go, go, go!
Oh my god, I'm soulbinding, I'm soulbinding us.
Yeah, I'm chilling, I'm chilling.
I probably stole it.
Yeah, I did.
Play the choke.
I'm gonna wall.
I got one, I got one!
I'm out of blood.
Oh, I don't have soulbind too.
Raccoon's weak.
You only have Mantis heals, you're walled off from Mantis heals.
Watch this, watch this.
We'll come back, we'll come back.
Oh, I got slept?
That's good, that's good, that's good.
I stole my ult.
Tracer's behind us, behind us.
I'm coming back.
Tracer, Tracer, Tracer.
Nice, nice, nice, that's a good...
I'm soulbinding, I'm soulbinding.
Turn around, turn around.
Got him, got him.
Jump, jump.
Yes!
I'm insane, I had him!
Told you I'm not a one trick!
Told you!
Alright, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
I'll be like, alright, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
I didn't even need Loki.
I didn't even need him.
I'm actually not a one trick.
I told you I can play other characters.
I fucking told you.
I beat the allocations.
I told you my fucking mind expanded there.
I can even carry with a 180 ping on Adam.
I fucking solo died in Amora.
He wasn't even looking.
I shot him in the back.
He looked forward and I go pop, pop in the back.
That's what you write.
Marco, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Epic, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, he took those back shots.
That's fucking right.
I hope he fucking closes his eyes and remembers me.
And I won't even call back.
I won't even call back.
B Porter, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Two, we just need two.
Will we be lucky enough to get those two though?
That's the question.
Will we be graced with the two?
Just gotta believe.
Gotta believe.
When can we get Spider-Man gameplay?
Necros is literally beneath me right now.
He's down the street, guys.
Necros is down the street.
I don't know any of these names.
To be fair, I don't play in the morning.
Wait, that makes so much more sense.
I'm like, who are these people?
And I'm like, oh yeah, I don't exist in the morning.
This is the first time I see these people.
In these hours.
I've never seen these people before because I've never played around these times.
I swear to God, if they don't ban Hawkeye, I'm gonna freaking freak out.
You need to ban Storm.
You're right, ban Storm.
Gil, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, not super chat, thank you.
I'm sorry.
You wanna play Hella here?
We're banning Hella, right?
Who the fuck plays Magic?
Get Hella out.
Thank you for the tier 1 sub for 11 months.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the gifted subs.
Thank you.
Astro, thank you for the $10.
Thank you, thank you.
Go to bed, don't let your...
No.
Two more games.
Not games, two more wins.
Or maybe three more wins.
Knowing me, it could be three wins.
Boring bans?
Who are you?
Alright, guys.
They banned Hulk.
We need a support player here, guys.
Lauki, how good is your Mantis?
He says, don't worry, King.
Okay, I believe in him.
Who bans for fun?
Who the fuck bans for...
Go back to, like, I don't know, Diamond.
Diamond or GM.
You're gonna ban for fun.
There's five days left of the season.
This is a game.
We have Glizzy Muncher.
These are the players at these hours.
Oh my god.
I'd rather have play against a Hella than a Hawkeye.
Cause a Hella is more easily counterable.
Cause a Hella takes two shots to kill something.
But a Hawkeye takes one shot.
And a Hella can...
A Hawkeye can kill somebody out of...
Kill a Mantis and a Luna out of ult.
But a Hella can't do fucking shit when it comes to that.
A Hella can't kill...
Can't kill people out of ult.
They're pushing in right now.
Oh wait, that's ours.
I'm just coming in here.
I'd like to...
Prematurely use my eyes.
And Wolverine's coming.
Shoot the Wolverine.
Wolverine's back here.
Come here.
Make a difference.
We must marshal our defenses.
Place poison point.
Wolverine is gonna go behind me and grab somebody.
Wolverine's in front, man.
Logang, walk.
They're...
Contesting point.
I was worried.
I'm asleep.
Mike half.
Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike.
Wolverine.
I'm grabbed.
Nice.
Oh.
I'm still dead.
That was a lot of dabbing.
I guess I back up.
Wolverine low.
I don't know if I live.
Wow!
That was a...
A great escape.
Wait, Mantis ult first.
There's a Wolverine behind!
Wolverine behind!
Okay, I guess I ult too.
Our poor...
Our...
Oh...
My...
God.
Yeah, I'm trying.
I can't heal up.
Oh...
My...
God.
Guys,
this ain't looking so good.
This...
This ain't looking so good.
Oh,
my God.
Guys, this ain't looking so good.
Guys, it could be...
It's gonna be three games!
Guys, I have a feeling this might be three games again.
Oh, he swapped off and...
Okay, let's try and hook their Mag.
Guys, this...
This ain't looking so good for us.
This...
Mag sucks.
Let's go.
Let's sleep.
Help this guy.
Lazy Muncher needs help.
I'm grabbed.
I'm welled.
Where are we going, guys?
I'm welled, guys.
I'm down.
I'm low, guys.
Oh,
my God.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Wolverine's still left.
Hook Mag.
Oh, shut the fuck up, Mantis.
Logang.
Logang's up left.
I'm gonna ult.
I have Doppelganger.
That's good.
Three, two, one.
Oh,
my God.
I got a gunner.
He's tight-rooted, Mantis.
Pretty cool.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Please.
Magnio's one.
They're gonna rez, though.
Right side, Memoir.
He's low.
Did they do it?
Magnio's low, Magnio.
Oh, he's half.
He's half now.
Mag.
Mag's still low.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Oh, I'm low?
He has no passive now.
I'm ulting this.
Kill the Wolverine.
He has no passive.
Yeah, I'm on the Wolverine.
Oh, they fully backed out.
No passive.
I need my life.
Can we even contest still?
I don't know.
Maybe.
I froze Groot.
I touched it.
I touched it for one second.
No!
I can't wait for three wins, guys.
I can't wait.
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon, I shine.
Guys, I'm so...
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
I can't wait for three games.
Three games, everybody.
Give it up for three games.
We're here forever.
Yeah.
I don't know, honestly.
I think this guy is a Penny Parker player.
Which is crazy because she's not meta anymore.
I don't think Glizzy Muncher cares.
I think he's already in the G.G.
Go next.
Glizzy Muncher is already fucking over.
What support do I even switch to?
You can go Lucky.
You can go Adam.
Adam is also good.
You can go triple DPS.
You can go Namori.
It's good.
Adam will give us three runs.
Pretty good.
Adam?
Adam will be really good.
I've never played Adam.
I don't even play support.
Alright.
Yeah, I can play Namori.
Here we go.
Behind us.
I'm rolling on mag.
Mag.
Agni is still low.
He has no shield.
Agni has one.
I'm shooting him.
Mag.
I'm solo healing.
Pressured.
I'm pressured.
Ogre in.
We are 20 off support ults here.
I have mine in two.
I'm going to use it now.
Just use it when you're in it.
Go.
Try and kill their Luna.
3, 2, 1.
I'm backing out.
Mantis.
They're really low.
Strange has ult too.
Wolverine.
Wolverine is low.
Strange 1.
Wolverine is up top.
Oh my god.
Wolverine no cooldown.
Where is Wolverine?
Where'd he go?
They're probably close to 1 support ult.
They didn't use Mantis ult yet.
Oh my god.
Get me out of this.
I'm okay.
Yeah, it's fine.
It's fine.
We just have Wolverine, I think, and Nagamoto.
They used both support ults, so...
And we actually...
We'll have Luna ult back, actually.
He's going for I, maybe, right side.
Wolverine's gonna grab me, guys.
Oh, missed.
Oh my god.
No more health.
Please.
We'll use Mantis ult first if we need to.
Actually, I'll use it.
I got it.
Oh.
Gotta get Kits.
It's fine.
I'm damage boosting.
I'm backing to the point.
Sorry.
I just thought that...
Because she didn't ult instantly, so I went for it.
Wolverine behind us.
Wait, wait, he's in, he's in.
We still have another push here.
I'm putting a self flick on Starlord.
Wait, go, go, go, go, go!
I have a Magneto on us.
Magneto's one, Magneto's one!
Crit one too, crit one!
Oh.
Jesus.
Wait!
Oh, he's guy's passive.
Stop!
Please.
Please stop.
I don't know if it is winnable, guys.
Their team seems just better.
Okay.
I'm okay.
I'm not okay.
I think the more we're so dead, the more...
We're so dead, the more...
That's fine.
We'll be fine.
Guys, three more games, guys.
Three more games!
Wow!
I love Marvel Rivals!
What the fuck happened to her?
What happened to her?
Oh, crit's low.
Crit's so low.
We've got 20 seconds, we've got to do this.
I'm gonna die, guys.
Wait, I thought...
Oh, okay.
It's 10 seconds.
Mantis, why?
Why, Mantis?
Mantis, you have ult!
What?
I'm just like...
Mantis?
The Mantis...
What happened to our Mantis?
The Mantis said, don't worry, king.
And then, that was...
That was our Mantis.
Oh my god.
Wait, what was...
Why did I thought...
The Mantis would be okay?
Why?
Why did he tell me, don't worry, Mantis?
I should have worried.
Guys.
Oh my god.
I can't believe...
I don't know why he held that ult!
I was like, Mantis?
Mantis?
Okay, let's do it.
Let's go.
Okay, let's go.
Oh shit.
Okay, sorry.
If it flips to me, I'm sorry.
I should have flipped him.
I'm not okay right now.
I've been...
I've been on right now.
I've been on for...
Oh my god.
It's been 13 hours.
Were they ban Luna?
I'm not a one trick!
I literally proved that!
I played...
I've won...
I did plays on Adam.
Oh my god.
I think I'm gonna freak out.
Don't worry.
Then it'll be two more wins after this, right guys?
Two more wins.
Two more wins after this game, right guys?
The 2.5...
Where does the .5 come from?
I used...
I used the...
Gosh, I don't even know what mic I...
Is it a Shure...
It's one of the Shure mics.
It's the classic Shure mic when you use for streaming.
It's one of those.
My brain is...
Can't comprehend stuff anymore.
All I can think about is...
Is Marvel Rivals.
I love Marvel Rivals.
I should...
I don't know.
This should be on Iron Man.
Oh, fucking hell.
I forgot.
I'm playing against an enemy.
Oh my god, I missed.
I missed.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
You gotta help the Iron Man if you want, by the way.
Oh my god.
There's a Hulk on us.
Please, I'm trying my best to help your stupid 1v1.
Iron Man, Iron Man.
I'm at top.
Can I have some fucking healing?
We have Hulk on us.
Hulk on me, Hulk on me, Hulk on me.
Stranger's low, Stranger's low.
Yeah, I'm in Hulk, I'm in Hulk.
I'm ulting this.
I'm on point, I'm on point with my heals.
Hulk behind us.
Hulk has ult, I think.
I'm dead here, I'm dead here.
Oh my god.
Was he the one that was like, I need some heals?
I'm like, I fucking, what do you want from me?
You have everything you've ever...
Wanted.
I'm gonna get D.Va, he's 1 HP.
He's killed his guy.
He's 1, he's 1.
Please, please, please.
Oh my god.
Where's my Iron Man?
Like, what do you want from me?
Iron Man, Iron Man, Iron Man.
Iron Man, D.Va, D.Va.
Oh, Mega, uh...
I'm just looking at Luna, looking at Luna.
He's Gamma, Gamma, Gamma, Gamma.
Luna, absolutely, D.Va.
Left side, Wolverine left side, left side.
Wolverine half on left side.
Oh my god.
I can walk in with Gamma here, I'm walking Gamma, I'm walking Gamma.
Look, look, look, Iron Man, Iron Man, Iron Man, Iron Man.
I'm not in a good position, Wolf.
Oh my god.
You only have low-key heals.
Only low-key heals.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I was like, I can't help you guys, you guys went high ground.
What do I do?
I'm coming back now, I'm coming back.
Oh.
What do you mean?
You get the snowflake, that's the most healing you can ever dream of.
Oh wait, it's not, okay, it was our, it was our Psylocke, that's, it's our Psylocke.
Sorry, buddy, you're right, no, he's right, no, he's so right.
Okay, no, he's right.
No, he's right, no, he gets jack shit.
Nevermind, alright, three, two, one.
Oh my god.
I, okay.
I'm coming back.
Oh my god, I'm coming back.
That's why I wanted to ban Mantis!
I got to grab, I got to grab Mantis.
Oh no!
Fucking go Mantis.
Alright, do you play?
Yes, I play Mantis, I'm gonna play Mantis.
I just need healing, I'm playing health packs.
Fuck it, man.
We're trying, we're healing.
Oh my god, our tanks are taking a fuck ton of damage, it's not just the unit deals.
Yeah, but I'm killing their Ironman, I'm killing their Lunar.
Good job, good job, you keep doing that, we'll keep doing our thing, okay?
Yeah, but your one thing is losing fights, apparently.
We're still losing fights right now.
Good for you, man, good for you.
Oh my god.
Bro.
Look at this, fuck.
Bro's getting knocked out, I'm so in for it.
But...
I love Marvel Rivals.
Oh!
Oh my, I don't know why I ricocheted.
I like ricocheted.
Can I get a heal?
WHAT DO YOU MEAN YOU PUNCHED ME?!
It worked out.
Everything worked out.
It all worked out, everybody!
It all worked out!
I don't know.
No more is one, no more is one.
We killed two.
We don't need it.
Mantis one behind, Mantis one to the left.
It all worked out!
There's a Magneto, right?
I'm forced,
I'm forced.
Oh, I thought you were gonna ult first, sorry.
I got him, I got him, I got him.
It's fine.
Oh, it's changing, changing.
I will help.
I'm coming over now.
Don't die, don't die, don't die.
I'm gonna have to ult, I have to ult.
I'm still alive, 3, 2, 1.
I froze Magneto.
I have my ult, I have my ult.
Wait, Bruce, Bruce banished, Bruce banished to your left.
Oh my gosh.
I'm looking at...
Jesus Christ.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, that was so stressful.
That was so stressful.
Yo, are you guys stacked?
No, what?
We're not stacked, bro.
We're not stacked.
Wait.
Holy fuck.
I hate this guy.
But like, in-game, in-game, I'm sure he's a lovely person outside of the game.
I'm pretty... he must be a lovely person outside of this video game.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna get my ult.
I hope you never end in Tassadar.
In-game, in-game, in-game.
I'm just warming up my legs.
It's good, it's good, behind.
Behind.
I'm ulting.
I have to reload.
Oh my god.
That was huge.
That was a huge ult.
Where do they come from?
Oh, this way.
Okay.
I couldn't remember.
I can't tell.
I'm fucking directionless right now.
Jesus Christ.
How?
What do you mean?!
Pokemon.
No, you're not.
You're so healthy.
He did it again, but you're still healthy.
I have to ult.
Oh.
I'm sorry.
That's fine.
I still...
Oh my god.
I didn't see the mantis having ult.
That was my bad.
Bro, like...
No, you know what?
No, he's a terrible person outside of this game.
I bet.
I take it all back.
I fucking take it all back.
I'm moving, I'm moving, I'm moving.
He is!
I know it!
I'm very close to you.
I don't want to walk out main.
I do not want to walk out main.
What's up?
Wolverine.
Watch Wolverine.
I need my cloak.
I have Wolverine behind me.
Wolverine is on support.
Heal me.
Strange one.
Wolverine is still on support.
He needs damage boost.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm heading over.
I'm gonna...
I'm heading over.
I'm coming.
Five seconds.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
I'm trying to keep our Mantis up.
I have Wolverine on me.
Please, I'm on you.
Please walk out.
Oh my god.
I don't know if we know how to play healer, but I don't think we do.
I've been listening to you guys.
It's okay.
Oh my god, how is this a stack?
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Oh my
god.
It sounds like something actually.
I need a note.
I need... what was his name?
Nubs?
In front of six... seven thousand people.
This guy.
No, what was his name?
Fuck yeah, I need a note.
I need a note.
Nubs.
You sound like you have no friends.
You actually...
Oh yeah.
What?
Wait, let me see.
Oh, I don't have...
Okay.
Wait, maybe we should get a DPS third.
Oh my god.
Bro, my healer's stuck.
I hope...
I hope he knows I'm a streamer.
And then...
Have a nice day when he reads the chat history.
I hope he has a great day.
Bro.
I hope...
Oh my god.
And then he's like, just top us off.
Just top us off.
Top me off.
And then I could...
And then he runs straight into damage.
How do we top that off?
And then he runs away from us.
Just like, yeah.
Wait, okay.
Oh, did Mac actually got off?
Oh, he climbed a bit.
No, I know Dosu is playing right now.
Let me see.
Oh my god.
He's like...
Wolverine on us with heal me.
Me and the other healer was like, Wolverine's on us.
And then he's like, where's my heals?
And I'm like, I don't fucking know.
We're getting chased by Wolverine.
It's not like we didn't communicate it either.
Like...
The fact that both me and the other support communicated that we were getting dived and nobody...
Like, he didn't care.
That guy is actually not real.
He was so not real.
Holy shit.
He's like, why did you...
I was like, I'm sorry.
I didn't see the Mantis at all.
I literally ulted because I thought we needed it.
I was like, oh shit.
Didn't see the fucking Mantis needing the ult.
He is real.
He is real in my heart.
I hope any other people...
I hope everybody that sees this guy in my queue in their games laugh at him.
But like laugh...
Sorry, not laugh at him.
Laugh with him.
I hope we all laugh with him and have a...
If we ever see that guy...
If any of you guys see that guy, I hope you all laugh with him.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
Where is ToeKeeperLover69?
I'm banning Hawkeye, bro.
I can't.
Why would you ban Luna?
Get rid of Hawkeye first.
Complaining about heroes when we have an Ironman and the Snowflake always has to go to the...
I swear...
Bro, I actually just like...
The fact that you chose Luna and chose 20% and now Hawkeye isn't banned or Hela isn't banned is going to cause me an aneurysm.
And then he bans Hela.
Can you stop voting for whatever you want?
He's going to ban Hela again, which isn't the worst thing.
But then we play against Hawkeye.
Oh, thank God.
I'm going to avoid this guy.
I'm going to freak out.
I'm going to freaking freak out to this guy.
Everything will be okay.
Everything will be okay, guys.
Two games!
Three games!
Oh, I'm at three games.
No, four games.
Fuck!
Alright, four games.
Alright.
Guys, I was going to settle with 150.
What happened?
Okay, 130.
I'll settle for 130.
Bro does a demon ban and then picks his negative win rate DPS.
Did he look?
Bro, he already looked up minions that fast?
Oh my God, that's actually crazy.
He already looked them up on a fucking tracker.
That's insane.
Oh my God.
That's so funny.
That's actually so funny.
Okay, let's EU.
I got to be sure what fucking area I'm at.
Oh, I slept him.
Oh, both tanks are down.
Oh, that's cool.
Yes, we can EU.
Okay.
Why did both my DPS...
Both my DPS let him...
Oh my God.
Okay.
I'm okay.
Oh, that's a good one.
Jesus Christ.
That was strange.
Oh, this is bad.
Wait, there's a lower map.
Oh my God.
What do I do here?
Oh my...
Okay, but they stared at me while I was sleeping.
Why didn't anybody wake me up?
I don't understand.
They literally watched me like fall asleep.
Oh my God.
Like, I don't know what you want me to do there.
I...
Oh my God.
Okay.
I don't know what you want me to...
Guys.
Guys, I might be...
Oh no.
This is not looking so good, guys.
This is...
I stunned him.
He's asleep.
Yeah,
I can touch.
Alright, we'll settle for a 100.
You're right, guys.
I'm gonna come to touch.
You're so right.
I'll...
Let me settle for a 100.
You're so right.
We'll...
You're so fucking right, guys.
There's a change behind us.
I'm on Adam.
Alright.
There's a Psylocke.
I'm alive.
I need help with Psylocke.
Oh my God.
I needed help with Psylocke.
Oh my...
I walked backwards, guys.
Did you guys see that?
Oh my God.
Please.
You're so healthy.
Wolverine.
Wolverine, one.
It's okay.
Let's settle with a 100.
I'm fucking ready to settle.
I'm ready to settle, guys.
I'm so ready to settle.
I have to use this.
Strange hatch.
Okay, we lost our other DPS.
Alright.
I'm backing up.
Oh, they're portaling.
They're going to portal.
We're spawning, guys.
We gotta get out.
I'm stuck.
We can get out left side.
We need to get out.
Okay.
I'm too thick.
Wolverine, you have.
Oh my God.
Wolverine, you got.
I don't know what's going on anymore.
Please!
I don't know what's going on.
What do I do?
Okay.
This team doesn't look so great.
Oh my God.
Guys, this...
This team is not looking so ideal.
I feel.
My team is...
It's not even me anymore.
It's not.
It's just not even me anymore.
No, we're selling for a hundred at this point.
I'm fucking selling for a hundred.
I'm ending.
If we get back a hundred points, at least it's positive.
Then we'll go again.
All over again.
Then we'll do it all over again.
Later today.
Of course I'm still on Rivals.
I love Rivals.
Yippee!
Oh, we have a Jeff now.
It's over.
We have...
Oh my God.
What happened to our team?
What happened?
Why do we have a Widow?
I don't know what happened to them.
Nice.
Unlucky.
That's so unlucky.
Oh my God, I can't even do anything about it.
Oh my God, we did it!
We killed somebody!
Let's go!
Oh my God.
I don't know what you expected there.
But definitely not enough healing.
Oh my God, we're doing...
We can do it.
I'm not even gonna shoot anymore.
I'm just gonna stay in this cart.
Yay.
What?
How'd that hit?
I literally heard the sound of it hitting his fucking face.
Oh my God.
I swear to God, I heard...
I heard it hit...
Oh my God, please.
Wait, what?
Oh.
Oh my God, this guy's one.
I don't know.
Oh my God, I'm fucking...
I'm going in.
I'm going... I'm not even gonna comm too.
I'm fucking going in.
I'm fucking beating him up.
Oh my God.
He missed.
I'm gonna start fucking beating him up.
None of them deserve damage boost now.
Oh my God, you...
There we go.
What is this?
What is this game?
What is this fucking game?
What is this?
Get out!
I am the damage at this.
I'm just...
Alright, it's fine.
Why?
Why did you...
Why did you peek, squirrel girl?
You're not gonna live...
Alright, whatever.
Fuck it.
I don't care enough.
He's opening a portal, guys.
We're TPing.
We're teleporting.
Yippee.
All of you do something.
Stand near me.
Stand near me or I die.
Stand... I...
I...
Okay.
I don't...
I don't know what that was.
I...
I don't...
I don't know if he cancelled my ult, but what the fuck was that?
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
He's asleep.
Okay.
There we go.
It's okay.
It's...
It's alright.
Sometimes some games are just...
Unwinnable.
It's just I accepted it.
I blame our guy for fucking selecting...
That our guy...
Our guy for selecting a ban on the 25% ban.
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck?
What is going...
What is going on?
Where's my team?
That was strange.
What?
What's going on?
I don't even know what's going on anymore.
I...
Oh my god.
He's rezzing.
What is...
Oh nice.
Cool.
I...
There was nothing I could do.
You know...
Some games are just...
Unwinnable.
And then you just gotta watch it happen.
You just... There's nothing else you can do.
There's nothing else you can do.
That's just it.
You think that...
Oh, there we go.
Please don't eat me.
Please.
I beg of you.
Who did he...
I don't know, man.
I don't know.
I...
I don't know, guys.
Oh, yay.
Bogr, man.
Bogr, actually.
Tip him.
What the fuck?
No!
Oh my god.
Bogr...
I...
I heard the mad...
I heard the tilt from Bogr.
Bogr has had enough.
I heard it.
He tilted right there.
I heard him.
He was like...
Oh, man.
He's actually freaking...
Guys, I think...
That poor man.
Oh my god, we should've stopped at 100.
Why didn't I settle at 130?
I'm down!
I can't settle now!
Because I'm even!
I cannot settle now that we're even score.
So many hours.
It's alright.
It's okay.
Maybe we can get...
Wait, is Dosu with anybody?
I'll check.
I don't know.
He usually plays with people.
So I don't know.
I can't tell.
Let me double check.
I could get a third.
Alright, it's...
It's tracking time.
Oh, he's playing with his team.
Wait, no!
Oh yeah, he's playing with...
Is he playing with his team right now?
Oh, they're playing...
They're in the tournament right now.
That's...
Guys, I don't think...
They're actually in a...
He's actually in a tournament right now.
Like, get out of that tournament.
It doesn't matter as much right now.
This is definitely more important.
Alright, I'm gonna use the bath...
Guys, I'm gonna use the bathroom.
It's time for a bathroom break!
Nevermind!
Nevermind.
Shiloh, thank you for tier one-something!
Thank you!
Look how we're just getting EU servers now.
It's alright.
I don't...
Can we ban Luna?
No.
Oh,
we have two Luna players.
We need to ban...
Oh shit, you're right.
We need to ban Wolverine.
Alright.
Or I won't play the game!
Alright, I'm banning Hawkeye.
Oh, fuck this.
Alright.
I guess it's Adam time.
We're not...
Oh.
We're banning Loki?
What the fuck do you mean?
Alright.
Trailblazer, you know you wanna play Mantis.
I'm leaning back now.
I'm so locked in, but I'm leaning back right now.
I'm leaning...
You guys are ready to do this all over again tonight?
Are you guys so excited to do this all over again tonight?
Loki, what?
Oh my god, I'm at the 14 hour mark.
Oh my god.
Loki, please.
I'm gonna hold you off.
I'm joking.
I'm gonna take like...
I might play off stream.
I don't know.
But...
After when I wake up.
But like now...
They have a Jeff.
It's fucking...
Thank god.
Alright, I'm sitting up right.
You can Groot wall for him.
Ooh.
Damn it.
Wait.
That's...
Wait, that's a thing.
That ATP don't work.
Oh my god.
That's so fucking...
That's great.
That's actually good.
Oh my god.
Oh.
I didn't realize that was a thing.
Wait, that's great.
That's actually so fucking funny.
I'm dead.
We're just a poke nation.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Is this winnable?
Nevermind.
I shouldn't have hesitated there.
I hesitated.
Jesus Christ.
I don't know now.
Feels like there's not a few.
Come on.
Please.
Oh my god.
Oh, they went triple support.
Fucking nerds.
I'm killing Rez.
Oh my god.
Rez.
Fuck off.
I'm on the backline.
Oh my god.
There's nothing I can do.
Bucky dead.
Rats stunned.
3, 2, 1.
Oh my god.
I'm coming back.
Bum bum bum.
I soulbonded just myself.
I just soulbonded myself.
That's fine.
I'm so important.
I just...
I accidentally just soulbonded only myself.
This is so bad.
That was such a waste.
I have Rez.
I'm gonna set up.
Oh my god.
I have...
I have a Sylak on me.
Oh.
Alright.
Born again.
I got a Hulk on me.
Alright.
Hulk on, Hulk on.
Nice.
No more Rez.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
Stop.
Stop!
Nice.
Strange, strange one.
I can soulbond.
Let me soulbond!
Strange half.
Strange one.
There's a Sylak though.
Behind.
Oh my god.
Soulbond!
Yeah!
Maybe I'll just be an Adam Warlock for me.
Fuck it.
They always bad Luna anyway.
Maybe I'll just be an Adam Warlock one trick.
Who the fuck cares?
I'm not an Adam player.
Adam is so wet.
I would say that I'm never gonna lose a second round.
I fucking can feel it.
I'm losing it.
God, I'm settling with 100 points.
It went from 200 to 150 to now 100.
I can't.
At least at 100 it's a positive.
It's a positive gain.
I don't need soulbond yet.
Where are we?
Oh my god.
Oh no, I feel scared.
Honestly, I'm scared.
No, I die.
No, I 100% lose.
Nice.
Hit.
He mad.
Oh, that's the key base.
We should go for it.
Will you be okay?
Yeah, you're fine.
I'm healthy, I'm healthy.
Alright, nice.
Nice, nice.
They're TPing, they're TPing.
Push up, push up, push up.
They're TPing.
You can sleep them.
Yeah.
Oh, they TP.
They got TP.
I'm by myself on the TP.
I have the soulbond there.
I'm on it with you.
I'm with it.
Nice.
Bubbles!
Nah, it's fine.
Okay.
I'm cocooning, I'm cocooning, I'm cocooning.
I got Ryze, I got Ryze, I got Ryze.
Okay, I'm dead.
You have mantis heals, you have mantis heals.
It's still winnable, it's winnable.
Oh my god.
I'm an enemy!
Let's go!
I'm fucking running as fast as I can!
I'm the perfect specimen.
Jesus Christ.
Oh.
I'm soulbonding, I'm soulbonding this.
Grut's so low!
There's a Psylocke on point!
Psylocke's on point.
Wait, Grut's one, Grut's one!
I'm one shot.
Enemies, just stay on point.
No supports though, no supports.
We're coming over now.
Yeah, yeah.
If you need us, we're coming over.
I'm soulbonding, I'm soulbonding.
Oh, nevermind.
The Psylocke got me.
Yeah!
Woo!
Oh my god, thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much!
Hello for those who are new here.
My name is Doki Bird.
Sorry, I almost forgot.
And I've been playing Marvel Rivals for a while now.
I'm trying, I usually stream on YouTube, but I'm on Twitch right now.
Cause I'm trying to fucking, trying to fucking get top 500.
I'm so fried.
We were so close to 150 points.
I was like, Doki, and then I'm like, oh, I should say Bird.
Alright, I'm gonna, I'm gonna use the bathroom.
This time for real.
Those people in my games.
I'm not used to seeing morning people.
I'm like, I'm not used to, I'm not used to seeing...
Oh my God.
Do we have a scrolla trick?
I'm not used to seeing all these morning gamers.
It's so weird.
I'm like, who are you?
I can't believe out of the 14 hours of streaming.
I have not bumped into a single streamer that's on my team.
Like, how is that possible?
Like, on my team.
There were so many people.
I meant, like, not on my stack.
It's actually crazy.
That has never happened.
Oh, that's fun.
Do we have a hella player?
We don't?
That's alright.
I should.
I should get dark circles for the grind.
Let me ask my mama right now.
I'm messaging.
Can I get dark circles for my...
Heroes make them safe.
There we go.
I did it.
The scroll pick is about to go crazy.
What is the average rating of this lobby?
What was it?
Poker's in my stack!
It's not the same!
Deathcap.
Deathcap?
Fucking hell.
Zombie.
I need help, I need help, I need help.
Where?
He took the health pack too.
Oh.
He, like, ran at me.
Jesus Christ.
Why did no one help me?
What?
Nobody, what?
Did they all just watch me die?
What the fuck happened?
I just don't know what happened.
Alright.
Oh my god, just...
He's so low.
He's one, he's actually one.
Go on top.
Oh my god.
I can't believe everybody just watched that happen to me.
That was crazy.
Oh my god, the Captain America taking my health pack was so smart though.
Shit.
Okay, I'm trying to...
First one!
Oh my god, I'm coming over.
I'm coming back.
Okay, I actually gotta lock in.
Okay, I'm gonna lock in.
I'm gonna focus for real.
I was not focused there.
What's with my frame?
It feels so sluggish right now.
Alright guys, I need to focus up.
That was some poor gaming there.
I can't see you.
Yeah, I got pulled in.
Oh, door one, door one!
I froze.
I got him.
I have Captain America on me.
I had to ult.
Oh, I didn't know you ulted.
I'll damage boost you.
What's on top right?
That was mine, but I didn't know you ulted.
Alright, let me Luna ult first.
She's half, she's half.
Usually Loki is second, so I never expect a Loki ult.
That's why I was not expecting it.
Loki ult is always second.
Definitely.
Because it's harder...
Behind us, behind me, behind me!
I'm on cap, I'm on cap.
Cap's done.
Jesus Christ.
Thor half, Thor low, Thor low, Thor low.
Thor, Thor, Thor.
Thor low, Thor, Thor, Thor.
Captain America half.
You're fucking healed!
Stop complaining, I'm sad.
I think Hela's in Arcade.
I'm actually so locked in now.
Thor behind.
I have one.
Thor's behind, I'm gonna ult this.
We're backing on 3, 2, 1.
Thor still.
I've frozen, I've frozen!
Mid ult!
He's still gonna have his ult.
Guys, where was the...
I have a Captain America on me.
I'm stunned, I'm stunned, I'm hooked.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
Hela's one, Hela's one.
Thor and Thor's behind us.
Captain America low, low, low.
Captain America one.
Kepler, Kepler.
He's healed, he's healed.
Oh my god.
Thank you for saying nice freeze, it means a lot guys.
After everything I went through, thank you so much.
Oh my god.
Thor has ult.
It's fine.
Hela's one HP.
I feel so locked in.
Thank you for ego boosting me.
I need it.
I told you I could lock in.
Guys, I told you.
I told you I could...
Oh no!
I'm still locked in, but I can't save him.
I was locked in, but what can I do about that?
Thor is behind, Thor is behind.
I froze him again.
I had to...
I got you, I got you, I got you.
They're almost dead.
I'm hoping after.
Thor, Thor, Thor, Thor.
I hate looking up.
No more supports.
I have to reload.
Lunar top right.
We have a pick, we have a pick.
Thor on the bridge.
I froze somebody, I don't know who.
I have Captain America on me.
I'm dead.
Oh my god.
I don't think we get that.
No, we have to fight second point.
Oh, that was so close.
I don't think we can touch that.
I'm regrouping.
Help, help, help.
There's two tanks in there.
I froze him.
He wasted ult.
They have night ult.
Nice, nice.
We got two, we got two.
We should push up.
Hold on, hold on.
I'm trying to keep you up.
I hear people behind us.
Yeah, Thor's behind us.
Thor's behind our Loki.
Get him, get him, get him.
He's stunned.
He's stunned again.
Nice, Captain America.
We have Vlad's last fight.
Someone might have ult.
I am ready to put on a show.
I'm on my health.
I'm ulting this, I'm ulting.
Both tanks are on us.
Oh, nice, DC9.
Oh, my god.
I played out of my mind there, guys.
I might have fucked up in the beginning, but I played out of my mind later on.
I fucking shut down their Thor so many times.
I locked the fucking...
Thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you, thank you.
I did it.
Girl, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the Twitch prize.
It's 14 hours.
I told you, Luna's like...
I can fucking play Luna, like, on autopilot.
Like, when you play...
It's not like, you know, like in Apex, I just talk while I play.
Because I just go autopilot at that point.
I just, like...
I play so much that, like, I can play them, like...
I don't have to, like...
I'm locked in, but I don't have to, like...
Think too much.
Because she's so, like...
She's so easy.
She's such an easy character to master.
What's my healing at?
28k.
It's only been on Bogr.
I usually put the snowflake on whoever I'm playing with.
No thoughts, just heals.
Guys, it's gonna be over in four more days, guys.
I swear to God.
It's gonna be over in four more days, guys.
It's gonna be over soon.
I froze Captain America.
Captain America low.
Torb, Torb, Torb.
We should push up.
I'm looking at Luna on point.
Luna, half.
Go point, go point.
We should go point, we should go point.
We have two picks.
Kept out, kept out.
I froze Strange.
Strange is low, Strange is low.
Strange is one.
Actually one, actually one.
RK two, RK two.
Low, low.
They got out.
Yippee.
Oh, we should go to Bastion.
That's fucking right, go to freezes.
That's right!
Enable me!
I'm fucking gaming!
They can't stop me.
Wait, they are.
What?
They are going three things.
Oh my God!
Wait,
he's low.
I can't.
Oh, I stunned him.
Nice, nice.
Oh, you're so, you're so healthy.
They're so low, they're so low.
They're really low.
Kept out, kept out.
Torb one, Torb one, Torb one.
Oh.
Nice, nice, nice.
Keep three or two on points.
Oh my God.
This is so easy.
Best Storm NA?
Ooh.
That would've been so cool if it hit, you know?
I don't think they're gonna, yeah, they're not gonna contest.
Yeah, I'm pushed.
Unless...
I'll go.
I'm damage boosting.
Torb, Torb, Torb.
Torb?
He's half, he's one.
Oh!
Nice, nice, left, nice, left.
Strange is low, Strange.
Oh my God.
Nice, nice, nice.
What?
Kill her.
Okay.
Okay?
Same, buddy.
Same.
Yay!
I'm here too.
I take those.
I fucking take those.
You're against bots to make streamers feel better?
What a sad game!
Oh!
I wish that were true because this guy's a real person.
This guy's a real person.
These guys are real people.
Oh my God, okay, but we'll do what, guys?
Okay, but what if we win another one and then we're 130, guys?
Actual paid actors.
I'm sorry to say, but I know this guy's real.
If anything, I know this guy.
Guys, okay, but what if we win the next game, though, guys?
Guys, okay, but if we win the next game, we'll be 130.
And that's almost like 150, though.
Guys, I'm all in.
All in.
Let's go gambling.
Guys, this is where the win streak is.
I believe.
It's true.
150 is 50.
Oh my.
150 is 50 off.
Oh shit, okay.
Okay, maybe it was a little bit of a mistake.
Okay, wait.
Wait.
Oh no, wait.
We have a magic one trick and a Captain America one trick.
I think we need Captain America.
Yeah, I'm down to New Cap.
You want me on Cap?
I mean, you can ban something else if you want.
I mean, guys, you have your choices right now.
You can choose.
Oh no.
You're the EU prodigy, buddy.
What's your call on it, man?
Oh man.
What's the EU Aura Maxers saying?
Part of me says that we should ban Hawkeye, but a second part of me says...
I can't lie to you.
I know that guy that wants magic.
He low-key might be the best magic in the game.
Wait, what?
This might...
It's gonna flip.
Fucking weebo.
I told you, I told you.
No, you fuck you.
You fucking piece of...
Who did that?
I didn't vote, buddy.
Who did it?
Who could have...
Who could have done something like that?
Oh man, I think we're gonna lose because of me.
The demons, Doki.
They're taking over.
If we die to magic, even one fight, Doki.
It's on you.
Wait, I didn't do it.
I cannot believe that Nightmare lost to me, Tei.
That's diabolical.
The guy that we accused of cheating, Tei.
He's from the team that won the NA tournament, Doki.
Yeah.
Wait, I didn't accuse him.
I didn't accuse him.
You particularly accused him.
No, no, I was like, let's invite him.
I said, let's invite him.
This could have been over, we got Rosa.
But if we had the easy way, then we would not have learned the hard way.
I froze somebody.
Can you top me off, real quick?
My new one!
He's focusing the E-spark on him.
Just have magic there.
There he is.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Guys.
Guys, I think I fucked up.
Guys,
I might have fucked up, guys.
Guys.
I might have fucked up.
I think we just gotta win another one after this, guys.
We mantis ult first.
Save our Magnia.
Okay.
That's...
Guys, I might have fucked up.
My mantis was low.
Guys, I might have fucked up, guys.
Guys, I might have fucked up.
I might have fucked up.
I didn't know!
I just...
I always ban Hawkeye!
How is this my fault?
I ban Hawkeye before they said anything.
That's not me.
Bob, thank you for the 2,500 bitties.
Okay.
All they said was they had a magic one trick.
And I was like, who the fuck cares about magic?
I'm getting Hawkeye.
And then after I banned Hawkeye, he was like, might be the best magic player I've ever seen.
And I was like, oh.
Oh, okay.
We're just keeping the game interesting, guys.
Honestly, who would have thought?
Alright, wait, there we go.
I'm never banning again, guys.
I've learned.
Please, somebody else shoot the thing!
What?
How did I get down here?
Oh, we win this, we win this, we win this.
Oh, look who won, look who won.
I'm on head to point.
I'm on point.
I can't see you.
Yeah, sorry about that.
Oh, man.
Okay, that's... yeah, that's a little overconfident.
Nice kill, nice kill.
Play with our Hela.
Fuck with our Hela.
Damage boost our Hela.
Give her everything.
She will carry this game.
You don't need me.
Fuck with our Hela, bro.
She's everything, she's God.
Oh my God.
Just damage boost only Hela.
Damage boost only Hela, I don't care.
Kill her, damage boost her, pocket her, shield her.
Fucking mantis ult her.
Okay, okay, I'll make sure she won't die.
Mantis ult first, though.
Oh, they're gonna...
They're going point, they're going point.
Yo, I'm gonna whale your Shango, okay?
I'm dropping a whale on your Shango.
Oh, they fucking broke my platform.
But I won.
He's low, he's low, he's so low.
I won, I won.
He's still really low, he's still low.
I will be safe.
Got him, got him, got him.
I can't.
I'm trying to get the Hela.
Okay, okay.
Okay, that was really funny.
I can't, I'm not even...
It's not, like, sleep deprived funny.
It's like, okay, I...
Okay, okay.
It's actually...
I'm gonna ult this.
If you wanna be safe, please stay on the point.
Okay.
5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Oh, man.
Oh, they got it halfway.
That's funny.
I thought it would do...
I
legitimately thought it would block the meteorite.
I thought it would block it.
I don't know.
I just thought...
I didn't get a chance.
Oh, my God.
3, 2, 1.
Was it a pillar or a giant metal ball?
I didn't know.
I legitimately thought I'd be safe.
I thought it would block it.
Magic, magic, magic.
I think it's under stat...
Oh, it's fine, we're even.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I'm dropping point, I'm dropping point.
Behind us, Magic.
Magic is on me.
Pocket our healer, pocket our healer.
I don't care what's happening.
Give her everything.
I'm pocketing.
She is so pocketed!
If you have to die, if you have to die, you have to die.
Just pocket it.
She's alive!
Sacrifice.
Sacrifice yourself.
Wait, there's a...
There's a healer back there.
Don't worry, I got you.
Thank you.
I'm with you, bro.
Hey, Mantis, can you look at me real quick?
I need heals, thank you.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna get them.
They have a name warner now.
It's fine, it's fine.
I'm gonna go behind them, I'm gonna go behind them.
They won't expect it.
They're one, they're one.
They're all one, they're all one.
All one.
I can't fight this.
I'm out, I'm out, I'm out.
Don't worry, you'll live!
You're so alive.
Hella, hella, hella, hella, hella, hella.
Let's kill this Hella.
Hold the choke, hold the choke, hold the choke.
Death Strangler, nice.
Protect.
No, don't let our Hella die!
He was one.
I'm asleep.
I woke you up.
I didn't see Strange.
I hear someone behind me.
I think they're walking downstairs.
I'm backing up, I'm backing up.
Yep, there he is!
I mean, I killed you guys.
It's all good, it's all good.
It's fine.
Also, yes, if you ever see me, please ban Hella.
I don't like playing this character.
Listen, you, Starlord, need to go flank.
With your ult.
And not die.
And press the button.
Or ult and sub tank.
No, we don't need a tank.
We don't need a tank.
We can just win with this.
I'm asleep.
My shield is down.
Left side, left side.
There's one.
I have to reload.
I have ult here.
I'm going, I'm going.
That's fine, we're even.
Dropping point, dropping point.
I got him, I got him.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Change, change, change.
Nice, good job.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we did it.
I get near site and explode.
It's terrible.
Oh my god.
I'm settling with this.
I don't think we can get better games.
I'm settling, I'm settling.
I'm settling.
Really?
Wow.
Oh my god, he sees.
He's fucking pushing my buttons.
He knows what to say.
Okay, again.
Let's go, let's go again.
He knows what to say.
It's okay.
I'm too easy to influence.
Thank you for the 10 subs.
Thank you, thank you.
I folded so easily.
I can...
I can fold.
Yes!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god.
I didn't even...
Okay, I didn't ask my mom.
I didn't even ask my...
My papa for this.
And...
They are...
They...
Oh my god, I don't know if they're actually watching this.
They already finished it.
They already made it.
Oh my god.
And then they messaged us like...
What was it?
22 hours ago.
Yes.
That's perfect.
It was messaged...
No, it was messaged like an hour ago.
Oh my god.
They're like, good luck with the grind.
I love Marvel Rivals.
Listen.
This might be a team comp of all time.
Listen, unironically, unironically.
What if we ban Luna and we play Mantis Adam?
And we explode.
Actually, no.
Ban Hulk.
Revolutionary.
Wait, you don't have to ban Hulk.
I play Iron Man.
No, no, no Hulk.
Hawkeye.
Oh my god, here we go.
Are you banning Star-Lord?
Or did you pick him?
I'm a Star-Lord player.
What happened to Psylocke?
I'm banning Hela.
Yeah, what happened to Psylocke, SK?
SK is ignoring us.
What?
Can you not hear me?
We have Psylocke!
We have Psylocke open.
Oh my god.
This is it.
Dr. Big Smack.
Please don't scream.
I'm gonna mute you.
What a fucking loser.
I just said we have Psy...
What?
I just said we have Psylocke.
What the fuck?
Oh, I'm sorry for showing emotions.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for showing fucking emotions in my games.
I just...
You know what I'd like to do on stream?
If they don't keep you.
You know like the thing where you're like here for the other stream to keep you, but they don't?
Yeah, like...
I just like to place the portals right in front of them when we're about to fight to ruin their frames.
Okay, I'll walk.
I'll walk.
I'm gonna walk.
Guys, this is it.
If I had a game where I did that, I might...
Maybe, maybe we'll make it.
Maybe we'll make it.
You should be ripping yourself more than the other team.
Oh my god.
That's much stranger.
I didn't think they would keep me.
Okay, I can do this.
Wait, this is EU.
This is EU.
Confuse them.
What I'd like to do is do both portals in front of them.
They're walking behind us.
Wait.
Wait, I'm in EU.
Change on.
Change is on us.
Oh my god.
Change health.
I need reload.
Change is on us again.
I need help, I need help.
Change one.
He's low, he's low, but I'm really low too.
I'm changing a bit.
I'm gonna go Quinn.
Okay.
I have change on me all.
Change is still on me.
What happened to my Adam?
Adam!
How did you fall?
How did you fall down?
I forgot about C.
Oh my god, you're right guys.
I have C.
I forgot I had a fucking Iron Fist because it felt like he never existed in my game.
It didn't feel like he was a person.
Sorry, it's hard to realize he exists when it feels like he does nothing.
He contributes nothing.
I don't know guys.
Sometimes I forget they're real people.
Green?
Green.
Fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear.
I'm ulting this.
Oh, we're so alive.
I'm pushing up.
Get predicted!
God, I'm fucking so good at video games.
I should get the mag.
Mag is awesome.
Awesome.
Nice goal.
Oh my god.
The most humble streamer right there.
Did you guys see that?
What?
Oh, TP, TP bot!
Dude, it's fine.
I have Magneto on me.
I died.
Oh my god.
Guys, I pressed C.
Did you guys see that?
I did it, guys.
I pressed C.
Did you guys see that?
I know, it's crazy.
I did the thing.
We're so bonded.
I throw a Psylocke behind us.
Oh no!
Not with a bolt.
No!
Okay, okay, okay.
Adam, do you play?
No, not Adam.
It's fine to spend.
I think it's fine.
Yeah, it is fine.
Alright, time to go no more.
Yeah, that's good.
We should do that.
Oh no.
Alright, everything will be okay.
Okay, but what if it will be different?
It could be different.
It will be different, guys.
It will be different.
It can be different.
I'm traumatized in the situation I'm in.
They swamped you.
I'm ulting.
How?
I got nobody.
I got somebody.
Fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear.
I need a big ult.
I have Magnius behind me.
Magnius one, Magnius one.
He's so low.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
You got this, guys.
I'm really low, though.
I'm like one hit.
He's already dead, by the way.
Oh my god.
Where's my other support?
Do they exist?
Are they with me?
They have strange ult.
Strange ult.
There's Namor behind you.
Namor's behind.
Change health.
Change one, change one.
Health, health, health.
1 HP, 1 HP.
1 HP, 1 HP, 1 HP.
Namor's behind us again.
Nice.
Namor's behind us.
I have Psylocke.
Psylocke is doing this.
I'm having health.
Namor's one.
Pushing in, pushing in.
We need to help.
We need to help SK after this.
I need heal from Namor.
I got both.
I'm about to ult this.
Yeah, yeah.
Go, go, go.
We win this.
Go on support, I think.
Namor's right.
I got one, I got one.
3, 2, 1.
I'm dead here.
Do we have item ult?
Oh, it's coming.
I got one.
Our item's getting harassed by Psylocke.
We need to die.
I'm one, I'm one, I'm one, I'm one.
Alright, alright.
Yeah, it's fine.
Oh, we're low key stunned.
Namor is half, Namor is half.
We have a lot of movement.
We need to touch, we need to touch.
I'm touching, I'm touching.
Namor's dead.
I'm dead though.
I'm coming back.
I'm almost there, I'm almost there.
We might need rez here.
I'm here, I'm here.
I can stay on point.
Tracer's pushing in.
Low key, low key.
I'm here.
Tracer, Tracer, Tracer, Tracer.
Tracer's half.
I have to reload.
They're half, they're half.
Tank's half.
Oh my god.
Our...
No.
Our item.
No, winnable, winnable, winnable, winnable.
That's all I'll say.
I saw our item.
I keep trying to kill a Psylocke for 20 years.
No you didn't, you fucking liar.
I spectated you, you fucking liar.
Isaac, you're such a fucking liar.
You're such a liar.
Now we all have someone to blame.
Call him out.
The lies people tell.
I fucking saw what you did.
You're a liar.
You're such a liar.
He could...
He could run.
I ran.
I saw what you did last summer.
I know what you were.
Oh my god.
Psylocke's inting.
Jesus Christ.
Jesus Christ, okay.
Ivan, they're more behind us.
They're more still behind us.
I'm arched, man.
I'm dead.
Trained one.
Oh my god.
Our item's gonna die.
Okay.
How did we just let him do that?
How did we just...
Guys.
How did we just let him do that?
How?
I froze him.
Will we be...
I don't think we'll be okay.
I don't...
Guys, I...
I don't think we'll be okay.
I...
This is not it.
This...
Guys.
I wanna save my ult for after they win ult.
I think.
Was that even me?
What does that even mean?
I think you have to build up.
Build up for 15...
Our 15...
Oh, that would've been so cool if I hit that.
That was literally like...
Hell Mary.
That would've been so cool.
Ooh.
Oh!
They broke the bridge!
I helped.
We could win this.
No.
Alright, here we go.
Change one.
Oh, you can ult after this one.
Fear.
Still fear.
TB!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Hello, everybody!
Alright.
Here I go again.
Okay.
Wait, we didn't even get a tick?
Guys, I just...
Well...
I blame my...
I blame my Adam.
My Adam.
That's why I'm...
We saw what our Adam did.
We...
We saw...
We saw our Adam.
The fuck is that ping?
Welcome to EU.
What was that Adam doing?
Oh yeah, I'm fucking avoiding that Adam.
That...
He was like...
I just kept dying to Magneto.
I'm like, no, I saw what happened.
I saw what you did, Adam.
Don't fucking lie to me, Adam.
I...
I was there.
You thought nobody would spectate you.
Well, too bad.
I died.
I saw what happened.
I saw you fight that Psylocke for like...
Three whole minutes.
I...
Now everybody knows.
How cooked am I?
I...
Maybe we should call it a hundred.
Maybe we should call it...
Maybe we should call it at a hundred.
I'm at a hundred and thirteen.
What is this?
Okay, so a hundred.
Is that...
Oh wait, no.
JK, I'm at a hundred and five.
We...
We did it.
Oh my god, we did it!
We...
We did it, guys.
We made it.
I do not have five points to spend.
Oh my god.
I can't.
What if we lose it?
What if we lose it, though?
We go again later today slash your tomorrow.
Oh, never mind.
Let's...
Let's go.
We got a third.
No, let's freaking go.
Let me...
Let me walk my dog first.
Wait.
Give me ten minutes.
Guys, I'm walking my dog.
I'm walking my dog.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'll be right back.
Walking my dog.
Give me...
Be right back.
I'm dumb.
I'm so easy to manipulate.
I'll be right back.
Alright, I'm back.
I'm...
I'm back.
How was the circus?
How was it, everybody?
Did you guys have a great time at the circus?
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm back.
I have 351 points.
We're gonna make sure you lose one above all.
Okay.
Okay, no.
How long would Q's even be?
How...
Bro, okay.
If I was at 350, I'd be fucking out.
I don't install Marvel Rivals.
What the hell?
I...
Marvel Rivals is...
It's gonna be uninstalled if I had 350, guys.
What the fuck?
Alright.
Are we waiting for Bulgar?
It's okay, guys.
I believe.
Yes.
Yes, he has been walked.
I've hit my third win.
I didn't think it'd be possible.
But I...
I've hit my third win.
I legitimately did not think I could actually do that.
Third.
Also, if you guys have been watching the past 15 hours, please head to bed.
You're not crazy as me right now.
I'm literally going through pure adrenaline right now.
Pure rank adrenaline.
And like...
Madigan...
Shit!
Yes.
I'm locked in.
I'm locked up.
Legitimately.
Madic energy right now.
And I keep going.
I need the win.
Please head to bed if you're tired.
If you're tired and...
And you need sleep.
Take sleep.
Guys...
Don't...
Don't do this to yourself.
Don't be like me.
Oh my god, guys!
Oh, never mind.
We were...
I had to walk my dog.
But we were the number one Marvel rival stream.
For a second.
We were there!
Oh my god, I'm actually proud of us.
I'm actually so happy.
Wow.
Alright, how long would the queues be though?
To be fair.
We were there!
We were the number one Marvel rival stream!
Everybody...
I hope everybody saw that fucker nubs.
I...
I'm not over it.
I'm not over...
I hope we all saw that.
I hope we all saw that guy.
Fuck that guy.
I hope he...
I hope he realizes I'm a streamer.
And then he reads the chat history.
And then he has a good rest of his Sunday.
And I hope that he has a good rest of his Sunday.
That's all I wish for him.
That's all.
You know.
I hope he has a good Sunday after that.
I hope he has a great day.
Keep himself safe.
Nubs was like 8!
Don't say that.
No, there's no way he was...
No.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
It was not 8 hours ago.
I still refuse to believe it.
Guys, I touched grass.
You cannot say I didn't touch grass.
I did it.
Games can't be this bad now, right?
Right?
There's no way.
Now that Helios is on his main account.
It can't get worse.
You know, I think top 16...
That's way too high.
We should take him down to top 100.
But like not...
Not like, you know, purposely or anything.
You know?
Not on purpose.
Just...
It could be a little funny.
We all suffer together.
One thing.
It could be a little funny.
But then we'll give him back top 16 too.
Alright, let's see how these games are gonna...
Why?
Why is there a GM 1 and 3?
Why is there a GM 3 in our lobby?
This guy... We have a top 16!
How did he get in here?
Oh, he must be dueling with...
He must be dueling with an attorney player.
There's no way he has to be dueling with somebody in here.
Who's not loaded in?
It's this guy.
MRC Champion.
Oh, did they win?
Did Helios' team win?
Oh my god!
Helios, what the fuck?
Where's the carry?
I'm joking.
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
If we don't ban it, then Toki might eat the record.
I can go Magneto.
Oh my god, Helios is...
Bro, you can't say that!
For the flowers!
Guys, we should try to be nice to the people that play with us right now.
If we want this to end, we gotta...
Try to be nice to the people that's gonna take us to the end.
We got this.
We don't want it to...
Young, thank you for the tier 1 sub.
Thank you.
Thank you for the tier 1 sub too.
For fuck's sake, thank you for the tier 1 sub.
I really appreciate it.
Oh my god, maybe this time it'll work.
It's okay guys, I'm going on my third wind.
I'm on my magic energy third wind.
Do you play... do you play sick... not so... what?
Strange?
Do you play Strange?
Me?
Yeah, you.
No, no, I'm supposed to be sucking with Strange.
Okay, okay, you are the mad guy.
It's fine though, Magic is okay by me.
I'm not the mad guy.
I'm not the mad guy, it's the minor.
It's not Doom queuing if we're winning!
I just mean...
By like two games, we're up two games.
Guys, I know it's been 15 hours and we're up two games and it might not be the best record ever.
But like...
We're still up.
We're still up, guys.
You have Iron Man 2, no?
No, we're up two games.
I still feel nothing about this on my side.
So I'm probably gonna have a big lag and can play for maybe... 56?
That's insane.
Okay.
So...
It's already cast.
Sorry, boys.
Actually, I see absolutely no one.
Oh...
You're a turret, you're a turret, okay?
That's awkward.
That's...
Ooh...
That's awkward.
That's...
I...
I healed our cloak.
I don't know if you saw that, but...
But our cloak...
Got healed as much as he was possible.
I...
Honestly, I respect it.
We still play though.
Oh my god.
I'm a little worried here.
Oh!
Yay!
We did it.
No, no, no.
That can't be a sign, right?
That can't be a sign.
There's no way.
There's no...
That's not God sending me a message that I should stop.
That's... no.
If he really wanted me to stop...
He would make sure the next game would be a DC too.
But like, in the beginning, so I don't lose anything.
So like...
If it really was a message from above, a divine intervention, then...
Then, it would happen a second time.
The first time...
The first time is just coincidence.
The second time, then maybe something is weird.
Is it the same people or different?
Okay, this looks a little better.
This looks a little better.
I feel so confident.
Get out.
Cool,
am I gonna vanish for this match?
I don't know those people too much.
But, they probably ban the crazy characters.
Alright, can't be that bad.
Can't be that bad.
Oh my.
Yeah, that's what I like to see.
They ban Hela.
Slowly maxing?
Yeah, but we cannot risk it.
Who's...
Are they min-maxing?
The editing team?
No.
I'm definitely not min-maxing right now.
I'm not.
Alright, here we go again.
Guys.
They said this is a little better.
Alright, this is alright.
I can fuck with this.
What can go wrong?
Absolutely nothing.
Nothing can go wrong.
If there is another divine intervention, he will do it again.
What?
Oh, they'll think he's Spider-Man.
Oh.
Wait, I think they're gonna...
That's fucked.
That's so fucked.
Alright, let's go.
She appreciates it.
Wait.
Wait, did he...
Wait, who said that?
I think you should put E on...
Wait, did he say...
Oh, he was my fan?
I don't expect that.
He said he was my fan?
I was...
Oh, nice.
Any heals?
I'm pushing in, I'm pushing in.
I'm not there.
Look at mine, look at mine, look at mine.
There's a Psylocke...
Oh, no, Starlord behind us.
Oh, I'm dead.
I froze...
Fiend.
There's a...
Manny!
There's a Starlord behind us.
Can you put me in the smoke later, Ducky?
Yeah, I got you, I got you.
Thank you.
I'm gonna get top ward.
Alright, here we go!
Look in now, look in now.
Mag, mag, mag, mag, mag, mag, mag, mag!
Nice.
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
I'm back, I'm back, I'm back.
Oh...
I'm pushing, I'm pushing.
I'm very low.
When I say so, we should push up.
I'm low though, I'm really low.
That was a great vision, I love it.
Oh my god, we did it.
Guys, we're gonna... we're gonna break this purgatory.
I'll try and do an ult there, Starlord ult.
Mercy, Mercy, Mercy!
I'm tanking, I'm tanking, I'm tanking.
My shield is broke, I'm gonna die.
Alright, here we go.
We have a dam, we have a dam, we have a dam, we have a dam, we have a dam, we have a dam.
So... 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
I froze.
He's down on point.
I... I don't know what Adam's vision was.
The Adam's vision was... I don't know what he was thinking.
That was... that was very ambitious, that's for sure.
I froze.
I froze Train.
I'm with you, I'm with you, I'm with you.
We got it, thanks.
I need a load, I need a load.
There's... I have two people on me!
Oh no, this is last fight.
Let's go, we'll win, we... me and you, me and you.
Okay.
Oh, come, come, come.
No point, no point.
Oh, come on.
Oh, nice.
I'm ulting bot.
Point, point, point, point, point, point.
No more still hides.
No more and Starlord.
One more, one, one.
That's fine, that's fine.
Oh, he did not need a cocoon.
He... what a waste of a cocoon.
I'll take... I'll take that one.
I don't know why he cocooned there.
I should have been like, no cocoon!
I should have yelled that at him.
I can ult them, maybe.
Yeah, I'm waiting, I'm waiting.
I hit him, I hit him.
He's good, he's good, he's good.
Oh, our mantis.
Oh, we have to proc.
He's got beam, Starlord.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
It's kinda bad.
Okay, let's push this one.
Yeah, R.
I trolled.
Okay, I think we... this is not working.
We switch up the comp.
What did we swap off?
What?
We have three support players.
We have three support players, but...
Also, I...
Why did Arad have to use his cocoon there?
Like, I'm like, we won the fight.
Yeah, three support works, but like...
Yeah, but just...
Yeah.
We need to play more together.
I feel like...
I feel like it's hard to...
Okay.
It'll be fine.
Guys, I believe in us.
Oh, thank god.
Oh, thank god he swapped off Adam.
I just... I don't think Adam is his character.
As a certified Adam player...
With a very positive win rate on Adam, I could tell that...
He was just not...
He was just not an Adam player.
Just...
You know, he could have done some things differently, you know, guys?
I'm on,
I'm on, I'm on, I'm on, I'm on!
Oh, he...
That's unfortunate.
I have...
I have no more on me.
I'm on, I'm on, I'm on.
Oh!
I couldn't do anything!
No more fuck me up!
I pressed Q!
I can't believe it.
I'm coming over.
Oh, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Alright, next fight I go in.
Alright.
It's just very unfortunate.
We just have a very, very unfortunate team right here.
Alright, this is it.
I go in with my ult and maybe we'll live?
Maybe we'll live?
Right, guys?
We'll live, I believe.
I think we can live.
Nice, let's go.
There's a Starlord behind us.
Starlord has ult.
He's right behind us.
He's looking for it.
He's going for it.
He can come for it.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
I'm a little worried about the Starlord ult.
Are we up top?
I'm on him.
I'm aiming him.
He's up.
I think we should stop chasing.
A little bit.
Just a little bit.
Thank you.
I hear Starlord above us.
There it is.
Yeah, they did.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Is he gonna live?
Oh, he's not.
I saw a whole fucking army.
Oh my god.
That was a whole army right there.
No, he's letting me.
Starlord on the right.
Oh, he pushed me.
That's so bad.
Okay.
That's cool.
Guys, it's just...
It's just that wasn't the game.
I'm the champion!
Oh my god.
No, don't say that, guys.
He has...
Guys, don't say that.
He won the tournament, guys.
Guys!
It's not Doom queuing.
Not my tournament.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're gonna settle.
We're gonna settle.
I'm settling at 100.
I'm gonna settle at 100.
I just need one more win and then we'll be fine.
It was a gold tournament?
It's like the full tournament, isn't it?
Isn't that the tournament that we had?
That's been going on for like two weeks now?
Wasn't that the tournament?
We just need one win.
We literally just need one.
I'm settling at...
I'm not settling at 80.
I refuse to settle...
I refuse to settle at 80.
I'm settling...
I'm settling at 100.
I just need one win.
And then I'll be happy.
And then I'll do it all over again!
Tonight!
Yippee!
Helios is like...
Helios is like, oh man.
It's over.
Just one more win.
I should have settled at 30.
Why did I...
I should have settled at 130.
Why did I ever convince me to go again?
I'm just so fucking...
Oh my god.
I'm so easily manipulable.
We could have stopped at 130.
I'm just so easily convinced.
I'm so...
Oh my god.
I never learn.
I just never learn.
Guys, I never fucking learn.
How do we have another person?
How do we keep getting more people?
What's this guy?
Who is he?
How do we adopt a third...
Ow.
When did this person show up?
Stop that.
Wait, he's winning.
Oh my god.
How did this third person showed up?
I'm so confused.
Where did he come from?
I miss Rosa.
I...
I don't know how they keep showing up.
I'm gonna break his streak.
Just like how I broke Ulysses' streak.
No longer chops.
No longer...
But like, not intentionally though.
It was not intentionally.
Herder into the madness.
I'm most likely there today.
I'm gonna play off stream later today.
I don't think I can do another long stream.
Today.
I don't...
Guys, do not camp out on my stream for today.
I'm gonna go sleep.
And then we're gonna do it all over again.
But like, I'm gonna do it off stream.
I'm gonna do it off stream.
What's the point?
I don't know.
I can't keep up with the manic energy on the nut again later.
I'm on my third win.
And can't keep doing this.
What's the point?
Think of the ad revenue.
Thanks for reminding me to have some ads.
Here, I have a 30 second ad.
Here's a 30 second ad.
Think of the ad revenue.
Real shit.
Thank you, I needed the reminder.
I can't wait to do this all over again.
But like, off stream.
Oh my god.
I feel like people watching me are watching me for like...
The descent into madness.
They're watching my descent into fucking madness here.
I cannot stream a nut.
I can't, guys.
I cannot.
I cannot, guys.
Guys, I'm literally settling.
Alright,
here we go.
I'm gonna lock in.
If we win this, we're free.
I should've fucking...
Guys, I don't know what was wrong with me.
Why did I not stop at 130?
Why did I let him convince me?
I...
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna lock in so hard.
Why, guys?
Why did you not stop me?
Why?
That's fine.
We tried.
No, I don't think I remember that.
I don't think I remember that.
We could've stopped at a nice 130.
Right there.
It's because you're a motherfucker.
Wait, did we have Mantis Ban?
Oh, we did.
Okay, I was gonna say...
Like, what's wrong with us?
We'll be fine.
We'll do this all over again.
One win.
Let's bring it home.
Booger's like, free me.
Booger, you did this.
We could've ended this so long ago.
I'm pushing the cart.
Break walls, break walls.
I'm walled off, I'm walled off.
Shit, shit, shit.
I'm shooting the walls.
Magnia's half.
Mike half, Mike half.
He has no...
You're walled off, you're walled off.
You're walled off.
One win.
You're walled off right now.
Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike.
Bye, guys.
I know what ult we have.
Just send it.
I froze him, I froze him.
Don't do anything to him.
No!
We need to win this one.
Who woke him up?
Got him, got him.
I'm coming back.
There's a Groot on our support.
One win, one win, one win.
We'll be free.
Doki, one win.
We could do it.
We could have stopped four games ago.
Listen, but we became better players.
Damn, I don't feel better.
We became better, we became better.
Heal us, rage, quit on us, what do you mean?
It's a one win though.
Oh my god, max one, max one.
One win, one win.
Doki, I want all of your energy right now.
I'm locked in.
I'm locked in with 180 ping, what do you want from me?
I want you, I want everyone.
Max, max energy.
One win.
You're locked, you're walled off, you're walled off.
I have my ult, watch this.
The one win.
Let's go.
Behind us, behind us, behind us, behind us, behind us.
Oh my god, I'm so low, please.
Please, I just needed a little heals.
Bruno's so low.
Oh, nevermind.
I know.
I think I inted.
I'm dodging in W.
I have TP, I have TP.
I'm coming back.
We win this, we win this.
Yeah, we got them.
He missed, he missed, he missed, he missed.
Oh.
Wait, wait, they still ulted, they still ulted.
I have one ping, one ping.
They danced.
I'm TPing, I'm TPing, I'm TPing, I'm TPing.
I have to reload.
One win, one win.
Go in, go in, go in with this.
Oh.
One win, one win.
Go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Go top.
One win.
Oh my god.
We're so...
We're doing it.
Oh, I'm pushing up.
Oh.
I...
I don't know what the plan was.
I can't even keep track of ults anymore.
Like, if something happened, it's just gonna happen.
Like...
I don't know.
If it happens, it happens.
I'm not even keeping track anymore.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting this.
Yay.
I'm pushing up, I'm pushing up.
Oh.
I'm pushing up, pushing up.
Oh my god.
I'm backing up a little.
Oh, I...
I don't know if we lived this.
Wait, did Luna ulted?
Oh my god.
They...
Luna ulted, so...
They don't have any split ults.
They just ulted.
Listen.
We get the lamp.
We get the lamp out.
Then Rek'Sai Nation does the rest.
I'm pushing this root.
Pray the wolves.
Use everything.
Yeah, I'm trying my best, but...
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh, yeah, you were taking a lot of damage.
We don't go there.
Go main.
We go main.
I won't group up.
Alright.
Walled off again.
Push this.
Help him.
Push the back lane.
Magneo's half.
Magneo's low.
Oh my god.
No.
No!
I'm down.
It's fine.
I got Magneo ulted.
They have another?
Oh my god.
Fear.
Actual fear.
He's low.
He's one.
I'm healing as much as I can.
I don't care.
Alright.
I'm moving up.
Can we get the turret?
But that's alright.
I guess we don't care.
I froze somebody.
I have a Magneo on me.
I need help.
Magneo's still on me.
Oh my god.
Come on, come on, come on.
I'm pushing the cart a little bit.
I don't know if I can save it.
You can, you can.
We need to play slow here.
We must have ults.
Magneo ult.
Oh.
Top.
Walled off for me.
We win this Rixi.
You and me, buddy.
We need to kill the backline.
Trying to get you.
We need to play for W.
I don't know if I can get it now.
I can't.
Oh.
I was 5% off.
Oh my god.
I was 5% off from that.
1 win.
No, it wasn't the other Luna.
It was their Loki.
Their Loki copied their Luna.
So it wasn't like the Luna just fucking got it all after one fight.
And then Rixi has a res.
And then it's really annoying for them.
If you can play Adam.
Oh my god.
Oh.
I can play Adam.
You play Luna?
No, no, no, no.
You stay Luna.
Okay.
No, no, no.
Adam is good.
He wants to play Luna.
And you go Adam.
Yeah.
But get the Luna.
You want to go duple support or something?
No, no, no.
Alright.
Okay.
Awesome.
Alright, here we go.
It's Adam time.
Let's go.
It's time.
Oh my god.
Doki said I can see my family again if you go somewhere.
I feel like I'm held hostage by you.
I was going to be done 4-5 days ago.
I was ready to call it.
Listen.
It goes both ways, okay?
What?
I was ready to call it.
Bubble.
I don't have shields.
I'm dead.
I'm like...
I have Q, though.
Run, run, run, run, run.
I'm just gonna ping.
I'm back.
You're so good.
The Magnias have.
I've returned, I've returned, I've returned.
I've returned, I've returned.
Very close, very close.
He's going for a hook.
No.
I'm playing right now.
The Magnia's low.
Oh, nevermind, nevermind.
He's going for a hook.
Magnias, yeah.
No lamp, no lamp.
Very low, very low.
I have my...
I have the Soba on this.
Magnia one.
Mag, Mag, one, Mag, one, Mag, one.
Chilling, chilling, chilling.
Watch out, Groot, too.
Keep me alive, keep me alive.
I'm ulting.
Come to me, I can hook.
I'm ulting this, I'm ulting this.
I got them all, I got them all.
What?
That's fine, that's fine.
One on this.
Mag, Mag, Mag, one.
Mag, one, Mag, one.
Nice.
Come on!
I'm on Sylar.
One wave.
What?
I missed my family.
That's fine.
I missed my wife.
I missed my kids.
What?
How the fuck did he get me there?
One wave.
I haven't eaten at all today.
This could have ended four games ago.
But we wouldn't have built this beautiful story of one wave.
Oh my fucking god, bro.
I'm still botting us.
I got hooked.
Nice, nice.
Nice kill, nice kill.
Break wall, break wall.
Live, chill.
Live, live, live.
We almost have winnable.
Play for winnable.
I literally just got fucked up.
You just keep going.
Okay, we can't do it.
I need to play up.
I need to push up here.
Fuck, he's low.
That was strange.
Can we push?
I'm pushing up.
Yeah, we're pushing up now.
Big one, big one.
I am at your service.
I am ready to put on a show.
You're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
I'm trying to.
I'm still botting, I'm still botting.
Nice, let's use, let's use.
I'm on Groot.
I'm on Strange.
Strange is low.
Strange is half.
Do not low.
One win.
Groot half.
Play in the open, play in the open.
Groot's gonna have a worse time.
There's a Starler behind us, careful.
I got both, I got both.
I'm helping him.
I'm ulting, man.
Where's the Strange?
I still botted, I still botted.
No more second chance, no more second chance.
Strange one.
No hook.
I have no heals, I have no heals here.
Strange has one, Strange has one.
Strange has got Strange, I got Strange.
No hook.
Watch out.
Don't die, don't die.
I'm moving, moving.
Low gank.
I'm trying to.
Low gank one, low gank one.
He's healed, he's healed, he's healed.
Could be the key to solving our crisis.
Just chill, chill, chill.
I still botted, I still botted.
Good, good, good.
We need to get a kill here.
We have to touch point, we have to touch point.
No lamp.
Oh, I got hooked.
Oh my god.
Guys, we have low gank on our ass.
I'm cocooning on cart.
Oh, that's bad for me.
Oh my god.
Okay, okay.
One win.
I tried to ult.
No, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I tried to cancel this.
Okay, okay.
Watch out, Wolverine.
No hook, no hook.
I should take an early fight then.
Yeah, I'm going in.
Watch out, watch out, Wolverine.
Watch out over here.
We should be close to Brutal.
Wolverine, Wolverine, Wolverine.
I got, I got you.
Oh.
I'm trying to slow bomb you.
I got your slow bomb.
Oh no.
I have rez here, but...
They used to move.
They used...
I can touch, I can touch.
I'm slow bombing.
I'm ulting.
I'm dead, you have to stay alive.
I actually want to go.
Go on the backline, backline, backline.
Wolverine one, Wolverine one.
Luna one, Luna one.
Luna, Luna.
I'm on Groot, I'm on Groot, I'm on Groot.
No passive, Wolverine.
Change.
Wolverine, no passive.
They still have one more fight.
Or we push, or we push.
Or they can TP.
I have slow bomb, but...
I'm going, I'm going.
I thought they were going to TP.
It's fine.
They're just trying to counter it.
I almost have ult.
No dying, no dying.
Kill the Lyra.
That's really good.
I got hook.
Let's go.
Watch out.
I have slow bomb now, I have slow bomb now.
I'm on Groot, I'm on Groot.
Groot's one, Groot's one.
One win.
One win, bro.
Guys, there's a bug ult, thank god.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm supposed to be an Adam main.
I'm fucking my play.
I might as well...
Oh my god.
I might as well be a fucking Adam player.
I literally...
I literally fucking win every Adam game.
Oh my god.
I'm trusting Adam.
Adam.
God, I'm a fucking Adam player.
I'm free.
I'm just an Adam player.
Jeez.
Oh my god.
You're right.
I can't.
You know, I can't.
It's like...
It's like I'm like an alcoholic and they...
But like, I'm on like sobriety.
And I'm like 20 months sober.
And then they were like...
I'm like 20 months sober.
And then...
And then he's like...
Just one sip, Doki.
Just one sip.
Oh my god.
I just...
I can't.
Oh my god, you're right.
You're right.
Let's...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll finish my story.
And then, like, I take that one sip.
And then I wake up...
I black out.
And then I wake up in a bar.
I wake up in a bar.
And then I'm like...
Oh no.
It's happened again.
Oh my god.
Okay, guys.
But what about one more win?
What about...
What about one...
Guys!
Guys, okay.
Last one.
For real, guys.
This is...
For real.
My last one.
Guys!
For real.
This is my last one.
I would never lie to you guys.
Guys, I promise.
What if I give you this?
Guys!
But what if I give you this, though?
I would never!
This is the last one.
I swear.
Whatever happens...
Oh, but then I'll be less than 100 points.
Oh god.
Okay, but like...
What do you mean I'm holding Bulgur hostage?
What?
He tweeted that I'm holding him hostage?
I was ready to leave four games ago!
Five games ago!
Which hero do you think you want to meet today?
I'm fucking BL hostage!
I was ready to leave five!
Yes, I was.
I was so ready.
I was like...
We're gonna leave.
I will win 130 points.
And like...
It's fine.
I'm fucking banning Hawkeye.
It's too addicting.
Okay.
Alright.
Last one.
For real.
This is my descent into madness.
Hey guys!
Oh my god!
Thank you for the...
Thank you for watching, bro.
Thank you.
You win, you win, you win, you win.
Guys, thanks for watching.
You win, you win.
Guys!
In four days, I'll return back to normal.
Everybody.
In four days, things will be back to normal.
Also, if you're new here, my name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube.
But I'm here...
I'm here on Twitch because I really want to hit top 500 in Marvel Rivals.
And...
Doki, you need to pull out the Mantis.
Okay.
Here we go.
And...
We're here.
Someday, I want to be able to cope as half as good as Kofi B.
Not so dead.
Thank you for the thousand bitties.
Guys, it's okay.
After this...
After this, we'll be free.
And then, like, today, I won't be streaming Marvel Rivals.
I won't.
Yeah.
After this...
After this, we won't have a stream later today.
I might play off-stream, though.
I'm not gonna lie to you guys.
I will absolutely play off-stream.
But after I wake up...
After I wake up...
Whatever time I fucking wake up, I don't even know.
But then...
Strange.
A rat.
They have a rat.
Thank fucking...
There's a Magnia up top.
Oh my god.
I don't have any leaves left.
They have triple support.
They're TPing.
They're gonna TP the doorways.
So you gotta get out of there.
Can you guys touch?
Our Starlord can.
I'm TPing.
I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming.
Here.
I got you.
We win this, we win this.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Punisher, Punisher, right side.
I'm on point.
Where is Strange?
Strange is here.
Oh, nevermind.
Where'd Muna go?
Punisher's low.
I don't have ult yet.
I'm 89.
I have ult here.
I might be staggered, I can't tell.
Might be.
What if you kill them?
I left.
Yeah, do you have Punisher ult?
I have, yeah, yeah.
They have Strange ult.
I'll try and save it for Strange.
I see Strange.
There's a Mantis!
Mantis half!
Oh, he's so low.
I didn't see where the Strange is.
He's on frontline, he's frontline-ing.
I have to use this.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
I'm fine.
I'm trying to get you.
I can't see you.
I got you, I got you.
I'm damage boosting you.
You're damage boosted.
Left side, left side.
I'm going, I'm going.
He's out, he's out.
You're damage boosted.
That's okay.
I don't see you all.
I got you.
I don't have enough leads for this.
I can damage boost whatever.
I'm frozen.
I'm trying to get to you.
He's looking for it.
By the eye of Agamotto.
Oh my god, the punish roll.
Oh my god.
They hit a checkpoint.
They're under a lot of pressure and that's just with the Punisher.
It's actually kind of crazy.
They have only Punisher damage.
And there's triple support, so...
They're like, healing everything.
They're kind of low.
Alright.
Nice.
He's asleep, he's asleep.
He's half.
He's one, he's one, he's one.
Oh
my god.
I'm gonna die here.
And they're gonna TP or spawn if I die here.
I'm trying, I'm ulting them.
Yeah, go, go, go.
We need to steal that climb.
I'm asleep.
I woke you up.
I'm trying to keep you up.
Oh, strangers low, strangers so low.
Oh, nevermind.
I can heal you, I can heal you.
I got you, I got you.
You only have me as support.
Tank's on me.
Strangers low, strangers half, strangers half.
I'm the only one supporting right now.
So please, don't die.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Aluna's back.
Did they use strangers?
No.
I'm backing up a little.
They're just looking for it, left side.
Yeah.
And he's flanking.
Oh no.
I'm gonna die here.
They're gonna strange ult after this though.
I have my ult up though.
There's a mantis on you.
Strange, strange, right side.
I'm ulting this.
I couldn't do anything.
Help me, help me, help me.
They're pushing point, they're pushing point.
Point, point, point, point.
Chill, chill, bro.
Strange is stuck, strange is stuck, strange is stuck, strange is stuck.
He's stopping me!
Mag on me.
I'm trying to help you right now.
We are undefeated!
Oh my god, there's nothing I could do.
I am ready to put on a show!
Someone needs to touch point.
Aluna almost has ult if someone touch point.
Stay point, stay point.
Nice, nice.
Help her, help her, help her.
Rocket's so low!
I'm on it.
Oh my god.
50 seconds, guys.
We can win.
Oh my god.
Is it me?
I don't know what to do here.
Oh, we need a triple support.
Maybe.
Do you think Psylocke is good now?
Punisher?
You can try Punisher.
Wolverine.
Do you play Wolverine, Vixen?
Nah, not a meta character.
Okay, okay.
Mistakes, do you play Wolverine?
Do we have a Wolverine player?
It's time to learn Wolverine live.
Oh my god.
I got baited.
Again.
How do I always get baited?
How do I always...
Ow!
I let myself get baited again.
Who could've seen it coming?
Who could've seen it coming, everybody?
It truly is unfortunate indeed.
We could've...
Who could've predicted this, guys?
Not me, that's for sure.
There's a Magneto just blocking us.
Magneto's one, Magneto's low!
Oh my god.
I'm with you.
You with me?
Yeah, I have ult here too.
We need to live this.
I'm trying.
I'm alive.
I can ult after this.
If we live this, we can win this.
I lost her Luna.
I don't have enough leaves.
I can still ult.
I'm leaving.
These ults were...
Oh my god, I got fucking...
Oh my god!
I got baited.
I got...
I got baited, chat.
I got baited.
I'm gonna go in, are you ready?
Help me out, help me out.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
I'm going in.
Summing now.
Oh my god.
I can't.
I can't deal with this fucking fear.
This fear magneto!
I'm coming back now.
There's nobody pushing cart.
There's a Punisher on the turret.
Punisher's on turret.
Punisher's low.
I want supports, I want supports.
I'm with you.
Is that Mantis on me?
Luna 1, Luna 1, Luna 1.
Mantis 1, Mantis 1, Mantis 1.
Strange health.
I got ult.
I'm 80% but I have it so...
Punisher, Punisher, Punisher, Punisher.
Strange health, strange 1.
Strange 1, strange 1.
Strange 1.
I'm dead here.
I don't want this.
Oh my god.
I can ult past.
Is Luna's push up?
I want Luna here.
Luna, Luna.
I've slept.
Mantis health.
They used both stuns.
Okay.
I'm going in as well.
Can I help you?
I got you.
I can't...
You're slow.
I'm dead.
I'm backing out, I'm backing out.
I am strengthened for battle.
Jesus Christ.
I might want to watch out over here.
My life energy flows stronger.
Here, here, here, here, here, here.
Here.
We got him, we got him.
Maltus.
Push up.
Mantis, Mantis 1.
I'm asleep.
We are undefeatable!
I'm pushing cart, I'm pushing cart right now.
They're like...
Mantis 1, Mantis 1.
Strange 1.
Strange half, strange half.
Wait, do you have Mantis?
Oh, thanks.
There's a rocky raccoon in the cubby.
By himself.
Don't die, don't die.
Hold the corner, hold the corner.
I'm hiding up here.
Oh my god.
I'm dead.
I'm going to try to save you.
Oh.
Mantis has returned.
Okay, I have my ult for the next fight.
We have a portal.
I have Mantis.
Is this the last fight?
Yeah, it is.
I'm opening a portal.
Get that vehicle moving again!
They used this.
Shake it off!
Down to 30 seconds!
Try to give you all the damage right now.
Strange, maybe?
Oh, I got him.
I see you, I see you, I see you, I see you!
You're my goat, you're my goat, you're my goat, you're my goat.
I'm pushing the cart, I'm pushing the cart.
There's a... there's a Punisher!
Double KO!
Vehicle reached a checkpoint.
Keep up the momentum!
Push up to get stragglers if you can.
I slept somebody!
Oh my, this is so low.
I'm ulting this.
Let's do this.
I don't have the health.
I slept somebody.
We got Moon Knight all here.
I have damage boost to you.
Okay, I'll save some leads for damage boost.
Oh no!
But I think we're good.
I slept them.
Damage boosting.
Oh my god.
You only have Luna heals, you only have Luna heals.
Where the fuck was that?
I literally absorbed every fucking rock!
I'm not like angry, it's just I'm like...
I'm actually like...
Impressed.
You know?
Strange is half.
I will heal.
Backline, backline, backline, backline.
Oh my, Punisher's so tanky!
Strange, Strange, Strange.
Strange, focus on Strange, please!
I'm on him, I'm on him.
She's still alive!
I'm just...
I'm just impressed!
They're gonna have Strange all here.
I can't...
Oh, got you.
Oh, I got hit!
Help our Luna, we can't...
I got...
I'm trying to save all.
Are you serious?
Oh my god!
Why?!
Why is it always me?!
Oh my god!
I can't...
Live!
Where did I go?!
I'm just impressed at that point.
I'm impressed that I get Magneto ulted every time.
Like, I can't...
Like, wherever I run to, I just get Magneto ulted.
Oh my god!
We're free.
I know, we're...
I know you guys are gonna get mad if I keep going.
I know!
I know you guys are gonna get mad if...
I keep going.
We're free now.
We're free.
I can't...
My chat is mad if I keep going.
Alright.
GG's guys.
GG's.
What a journey.
I'll get one win without...
That's so fucked.
Hey guys.
What a...
What a journey.
Those were some really fucked up games that I had.
But, thank you all for watching.
If you guys are new here, my name is DokiVid.
I usually stream on YouTube, but...
It's been a fucked up tight week.
It's been a fucked up week on Twitch.
I hope I do end top 500.
I hope.
Anyway, feel free to please subscribe to me on YouTube, because I usually stream there.
I mean, it will be normalized in four days.
I will start streaming there.
I'll be back to normal in four days.
Please follow me on Twitter, because I usually tweet out whenever I'm streaming on Twitch.
Is there anything else?
Check out my Nendoroid.
Buy my merch.
All that stuff.
I don't know what else to show right now.
Check out my Nendoroid.
Buy my merch.
Nendoroid.
Yes, I have my very own Nendoroid.
Gamersubs.
Hi it.
All that stuff.
Check all of that out.
Hey guys.
Thank you all for watching.
It's been a while, right?
We were number one on Marble Rivals.
We were number one.
I'm so crazy.
I didn't expect myself to be number one.
But anyway.
Don't pitch intense.
There will not be a Marble Rivals stream today, because I streamed for 16 hours.
So anyway guys, as always, everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.